THE LATE START THERE'S SO BEEN A
TO GO AHEAD AND GET START WITH
THE COMMITTEE YOU CAN SEE WE'RE
STARTING AS A VERY SMALL
SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF TWO BUT I SURE YOU THERE WILL
BE OTHER PEOPLE HERE SOON -- WE
WILL BE HEARING TO WITNESSES PER
SIDE WITH A TIME LIMIT OF THREE
MINUTES EACH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WE ASK YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND POSITION ON THE BILL -- THE
FOLLOWING THOSE ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
ANY MEMBER THE MAKE OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY REMOVE A BILL FROM
CONSENT.
THE ITEMS ARE NOT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB THREE SIXTEEN BY MISTER
RAMOS.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
FOURTEEN BY WOOD.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB SEVEN
SIXTY NINE BY I MISS SMITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN A. B.
TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY MR MCCARTY.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO BY MISS POWER
QUE HAN.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE AB SIXTEEN
OH ONE BY MR RUN MOST AND ITEM
NUMBER.
FORTY FIVE THAT'S CORRECT FORTY
FORTY FIVE THERE'S A LOT OF
ITEMS TODAY -- AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY THREE OF MY BY AND WOOD.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS -- THAT WILL HEAR THE
FOLLOWING BILLS -- FIRST WILL BE
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR
MISTER BONTA FOLLOWED BY AB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT MISTER BLOOM.
A. B.. SEVEN SIXTY FOUR MISTER --
OF BONTA AGAIN A. B.. FOUR SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE I MISS WICKS.
AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE FROM
THE COUNTER.
TO TO ADD I'M SORRY SEVEN SIXTY
SIX GIVES ME.
MR CHU HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S CALENDAR THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR AS HAS -- AB EIGHT
NINETY NINE BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN.
SO WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
START -- MISTER BONTA
[inaudible]
AB.
FOR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A BEFORE.
A BEFORE SEEKS TO EXPAND MEDI
CAL COVERAGE TO INCOME ELIGIBLE
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS.
SIMPLY PUT THIS BILL REMOVES A
BARRIER TO HEALTH ACCESS.
DUE TO IMMIGRATION STATUS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ELECTED TO IMPOSE.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE WITHOUT
INSURANCE ARE LESS LIKELY TO GET
THE MEDICAL CARE THEY NEED.
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS ARE
THE LARGEST SINGLE GROUP OF
UNINSURED INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE.
YET THEY CONTRIBUTE OVER THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TO STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES AND ARE A MAJOR
PERCENTAGE OF OUR WORKFORCE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE CANNOT REACH.
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE UNTIL
CALIFORNIA REMOVES ELIGIBILITY
EXCLUSIONS BASED ON IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND MAKES MEDI CAL
INCLUSIVE OF ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
RESIDENTS IN OUR STATE.
THE FEDERAL INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE PUT IT SUCCINCTLY.
UNINSURED PEOPLE ARE MORE LIKELY
TO RECEIVE TOO LITTLE MEDICARE
AND RECEIVE IT TOO LATE.
AS A RESULT THEY ARE SICKER AND
DIE SOONER.
A BEFORE WILL BRING CALIFORNIA
CLOSER TO ENSURING THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA HAS COMPREHENSIVE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE HEALTH
CARE.
OVER THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
WITNESSED THE BARRAGE OF ATTACKS
ON HEALTH CARE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL INCLUDING MULTIPLE EFFORTS
TO REPEAL THE ACA.
AND VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIONS THAT UNDERMINE ACCESS TO
CARE.
CALIFORNIA HAS WORKED TO SHIELD
OUR STATE FROM THESE ATTACKS TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE AND WE MUST
CONTINUE TO CHAMPION AND LEAD
THE NATION.
IN BOLD AND INCLUSIVE POLICIES
THAT SUPPORT THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
DUE TO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIA'S.
DUE TO OUR UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS BEING UNABLE TO
ACCESS HEALTH INSURANCE AND THE
COMPOUNDING FEARS AND CHILLING
EFFECT CREATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
TE QUALITY OF LIFE IS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED AND
ADDITIONAL TRAUMAS OR CREATING
AND URGENCY TO ENSURE THEY ARE
PROTECTED AND INSURED.
INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO RECEIVE
CARE IN A TIMELY MANNER TO
PREVENT ILLNESSES FROM
DETERIORATING MANY A DOCUMENT
CALIFORNIANS ONLY ACCESS HEALTH
CARE IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
WHERE MANY TIMES PROVIDERS ARE
NO LONGER ABLE TO HELP DUE TO
THE EXACERBATIONS?
OF THE ILLNESS.
NOT ONLY IS THIS CURRENT STATE
OF AFFAIRS DETRIMENTAL TO OUR
FELLOW CALIFORNIANS ALSO
INCREASES THE DEMAND ON
EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES AND
INCREASES COSTS.
IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
OVERALL COSTS THAT COULD BE AND
SHOULD BE PREVENTED.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
WITH A BEFORE WE WILL A BEFORE
BUILDS UPON THE LEGISLATURE'S
WORK WITH HEALTH FOR ALL KIDS.
TO HELP ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
HEALTH CARE.
I'M GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR NEWSOME
FOR TAKING THE STEP TO EXPAND
HEALTH CARE TO YOUNG ADULTS A
CONFIDENT WE CAN WORK TOGETHER.
TO ENSURE TO EXPAND IT TO ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY ON A BEFORE.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
I HAVE BRENDA LOUD ENOUGH WITH
THE SO TO A COMMUNITY MEMBER
HERE SHARE HER STORY.
DEEP IN GUN MAY HAVE WITH CENTER
FOR IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND
JESSICA MORAN WITH ALL THAT
HEALTH ACCESS SO YOU DO HAVE
THREE WITNESSES WILL BE TOTAL
SIX MINUTES AND THAT'S THAT'S
FINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BRENDA WHAT THE
SUBTLE I'M A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE IN THE THEIR WHICH
SHIA LOVES THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS.
I LIVE IN IS LOS ANGELES I HAVE
A TO THE UNITED STATES WHEN I
WAS TWELVE YEARS OLD FROM MEXICO
CITY I AM UNDOCUMENTED INTO NOT
ALL FOR THAT.
IN JANUARY I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF MEETING WITH GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM TO THIS BECAUSE HE'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE HELPFUL TO
IMMIGRANT YOU'D LIKE MYSELF.
THE GOVERNOR CAN BEATTY'S
COMMITMENT TO EXPANDING ACCESS
TO HEALTHCARE AND I AM GRATEFUL
THAT HE LISTENED TO THE STORIES
OF INFECTED INDIVIDUALS.
I APPRECIATE HIS PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND MEDICAL FOR YOUNG ADULTS
HOWEVER IT WILL NOT ALLEVIATE
THE SUFFERING AND ECONOMIC
BURDEN.
FACE VALUE AND DOCUMENT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF IF IT
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
OUR PARENTS AND OTHERS.
MY MOM IS A SINGLE PARENT AND
THE MOST HARD WORKING PERSON I
KNOW.
I'LL NEVER FORGET THE DAY ARE
YOU LOCAL WHEN SHE BEGAN HAVING
THIS IN YOUR STOMACH THE SHE
DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL BECAUSE SHE DOES NOT
HAVE.
INSURANCE SHE GIVE HOPE IN THE
HALLWAY.
BUT HE CONTINUED TO GET WORSE
FOR TWO WEEKS THIS IS WHAT SO
MANY UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS TO THE
SOFTWARE IT'S CRISTINA PAIN KEEP
GOING TO WORK AND SACRIFICE
THEIR OWN WELL BEING SO THEIR
CHILDREN COULD CONTINUE TO GO TO
SCHOOL LEARN AND HAVE A CHANCE
AT A GOOD FUTURE.
IT WASN'T UNTIL MY MOM COULD NO
LONGER STAND UP THE WE FINALLY
HAD TO TAKE HER TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM.
THE DOCTOR THE DOCTOR TOLD US
THAT HE WAS TOO LATE TO OPERATE
ON HER. TO REMOVE HAPPENED IT'S
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ALREADY
EXPLODED AND COUSIN INTERNET
CONNECTION.
THEY HAD TO ANSWER TO ONE OF HER
STOMACH TO REMOVE THE INFECTIONS
OR SEE TOOLS OF THE PENDANTS.
THE DOCTOR TOLD ME THAT HE WOULD
HAVE WAITED ANY LONGER MY MOM
WOULD HAVE DIED.
MY MOM'S RECOVERY TOOK ABOUT TWO
MONTHS AND SHE WAS NOT ALLOWED
TO GO TO WORK DURING THE TIME.
WITH ALL MY MOST PAYCHECKS MY
FAMILY REALLY STRUGGLE
FINANCIALLY ON TOP OF THAT WE
HAD ON THE STAND AND MEDICAL
BILL OR SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
BECAUSE NOT EVERYTHING WAS
COVERED BY THE MACKENZIE MEDICAL
SHE APPLIED FOR AT THE TIME.
GROWING UP LOW INCOME I WAS
ALREADY USED TO THE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER TO
PERMIT TO SPAIN RAIN OR PUTTING
FOOD ON THE TABLE.
WELL WHEN THE PRIMARY INCOME
EARNERS.
WAS SICK AND MISS WORK IT ADDED
AN ADDITIONAL LAYER OF EMOTIONAL
AND FINANCIAL POURED INTO MY
LIFE.
A DOUBLE THE STRESS THE HOW
THIRTY COMES WITH BEING ON THE
DOCUMENT THAT COLLEGE STUDENTS.
MY ABILITY TO SEE DOCTOR THEM
EQUIPMENT IN ALL MY LEADERSHIP
ACTIVITIES THAT UC RIVERSIDE.
AND THAT TO MY FULLEST POTENTIAL
IS CLOSELY TIED TO MY MOM
SKILLED AND ECONOMIC INSTABILITY
OF MY ENTIRE HOUSE SCHOOL.
MY EXPERIENCE IS THE SAME AS SO
MANY OTHER ON DOCUMENT THE YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS.
ON ALL OF THEIR BEHALF I THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO DATE AND
ASK YOU TO VOTE YES ON THE FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DEEPENING ACNE SO WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER -- WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF BLOOD OF AB -- FOR
TO EXPAND MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY
TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS -- AND I THINK AS WE JUST
HEARD BRENDA'S STORY IS HOW
INTRICATELY TIED -- STABILITY IS --
WITH HEALTHCARE ESPECIALLY
ECONOMIC STABILITY AND I REALLY
LIKE TO UPLIFT ONE OF THE POINTS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MADE
I'M IS THAT UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS CONTRIBUTE THREE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
EACH YEAR AND STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO A SYSTEM THAT THEY
DON'T RECEIVE ANY BENEFITS FROM.
FROM AGRICULTURE CONSTRUCTION
DOMESTIC WORKERS TO SERVICE WORK
IMMIGRANT WORKERS ARE HIGH ARE
HEAVILY REPRESENTED INDUSTRIES
THE WITH A HIGH RISK OF INJURY
ON THE JOB AND THE LOW RATE OF
EMPLOYER PROVIDED BENEFITS
INCLUDING HEALTH INSURANCE. ONE
OF THE KEY EXAMPLES IS DURING
THE RECENT WILDFIRES WHERE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT WORKERS
FARMWORKERS WORSE ON THE FIELD
I'M EXPOSED TO THE TOXIC AIR
QUALITY AND THEY WERE UNWILLING
TO LEAVE THEIR JOBS BECAUSE THEY
NEEDED. TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND I IS A DISGRACE AND
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO RECEIVE THE
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS THAT THEY
WILL LIKELY NEED.
I'M TO THE NEGATIVE HEALTH CARE
FACTS OF THAT.
WATER FIRE SMOKE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EXPANDING
MEDICAL ACCESS WE SIMPLY TALK
ABOUT -- PROVIDING LIFESAVING
TREATMENTS -- THESE ARE FAMILIES
THAT DON'T RECEIVE MANY OTHER
MEDICAL BENEFITS AND ARE IN
CRITICAL NEED OF IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JUSTIN
RANDALL CONTACT THIS CALIFORNIA
THE STATE WIDE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION I'M HERE TODAY AS A
SPONSOR IMPROV SUPPORTER OF
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH WOULD EXTEND
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY TO ALTHOUGH
INCOME.
AND DOC ADULTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS BY
SPENDING MEDICAL TO ALL LOW
INCOME UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS YOU'D
EXPECT ONE POINT ONE FIVE
MILLION ADULTS TO ENROLL BY.
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH TO DECREASE
CALIFORNIA'S UNINSURED RATE BY
ABOUT A QUARTER.
LOW INCOME AND DOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT ARE USUALLY
NOT OFFERED DOT THESE HEALTH
INSURANCE IS SIMILAR TO MANY
LAWFULLY PRESENT LOW INCOME
WORKERS.
HOWEVER 90% OF ALL UNDOCUMENTED
LOW INCOME WORKERS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
COMPARED TO ONLY 10% OF THE
LAWFULLY PRESENT COUNTERPARTS.
CURRENTLY THE UNDOCUMENTED YOU
QUALIFY FOR EMERGENCY SCOPE
RESTRICTED MEDI CAL BUT THAT'S
ONLY FOR EMERGENCIES AND ONLY
STABILIZE THE PATIENT IT DOESN'T
GET PROVIDE ANY PRIMARY CARE
PREVENTIVE SERVICES OR EVEN
ACCESS -- TO PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY LIVE
THEY MIGHT HAVE ACCESS TO COUNTY
BASED HEALTH CARE PRO STICKY
NOTES BUT IN MANY ROAD AREAS THE
SICKNESS DO NOT EXIST SO MANY
CHOOSE TO GO WITHOUT CARE OR TO
SEEK OUT HOME REMEDIES FOR THEIR
AILMENTS.
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE -- OFTEN MEANS THAT
PREVENTIVE CARE IS OUT OF REACH
AND CHRONIC ILLNESSES GO
UNTREATED LEVY LEADING TO POUR A
HELL ON HEALTH OUTCOMES.
LACK OF HEALTH INSURANCE ALSO
MEANS THAT YOU COULD BE ONE
SICKNESS OR MEDICAL ILLNESS AWAY
FROM ENOUGH TO CALAMITY DUE TO
HIGH MEDICAL COSTS AND MOUNTING
MEDICAL DEBT.
BUT PASSING YOU BEFORE WE CAN
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IN OUR
STATE HAS ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY WERE
BORN FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOUR I THOUGHT TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOR PLEASE COME FOR JUST YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MARKETS GO THROUGH ON THE
CALIFORNIA BENEFIT HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BY
CALVIN I WORK IN SUPPORT.
VICTOR CHRISTY CALIFORNIA
HELPLESS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
HAVING OUR SAY COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU --
MAURICE RICHARDSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION OF SUPPORT.
SERRA IDEAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WITH ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THE
CURE.
CECILIA GOMEZ GONZALEZ FROM THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY IN.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BECAUSE
ALL LIFE SHOULD MATTER.
MY NAME IS CHAU MUSLIM AND
ACTUALLY I DON'T WORK AT THIS
TIME I AM A PATIENT RECEIVING
DIALYSIS FOR ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS
NOW.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS AND
BASICALLY WITHOUT DIALYSIS I
WOULD BE BASICALLY DID AND I
HAVE TWO KIDS WE NEED ME AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE JUST YOUR
NAME IN OUR POSITION THANKS YEAH
I GOT A GOES WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MARIA JOSE FERNANDEZ FLOORS
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HIGHLY THIRTIES HAS THE LOS
ANGELES SAID SUPPORT THOUGH
TAMBIéN AND BECAUSE HE'S GOT A
LESSON.
GLORIA CONNELLY'S STORY -- THE
LOCAL MONEY THAT THEY CENTER LOS
AFTER THIS THANK YOU.
FOR NORMA ARMSTRONG OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS ALYSSA DAVIDSON I
AM FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DALE FOUNTAIN IN ACT UNIVERSAL
HEALTH CARE FOR CALIFORNIA THE
LARGEST SINGLE PAYER
ORGANIZATION CALIFORNIA --
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS -- THE
TO ENHANCE OUR ONE IS IT'S IT'S
EITHER IT'S YOU IS YOUR THEIR
SUPPORT WHICH WE'RE NOT
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS FROM HERE
SO IT'S EITHER.
IS YOUR NAME AND IN YOUR
POSITION PLEASE.
OKAY -- WELL WITHOUT IT JUST
YOUR NAME A POSITION PLEASE YES
YES DOCTOR WOULD WELL WITHOUT
THE STATE FIND BEING.
HI MY NAME IS CAROLINE I'M
MARTINEZ HE YOUR FOR YOU OKAY LE.
LET COASTAL THE LESS THEY WOULD
AND SO THE GUY SAID TO SAY I'M
ABOUT COUPLE FOR MORE BOOK IT
YOU'LL SOLELY.
MY MUSCLES THAT I EAT IT MAY BE
IN THE FECES BY GOT ME ME CALL
PAYING THE THE SALUTE.
THANK YOU.
WELL A LITTLE RESTAURANT REALLY
OR THREE IS THE LUCK WITH OTHER
CAN AFFECT A MENTAL HISTORICALLY
THEM UP FOR YOU BUT OUR LOVE WAS
THESE OTHER LESS ON RULES.
LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU SIR.
ME NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN MARTINEZ
THE BEST PHONE.
THANK YOU PUT UP FOR YOU.
BUT I WAS TO SET UP A LESSON.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALEX MALICE AND FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- CHOICES
STORE FROM FRESNO AND I SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SO I CRISTINA CASTRO THIS SORT
OF SACRAMENTO YEP -- YOU'LL --
EASILY.
THANK YOU.
WE'VE BEEN IN A MEAT IS I'M
GONNA PUT IS MY ACOUSTIC BUT A
FOUR YEAR LIBERAL.
THE PROPOSED THAT THEY IS SO LOW.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OF FREEDOM -- FROM --
THERE'S STILL FROM SOCIOLOGY OF
NICE AND NINE MON.
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED SEES HIM
[inaudible]
FORTY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DWAYNE QUITE FRESNO
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE JUST IS
NOT SUPPORT THINK SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND JOSEPH IS A
ROWDY.
I'M HERE FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI YOU'LL SAY MY THE OFFICIAL
FULLER AUDIO VAGAL THEM ALL THIS
TOO YES TO YANKEE FOR CARE FOR
YOUR WHOSE FEES YEAH THE LAST
THING.
LET THEM KNOW MY NAME WHEN I
DON'T HAVE A FROM SOMETHING I
THINK OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS SUPPORT AHEAD OF YOU
THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KEVIN UNLESS IDEALIST I CALL OF
THE FRANKLY.
I AM A MEMBER OF YOUR H. W. FOR
HOW TO KERR YEAH.
I AM HERE TILL THE SUPPORT THE
CUTTER.
HEAD KERR FOR A PLUS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER IS THIS WAS UP BODIES.
BEING WITH THE LOS ANGELES.
BINGO THE LOS ANGELES IS A KEY.
BUT I UP FOR YET I LIKE WAS THIS
YEAR THE LAST SALUTE.
THE LOS BEING WHAT WE GOT LOS
GLASS YES.
MY NAME IS JOYCE GEORGE -- S. CI
YOU YOU H. W. COMMUNITY ACTION
LATER.
ASIANS TO THE FRONT SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
I SUPPORT.
SEC SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
AND PEACH THE PRIVATE ESSENTIAL
ACCESS COMMUNITY HOSPITALS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHARON BROOKS BOYD HEALTH CARE
JUST AS PAUL SEIU MEMBER IN
SUPPORT.
YEAH DAVID THE FROM SACRAMENTO
OF FIGHTING -- LEUKEMIA -- SEIU
MEMBER -- AND ALSO -- WORKING
FOR HEALTHCARE JUSTICE WE
SUPPORT.
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER ON ON BEHALF
OF NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GILLIAN MEREDITH FROM SAMPLES
KISCO.
HEALTHCARE JUSTICE PLAN.
A VOTE FOR A FOR BE.
HI KRISTIN GOLDEN TESTED WITH
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SARAH MAD I'M A
RECENT YOU SEE GRADUATE AND I
SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS RANDY ORTON ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAY MY NAME IS MY NAME IS AS
I AM A MEMBER OR FOR THE HEALTH
CARE -- JUSTIN'S THE TEAM.
I SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAT TO WORK WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
I AM WITHIN THE GLAZER SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA I AM A
MEMBER OF SAN FRANCISCO.
HEALTH CARE TEAM JUST SYSTEM I'M
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVEN SO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
NONE.
SORRY I AM ARMENIAN GOT US OFF
IDEA.
YES.
YEP BUDGET WOULD CALM SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SHE SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSES WHICH OF THE
CALL THIS REMAIN IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
YOUTH ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM AT WORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE GIVEN THE FOR
TESTIMONY.
MONEY TO IF YOU GET THE ITEMS
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I AM.
A MEMBER OF HIS COULD JUST STICK.
I THE I'M SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
I THINK A LIMIT AS WITH THE LET
ME KNOW COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
YOUR LANDED ON A WAIVER RETIRED
EMPLOYEE FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA S. CI YOU YOU H. W..
I. SUPPORT.
MATTHEW MORRISON WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
IN WORKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER ALI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND
SUPPORT.
YEAH A MINIMALIST BECAUSE SEVEN
MM ANGLE THE OAKLAND.
APPOINTED UP REPLACED BECAUSE
THIS HAPPENED A LITTLE.
CARL SUPPORT OF BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS IN
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
MARK WINDOWS WITH US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ROSS ACOSTA THIS HUMP BY RIZZLE
EIGHTY UP FOR YOU LIBERAL CECILE
EVEN THOUGH THE LOOK ON THE THAT
IS SOME PROBLEM.
CENTER CITY AROUND SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT ME NUMBER IS PROUD OF
THAT FLORA MAKING YES YOU BY.
LEAVING GOAL TIME BEING PART OF
THE MEDIC GOT IT YEP FOR YOUR
THAT IS. SEVEN BRAMBLE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAT CARRILLO HERE FOR THE
SACRAMENTO MANY MANNERS SENIORS
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LEE LOW WHAT THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KATHY MUST FOR GLOBAL HEALTH
PLANS OF CALIFORNIA'S WILL
CENTRAL ASSET ACCESS HEALTH IN
SUPPORT.
DARIA GREW CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SERRA BLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
MONICA MATOS A PEDIATRICIAN HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARKER BUT WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN SUPPORT -- MICHAEL
WRITING ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND SPORT.
BRIT OKOLI AC I YOU CAN'T
SUPPORT OF THE HEALTH CARE AND
ON HERE THANK YOU.
DOCTOR FLOWS ON CO FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BLACK APPARATUS HAS THE JUSTICE
ARE YOU SENSIBLE.
PLEASE A CHAIR FROM ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE AND
PART OF HEALTH FOR ALL IN
SUPPORT.
DOWNEY SHOW BROUGHT IN WITH A C.
I. YOU YOU H. W. IN CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL BONTA WITH HEALTH HEALTH
CARE JESSA'S IN SUPPORT.
LINDA RATE S. CI YOU JUSTICE.
FOR HEALTH CARE AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CONNIE TAYLOR SMITH AS WE ARE
YOU HEALTHCARE JUST JUST SUPPORT
REGIONAL CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
NUMBER A CIRCLE SO YOUR CHIRLA.
MANGO THAT STARTS ON THE FRENCH
CAM.
YEP FOR YOU.
LOS ANGELES HELLO BUT A TOTAL OF
SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN MADONNA
I'M A GRADUATE STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH CARE JUSTICE -- ON MY
FAMILY AS WELL WE'RE IMPACTED.
ON IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CARLOS CASTANEDA IT'S HOW YOU
YOU NAY AKKALKOT JUSTICE ON
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MRS SO CHATTY BARBOSA
ON FOR FIRST OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS DONE THE LAMENT THERE
IS HE ARE YOU -- EXECUTIVE BOARD.
IT IS AN AMERICAN ONE OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM IS TO HAVE OF A
GOOD CARE IT'S SUPPORT THANK YOU
JUST.
A SUPPORT THANK YOU BYE.
I GUESS MY NEXT COURT MY NAME IS
ISABEL BUT IS THIS I SUPPORT THE
BEFORE.
THANK YOU AND DIVIDENDS ALSO
AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN GROUPS IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY BE MY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
SO IF YOU HAVE THIRTY WILL ALSO
FRANCISCO I'M FROM HEALTHCARE
JUSTICE I TEAM AND I AM
SUPPORTING THANK YOU SONYA
VASQUEZ COMMITTEE HEALTH
COUNCILS IN LOS ANGELES AND WE
ARE ADAMANTLY SUPPORTIVE.
THE VATICAN GREEK CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND I SUPPORT HEALTHCARE.
HERE GRAMMAIRE IS PRESENTING
COMPROMISSO ESSAY WHY TIME
NETWORK ANY STATION FOR PROMOTED
THIS HOW DO WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR DIAMOND LEANS ACKERMAN A
PEDIATRICIAN IN SUPPORT.
IN.
ORDER MARTINEZ A HEALTHCARE
JUSTICE I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COM ACCORDING.
BONTA.
EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARIO A. NICK I'M
FROM CARLSBAD CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIR ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
OKAY. THIRTY ONE IN OPPOSITION.
THIRTY ONE IN BETWEEN.
SO I DID I DID HEAR SOMEONE IN
BETWEEN IF THEY THAT THEY WANT
TO SPEAK IN.
AND BRIEFLY WE'RE NOT TAKING
AMENDMENTS BUT YOU JUST BRIEFLY
SPEAK TO YOUR YOUR CONCERNS.
THE COMMENT FROM TARGETING
DOCTORS.
I HOPE SOMEONE.
TRUST ME I'M -- IS [inaudible]
OKAY.
NO IT WAS IT WAS ON ON MY DOOR
THE OTHER AGO OKAY THANK YOU
DOCTOR WHAT I APPRECIATE SECOND
CHANCE.
IT IS SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS I
REALLY WANTS IT. ONE IS THAT THE
COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS -- STILL -- DOESN'T HAVE
ITS APPOINTMENTS BY GAVIN NEWSOM
I AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD
FALL UNDER THAT COUNSEL'S
PURVIEW BUT THE SECOND ONE FINAL
THING IS THAT -- MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE OF MEDICARE ADVANTAGE --
MANAGED A SYSTEMS IS A PRIVATE
MOSTLY PRIVATE 80% -- IF WE USED --
THE STATE COMPENSATION INSURANCE
FUND AND OPEN THAT UP TO PUBLIC
OPTION.
AND THEN.
YOU COULD EVEN CONTRACT THAT OUT --
THROUGH MEDICARE ALL I BELIEVE
THAT WOULD SAVE THE STATE A LOT
OF MONEY ON THIS INSTEAD OF THAT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS GOING.
DIRECTLY TO PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
INSURANCE SO THOSE WOULD BE THE
THINGS THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
CHANGE THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
SO NO OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO MUCH TAKE
ROLE IF YOU DON'T MIND.
MY WHAT I HEAR MAYES.
THANK YOU VERY.
HELLO HI HERE.
ON BONTA.
I HEAR [inaudible]
TO BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA.
LIMON MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
RAMOS [inaudible]
VEGAS [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
OKAY.
IT'S IT WAS MESSY BUT WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MISTAKE HERE.
THANK YOU SELLING THEIR BONTA
FOR BRING THIS FOR ITS REALLY
IMPORTANT MY COMMUNITY -- I'VE
WORKED ON THESE KINDS OF THINGS
FOR OUR IMMIGRANTS FOR A LONG
TIME.
THANKS FOR MOVING FORWARD AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY
AND I'D LIKE TO BE AT AS A CO
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU WILL BE HONORED
[inaudible]
HE WANTS.
ANYONE ELSE OKAY JUST UP ON THE
COMMENT THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER BONTA RING FOR I WOULD
THINK YOUR WITNESS FROM UC
RIVERSIDE MY LOOK NICE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT --
THANK FOR MAKING THE TRIP I JUST
WANNA SAVE IN SUPPORT SUPPORT
THE USE SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE ABSOLUTELY -- I FIRM
BELIEVER THAT -- THE SYSTEM
WORKS BEST WHEN EVERYONE IS
COVERED AND WHITE I TO WANT TO
SEE THAT PEOPLE GET -- EARLY
PREVENTIVE CARE -- SO WE CAN
AVOID SOME THE COSTLIER --
EXPERIENCES AS WAS RELATED LIKE
BY YOUR WITNESS HERE SO --
COMPLETE SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING -- WOULD YOU WITH THAT
WOULD IT DISCUSS OBVIOUSLY
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WHICH I LIKE TO CLOSE.
MISTER CHAIR JUST OF A COUPLE
REAL QUICK CLOSING REMARKS.
I THINK WE HAVE A BOTH A MORAL
IMPERATIVE AND FISCAL IMPERATIVE
TO PASS A BEFORE.
MAYBE YOU'RE LIKE ME YOU THINK
THAT HEALTHCARE IS A RIGHT NOT A
PRIVILEGE AND IT'S FOR ALL NOT
THE FEW OR MAYBE YOU THINK IT'S
THE FAIR AND JUST THING TO
PROVIDE EVERYBODY WITH HEALTH
CARE.
EITHER WAY I THINK WE HAVE A
MORAL OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE -- TO EVERYONE IN
OUR STATE AND THIS IS A BIG STEP
TOWARDS DOING THAT WE'RE STATE
THAT BELIEVES IN THE US WERE
INCLUSIVE -- WE DON'T BELIEVE ME
JUST PIECES OR PARTS OF OUR
STATE WE BELIEVE IN ALL OF US.
RISING TOGETHER.
ALSO IT'S IT'S THE FISCALLY
PRUDENT AND WISE THING TO DO
BECAUSE WITH HEALTH CARE -- FOR
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS IN AMERICA
WILL BE ABLE PROVIDE PREVENTION
SERVICES EARLY INTERVENTION AND
WELLNESS AND NOT WAIT.
HAVE TO WAIT TILL SOMEONE GOES
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM WHERE WHEN
THEY'RE DISEASE HAS -- GOTTEN
WORSE AND THEIR ILLNESS MAYBE
BEYOND -- HELP SO IT'S
FINANCIALLY -- THE RIGHT THING
TO DO MORALLY THE RIGHT THING TO
DO AND I THINK IT REPRESENTS WE
ARE AS A STATE.
BUT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT MR BONTA WE HAVE
A MOTION -- BY MISS AYE GEAR
CURRY SECOND BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
A MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA.
HI.
I BURKE.
CARILLO.
FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMóN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
FROM MOST.
PROMISED AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON NO [inaudible]
SIXTY SIXTY TWO WE NEED WE ONLY
A COUPLE MORE VOTES MISTER BONTA
BUT WILL BE THE POINT WE
OBVIOUSLY.
HAVE MORE MEMBERS ARE MISSING
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
AND WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
ORDERS SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS.
I CONNECTS I AM THE SPECIAL
ORDER.
YES SO IT'S NOT YOU THEM.
UP OKAY AS MISTER BLOOM IS NOT
HERE IN WHICH CASE IT CAN BE YOU.
HI MEGAN HOW MUCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF --
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB.
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR I WANNA BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE.
AB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR TARGETS ARE
PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC BY
PROHIBITING THE USE OF
PROMOTIONAL SUBSIDIES AND
MARKETING INCENTIVES DESIGNED TO
INCREASE THE CONSUMPTION.
OF SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES
DRINKING SODA AND OTHER SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES LIKE SPORTS
DRINKS ENERGY DRINKS AND SWEET
TEAS.
CONTRIBUTE TO A NUMBER OF VERY
SERIOUS HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING DIABETES HEART DISEASE
TO THE K..
AND OBESITY.
THESE CONDITIONS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY FELT IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES MARKETING
TACTICS EMPLOYED BY BIG SO TO
LIKE COKE AND PEPSI.
MIGHT ARTIFICIALLY DRIVE DOWN
PRICES BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE THESE
TACTICS HURT CONSUMERS AND DRIVE
UP HARMFUL HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
HEALTH CARE COSTS. FOR ALL OF US
PROMOTIONS SUCH AS MANUFACTURERS
COUPONS ARE ONE KEY CONTRIBUTOR
TO OUR EPIDEMIC.
SPECIFICALLY MANUFACTURER
SUBSIDIES LOWERED THE COST OF
SUGARY DRINKS AND OFTEN THESE
SUBSIDIES RESULT IN SODA
ACTUALLY BEING CHEAPER THAN
BOTTLED WATER.
AGAIN THIS PUTS GREAT PRESSURE
PRESSURE ON POOR FAMILIES MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO MAKE
HEALTHY.
PURCHASING DECISIONS AB SEVEN
SIXTY FOUR WILL PROHIBIT A SODA
COMPANY FROM OFFERING A
MANUFACTURER'S COUPON TO THAT
PARTNERING MANUFACTURERS
DISTRIBUTORS OR RETAILERS WE
MUST LOOSEN THE GRIP OF BIG SODA.
ON OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND FAMILIES
AND INSTEAD PROMOTE HEALTHIER
LIFESTYLES AND PURCHASES AB
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR WILL REDUCE THE
CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES AND PROMOTE.
GREATER HEALTH ESPECIALLY AMONG
OUR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF RESPECT WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR ARE.
MORGAN COVER HALL LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND DR
ARIANNA.
CHIEF DENTAL OFFICER OF LIKE
WHEN YOU GET A LOT I SAW IN
OAKLAND.
THE BILL.
PLEASE THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS --
MORGAN CARVALLO THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I SEE MAYES
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS REDUCE THE
INCIDENCE OF BIG SODA COMPANIES
THAT TARGET COMMUNITIES TO LOWER
THE PRICE FUND HEALTHY PRODUCTS.
AND INCREASED CONSUMPTION --
THIS IS A THIS PRODUCT ONLY OR
THIS MECHANISM FOR PROMOTIONS
ONLY WORKS WHEN THE TARGETED
COMMUNITIES ARE MAKING ECONOMIC
DECISIONS BASED ON THEIR
SELECTIONS AT THE GROCERY STORE.
WHEN FAMILIES ARE CHOOSING TO
PURCHASE OUT OF BECAUSE IT'S
CHEAPER THAN THE HEALTHIER
OPTIONS?
THEY'RE CHOOSING TO DO SO
BECAUSE THOSE PROMOTIONS ARE LED
BY THE SENATE COMPANIES.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
MANUFACTURE DISCOUNTS ARE NEARLY
TWICE AS LIKELY TO HAVE SODA
DISPLAYS PROMOTIONS PAID BY THE
COAT SO TO COMPANIES.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE MONTH AT
THE SAME TIME THE FOOD STAMPS
ARE DISTRIBUTED.
UNHEALTHY FOOD BEVERAGES ARE
LESS EXPENSIVE BECAUSE
MANUFACTURERS ARE PAYING FOR
THOSE LOW PRICES THAT ARE
GROCERY STORES. FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES THE REAL COST OF THE
MANUFACTURE DISCOUNT ISN'T IT IS
A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN THE
CALORIES THAT ARE BEING CONSUMED
AND IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE TAKE
STEPS TODAY TO REDUCE THE
PERVASIVENESS AND OF OF THESE
MANUFACTURER COUPONS AND
DISCOUNTS.
ON AND HEALTHY SERVICE WITH
BEVERAGES I'M HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT SHOULD THERE BE
ANY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DR TRUE RIGHT.
SET ON GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIRMAN WOULD AND MEMBERS --
DONALD DIRECTOR CHIU DAHLE
OFFICER FOR LIKE ANY OTHER
ADDRESS I IN EAST OAKLAND --
I'VE BEEN IN PRACTICE FOR THIRTY
THREE YEARS AND HAVE SINCE SEEN
THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF SUGARY
DRINKS.
FIRST HAND FOR EVERYONE OF THE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN PRACTICE
OUR CLINIC IS A FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER WILL
FULLY INTEGRATED SERVICES
MEANING WE TREAT ALL ASPECTS OF
PATIENTS HEALTH.
NOT JUST THEIR ORAL HEALTH I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
DENTURE MENTAL HEALTH EFFECTS
THAT THESE BEVERAGES HAVE ON THE
OVERALL HEALTH OF CHILDREN
ADULTS.
SENIORS INCLUDING DIABETES
OBESITY HEART DISEASE AND DENTAL
DISEASE AND I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THAT THIS -- THESE DISEASES
DON'T KNOW THE DIFFERENCE AND
SOCIO ECONOMIC SO WHILE THE
LOWER INCOME POPULATIONS ARE HIT
THE MOST IT AFFECTS EVERYONE AT
ALL.
ALL AT ALL SOCIOECONOMIC CLASSES
THERE IS AN OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE BETWEEN THE LINK
BETWEEN OBESITY DIABETES DENTAL
DISEASE HEART DISEASE AND THE
CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES SUCH AS SOFT DRINKS
ENERGY DRINKS.
SWEET TEAS AND SPORTS DRINKS
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN REPORT BY THE
UCLA CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIA DOGS.
HAVE BEEN REPORTEDLY DIAGNOSED
WITH DIABETES REPRESENTING ONE
OUT OF TWELVE CALIFORNIANS
COMBINED WITH AN ESTIMATED
THIRTEEN MILLION ADULTS WHO WHO
HAVE PRE DIABETES OR UNDER AYE.
DIET AND UNDIAGNOSED DIABETES
THESE GROUPS MAKE UP 55% OF OUR
POPULATION IN ADULT POPULATION
CALIFORNIA.
ADULTS WITH TYPE TWO DIABETES
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE CARDIO VASCULAR DISEASE
ARTHRITIS KIDNEY FAILURE
PERIODONTAL DISEASE THAN ADULTS
WITHOUT DIABETES. ONE HALF OF
ADULTS WITH TYPE TWO DIABETES
ALSO HAVE HYPERTENSION.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE PREVENTABLE
DISEASES ARE HIGHLY PREVALENT IN
OUR STATE'S MINORITY COMMUNITIES.
LET THE LOS AMERICA AFRICAN
AMERICANS NATIVE AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS HAVE A HIGHER
PREVALENCE OF TYPE TWO DIABETES
THE NON HISPANIC WHITES.
IF THE TRENDS ARE NOT REVERSED
IT IS PREDICTED THAT HALF OF THE
LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN BORN INTO A IN TWO
THOUSAND IN TWO THOUSAND WILL
DEVELOP TYPE TWO DIABETES AND
THEIR LIFETIME.
OUR COMPANIES ARE EXERTING
MASSIVE INFLUENCES ON THE
CONSUMPTION PATTERNS OF OUR
CHILDREN AND VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS THEIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES ARE DIRECTLY LINKED TO
OUR STATE'S HEALTH PROBLEMS AND
MASSIVE COSTS TO THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM.
CDA IN OUR MEMBER DENTISTS HAS
SUPPORTED LOCAL TAX INITIATIVES
INCLUDING IN MY HOME TOWN OF
BERKELEY WHERE WE PASS THIS --
SO TO TAX BY 75%.
BUT THE BUT WITH LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR TO BAND LOCAL SODA
INITIATIVES COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CAN NO LONGER MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS. TO LIMIT
THE CONSUMPTION OF SUGARY DRINKS
BECAUSE THE LOCAL OF EFFORTS ARE
BANNED WE'RE COMING TO YOU WITH
ALTERNATIVE POLICIES TO ADDRESS
THE OVERALL CONSUMPTION.
OF SUIT. TO ADDRESS THE OVERALL
CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES OBESITY DIABETES AND
TOOTH DECAY RATES IN CALIFORNIA
ART CRISIS LEVELS AND POLICY
MAKERS MUST TAKE ACTION.
AB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR IS JUMPS ONE
STEP.
BUT IT WILL LIMIT THE MARKETING
INFLUENCES OF COKE AND PEPSI ON
CALIFORNIA AND HELP BATTLE THE
EPIDEMIC WE'RE FACING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
WITH JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
IN WORKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF PROPERTY HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT.
VICTOR CHRISTY CALIFORNIA
HELPLESS ADVOCATES ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATTHEW MONSON WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL DIMMICK ROUTE TO CHANGE
IN STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BEST SMOKER WITH A CALIFORNIA
FOOD AND FARMING NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THE ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
OUT THE WORK AND SUPPORT.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND SPORT.
CAT CARELL SUBSTITUTE TEACHER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WRITE THIS
LETTER FROM BERKELEY ON THE
COMMISSION ON THE SUGARY DRINK
COMMISSION.
IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MONIQUE BLODGETT BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA THIRSTY FOR CHANGE
PROGRAM I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE -- THREE
ONE IN OPPOSITION.
AND JUST WHAT JUST AS AS
OPPOSITION IS KIND OF JUST SO IF
SOMEONE HAS A POSITION BETWEEN --
SUPPORT AND IN A POST.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO STATE THAT
I'M IN I AM IN BETWEEN.
AND THE MY REASONS FOR BEING IN
BETWEEN ARE THIS AND THAT AND
I'M HAPPY TO HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THAT TESTIMONY -- SORRY MR
CHAIRMAN.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS AND SPORT.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT I'M
AND I WANT PEOPLE RUNNING EITHER
SO.
THE ANGEL MY PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU GREAT WE DON'T ANYBODY
GETTING HURT AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE TODAY OKAY.
SO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO WE HAVE
OPPOSITION THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN LATTIMER ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND IN OPPOSITION.
OUR RETAILERS IN CALIFORNIA DO
SELL HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS
OF DIFFERENT PRODUCTS FOODS AND
BEVERAGES WE SELL FRIED FOODS
AND DELIS CHIPS CANDIES ICE
CREAMS AND TO THE OTHER END OF
THE OF FOOD SPECTRUM VEGETABLES
WHOLE GRAINS DAIRY PRODUCTS
WATER TETRA.
WE PROVIDE OUR CUSTOMERS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WITH CHOICES
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING.
FOR THIS BILL ASSUMES A BECAUSE
A MENU FOR MANY BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURER OFFERS A RETAILER
DISCOUNTED PRICING ON BEVERAGES
SO THAT WE CAN PASS THAT
DISCOUNT ON OUR CONSUMERS THAT'S
HARMFUL PRACTICE WE DISAGREE.
THE GROCERY BUSINESS WE HAVE
123% MARGINS PRICE DISCOUNTS FOR
MANUFACTURERS ALL OF OF ALL THE
PRODUCTS WE SELL NOT JUST SODAS
NOXIOUS SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES ALL THE PRODUCTS WE
SELL.
OR IMPORTANT AN IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR MARGINS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE VALUE PROPOSITION OUR
CUSTOMERS EXPECT FROM US.
THIS BILL DOESN'T APPRECIATE
THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE OFTEN CITED AND AND CITED BY
THE PROPONENTS TODAY -- DON'T
QUITE ADD UP.
THE THOUGHT THAT THE SUPER
SWEETENED BEVERAGES MUST BE
BANNED AS A FORM OF COUPONING
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE DRIVER IN
THIS OBESITY EPIDEMIC.
OBESITY AND DIABETES EPIDEMIC --
DON'T ADD UP UNFORTUNATELY SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES THE
CONSUMPTION OF THEM ARE
DECLINING INC IN THE UNITED
STATES NOT JUST CALIFORNIA
UNITED STATES. FOR THE CDC TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN CONSUMPTION FROM
CALORIES FROM SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES DECLINED BY 26% FOR
ADULTS AND 35% FOR YOU.
SO AT THE SAME TIME OBESITY
PREVALENCE FOR ADULTS INCREASED
BY 30% AND YOUTH BY 33% WE'RE
NOT HERE IN DENIAL THE FACTOR OF
PROBLEMS.
WERE SIMPLY COMING IN ARGUING
THAT SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES
ALONE OR NOT THE DRIVER OF THIS.
TODAY IN FACT AND THIS IS AGAIN
FROM THE RETAILER PERSPECTIVE
50% OF THE BEVERAGES PURCHASED
BY CONSUMERS ARE ZERO OR NO
ADDED SUGAR.
WITH WATER BEING NOW THE MOST
POPULAR BEVERAGE OF THAT CLASS.
AGAIN OF SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES WERE SUCH A PROBLEM
THE DISCOUNTS HAD TO BE BANNED
THEN WHY AREN'T WE SEEING A
REVERSAL ON THESE NUMBERS
BECAUSE THE CONSUMPTION IS
ALREADY GOING DOWN.
I WOULD ALSO MAKE IT CLEAR TO
THE COUNT LIKE TO MAKE CLEAR TO
THE COMMITTEE THIS BILL DOESN'T
SIMPLY BEEN COUPONS SO IF YOU
HAVE A PROMOTION IT MAY RUN IN
YOUR GROCERY STORE WHERE IT'S BY
A CHICKEN.
BY A SALAD YOU GET A DISCOUNT ON
SOFT DRINK OR SMARTWATER IT'S
AFTER THAT BROKE PROGRAM BE GONE
AS WELL.
GIVE A CLUB OR PROGRAM AND THE
MANUFACTURER PARTICIPATES IN THE
FINANCES OF THAT WHICH THEY DO
AND MANY OF THEM.
BY TWO TWELVE PACKS AND GET ONE
FREE ON THAT WILL NO LONGER BE
AUTHORIZED.
THERE ARE A LOT OF IMPACTS TO
CONSUMERS AND AGAIN WE WOULD
ARGUE THAT CONSUMERS WANT
CHOICES AND WE TRY TO PROVIDE
THEM FOR THEM IF ANYBODY'S BEEN
DOWN THE AISLE IN THEIR
SUPERMARKET ANYTIME SOON THEY
COULD SEE THERE'S A WHOLE ISLAND.
SO DOZEN WATERS AND TEASE SORES
AND TEASE IS A WHOLE NOTHER
ISLAND WATERS AND JUICES AND
OTHER CHOICES AS WELL WE THINK
ALL CHOICES OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE SAME KIND OF CONSUMER
BENEFIT MEANING A DISCOUNT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
HEARING CAREER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION SOME PARKS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
AMUSEMENT PARKS THEME PARKS
WATER PARKS AND FAMILY
ENTERTAINMENT CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- I WANTED OFFER A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
AND THAT'S FOCUSING ON THE
PROMOTION -- THE NATURE OF THE
PROMOTIONS -- MUSE BUT PARKS
ENTER INTO CONTRACTS WITH
BEVERAGE -- COMPANIES AND
FREQUENTLY THE PROMOTIONS ARE
PART OF THAT CONTRACT.
AND THE YOU KNOW THE THE
PROMOTIONS THAT YOU KNOW WOULD
AFFECT THE THEME PARKS ARE THE
ONES THAT YOU SEE IN A BRING IN
A CAN.
AND GET AT A DISCOUNT ON YOUR
PARK TICKET.
AND THE ANOTHER ONE WOULD BE --
SOMETIMES THE BEVERAGE COMPANY
WILL ARRANGE FOR US TO HAVE A
PROMOTION WITHIN THE RESTAURANTS.
THIS IS A GREAT MARKETING TOOL
FOR CALIFORNIANS AMUSEMENT PARKS
WHICH ARE A HUGE ECONOMIC DRIVER
IN THE STATE.
AND ADDITIONALLY.
THERE.
THE THE PARKS USE THESE TO
OFFSET BUDGETS FOR EXAMPLE
YOU'LL SEE THE REFRIGERATORS
THAT MAY BE BRANDED.
BUT THEY GOT THOSE FOR FREE SO
IN OFFICE AS AN A BUDGET A
BUDGET EXPENSE FOR THE PARKS AND
AT WITH THE UMBRELLAS TO YOU'LL
SEE THOSE BRANDED.
THE USE THIS TO BRING DOWN AT
THEIR OPERATING COSTS.
AND THE BIGGEST IMPACT THOUGH I
THINK IS THAT.
THESE KIND OF PROMOTIONS THEY
DRIVE ATTENDANCE TO CALIFORNIA'S
PARKS.
WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW MILLIONS OF VISITORS
EVERY YEAR BUT THAT NUMBER IS
GREATLY INCREASED BY THESE
PROMOTIONS IN THAT TENS TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- AND THEN YOU KNOW
MANY OF YOU HAVE KIDS WHEN YOU
WANT TO GO TO A THEME PARK YOU
PROBABLY DO LIKE I'VE ALWAYS
DONE YOU GO ONLINE AND YOU LOOK
FOR DISCOUNTED TICKETS.
FREQUENTLY THAT WILL POP UP IN
YOUR IN YOUR GOOGLE SEARCH
YOU'LL SEE -- I CAN GO GET A CAN
OF SODA AND USE THAT FREQUENTLY
THE CANS ARE EVEN CONSUMED BUT
THEY ARE USED TO GET THAT
DISCOUNT AT THE GATE -- SO AGAIN
THERE'S A GREAT MARKETING TOOL
THAT GETS YOUR PARKS NAMES OUT
INTO GROCERY STORES AND IN MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS.
IT IS DRIVES ATTENDANCE AND IT
HELPS FAMILIES AFFORD A GREAT
DAY OF FUN IN ONE OF MANY
CALIFORNIANS THEME PARKS THANK
YOU.
YOU HAVE LESS THAN A MINUTE SO
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- BERMAN
ABILITY ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN A PATROLMAN CONVENIENCE
STORE ASSOCIATION THIRTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS STRONG.
I'M GOING TO ECHO WITH JOHN AND
THE OTHER LADY SAID LADY
MENTIONED THAT THE RESTRICTIONS
PROPOSED IN THIS LEGISLATION
KIND OF A RAISES SOME REALLY.
SERIOUS CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
AND THE PUBLIC POTENTIAL --
COMMERCIAL FREE SPEECH UNDER THE
FIRST AMENDMENT -- FOR THE MORE
THE LEGISLATION INTERFERES WITH.
THE OPERATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
VENDORS AND OUR RETAILERS -- IN
A MANNER THAT UP PLACES BOTH --
BRICKS AND MORTAR BUSINESSES IN
A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE IS
OUT WITH THEIR ONLINE
COMPETITORS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
AND JUST YOUR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
CAVENDER CHECK KARA A PCA
PRESIDENT SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE
THIS.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS SUMMER GAETA SMALLEY
I'M OF LOCAL -- SACRAMENTO
BUSINESS OWNER AND A WHOLESALER
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE CHAU.
I'M A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND
BEHALF OF OTHER SMALL BUSINESSES
IN SACRAMENTO CITY ICE TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL LET THE ADULT PEOPLE
CHOOSE THE RIGHT. TO DRINK OR
EAT THANK YOU JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
HELLO NURSE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
GREG HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE CAN
MANUFACTURES INSTITUTE OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
THROW COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY SO
SHE XIN ALSO OPPOSED A BECAUSE
THE BILL WOULD APPLY. TO A
TWELVE OUNCE TRANSACTION
MANAGEMENT.
GRADUATION OR MORE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUDY IS THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION.
JOHN WINGER ON THE OTHER
CALIFORNIA FUELS AND CONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITHOUT GOOD THANK YOU.
DRUG RIGHT POLICY MANNER MANAGER
LA COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION.
ROBERT DOWNEY WITH CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATIC MANY COUNCIL IN
pOPPOSITION.
NOT CERTAIN OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
LO THESE RUMORS WITH THE
ORGANIZING LEADERSHIP ACADEMY
AND I APOLOGIZE WE MISTER QUEUE
BUT I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS JASMINE I'M IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ISAAC TYSON AND I'M
IN HIGH SCHOOL I ALSO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CHRISTIAN GARCIA WITH THE
ORGANIZING LEADERSHIP AND CAT
ANY IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS POINT.
ANYBODY ELSE'S SUPPORT FOR
ANYBODY ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S AN OPEN MIKE [inaudible]
JUST KIDDING.
AND WE DON'T DO KARAOKE SO --
WITH THAT I WOULD -- NO MORE
WITH NO MORE SPEAKERS WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MR BIGELOW.
YEAH.
MR BONTA COULD COULD YOU.
AS YOU VISION YOUR BILL.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN.
WHAT'S ALLOWED WHAT'S NOT
ALLOWED HOW USE ENVISIONED THE
MARKETING.
ASPECT OF THIS -- BUILD MOVING
FORWARD AND THE IMPACTS.
CAN YOU MAYBE HIT ON THOSE
POINTS [inaudible]
YES.
SO THE IDEA IS TO PREVENT A BIG
A COMMON PRACTICE THAT I BELIEVE
IS MANIPULATE THE MARKET AND IN
HIS PREDATORY.
FROM CONTINUING TO TAKE PLACE
WITH RESPECT TO SUGARY BEVERAGES.
IF SOMEONE WISHES [inaudible]
TO VIED.
PRICE SUBSIDIES REFORM OF
COUPONS -- OR OTHER AB FINANCIAL
ARRANGEMENTS.
FOR WATER. FOR HEALTHY BEVERAGES
THEY MAY OUR BILL DOES NOT
PREVENT THAT.
BUT IT DOES GO AFTER NOT THE
EXCLUSIVE DRIVER BUT A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR. TO AN
EPIDEMIC THAT WE'RE FACING A
PUBLIC HEALTH.
I WITH RESPECT TO DIABETES AND
AND HEART DISEASE AND TOOTH
DECAY AND OBESITY AND THAT IS
SUGARY BEVERAGES WE KNOW OF FROM
THE CDC THAT FORTY SEVEN POINT
1% OF ADDED CALORIES COME FROM
SERVICE WITH BEVERAGES.
CONSUMPTION MAY BE DECLINING --
IN SOME FORMS -- BUT THAT NUMBER
IS WAY TOO HIGH AND WE KNOW FROM
THE STATS -- THAT THE RESTORE
PUBLIC HEALTH SO THE FOCUS IS ON
SUGARY BEVERAGES IT'S NOT ON
BRANDING OF OF PRODUCTS -- IT'S
IT'S THE MANUFACTURER'S COUPONS
AND THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
DISTRIBUTORS AND RETAILERS. TO
REDUCE THE PRICE IN WHAT ARE
IDENTIFIED.
BY THE COMPANIES THEMSELVES AS
UNDER PERFORMING MARKETS MARKETS
THAT AREN'T.
DRINKING ENOUGH FOR THEIR SODA
OF THE SUGARY BEVERAGE.
AND WE ARE WE KNOW THAT WOULD
YES BUT THE OUTCOME WHAT I THINK
THE OUTCOME IS.
CONSUMERS ARE HIGHLY PRICE
SENSITIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
SUGARY BEVERAGES THIS IS THE THE
THE DATA SHOWS THAT IT'S HIGHLY
ELASTIC THAT WHEN PRICES -- GO
DOWN CONSUMPTION GOES UP.
WHEN PRICES GO UP [inaudible]
CONSUMPTION -- GOES DOWN.
SO WE EXPECT THERE TO BE LESS
CONSUMPTION [inaudible]
OF A ONE DRIVER OF OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT CAN -- EPIDEMIC AND
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING --
AND IF IT.
IF IF BUT THE OPPOSITION SAYS IS
TRUE ABOUT.
SOME OF THE CONSUMPTION GOING
DOWN AND THIS BILL HAVE TO GO
DOWN FURTHER.
GOOD WE LIKE THAT OUTCOME THAT'S
THE DESIRED OUTCOME.
SO IT IT SEEKS TO END DATE --
MANIPULATIVE MARKETING PRACTICE --
IN ORDER TO ENHANCE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS.
STE SO JUST JUST AS ONE READING
THROUGH THAT -- MAYBE I MISSED
THE PART BUT I THOUGHT IT JUST
KIND OF RELATED TO ALL PRODUCTS
PROVIDED SO I WANT TO BE GOOD.
I WANT TO ASK THE QUESTION OF OF
MAYBE THE OPPOSITION OR THE
FOLKS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
AISLE.
DO YOU READ IT THE SAME WAY DOES
IT ANCHOR ALL PRODUCTS OR IS IT
LIMITED TO JUST SUGAR.
PRODUCT IF YOU KNOW WE READ THE
BILL AS ALL SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES -- THE DEFINITION OF
WHICH IS FROM FROM OUR
REDEFINITION WHICH IS ANYTHING
OVER TWENTY CALORIES WOULD BE
CONSIDERED SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGE AND THEREFORE A COUPON
OR ANY KIND OF PROMOTIONAL
ACTIVITY GET NOT JUST COUPON
WOULD BE PERHAPS [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
SO IS ACTUALLY IN YOUR MIND IN
YOUR MIND ELIMINATES EVERYTHING.
YEAH EVERY SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGE POSSIBILITY FOR ANY
KIND OF PROMOTIONAL ACTIVITY YES.
AND HOW WILL THAT BE DETRIMENTAL
TO THE HOW DETRIMENTAL WOULD
THAT BE FOR OUR DESTINATIONS
[inaudible]
MR ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW AND
I'VE RECEIVED REPORTS FROM
SEVERAL OF OUR PARKS THAT THEY
TRACK THE PROMOTIONS AND ON ANY
GIVEN DAY THAT THERE ARE
PROMOTIONS AND AFFECTED CAN
INCREASE -- ATTENDANCE BY ABOUT
A THOUSAND OR SO -- SO THIS
WOULD DEFINITELY YOU KNOW IMPACT
OUR ABILITY TO DRIVE ATTENDANCE
AT THE GATES [inaudible]
OKAY.
WELL AGAIN I'LL JUST GO BACK
INTO CHAIR.
MY READING WAS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE ISSUES OF TWELVE
OUNCES -- WITH TWELVE OR TWENTY
CALORIES OR MORE.
THAT'S QUALIFIED AS A LOW -- CAL
BEVERAGE COUNTY YOU KNOW CALORIE
BEVERAGE.
SO I'M I'M THINKING THIS IS
GONNA.
INCLUDE EVERYTHING AND IT'S
GONNA BE PRETTY.
PRETTY DIFFICULT FOR US TO TO
MANAGE OR FOR ANY.
INSTITUTION IS TRYING TO MARKET
THEIR PRODUCTS ANYWAY I'M NOT
SURE I QUITE GET THERE WITH YOU
TODAY MISTER BOND.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU THANK
MISTER BIGELOW OTHER QUESTIONS
CONCERNS FROM COMMITTEE.
SHARES ROSE CLARIFICATION ON THE
EXCLUDE SOME PART OF THE
DEFINITION OF SS BE.
I'M IN ONE OF THOSE OR IS IT
TALKS ABOUT THE EXCLUSION BEING
BOTTLED SS BE SYRUP SOME POWDER
SO TO THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT.
AND AMERICAN INDIAN TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IS THAT CLEAR TO SAY
THAT EXCLUDES THAT FROM BEING
PART OF THIS [inaudible]
THAT'S CLEAR.
THAT'S RIGHT THE BILL YES.
SO IF I'M READING THAT READ
EXCLUDING THEM ALLOWS FOR THE
SALE TO CONTINUE.
YES THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CNN WILL BRING BACK TO THE
AUTHOR WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
YES I I APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS BILL
I I ALSO APPRECIATE THE INPUT
FROM THE OPPOSITION -- GIVEN%
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE SUCCESS
OF OUR BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA --
I I DO WATCH ONE IS A QUICK
POINT ABOUT OUR OUR MISSION
PARKS.
IT YOU KNOW THE IDEA THAT ARE
MUSEUM PARKS -- WILL ONLY BE
SUCCESSFUL OR IF YOU HAVE A
RANGE OF WHERE YOU DRINK A SODA
YOU GO TO THE AMUSEMENT PARK.
I I THINK I'M USING PARKS A MUCH
MORE THAN THAT I THINK PEOPLE GO
BECAUSE ALL THE THINGS THAT WERE
SAID THEY GO WITH THE FAMILY I
TAKE MY FAMILY I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF REASONS THAT CALIFORNIA
ENJOY THAT AS PART OF WHO WE ARE
AND AND AND PART.
OF OUR OUR SOCIAL EXPERIENCE SO --
I DON'T THINK THEY NEED.
TO BE PART OF WHAT IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EPIDEMIC BY ALL MEASURES.
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL I
THINK THEY'LL BE SUCCESSFUL WITH
WITHOUT -- THAT PRACTICE AND SO
THIS THIS REALLY TARGETS ONE
SPECIFIC PRACTICE WHICH I
BELIEVE IS PREDATORY WHICH IS
MANIPULATIVE -- WHICH TARGETS
PHONE OF A POPULATIONS AND ADDS
TO AN ALREADY UNACCEPTABLE
EPIDEMIC AND I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO HELP
ADDRESS THIS EPIDEMIC WITH THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS.
I HAVE I I WOULD DO OKAY THANK
YOU HAVE YOU DO OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BEFORE EVER APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION ON BOTH SIDES AS DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
BUT WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
AGUILAR CURRY.
AND AS SECOND BY I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
MISS MCCARTY OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
SO WE HAVE MET A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- WILL GO AHEAD AND THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND HAVE BEEN
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT
I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY I GET CREE AYE
BIGELOW.
NO BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BY.
I BURKE.
BURKE I WICKS [inaudible]
FLORA.
FLOOR NO LIMóN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RAMOS NO RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON. THREE OF FIVE VOTES
BELIEVE THE BILL ON CALL HIM AT
A MEMBERS MISSING THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THINKING
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF AS
MISTER BLOOM IS COMING UP.
A COUPLE ADDITIONAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS -- FIRST VOTE
TODAY MY APOLOGIES FOR NOT
MENTION THIS EARLIER I MISS
WEEKS WILL BE FILLING IN FOR
MISS CARILLO -- FOR THIS MEETING
ONLY SO SHE WILL BE JOINING US
AT SOME POINT -- AND THEN SECOND --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE BY MISS WEEKS HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
TODAY.
SO MISTER BLOOM WILL BE
PRESENTING A. B. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT MR BLOOM [inaudible]
SHARE [inaudible]
THIS.
THE SCIENCES IS OVERWHELMING
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND RATES OF TYPE
TWO DIABETES AND OBESITY HAVE
RISEN DRAMATICALLY OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL DECADES.
TODAY NEARLY THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE DIABETIC.
MILLIONS MORE WILL BECOME
DIABETIC.
THESE HEALTH IMPACTS ARE FELT
HARDEST IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WITH
BLACK LATINO AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
DIABETES AT RATES TWICE AS HIGH.
AS THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS.
THE HUMAN TOLL OF THIS HEALTH
CRISIS IS AMOUNTS.
KIDNEY FAILURE HIGH AMPUTATION
RATES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AND THE ECONOMIC IMPACT IS NO
SMALL MATTER.
DIABETES ALONE COST THE STATE AN
ESTIMATED TWENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
IN DIRECT MEDICAL EXPENSES AND
IS DRIVING UP SYSTEM WIDE HEALTH
CARE COSTS.
PATIENTS WITH DIABETES ACCOUNT
FOR ONE IN THREE
HOSPITALIZATIONS. ONE IN.
THREE THESE COSTS ARE BORNE BY
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND BY THE
STATE THROUGH INCREASED SPENDING
ON MEDICARE ALL.
AS DAUNTING AS THE HEALTH CRISIS
IS TODAY WE HAVE AN
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY TO ACT
ON THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
AND AGAIN.
LET ME REPEAT THE SCIENCES
OVERWHELMING.
SUGARY DRINKS HAVE PLAYED A
UNIQUE ROLE IN DRIVING THE
HEALTH EPIDEMIC THAT WE FACE
TODAY.
THEY ARE THE SINGLE LARGEST
SOURCE OF ADDED SUGAR IN THE
AMERICAN DIET.
AND LEAD TO INCREASED RISK OF
DIABETES HEART DISEASE LIVER
DISEASE OBESITY TOOTH DECAY.
AND EVEN SOME CANCERS.
AND NO IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
CALORIES SUGARY DRINKS ARE
UNIQUELY ON HEALTHY.
THEY ARE EMPTY CALORIES THAT ARE
METABOLIZED QUICKLY IN A WAY
THAT CAN OVERWHELM THE PANCREAS
AND LEAD TO THE KIND OF WEIGHT
GAIN THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
AS WELL AS PROSTATE AND BREAST
CANCER.
ABOUT HALF OF ADULTS IN TWO
THIRDS OF YOUTH CONSUMER SUGARY
DRINK.
EVERY DAY.
ON AVERAGE CHILDREN CONSUME OVER
THIRTY GALLONS OF SUGARY DRINKS
EVERY YEAR THAT'S ENOUGH TO FILL
A BATH TUB.
AND SO HERE WE ARE WITH THE
HEALTH CRISIS.
AND LITTLE TO NO PREVENTION
FUNDING.
AND WITH THE PRODUCT IN AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS.
TRULY.
A UNIQUE AND THAT'S WHERE.
MY BILL COMES IN AB ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PROPOSES TO LEVY A TWO
CENT PER OUNCE.
UGH UGH THAT FLUID OUNCE.
TAX ON SUGARY DRINKS THE REVENUE
OF WHICH WOULD BE USED TO
CONFRONT THESE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS HAD ON THROUGH
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HARSH HARDEST HIT BY
THE DIABETES.
AND OBESITY EPIDEMICS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS DESIGNED TO DO
TWO THINGS FIRST REDUCE
CONSUMPTION ANDSECOND.
RAISE THE FUNDING NEEDED TO
EDUCATE AND EMPOWER CALIFORNIANS
TO LIVE HEALTHIER LIVES A GOAL I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON THIS
BILL HOLDS IMMENSE POTENTIAL TO
COUNTERACT THE ALARMING HEALTH
TRENDS THAT WE'VE WITNESS.
CITIES AROUND THE U. S. AND
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD HAVE
ALREADY PASSED THEIR OWN SUGARY
DRINK TAXES WHO WOULDN'T BE
FIRST IN THIS.
AND THEY'VE SEEN POSITIVE
RESULTS NEARBY A FEE BY A FEE
AND BERKELEY REDUCE CONSUMPTION
BY ALMOST 10% OVERALL.
AND 21% IN LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THAT'S JUST
WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR.
CONSUMPTION OF TAP AND BOTTLED
WATER INCREASED BY AN ESTIMATED
63%.
IN MEXICO A SUGARY DRINK TAX
REDUCE PURCHASES OF THESE -- BY
FIVE POINT 5% IN THE FIRST YEAR
AND NINE POINT 7% IN THE SECOND
YEAR.
IN ADDITION TO REDUCING
CONSUMPTION.
REVENUES WERE HELP FUND
IMPORTANT PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
EVERYTHING FROM SCHOOL NURSES TO
NUTRITION EDUCATION TO PHYSICAL
EDUCATION.
AND ACCESS TO SAFE.
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE FOR WORKING WITH ME
ON LANGUAGE REGARDING EXACTLY
THAT TOPIC AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
AND I WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW THAT
I'M COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE FUNDS
ARE DEDICATED TO THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS PILOT PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL HELP CONFERENCE
RECIPIENTS AFFORDABLY ACCESS
DRINKING WATER [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA'S INACTION ON THE
SEWERS ISSUE IS NO LONGER
EXCUSABLE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN NO LONGER
PASSED THEIR OWN ORDINANCES.
A POLICY THAT THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY FOUGHT.
FOR AND AS YOU ALL REMEMBER
STRONG ARMED THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST SESSION.
I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION.
THE FIRST IS THAT SIN TAXES
DON'T ACTUALLY CHANGE BEHAVIOR
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT IS
DEMONSTRABLY FALSE.
WE HAVE DECADES OF EVIDENCE FROM
TOBACCO TAXES THAT HAVE SHOWN
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS AT REDUCING
TOBACCO USE AND IMPROVING HEALTH
OUT OUTCOMES.
AS I AS I MENTIONED WE ALSO HAVE
IT OF EVIDENCE FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE PASSED
THEIR OWN SUGARY DRINK TAXES.
AND I'D LIKE TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT IMMEDIATE
REDUCTION IN CONSUMPTION IS ONLY
PART OF THE BILL'S GOAL THE
SECOND LONG TERM GOAL.
WHICH IS EQUALLY IF NOT MORE
IMPORTANT IS TO CREATE A
DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE FOR
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
ANOTHER CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED BY OPPOSITION IS THAT THE
BILL WOULD NOT ACTUALLY HAVE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
AS MUCH AS WE LOVE INSTANT
GRATIFICATION TRANSFORMING
HEALTH OUTCOMES DOES TAKE TIME.
AND WE KNOW THAT SUGARY DRINK
TAXES REDUCE CONSUMPTION AND WE
ALSO HAVE A LITANY OF HEALTH
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW ARE
EFFECTIVE.
IF WE COULD JUST FUND THE AND OF
COURSE WE HAVE THE TOBACCO TAX
EXAMPLE THAT HAS OVER TIME
DEMONSTRABLY AFFECTED THE HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS OF AMERICANS OF
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD. FOR THE
BETTER.
THE COALITION OPPOSE LETTER IN
ARGUING IT'S POINTS LINKS TO THE
HEARTLAND INSTITUTE.
A THINK TANK KNOWN FOR ITS
PARTNERSHIP WITH PHILIP MORRIS
TO UNDERMINE TOBACCO TAXES.
AND AS WELL IT'S CLIMATE DENIAL
RESEARCH.
BACKING FOR THE COALITION'S
CLAIMS ALSO COMES FROM
RESEARCHERS AT THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND HEALTH
WHICH IS AN INDUSTRY FUNDED
SCIENCE GROUP.
THAT ADVOCATES AGAINST CHEMICAL
AND HEALTH REGULATIONS AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
FINALLY THOUGH THE INDUSTRY
ARGUES THAT THE COULD BE JOBS
AND ECONOMIC IMPACT -- NUMEROUS
STUDIES FROM BERKELEY AND FROM
PHILADELPHIA HAVE SHOWN THAT
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY THE CASE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE ARE A ARE IMMENSE COSTS TO
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IF WE
LEAVE THIS CRISIS UNCHECKED.
AND THINK ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR PEOPLE THAT WE ALL KNOW
WHO ARE AFFECTED BY THE DISEASES
THAT I HAVE MENTIONED.
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A PRICE TAG
AND YET.
WE CAN EXPECT IMPROVEMENTS IF WE
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS INITIATIVE.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN STUDY AFTER STUDY THAT
CONFIRMS THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
SUGARY DRINKS AND I'D BE THIS.
THE SCIENCE IS QUITE CLEAR.
WE'VE WITNESSED LANCS THE
INDUSTRY WILL GO TO TO PROFIT
CONSUMERS EXPENSE MUCH LIKE BIG
TOBACCO DID INCLUDING MISLEADING
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
TARGETING CHILDREN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
SUPPORT HAS GROWN IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MEDICAL COMMUNITIES
IN RESPONSE TO BOTH THE
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE WHICH IS
COPIOUS.
AND THE RESULTS FROM OTHER
SUGARY DRINK DRINK TAXES.
IT IS NOW TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
STEP UP AND DO ITS PART.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE JASMINE TORONTO A
STUDENT FROM STOCKTON AND MONICA
MATOS A PEDIATRICIAN TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
ADDITIONALLY WITH ME HERE TODAY
ARE LAURA PALMER AND CAN AFFECT
TO RESEARCHERS WITH THE
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE.
WHO WILL BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON THE
SCIENCE OF SUGARY DRINKS?
AND THE IMPACT OF SUGARY DRINK
TAXES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER BLOOM QUIT WITH YOUR
WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NUMBER NINE
NAME IS DOCTOR MONICA MATHIS AND
I AM A PEDIATRICIAN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS.
IN CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS OVER
FIVE THOUSAND BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIANS I APPRECIATE
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
AS PEDIATRICIANS EVERY DAY MY
COLLEAGUES AND I SEE CHILDREN
HARMED BY SUGARY DRINKS FROM THE
TEAM THAT'S DIAGNOSED WITH TYPE
TWO DIABETES TO THE TODDLER RT
SHOWING SIGNS OF FATTY LIVER
DISEASE.
A DIFFICULT CHILD IS MENTIONED
CONSUMES OVER THIRTY GALLONS OF
SUGARY DRINKS EVERY YEAR CURRENT
DIETARY GUIDELINES RECOMMEND
THAT CHILDREN AND TEENS CONSUME
FEWER THAN 10% OF CALORIES FROM
ADDED SUGARS.
BUT DATA SHOWS THAT THE NOW
CONSUME NEARLY DOUBLE THAT
RECOMMENDED LET ME AND MORE THAN
HALF OF IT COMING FROM SUGARY
DRINKS.
WHILE INDIVIDUAL CHOICES IN
CREATING A HEALTHY HOME
ENVIRONMENT ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THEY ARE NOT ENOUGH
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT.
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY APPROACHES
WERE NECESSARY TO CURB TOBACCO
AND ALCOHOL USE AND WE NEED
SIMILAR INITIATIVES TO REDUCE
SUGARY TRIP AND DRINK
CONSUMPTION IN CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS.
AS TOBACCO TAXES INCREASED IT'S
A GREAT USED DROP PRECIPITOUSLY
ALCOHOL TAXES REDUCE EXCESS
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION AND ALCOHOL
ASSOCIATE MOTOR VEHICLE
AND EXCISE TAXES ON SUGARY
DRINKS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY REDUCED
CONSUMPTION IN CITIES LIKE
BERKELEY AND SAN FRANCISCO.
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT SUGARY
DRINK WOULD BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO LOWER
RATES OF CHILD THROUGH THE CITY
LEADING TO PREVENTION OF OBESITY
IN OVER FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN.
AND A TEN YEAR NATION MY SAVINGS
OF THIRTY ONE DOLLARS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT.
OPPONENTS ARGUE THAT THE TAXES
CAN BE REGRESSIVE AS LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS BEAR GREATER
BURDEN FROM THE TAX.
HOWEVER WHEN THAT WHEN THE
MONIES RAISED PAY FOR PROGRAMS
THAT WILL REDUCE HEALTH
INEQUITIES THE COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY THE TAX ARE THE SAME
COMMUNITIES WHO BENEFIT MOST
FROM BOTH AN ECONOMIC IN HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE.
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION HAVE TOTALLY INDOORS
SUGARY TAXES LIKE THE ONE IN AB.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT TO REDUCE
EXCESS SUGAR CONSUMPTION IMPROVE
HEALTH AND SAVE LIVES EVERY
CHILD DESERVES TO GROW UP
HEALTHY I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS JASMINE I CAME
HERE WITH ISAAC.
WE BOTH CAME FROM WE BOTH CAME
FROM A YOUTH PROGRAM OF TWENTY
BUT WE DIDN'T COME HERE WITH
JUST A TWO PERSON ARMY.
WE BOUGHT THOUSANDS WE ABOUT
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE GREEN WITH
THIS BILL THESE THESE ARE THESE
PEOPLE -- PAPERS ARE FILLED WITH
PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY MANY MORE OUT
MANY OF MY HOURS AND OTHERS HAVE
BEEN WASTED BECAUSE YOU ALLOWED
TO SIT ON PASSED ON AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE THOUSANDS OF
LIVES.
IN THOUSAND COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO BE TO CONTINUE TO
SELL THE SHARES.
WELL YOU IN THE RIGHT YOU WERE
THERE WE WERE WALKING A HUNDRED
RE HE FOR THE FUTURE YOU
CURRENTLY TOSSED AWAY MY FATHER
A DIABETIC ON DIALYSIS MY
BROTHER PRE DIABETIC MY NIECE.
WHO'S OVERWEIGHT SHE SPENT SUGAR
BECAUSE HER MOTHER DOESN'T KNOW
BETTER.
YOUR YOUR WHAT YOUR LOVE WOULD
RIGHT NOW STRENGTHENING THEIR
LIFE WAY AND YOUR LIVING HAPPEN
BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING PAID.
YOU'RE LETTING US.
YOU'RE TELLING YOU TOLD US THAT.
YOU TELL US AT THIS WILL ONLY
HURT ARE COMMITTED BY NATIONALLY
BUT WE CAN'T AFFORD THE WATER
BUT THEN YOU TURN AROUND
EXPRESSED EXPECTED TO PAY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN MEDICAL
BILLS. FOR DISEASES THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN EASILY PREVENTED IF WE
HAD MORE OPPORTUNITIES OR
KNOWLEDGE WE COULD SEE.
WE STAND HERE TODAY HOPING FOR
YOU TO KEEP A PROMISE YOU TOLD%
US.
FROM SOME FROM THE SUMMER YOU
WILL HELP US BRING A BRIGHTER
FUTURE IF WE RETURN APPEARED
ONCE MORE AND NOW WE HEAR IT
AGAIN.
A NUMBER ON MY HEAD A 50% CHANCE
OF GETTING DIABETES IN MY
COMMUNITY.
THAT THAT AND NUMBER AS A
RESPECTED MY FATHER MY MOTHER MY
SISTER MY BROTHER AND IT'S ABOUT
AFFECT MY LITTLE NIECE ONE WILL
EFFECT ME.
WHEN WE INCREASE THE CHANGE
UNTIL IT COMES ACROSS ME INTO A
TRANCE TAKE MY LIFE?
PLEASE URGE YOU TO VOTE FOR AB
ONE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NOTHING AWESOME UP WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH THIS ISSUE WITH PLEASED
TO CO SPONSOR STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU.
THERE ARE STILL SO JUST LEARNING
STOOD OUT OF INGLEWOOD -- WITH
THE CALIFORNIA.
SORRY BUT WE ARE SUPPORT -- IS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE INCLUSION OF
THE EQUITY FROM.
SARAH CHANG ALSO FROM THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE LEARNING INSTITUTE IN
INGLEWOOD IN SUPPORT WITH THE
EQUITY FOR MARK THANK YOU.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
RICK THAT TODD WALKER I'M
CARDIOLOGISTS IN SANTA MONICA
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
A REAL CARDIOLOGISTS IN TORRANCE
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA.
CHAPTER THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
CONDUCTOR DANIEL JR WHAT'S --
CARDIOLOGISTS IN SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
I'M DOCTOR JOHN BAKER I AM IN
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL ALSO WANTED TO SAY
THAT OBESITY IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS IN.
OUR NATION RIGHT NOW CHILDHOOD
OBESITY THIS IS A HUGE STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION WE DEAL WITH THE
FACTS OF DIABETES ALL THE TIME
IN OUR GROUPS -- WE DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU SUGGEST YOUR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE IN BREAKING
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EVERY OTHER MADE AS WITH THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL DIMMICK ROUTED CHANGE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DEANGELO MAC PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RONALD KOEMAN ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DARIA GREW CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MONIQUE BLODGETT BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I VOLUNTEER FOR THE
THIRTY FOR CHANGE PROGRAM MADE
POSSIBLE BY THE SUGAR TAX I
SUPPORT.
HOLLY SHADER COMMISSIONER ON THE
BERKELEY SUGARY DRINK COMMISSION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VICTOR CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA
HELPLESS ADVOCATES ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DR ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
LIKE HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
ARE DISCUSSED IN HONG CALIFORNIA
PEN AT THE CULT NETWORKING
SUPPORT. THIRTY ONE REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT.
ARMONK IN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR THE SPELLING OF YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ISAACS HYPHEN IN
MY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT FROM
STOCKTON WHO SORT OF WORKED ON A
SIMILAR PROJECT FOR THE LOCAL
SENATE TAX AND I'M ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
OR GARGLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PATRON WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT -- MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR DIAMOND LEANS ACKERMAN A
PEDIATRICIAN IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR ACTUALLY CHIEF DONE
OFFICER LOOKING TO GO THAT
ADDRESSING IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF PUTTING TOGETHER A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION ON THE MEASURE
TO CLARIFY HOW THIS BILL WOULD
IMPACT THE GENERAL FUND IMPROPER
NINETY EIGHT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO TAKING A SUPPORT POSITION
VERY SOON.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
SEE NO -- ONE OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN NUMBERS.
SAID RICK MCGEE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THIS
AFTERNOON.
FIRST OF ALL WHEN A POINT OUT
THAT WE MAKE THESE LABELS ABOUT
SUGARY SWEET BEVERAGES BUT THE
DEFINITIONS KEEP ROTATING FROM
ONE TO ANOTHER.
THIS YEAR -- AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT
HAS A DEFINITION LEVEL FOR
SERVICE WE BEVERAGE AT TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE CALORIES IN A
TWELVE OUNCE SERVING.
DIFFERENT THAN IT HAS BEEN IN
THE PAST WHICH WAS AT SEVENTY
FIVE CALORIES HUGE DIFFERENCE
OUR COMPANIES HAVE BEEN WORKING
OVER SEVERAL YEARS. TO TRY TO
HAVE MORE INCREASE LOW AND NO
CALORIE BEVERAGES -- THERE'S A
TYPICAL SO TO WOULD BE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY CALORIES THIS NOW WITH
CAPTURE SAY ITS HEAT THAT HAS
FIFTY CALORIES IN IT AND NOW
WOULD BE TAX ON IT SO WE'RE
TRYING TO MOVE PEOPLE. TO THOSE
HEALTHIER OPTIONS HOPEFULLY DOWN
TO A ZERO OPTION -- THAT IS NOW
TAX -- OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
60% OF OUR NEW BRAND PRODUCTS
HAVE BEEN LOWER NO CALORIE
BEVERAGES WHAT ARE STILL SAY
THAT 50% OF WHAT SOLD UP OUR
PRODUCT OUR ZERO CALORIE
PRODUCTS.
I'M SO THIS WOULD CAPTURING IT --
MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED A LITTLE
EARLIER IN THE OF TESTIMONY ON
THE EARLIER BILL IS THAT
CONSUMPTION IS DOWN 2526% IN
ADULTS THIRTY FIVE POINT 9% IN
USE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THE OBESITY
RATES HAVE GONE UP THIRTY AND
33% AT THE SAME TIME PERIOD.
SO OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
THE US DOUBT -- CALORIES DIET
HAS GONE UP FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE CALORIES SO THE
AVERAGE PERSON IS CONSUMING MORE
THAN. FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
CALORIES MORE PER DAY THAN THEY
HAD IN THE PAST.
MOST OF THAT 38% IS NOT -- IS
COMING FROM STARCHESSOLD MOST
OF THOSE EXTRA CALORIES A WE ARE
CONSUMING IT IS NOT JUST
CIGARETTES START IN FACT AS WELL
SO WE ARE INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF CALORIES THAT WE ARE
CONSUMING.
EVERY DAY EVERYONE LOVES TO TALK
ABOUT BERKELEY AS A SUCCESS RATE.
AND BERKELEY DID PASS IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN BUT THE
REALITY OF IT IS IS THAT
BERKELEY WHEN THE THE COLLEAGUES
ONLY DID -- THE STUDY THEMSELVES
IN BERKELEY THEY INDICATED THAT --
THE CALORIE CONSUMPTION FROM
SODAS WENT DOWN -- SIX CALORIES
PER DAY WHICH DOESN'T EVEN
INDICATING ANY KIND OF WEIGHT
LOSS BUT THEY STARTED DRINKING
SMOOTHIES AND SO THEIR CALORIE
COUNT WENT UP THIRTY TWO
CALORIES A DAY.
AND SO BERKELEY ALSO SAYS --
WE'VE HAD THIS DECREASE BUT
THERE THERE ARE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE HAS BEGUN INCREASING AND
BERKELEY SO IT THAT'S ON
BERKELEY'S WEBSITE SO IT CAN'T
BE GOING DOWN AND YOUR REVENUES
ARE CONTINUING TO GO UP.
THERE WAS JUST A GATE STUDY BAD
WAS FUNDED NOT BY OUR INDUSTRY
BUT THE GATES FAMILY THAT WAS A
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS WORLD WIDE
STUDY OF WHAT WE'RE CONSUMING.
AND THEY THOUGHT THAT SUGARY
DRINKS WOULD BE ON THE TOP OF
THAT LIST UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT PEOPLE WEREN'T
EATING HEALTHIER PRODUCTS SO WE
ACCESS TO FRESH FRUITS.
FRESH VEGETABLES AND THE
EXAMPLES WERE NOT JUST THE US
BUT ALSO IN MEXICO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AT THOSE WERE THE
FACTORS.
I'VE BEEN GIVEN TIME GO AHEAD
LET MY PROBABLY FINISHED.
I GOTTA TALK FASTER.
THIS GERMAN MEMBERS -- JOHN MY
RUN HAVE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION -- FIRST OF ALL ARM
OUR MEMBERS ARE OPPOSED -- TO
PRODUCT SPECIFIC TARGETED TAXES
AGAIN WE HAVE A PHILOSOPHY WE
WANT OUR ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS.
TO BE ABLE HAVE CHOICES AND WE
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD TAX THOSE
CHOICES -- WE SHOULD PROVIDE
THEM WITH A RANGE OF OPTIONS AND
LET THEM MAKE WHAT BUT HOPEFULLY
IS THE BEST OPTION FOR THEM -- I
DO WANT TO GO BACK TO DATA POINT
THAT GETS TRANSPOSED AWFUL LOT
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE MAY.
OFFERED BY THE PROPONENTS AND
THE AUTHOR THAT THAT ADDED
SUGARS THAT SOFT DRINKS SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES ARE THE
FOREIGN AWAY THE MAJORITY OF THE
CALORIES FROM ADDED SUGARS IN
OUR DIET.
AND WHILE I DON'T DISAGREE THAT
THE CDC NUMBERS TO TELL US THE
MOST RECENT ONES THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF CALORIES FROM
ADDED SUGARS IN OUR DIE.
FROM ALL BEVERAGES THAT ARE
SUGAR SWEETENED OR ABOUT 48% OF
THOSE CALORIES.
WHAT'S NOT CLEAR HOWEVER WE HAVE
TO BE CLEAR HEREIS THAT THE
CALORIES FROM ADDED SUGAR IN OUR
DIET OR LESS THAN 6% OF THE
CALORIES IN OUR DIET.
SO IT ISN'T THAT THE NUMBER OF
CALORIES FROM ADDED SUGAR THAT'S
COMING FROM SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES YES IT'S IT'S THE
LARGEST.
LARGEST PERCENTAGE NOT THE
MAJORITY TO LARGEST PERCENTAGE
BUT AS OF THE CALORIES OF ADDED
SUGAR AS AS MS -- AS FREDERICK
WAS SAYING A MOMENT AGO.
THE CALORIES THAT ARE DRIVING
THE CONSUMPTION PATTERN IN THE
AMERICAN DIET IN PARTICULAR ARE
NOT FROM BEVERAGES THERE FROM
MANY OTHER FOOD SOURCES
INCLUDING DAIRY PRODUCTS OVER
GRAIN PRODUCTS.
BEEF PRODUCTS ETCETERA ETCETERA
SO BUT IT'S AGAIN IT'S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THAT PROPER THAT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE DATA HERE -- FINAL
FINAL POINT AGAIN WE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY OPPOSED THESE
MEASURES -- THE ONE THING THAT
WE WOULDN'T DISPUTE -- THAT -- A
SOMEONE BLOOM SAID THERE IS A
CLEAR CAN'T BE IMPACTS CERTAINLY
ON OUR CONSUMERS AND IT MAY
CHOOSE THEM TO SWITCH.
BUT BUT THE INDUSTRY AND
RETAILERS HAVE GONE ON THEIR OWN
TO AGGRESSIVELY PUT MEANT
MULTIPLE OTHER CHOICES OUT THERE
FOR FOLKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ONCE
AGAIN YOU HAVE LESS ARGUMENT
JESUS CHRIST I FOLLOW THE TO
HARD ACT TO FOLLOW HERE --
BERMAN NOBLE VIA ON BEHALF OF
AFTER THE AMERICAN PETROLEUM AND
CONVENIENCE STORE ASSOCIATION --
WILL ECHOING WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SAID WERE OVER POSTED AB --
ONE THIRTY EIGHT ONE THE
BEHAVIOR DOESN'T CHANGE THE
BEHAVIOR PATTERNS -- POSITIVE
HEALTH EFFECTS EVEN THOUGH I
HAVE A TWO DAUGHTERS AT BOTH
GRADUATED FROM BERKELEY HAVE A
HIGHEST DEEPER BERKELEY BUT
THAT'S INCONCLUSIVE.
AND THREE IT'S A REVENUE
INSTABILITY.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MY NAME IS KEVIN -- CHECK KARAM
PRESIDENT AFTER ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED NINETY
ONE BUSINESSES I AM ALSO
DIABETIC I HAVE A CHOICE TO
CHOOSE I WANT MY CUSTOMERS TO
HAVE THE SAME CHOICE.
THANK YOU.
MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN OPPOSITION.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE OPPOSED AND IT IS ON OUR
JOB CODE LIST THANK YOU.
YOU'RE A GIRL AND THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTIONS AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
DROUGHT COOK CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
I'M SEVENTY SMALLEY FORM --
SACRAMENTO LOCAL A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND A WHOLESALER
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
IT WILL BE A CHAU A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND BEHALF OF FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESSES I OPPOSE
THIS BILL I'M BE DIABETIC AND
IT'S MY LIFESTYLE NOT SODA THANK
YOU.
BUT CERTAIN THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
TO THE TAX THAT COMES TO OUR
MEMBERS THINK.
DR RIGHT BIZ FED IN OPPOSITION.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA FEELS INCONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE POST.
THANK YOU. THIRTY YEARS OF
CALIFORNIA -- PRODUCERS SMALL
POSITION THANK YOU.
GREG ON OUR BEHALF WE CAN
MANUFACTURES INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
WERE OPPOSED.
ROBERT DOWNEY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA AUTOMATIC RENDERS
COUNCIL WE OPPOSE.
TENNIS Là PROBABLY HAVE
CALIFORNIA DISTRIBUTORS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE.
MICROBES AND WE HAVE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF THEATER
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA NEVADA
YONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OKAY MISS BURKE.
UP FIRST I I'D LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM I HAVE
BEEN A COMPLETE PAIN ON THIS
BILL MORE THAN ONCE AND YOU HAVE
TOLERATED -- NOT JUST MY
ARGUMENTS BUT TAKING THEM INTO
CONSIDERATION THIS TIME WHICH I
TRULY APPRECIATE -- CLEARLY THE
THESE ARE THE KIND OF TAXES THAT
AFFECTS MY COMMUNITY
TREMENDOUSLY AND THE IDEA THAT
ANY PROGRAM THAT CAME OUT OF
THIS.
DIDN'T ALLOW FOR WATER TO BE
CHEAPER OR FREE WAS A REAL ISSUE
FOR ME AND HAS KEPT ME OFF THIS
BILL AS A PERSON WHOSE FATHER
SUFFERS FOR DIED FROM DIABETES.
I THINK THE FIRST TIME YOU
BROUGHT THIS TO MY DAD WAS IN
THE HOSPITAL SUFFERING FROM
ISSUES OF DIABETES AND I STILL
VOTED NO.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY MY
DAD HAS THE MONEY TO CHOOSE
DIFFERENTLY.
HOWEVER THERE ARE PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT TO DON'T.
AND UNTIL WE PROVIDE AN OPTION
THAT IS EITHER FOR YOU OR AT THE
SAME PRICE AND SO THAT FOR ME I
COULD NEVER GET THERE AND SO I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME.
I HAVE LIKE I SAID I HAVE
ANNOYED HELLO TO YOU.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME TO FINALLY COME UP WITH A
PROGRAM THAT WILL WILL
POTENTIALLY GIVE.
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE WATER AT THE
SAME PRICE AS SODA.
THAT MEANS A LOT TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHERE I LIVE.
AND SO I KNOW IT'S BEEN ROUGH
BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING TODAY
AND I THINK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR HARD WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TWO
QUESTIONS FOR THE FOR THE AUTHOR.
FIRST I'M NOT SURE IF IT WAS
THIS PRESENTATION OF THE PRIOR
ONE BUT EITHER ONE IT'S IT'S A
SIMILAR ISSUE MR BLOOM.
THERE'S BEEN SOME -- ASSUMPTIONS
THAT THE THAT THE THE AMOUNT OF
CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR SWEETENED.
BADGES BEVERAGES HAVE HAS GONE
DOWN WHEN AND IF YOU ARE ANY OF
YOUR WITNESSES KIDA COULD
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE YEAH I I
THINK -- IT'S A TECHNICAL
QUESTION BEST ANSWERED BY THEM
BUT IT SHOULD BE SELF EVIDENT
THAT CONSUMPTION IS SOMETHING
THAT TAKES PLACE TODAY THE D.
DISEASE PROCESS PROCEEDS OVER A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME SO WHEN
WE'RE STUDYING THESE THINGS
WE'RE GONNA.
NOTICE CONSUMPTION GOING DOWN IN
THE NEAR TERM AND THE GOOD
HEALTH RESULTS IN THE MORE AND
IN THE LONGER TERM BUT BEYOND
THAT ALL TURN TO THE EXPERTS.
BERNIE TUITION POLICY INSTITUTE
AND OTHER SAD CONSERVING HAS
GONE DOWN BUT IT REMAINS HIGH SO
HALF OF ADULTS CONSUMERS AGREE
DRINK ON ANY GIVEN DAY AND MORE
THAN 60% OF CHILDREN.
SO THE NUMBERS ARE GOING DOWN
BUT THEY'RE STILL UBIQUITOUSLY
CONSUME TEACHER.
WERE YOU LOOKING FOR ME I
COULDN'T TELL I DO NOT THAT'S
CORRECT CDC I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WERE LOOKING AT ME TO RESPOND OR
NOT.
THAT YES THOSE NUMBERS THAT I
ARTICULATED OR FROM THE CDC YET
THAT AND THEN I WILL ALSO ADD
THAT I'M IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE -- BUT WHEN WE TOOK
SODAS OUT OF SCHOOLS CHILDHOOD
OBESITY RATES -- PREVALENCE
RATHER AND DECREASED AN
OVERWEIGHT RATES HAVE DECREASED
AS WELL SO THE LOCUS OF AND OF
EFFORT HAS BEEN ON CHILDHOOD
OBESITY PREVENTION AND THAT IS
THE AREA OF THE POPULATION WHICH
WE HAVE SEE AN APPLIED TELLING
ABOUT THE CITY RATES.
Q..
AND THIS.
WAS IN ANSWER I THINK MR HACKED --
WITH.
LOCAL RESIDENTS.
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE OKAY OKAY AND
THE SECOND QUESTION IS -- I
THINK I KNOW THE ANSWER BY NEED
MAYBE YOU CAN HELP AND LIGHTNESS
THAT.
NO THERE'S ARGUMENTS IT'S NOT
YES SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES
LIKE A TV TO THE CAN TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE INSANE
INCREASE IN -- IN CALORIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND OF COURSE THE
THE OBESITY RATE.
AND THAT FOLKS WOULD SAY WHY
DON'T YOU DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
CHOCOLATE CAKE HEARD SNICKERS
BARS OR CHEESE BURGERS AND I I
THINK YOUR YOUR ARGUMENT IS THAT.
SODA ARE ARE EMPTY CALORIES
UNLIKE A POTENTIAL SMOOTHLY
WHICH HAS SOME VALUE IN
NUTRITION A SODA FOR SERVICE WE
MEMBERS ARE EMPTY CALORIES IS
THAT WHAT THEY ARE WE I THINK
IT'S A MISTAKE TO GET LOST IN
THE DISCUSSION OF OF OF CALORIES --
THE A SIMPLE FACT ABOUT SUGARY
BEVERAGES IS THAT LIQUID SUGAR
IS METABOLIZED DIFFERENTLY AND
IN THE IN THE BODY -- IT TO A IS
PROCESS BY THE PANCREAS AND IS
DEPOSITED IN THE BODY IS FAT --
IN VERY RAPID FASHION SO THE
MORE LIQUID SUGAR ONE CONSUMES
THE MORE LIKELY ONE AS TO BECOME
OBESE OVER A RELATIVELY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
OKAY AND THEN JUST JUST A FEW
POINTS I WANT.
TO TOUCH ON AS YOU NOTED.
THESE POLICIES WORK WHEN THESE
POLICIES STARTED IN MEXICO THE
OPPOSITION SAID.
WELL THAT'S MEXICO IS DIFFERENT
THERE.
WE'VE SEEN HIM NOW IN CALIFORNIA
IN RICHMOND IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
BERKLEY NOW IN PHILADELPHIA.
WE KNOW THAT THESE POLICIES WORK
TO DECREASE CONSUMPTION.
AND MAKE COMMUNITIES A HEALTHIER
AND I THINK YOU KNOW THE OBESITY
EPIDEMIC AND THE NUMBERS ARE
JUST.
MIND LINE.
NO THE FACT THAT THE THE OBESITY
RATE FOR KIDS HAS TRIPLED IN THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS.
THE LIFE EXPECTANCY FOR THIS
GENERATIONS WALLING BACK AND
FORTH IS WAS PROJECTED A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WITH THE FIRST IN
CENTURIES HAVE A LOWER LIFE
EXPECTANCY THAN YOUR PARENTS BUT
THEY MAY NOT BE THAT.
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IT'S
GOT A LITTLE BIT BETTER BUT
STILL THE OVERALL LIFE
EXPECTANCY RATES ARE GOING DOWN.
AND YOU KNOW I REALLY WANT TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
REGRESSIVE NOUS BECAUSE
INDIVIDUAL SAY THIS IS.
REGRESSIVETO POOR PEOPLE. TO
BROWN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES WILL
YOU KNOW IT'S REGRESSIVE TO
BROWN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES.
TIED TO TYPE TWO DIABETES AND
OBESITY THAT IS A PROVEN FACT
THE NUMBER OF KIDS WHO ARE ON
THE ONE WAY TRAIN TO TYPE TWO
DIABETES FOR KEEPING IS THE
COLOR OVER 50%.
AND THE THE LAST THING AND AND
I'VE HAD THIS IN MY DESK FOR TEN
YEARS BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ON THIS
ISSUE WHEN I WAS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER BUT IT SHOCKING. TO
BELIEVE THAT THIS.
THE AVERAGE TEENAGER.
IN AMERICA AND CALIFORNIA.
DRINKS AND A SODA TO HAVE OVER
ONE HUNDRED TEASPOONS.
OF SUGAR AND YOU POURED.
TEASPOON AFTER TEASPOON AFTER TO
SPUR THE AVERAGE TEENAGER AGAIN.
CONSUMES THIS.
ON A WEEKLY BASIS ON A WEEKLY
BASIS AND THAT CANNOT BE GOOD
FOR YOUR HEALTH ESPECIALLY WITH
EMPTY -- CALORIE ENTITY LIKE A
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGE -- THIS
IS A SOUND PUBLIC POLICY IT'S
NOT MANY GOVERNMENTS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS COST US DEARLY
IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH COSTS WE
KNOW THESE MONIES WILL GO TO
PREVENTION AND HEALTH CARE AND
MAKE OUR MAKE OUR STATE TO
HEALTHIER AND FRANK TO LIVE
LONGER SO I APPLAUD YOU FOR
PUSHING THIS FOR MEASURE FOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE SECULAR KERR.
A MISTER BLOOM I WANT TO THANK
YOU FIRST FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
MEET ME ONE ON ONE BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW I HAVE SOME.
CONCERNS ON THE IMPACTS OF
POTENTIAL NEW TAX -- BUT I WILL
VOTE FOR YOU TODAY BECAUSE I
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORKING OUT
THE DETAILS.
MY VOTE TODAY REPRESENTS.
THE SUPPORT OF FOR PUBLIC FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE.
AFTER ALL WE ARE IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE -- BEFORE I VOTE AGAIN
I WILL REASSESS MY POSITION
BASED ON WHERE YOU GO FROM HERE
ESPECIALLY RELATE TO THE
REVENUES AND HOW THEY ARE GOING
TO BE COMMITTED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR MAKES.
WHAT'S THE TOTAL AMOUNT THE THAT
THIS WILL BE COLLECTED ANNUALLY
WHAT'S YOUR THE ESTIMATE IS --
BETWEEN TWO AND THREE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND WHAT WILL
BE DONE WITH THAT THAT MONEY
WILL JUST GO TO THE GENERAL FUND
WILL IT BE -- USED FOR DINNER --
GRAMS NO IT IS KEPT IN A A
DISCREET FUND -- IT DOES HAVE A
UP -- AS I THINK ONE OF THE THE
THE A CTA A SPEAKER OBSERVE DAY
UP -- PROP NINETY EIGHT TO
IMPACT WILL NEED TO CLARIFY OUR
LANGUAGE OFF ON THAT -- BECAUSE
OF THE TAX SO -- TWO POINT THREE
TWO TO THREE BILLION DOLLARS IS
NOT ULTIMATELY THE AMOUNT THAT
THE STATE WILL HAVE -- TO SPEND.
AND THAT MONEY WILL THEN BE
DISTRIBUTED ACCORDING TO AN
EXPENDITURE PLAN WHICH IN THE
PRIOR ITERATIONS OF THIS BILL WE
SPELLED OUT VERY CAREFULLY
COMING INTO COMMITTEE -- IN THIS.
INSTANCE WE DECIDED TO WAIT AND
HEAR FROM MEMBERS WHAT THEY FELT
THE PRIORITIES ON THE BILL OUGHT
TO BE -- I'VE MADE A COMMITMENT
TO VIRTUALLY EVERYONE THAT I'VE
SPOKEN TO THAT THE MONEY WILL BE
PREDOMINATELY USED FOR
PREVENTION EFFORTS -- THAT MEANS
IN ADDITION -- TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
IT MEANS SO THINGS LIKE --
SCHOOL NURSES -- A SCHOOL NURSE
PROGRAMS IT MEANS COMMUNITY
HEALTH PROGRAMS WHERE -- FARM
WORKER PROGRAMS WHERE GOOD
HEALTH -- CAN BE TAUGHT AND THE
I THINK THAT IT IS THIS.
DUALITY OF BOTH THE TAX THAT
WILL HAVE AN EFFECT OF OF
BRINGING DOWN CONSUMPTION AND
THE LONG TERM -- APPLICATION OF
REVENUE TO VARIOUS PROGRAMS
AROUND THE STATE THAT WILL HELP.
LEAD TO HEALTHIER LIFESTYLES
HERE LOOK HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
LONGER LIVES.
HEALTHIER LIVES -- AND LOWER
HEALTH CARE COSTS OVERALL.
SO I'M I'M TOWARD A BIT -- ON
THIS -- NO A A SHARE WITH YOU
WELL WELL WHY I WAS JUST LOOKING
AT KEVIN MCCARTY IS -- LITTLE
JAR OVER THERE AND I'M PRETTY
DARN SURE THAT THAT'S WHAT I
DRINK EVERY DAY -- BACK WHEN I
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL -- I WOULD
DRINK FIVE OR SIX CANS OF PEPSI
EVERY SINGLE DAY NOT GOOD.
FOR A FOR FOR MY HEALTH AND I
CAN TELL YOU THE PEOPLE MY
COMMUNITY ALSO DO THAT.
AS ALSO VERY TRUE -- THAT ARE --
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE
WE HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM WE
OVER USE THE TERM CRISIS BUT IT
IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE -- THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO DIABETES AND AND AND
HEART HEALTH AND AND OTHER
THINGS THAT WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
PROBLEM -- I HAVE A FRIEND --
MANY OF YOU HAVE -- MET HER --
WHO IS A PEDIATRIC DENTIST --
AND JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO THAT
WAS IN THE OFFICE HAVING A
MEETING WENT OVER TO MY PHONE
AND SAW ON MY PHONE -- A PICTURE
OF A OF A OF A CHILD THAT SHE
JUST WORKED ON WAS ABOUT TO WORK
ON AT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
THE THE THE THESE TEETH WERE
COMPLETELY CAVITY WRITTEN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM COMPLETELY.
DARK.
AND THEN SHE TEXTED AFTER I
LOOKED AT THIS AND SAID OH MY
GOSH.
THE FIVE YEAR OLD CHILD.
THE FIVE YEAR OLD CHILD EVERY
SINGLE TOOTH WAS COMPLETELY
CAVITY OF LADEN AND IT WAS
BECAUSE OF SUGAR SWEETENED
SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
AND THEN YOU THINK TO YOURSELF
WELL WHAT IS IT THAT WE GET WITH
THAT WE CAN -- THAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT ABOUT THIS -- IS IT
EDUCATION WELL THAT IS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT -- BECAUSE
IT REALLY IS A PART OF OUR OF
OUR SOCIETY AND YET THE REASON I
SAID THAT I WAS A TORN ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE I THINK THE INTENT
OF THE AUTHORS -- BILL IS TO BE
ABLE TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS -- THAT THAT WERE
IN.
AND YET I ALSO KNOW -- THAT --
TOBACCO IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM AND
I VOTED AGAINST THE TOBACCO TAX
AND THE REASON I VOTED AGAINST
THE TOBACCO TAXES BECAUSE
PHILOSOPHICALLY WHEN I THINK.
OF OF OF WHAT OUR TAX SYSTEM IS
FOR IS TO BRING REVENUE INTO
INTO THE THE GOVERNMENT TO BE
ABLE -- TO TO DEAL WITH -- ARE
ARE THE NEEDS OF OUR BAR BASIC
OUR BASIC NEEDS IT'S NOT TO
INCENTIVIZE -- OR DISINCENTIVE
EYES BEHAVIOR AND SO I DO I
STRUGGLE WITH THIS AND I'VE GONE
BACK AND FORTH IN MY HEAD WITH
THAT WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS --
TODAY BECAUSE YOUR INTENT IS
ABSOLUTELY ACCURATE WE HAVE A
PROBLEM AND I WISH THAT PEOPLE
ARE WATCHING AT HOME WATCHING
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING WHICH
THEY'RE NOT.
I WISH THAT WE ARE HAVING THESE.
THEY'RE NOT -- I DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU ALL ARE HERE BUT BUT BUT
PEOPLE AREN'T PAYING ATTENTION
TO BUT IT IS AFFECTING OUR LIVES
IT IS AFFECTING BY THE WAY IT IS
AFFECTING OUR BUDGET.
IS WELL -- I'VE HAD LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS OVER
OVER THE FALLS -- WAS AT A
CONFERENCE A LEARNED QUITE A BIT
QUITE A BIT ABOUT IT AND SUGAR
IS TOXIC.
AND THE LEVELS OF SUGAR THAT WE
ARE TAKING IN IS IS TOXIC AND
YET I STILL STRUGGLE WITH
WHETHER THIS IS THE BEST AVENUE.
A TO BE ABLE TO BUT TO GO DOWN
TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE A SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM -- BUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THERE BUT JUST AGAIN
THE THE LADY YOU KNOW WHERE I
WHERE I'M AT WELL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LET ME TRY TO ANSWER IT
ANYWAY -- THE THERE'S NO
QUESTION PENDING WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR -- WE
DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO LOOK
FOR THIS KIND OF PREVENTION
PROGRAM AND IF YOU IF IF IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT WE HAVE TO FUND
PREVENTION IN ORDER TO MAKE SOME
PROGRESS JUST LIKE WE DID.
WITH TOBACCO AND I DISAGREE WITH
HOW YOU VOTED ON THE TOBACCO TAX
BUT I THINK WE WOULD PROBABLY
AGREE THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE IN PEOPLE'S
BEHAVIOR.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT FROM THE
TOBACCO TAXES OVER TIME.
AS A RESULT OF THAT WE HAVE SEEN
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING LONGER
LIVES WHO ARE LESS DISEASE
RIDDEN THAN A HAPPEN AND AND IN
THE PAST.
SO.
YOU KNOW I'LL I LOOK AT THIS AS
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY NOW IT'S
VERY FOCUSED SOME FOLKS HAVE
SAID DON'T TAKE MY CHOICE AWAY
WE DON'T TAKE ANYBODY'S CHOICE
AWAY TO DRINK ANYTHING.
IT WILL BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR YOU TO DRINK
SOMETHING THAT IS LESS HEALTHY
FOR YOU.
AND SO THAT IS A FACT BUT WE
DON'T TAKE THE ULTIMATE CHOICE
AWAY FROM PEOPLE WHAT WE DO IS
WE TAKE THAT MONEY AND WE POUR
IT.
INTO PROGRAMS THAT WILL HELP
EVERYONE.
EVE EVEN IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE
FORTUNATE WHO NEVER HAVE A BAD --
HEALTH PROBLEMS IN YOUR LIFE AND
IT DOES YOU KNOW WE WE MARVEL AT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO LIVE HEALTHY
LIVES AND PASS AWAY HAVING HAD
NO SERIOUS ILLNESSES -- THOSE
CASES DO EXIST BUT EVEN FOR
THOSE PEOPLE THEIR INSURANCE
RATES WILL BE LESS OVER TIME IF
WE'RE ABLE. TO BRING THIS
DISEASE AND THE AND THE VARIOUS
DISEASES THAT EXIST AS A RESULT
OF THE CRISIS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IF WE'RE ABLE TO BRING
THOSE DISEASE RATES DOWN.
SO THERE IS NO NEGATIVE SIDE TO
THIS OTHER THAN IT WILL COST A
FEW MORE PENNIES. FOR A DRINK.
MR FLOOR.
MR BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS -- OBVIOUSLY I'M I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO TO GET THERE
BUT I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
OBVIOUS.
I'M I'M HOLDING OUT HOPE.
YEAH.
WELL WE'LL WE'LL TALK ABOUT SOME
OTHER BILLS -- BUT I AM
CONCERNED -- WITH THIS BECAUSE
THERE IS I MEAN I REPRESENT A
POPULATION OF OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
THERE ARE PLACES WHERE -- I WAS
JUST LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
AVERAGE IS ON WHAT IT COSTS FOR
BOTTLE WATER VERSUS THE COST FOR
A TWELVE OUNCE SODA.
THESE NUMBERS ARE REAL.
AND SO LIKE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS I THINK ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT BUT I EIGHT I DO
THINK THERE'S ONE VERY IMPORTANT
THING WE'RE MISSING IN ALL OF
THIS -- CHILDHOOD OBESITY
CONVERSATION AND AS A LACK OF
EXERCISE THAT OUR KIDS ARE DOING.
LIKE THIS STATE WE DON'T WE
DON'T ADDRESS THIS AT ALL WE
TEND TO TAX EVERYTHING THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO OUR KIDS TO DO
WHAT WE DON'T WANT OUR KIDS TO
CONSUME THESE THINGS.
BUT THE EXERCISE PROGRAMS AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS THE THINGS WE DO
FOR OUR KIDS TO GET THEM OUT
THERE AND TO GET THEM ACTIVE I
THINK WE'RE MISSING THAT.
WE CAN CUT OUT ALL THE SODA IN
THE WORLD THEY COULD DRINK WATER
1100% OF THE TIME. TO GO TO ANY
TO WHATEVER THEY'RE EATING AND
THEY'RE NOT EXERCISING DEFER
SETTING IN FRONT OF THEIR TV.
PLAYING VIDEO GAMES ALL DAY WHEN
THEY GET HOME.
THIS WILL BE EASY THING IS A
TRUE TRUE ISSUE LIKE CHAD -- I
DRINK A LOT OF SO WHEN I WAS A
KID BUT WAS ALSO VERY ACTIVE.
OTHERWISE I WOULD HAVE ISSUES
RIGHT MY DAUGHTERS I GOT TWO
LITTLE GIRLS I'M IT'S A DECISION
MY WIFE AND I HAVE MADE WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF STUDENTS IN OUR
HOUSE WE HAVE OTHER THINGS FOR
THEM.
OKAY THIS IS DECISIONS AND I AM
JUST IN THE MODERN ERA OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE WAY THAT WE
COMMUNICATE.
STUDIES AND DATA AND AND THE
DRIVERS IN THE MARKET YOU GO
DOWN TO THE SUPERMARKET.
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF HEALTHY
OPTIONS AND THOSE WOULDN'T BE
THERE IF CONSUMERS WERE BUYING
THEM MANUFACTURERS ARE GOING TO
PRODUCE PRODUCTS IF NOBODY'S
BUYING THEM.
SO I THINK AS A AS A GENERATION
IS A CULTURAL CHANGE THAT WE ARE
MAKING HERE THE MANUFACTURERS
ARE MAKING THOSE ADJUSTMENTS.
AND I DO APPLAUD THAT NEW
CONSUMERS OUT THERE FOR MAKING
BETTER CHOICES BUT I WOULD I
JUST WANNA PUT IT ON RECORD WE
NEED TO HAVE SOME CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING TO MAKE
SURE OUR KIDS GET OUT OF THE
HOUSE AND INTO AN EDUCATION
PROGRAM AS RELATES TO EXERCISE
THANK YOU WELL IF I MIGHT
RESPOND VERY BRIEFLY -- WE DO IN
FACT ADDRESS THAT AND SO I DO
HOPE THAT -- Y'ALL Là THINK
AGAIN ABOUT THIS BILL -- GOOD
NUTRITION PROGRAMS -- A GOOD
PREVENTION PROGRAM INCLUDES A
DISCUSSION ABOUT A HEALTHY
LIFESTYLE AND HEALTHY LIFESTYLE
OF COURSE INCLUDES EXERCISE THAT
EVERYONE.
SHOULD HAVE -- AND IF I CAN JUST
PUT IT BACK ON YOU SIR AND SAY
YOU TELL ME WHAT YOU WANT IN
THIS EXPENDITURE PLAN BECAUSE
THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY THERE. TO
TAILOR THESE PROGRAMS SO THAT
THEY ADDRESS THE NEEDS THAT WE
AS A BODY THINK ARE IMPORTANT SO
I'M LISTENING TO THAT COMMENT
AND WE WILL CONSIDER LANGUAGE
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU COME
ON THE BILL OR NOT BUT I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL CHANGE YOUR MIND AS
A RESULT.
OF OF THAT AND PUT [inaudible]
MR DESERVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YOU'RE GETTING A GOOD DEAL BY
THE WAY SOMEONE NUMBER FLORA --
I TOLD HIM HE HAD ME AT HELLO SO.
NO THAT'S ON POLICY.
THAT'S ON GOOD POLICY.
I I SAW THAT MOVIE AND I'M NOT
SURE I APPRECIATE THE REFERENCE.
SORRY I'M.
I'M YOUNG I DON'T REMEMBER WHEN
WE WERE YOUNG AND WEALTHY.
I'M STILL YOUNG.
OF YEAH WE WE TALK ABOUT THESE --
EXPERIENTIAL IS AND AND AND AND
AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE MY
TWO COLLEAGUES WHO JUST SPOKE
RIGHT NOW I RESPECT YOU VERY
MUCH AND I VALUE YOUR OPINION
AND I UNDERSTAND THE STRUGGLE
YOU'RE HAVING.
AND AND AND APPLYING IT TO YOUR
REAL LIFE EXPERIENCE -- BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE CHANGES
THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF DECADES WHILE WE'VE
BEEN.
OF MATURING IN THIS PROCESS SO
WHEN WE WERE YOUNG WE DIDN'T
HAVE TO THE SUPER GULP SIZES.
OF OUR MADE MAYBE I'M A LITTLE
OLDER THAN YOU SO MAYBE YOU HAD
IN YOUR YOUTH -- BUT BUT
MARKETING HAS CHANGED OF THE THE
PRODUCT HAS CHANGED -- THE
AGGRESSIVENESS.
OF THESE PRODUCTS AND THEIR
MARKETING HAS CHANGED.
IN FACT THEY I WASN'T REALLY
GOING TO MAKE A COMMENT BUT WHEN
I ALSO HEARD ABOUT HOW.
SODA CONSUMPTION HAS GONE DOWN
BUT IN ITS PLACE -- SMOOTHIE
CONSUMPTION HAS GONE UP.
I DON'T CLAIM TO BE A HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONAL.
BUT I THINK IT'S BETTER.
TO CONSUME YOGURT BASED.
NUTRITIONAL PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
CERTAIN BACTERIA IN IT THAT IS
ACTUALLY HELPFUL TO YOUR BODY.
UP VERSES OF AS A SUGAR BASED
DRINK THAT QUICKLY TURNS INTO
STARCH AND CONTRIBUTES TO MANY
OTHER DISEASES THAT WE SEE.
ON A DAILY BASIS IMPACTING OUR
STATE BUDGET AND IS ONLY GOING
TO GROW.
OVER TIME.
WE THINK WE HAVE PROBLEMS NOW --
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE BIGGEST COST
DRIVERS IN HEALTH CARE?
THE HEART DISEASE CANCER BY THE
END DIABETES RELATED DISEASES
AND IT'S ONLY GONNA GET WORSE
OVER TIME IF WE DON'T.
TRY TO TAKE STEPS THAT ARE GONNA
IN A MEASURED WAY.
UP CREATE A BALANCE.
WE SAW THAT BALANCE HAPPEN IN
THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY.
AND AND I'M HOPING THAT THIS
BALANCE HAPPENS -- THROUGH A
MEASURE LIKE THIS THIS BALANCE
HAS BROUGHT ABOUT IN THIS ARENA
AS WELL.
I AM -- AND MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME FOR A MINUTE I
I STRUGGLE TO SUPPORT SOME OF
THE OTHER BILLS TODAY.
BECAUSE I FEEL THAT IT'S GOING
AFTER A GENERAL PRACTICE ON THE
MARKETING SIDE.
OF WHICH CAN THEN APPLY TO MANY
OTHER.
ARENAS BUT THIS IS SPECIFIC TO
THIS ISSUE AREA AND WE KNOW IT'S
IMPACTS.
SO THAT'S WHY I'M A PROUD TO BE
A CO AUTHOR AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE STEADFASTLY
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST AT
LEAST. THREE YEARS -- AND THEN
GOING ON MAYBE EVEN FIVE YEARS
OR LONGER WITH SENATOR MINING SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS TO RODRIGUEZ.
YES I JUST WANTED TO ECHO FEW.
CONCERNS I HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
GO BACK ON MY COLLEAGUES HERE
WITH WITH CHAD AND AND HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN THEY'RE YOUNGER YEARS THEY
STRIKE FIVE OR SIX SODAS A DAY
AND THEN?
IN I DON'T SEE THE HAVING ISSUES
NOW WITH WITH OBESITY OR OR
ANYTHING FOR THAT MATTER -- AND
I THINK A LOT OF IT COMES UNDER
CHOICE RIGHT YOU KNOW I TALK
ABOUT MY GROUND SINCE -- I'D TO
BILLY TAKE YOUR MY GRAND KIDS
EVERY WEEKEND.
AND I MAKE SURE THAT THEY EAT
HEALTHY STAY ACTIVE.
BUT NOT EVERYBODY HAS THAT
OPPORTUNITY GLOVER STARTS AT
HOME WITH THE UPBRINGING ARE.
OUR PARENTS OR GRANDPARENTS OR
WHOEVER SPECIALLY OR OR YOUR
GENERATION COMES FOR THAT COMMON
SENSE TELLS YOU THAT YOU
SHOULDN'T BE DRINKING SODA EVERY
DAY OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT IN IN
I THINK SODA OR ANY ANY BEVERAGE
THAT CONTAINS.
MORE SUGAR THAN WHAT IT SHOULD.
IS MAYBE PART OF IT BUT THAT'S
NOT THE ONLY PART WHERE PEOPLE
ARE HAVING DIABETES OBESITY
THERE'S OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO
IN LIFE OTHER THINGS THAT WE EAT --
THESE ARE WE CONSUME AND I THINK
THE LACK OF EXERCISE IS HUGE
WITH THAT AS WELL.
I WAS TALKING SOME REAL TODAY
TELL ME THAT.
THEIR THEIR CHILD IN HIGH SCHOOL
WHEN HE HAS P. E. ONE DAY A WEEK
AND I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THAT EVEN
CHANGE WERE WE ALREADY GOING TO
A DIFFERENT WAY OUT OF LIFESTYLE
THAT -- WE'RE NOT KEEPING
HEALTHY BEING ACTIVE LIKE WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD OF RIGHT AND
THEN ONCE AGAIN I SEE WE'RE
TRYING TO DO -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARE APPLIED TO HELP IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE BUT I JUST
DON'T SEE THAT IMPOSING A TAX ON
SODA.
IS GOING TO FIX EVERYTHING YOU
KNOW BECAUSE IT'S IT'S ONE
COMPONENT OF MANY OTHER
COMPONENTS I SEE THAT.
ATTRIBUTES TO ALL OF THESE
HEALTH ISSUES OTHER THAN SODA
AND ONCE AGAIN I LOOK BACK AT IT
AS BEING.
A CHOICE.
OF OF WHAT WE EAT WHAT WE DRINK.
AND AND THE UPBRINGINGS BY OUR
FAMILIES ARE OR FAMILY MEMBERS
OF PEOPLE WHO WE HANG AROUND
WITH OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL AS WE
TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW SODA AND SUGARY
BEVERAGES HAVE BEEN.
ARE NOT -- IN THEM.
VENDING MACHINES THAT ARE HIGH
SCHOOLS AND JUNIOR HIGH.
BUT YET THEY'RE STILL ISSUE
THERE WITH FOLKS HAVE BEEN
OBESITY DIABETES.
AND AND I GUESS THAT HELP BUT
THEY'RE STILL ISSUES OUT THERE
ONCE AGAIN I JUST THINK THAT.
THERE'S MORE TO IT THAN THAN --
DRINKING SODAS AND DOING OTHER
THINGS WITH THAT.
US WHAT THAT I WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
AND JUST WANT TO SHARE MY
THOUGHTS CONCERNED ON THAT AS
WELL. THREE MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
WELL I HAVE SOME COMMENTS AND I
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE ON THIS
ISSUE -- IT'S I'VE I'VE I'VE.
I'VE BEEN ACTUALLY PERSONALLY
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE RELATED TO
SUGAR -- IN SOFT DRINKS
[inaudible] FOR YEARS I DON'T
EVEN REMEMBER HOW LONG QUITE
FRANKLY I REMEMBER WE LOOKED AT
THE POTENTIAL OF A FIVE CENT.
A GALLON TAX.
OR FEE.
ON THE SERVER [inaudible]
YEARS AGO.
AND THAT ARGUABLY WOULDN'T OF
WOULDN'T HAVE -- ACOSTA
CONSUMERS A GREAT DEAL BUT WHAT
IT WHAT IT DONE WAS GIVE US
MONEY FOR DENTAL DISEASE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
AND WE COULDN'T EVEN GET OUT OF
THE STARTING GATE WITHOUT QUITE
FRANKLY AND IT WAS IT'S
DISCOURAGING -- I AM PREVENTION
ORIENTED BY NATURE THAT IS MY
TRAINING THAT IS MY EXPERIENCE
THAT WAS MY CAREER.
WEATHER WAS TOBACCO. FOR FOR
SUGAR -- FLOOR OR JUST OTHER
KINDS OF HABITS [inaudible]
PREVENTION.
IS THE KEY.
TO LONG TERM HEALTH QUITE
FRANKLY.
AND SO.
OUR ASK MY COLLEAGUES IN AND ONE
OF HIS MISSING BUT MAYBE HE'S
LISTENING SOMEWHERE YOU KNOW WE
START.
THAT ARE KIND OF ON THE FENCE
MAYBE ON THIS TO THINK ABOUT
THIS A LITTLE BIT.
WE AS A STATE SPEND HUGE AMOUNTS
OF MONEY FOR A MEDICARE
POPULATION ON THE TREATMENT OF
DIABETES [inaudible]
INSULIN.
WOUND CARE SOMETIMES AMPUTATIONS
AND AND SOMETIMES PROSTHETICS
THAT GO ALONG WITH THAT HUGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT
WE NEED TO HELP WITH THE
PREVENTION.
IF WE COULD HAVE SOME OF THAT
MONEY. FOR PREVENTION AND REAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
ONGOING PROGRAMS NOT A YOU KNOW
I ONCE ONE SHOT SORT OF PROGRAM
AND AND A LITTLE EDUCATION HERE
THESE HAVE TO BE ON GOING
PROGRAMS TO INFLUENCE PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
WE COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
AND WITH THE WILD RESPECT MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THERE ARE SKINNY FOLKS
THAT ARE DIABETIC OKAY YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE IT DOES THAT THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY GO HAND IN
HAND -- AND SO -- I JUST YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW IT IT.
I HEARD SOMEBODY SAY THANK YOU
OUT THERE OF SO BUT IT'S A BIG
DEAL.
IN MY PRACTICE -- WHEN I WAS
PRACTICING DENTISTRY?
I SAW A COUPLE OF THINGS I SAW
THE RAVAGES OF TOBACCO.
I SAW WHAT HAPPENED A PEOPLE'S
MOUTHS FROM TOBACCO USE -- AND
THANK GOODNESS IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE PASS ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST REFORM PACKAGES
FOR TOBACCO IN IN THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS AND THAT WILL IMPACT
PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT WILL SAVE US
MONEY ON TREATMENT FOR HEART
DISEASE.
CANCER YOU KNOW IMPROVE ORAL
HEALTH IT'S A HUGE GAME CHANGER
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I SEE THIS THE SAME WAY.
I SEE THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE I SAW IN MY PRACTICE
YOUNG PEOPLE COMING INTO MY
PRACTICE WITH BEAUTIFUL
PERMANENT TEETH THESE ARE NOT
THE FOUR AND FIVE YEAR OLDS THAT
WERE RAVAGED REALLY THESE ARE.
ELEVEN TWELVE THIRTEEN YEAR OLDS
DRINKING A HALF A DOZEN SOFT
DRINKS A DAY I SAW THE FROSTED
APPEARANCE OF THEIR TEETH.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS AND THEN WE'D
SEE BEGINNINGS OF DECAY AND THEN
WE START TO SEE THOSE BLACK
SPOTS LATER ON AND IT'S HORRIBLE
TO SEE IT'S HORRIBLE TO SEE.
AND A COMMON DENOMINATOR THEIR
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
AND SO I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
THE RESOURCES -- WE NEED TO
PREVENTION -- I APPLIED YOUR
TENACITY OF FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- AND I AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR REALLY WORKING
WITH COLLEAGUES AND ONE THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH MISS BURKE --
WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT WAS OF
CONCERN TO HER AND YOU MET WITH
HER AND YOU AND AND AND YOU YOU
MET HER ON THAT AND I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THAT SO -- IT IS I THINK
IT A TIME WHEN WE ARE ARE
STARVED FOR RESOURCES IN THIS
HUGE BEAUTIFUL STATE -- TO HAVE
RESOURCES TO HELP WITH THIS IN
THE LONG RUN WILL HELP.
INCREASE IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AND MAYBE WE'LL HAVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO COVER AND TAKE CARE
OF THE REST THE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA -- FOR FOR OVERALL
HEALTH CARE.
MAYBE IT'S A BIG DREAM BUT MAYBE
WE CAN GET THERE WE GOT TO START
SOMEWHERE.
AND THAT THAT THE SUFFERING
SIZES WERE THEIR HUGE NOW THE
ORIGINAL COKE WAS EIGHT OUNCES.
YOU CAN'T FIND OUT IF YOU CAN
FIND ANY DOUBTS COKE OUT THERE
IT'S IT'S A RARITY I THINK YOU
MIGHT GO FIND A BUT THERE ARE
THAT'S NOT THE SIZE ANYMORE SO.
SO I APPLAUD YOU -- HIGH -- THE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S OBVIOUS -- BUT BUT I
WOULD WELCOME YOU IT IS ABOUT
PEOPLE.
BUT CLOSE MISTER GOING I'LL --
WITH YOUR PERMISSION.
MISTER CHAIR -- ADOPT YOUR
COMMENTS AS MY CLOTHES AND TO
ASK RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE A
HERE MOTION.
OKAY THE MOTION BY MISS BURKE A
SECOND BY MISTER MCCARTY.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO REVENUE
AND TAXATION -- MA'AM SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHEN I WHEN
I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FIGURE CURRY [inaudible]
I BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA.
BURKE.
I WICKS [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
LOAN.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE.
NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
ALMOST NO RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ NO
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO WALDRON.
YOU HAVE FIVE VOTES WE HAVE
MEMBERS MISSING MISTER MISTER
BLOOM THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU TO HEAR WITNESSES
CHRISTIAN.
THAT ENDS ARE A SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS WILL NOW MOVE INTO OUR
REGULAR -- ORDER OF BUSINESS --
THIS WILL HAVE MISTER GIBSON
[inaudible]
JUST A AND IT WILL JUST AT THIS
POINT I JUST THE FIRST THE FIRST
BILL.
AT THIS POINT IT'S JUST -- TEN
THIRTY SEVEN HAVE YOU COME BACK
FOR THE OTHERS OKAY THANK YOU
SIX TO SUPPORT MARTHA KING
JUNIOR COMMUNITY HOSPITAL TO
ESTABLISH A FOUNDATION.
SO THAT -- THEY MAY BETTER SERVE --
THEIR COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
SERVE AND THAT I REPRESENT IN
OKAY HOSPITAL SIR SOUTH LOS
ANGELES REMAINS A FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SHORTAGE AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED.
AREA POSITION SHORTEST TOTAL
TWELVE HUNDRED FOR MLK SERVICE
AREA AND THOSE SUFFERING FROM
THE SHORTAGE ARPA DONNELLY --
PERSONS OF COLOR AND OUR LOW
INCOME ALLOWING MARKING
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL TO ESTABLISH
A MEDICAL FOUNDATION WOULD HELP
EASE THE EASE THE SHORTAGE IN
GENERAL MEDICAL FOUNDATIONS ART
INSTRUMENT ALLOWING HOSPITALS TO
CREATE A NONPROFIT ENTITY.
THAT EMPLOYS POSITION THIS MODEL
OFFERS HOSPITAL A VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY A COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
DOCTOR ELAINE BACHELOR
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN THIRTY SEVEN A BILL THAT
WILL ALLOW THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR COMMUNITY HOSPITAL.
TO ADDRESS A CRITICAL SHORTAGE
OF PHYSICIANS IN OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGH THE CREATION OF A
NONPROFIT MEDICAL FOUNDATION.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR LANE BACHELOR
AND I'M THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF IN OKAY HOSPITAL.
I HAVE DEDICATED MY CAREER TO
ENSURING THE HEALTH OF
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND HAVE
SERVED AS THE HOSPITAL CEO SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE OUR PUBLIC
PARTNERS LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN KEY TO OUR SUCCESS.
THEY HAVE ENABLED US TO BE
EFFECTIVE AS A PRIVATE ENTITY
NIMBLE ENOUGH TO INNOVATE AND
SOLVE PROBLEMS QUICKLY.
OUR HOSPITAL IS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE BED FACILITY
PROVIDING EMERGENCY MATERNITY
GENERAL MEDICINE SURGERY AND
ANCILLARY SERVICES. THREE YEARS
INTO OUR WORK WE'RE SERVING MORE
THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS
A YEAR AND ARE MERCHANTS HE
DEPARTMENT MAKING OURS ONE OF
THE BUSIEST IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
OUR VOLUME IS LARGE.
LARGER THAN HOSPITALS THREE TO
FOUR TIMES OUR SIZE AND REFLECTS
THE LACK OF PRIMARY PREVENTIVE
AND SPECIALTY CARE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE SERVE A LOW INCOME POPULATION
70% OF OUR PATIENTS ARE ON
MEDICAID BECAUSE OF LOW PROVIDER
PAYMENTS FEW.
DOCTORS ARE WILLING OR ABLE TO
WORK IN SOUTH LA.
AS A RESULT WE HAVE A DEFICIT OF
TWELVE HUNDRED PHYSICIANS.
OUR COMMUNITY SUFFERS SOME OF
THE WORST HEALTH OUTCOMES IN THE
STATE FOR EXAMPLE THE DIABETES
MORTALITY RATE IS 72% HIGHER
THAN A LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE PREVALENCE OF DIABETES IN
OUR COMMUNITY IS 92% HIGHER THAN
OTHER COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND DIABETIC AMPUTATIONS ARE
AMONG OUR MOST FREQUENT SURGICAL
PROCEDURES CARRIED OUT AT THE
HOSPITAL.
RECRUITING AND SUPPORTING
DOCTORS WHO HAVE A PASSION FOR
SERVING A SAFETY NET COMMUNITY
IS KEY TO ACHIEVING HEALTH
EQUITY IN SOUTH LA.
IF YOU ARE ALREADY WITH US
DOCTOR YOUR MIND EDWARDS WHO
GREW UP IN OUR COMMUNITY WENT TO
HIGH SCHOOL ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE HOSPITAL.
DOCTOR STAND FRENCH SURE A
FORMER CHIEF RESIDENT AT YALE
GREW UP IN DETROIT AND SAW FIRST
HAND THE AFFECTS SUPPORT HELP ON
A VULNERABLE COMMUNITY.
DOCTOR YOU'LL SEE MONTERO A UCLA
TRAIN FAMILY PHYSICIAN RECENTLY
PURCHASED A HOME WITH HER
HUSBAND IN COMPTON.
OUR PATIENTS IN SOUTH LA
DESPERATELY NEED CARE FROM
DOCTORS LIKE THESE BEFORE THEIR
CONDITIONS PROGRESS TO CRITICAL
AND COSTLY STAGES.
ON RELEVANT TO THE CONVERSATION
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT THE SODAS.
AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN IS ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT TOOLS WE
CAN HOW TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
SELF LA.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLYMAN
GIBSON SUPPORT FOR OUR COMMUNITY
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL THE SACRISTY WE SOME BEHALF
OF MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL DOCTOR ABOUT
SORT OF FOUR BETTER THAN I
COULDN'T WORK WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OTHERS A SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH AND WORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND WITH APPRECIATION
FOR THE OFFICE THANK YOU.
IT ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
CAT CARRILLO FORMER RESIDENT OF
BELLFLOWER CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE -- WHICH I CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S A
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU WELL THIS DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THANKS
VERY MUCH WAS TERM FULLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO AND AND THANK YOU THINK
YOU'RE WASN'T WITNESS FOR COMING
HERE TODAY -- WE DO.
HAVE A NEW -- A MOTION BY MISTER
MAYES.
SECOND BY MISTER SANTIAGO --
THAT -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES THANK YOU?
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE I'D [inaudible]
WICKS.
FLORA.
LIMóN MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
PROBLEMS.
RUN A FIVE RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
OKAY I WALDRON.
WE HAVE -- FIVE WE'VE HAD PEOPLE
HERE BUT THEY'RE NOT NOW AND I
THINK THEY'LL BE BACK AND ARE
PRETTY SURE YOU'RE GONNA GET
YOUR BILL OUT MISTER GIVE SOME
BUT LEAVE THE ROLE WILL LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL.
AND I'LL BE BACK I'D I'D I KNOW
YOU WILL BECAUSE YOU HAVE THOUGH
THE BILLS I DO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- IT I
MISTER TO I KNOW YOU HATE ME HAS
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVEA PROBLEM.
I WAS HE KNOWS THE ONE OF THE
BUSY THE BUSIEST DAY I CAN EVER
REMEMBER MR MATHIS IS ACTUALLY
BEING HELD TO COMMITTEES ARE
BEING HELD OPEN WAITING FOR HIM
TO TESTIFY -- HE HAS A VERY
QUICK PRESENTATION FOR MISTER
SANTIAGO AND FOR MR.
I'M SORRY FOR MR SEE I DON'T
EVEN KNOW IS PRESENTING FOR NOW --
SERVICE TO GARCIA EXCUSE ME.
SO.
MISTER MR OF FOR MR GARCIA WHO
IS -- MOVED.
THANK YOU.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
LARA.
HAS RECOMMENDATION.
WHAT WITH DATA IT'S A GREAT
PLEASURE TO PRESENT AB AT --
SEVEN SEVENTY FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER [inaudible]
EDWARD GARCIA I RESPECT THE
SUPPORT SUPPORT AND I WILL KEEP
IT SHORT TO THIS THIS JUST --
HOUSES GET MORE MONEY FOR OUR
LOCAL -- CLINICS ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL AREAS.
ASK YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARNOLD TOURISTS -- REPRESENTING
THE SPONSORS THE CENTER BECAUSE
HEALTH NETWORK WANTED TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR REACHING
AGREEMENT ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAD DISCUSSED -- WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDS THAT UNFORTUNATELY
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IS NOT BEEN FOLLOWING FEDERAL
LAW -- THEY'VE BEEN FOLLOWING --
LEGISLATING BIOTICS IN ESSENCE --
THIS BILL REALLY ALLOWS THE
CLINICS TO BE REIMBURSED
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW CASE
LAW AND CONGRESSIONAL INTENT.
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT PUTTING
CONSIDERATION THE FOLLOWING
POINTS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY A
NUMBER OF HEALTH CARE CONCERNS
THAT OF ARE CONCERNED TOO MANY
MEMBERS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS
POINTS WHICH OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS PROVIDE
TREMENDOUS HEALTH CARE TO ONE
OUT OF EVERY SEVEN PEOPLE SIX
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA RECEIVE
CARE FROM THESE HEALTH CENTERS
THEY PROVIDED TWENTY MILLION.
MEDICAL ENCOUNTERS LAST YEAR TO
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT ACCESS AND
THEY'RE NOT BEING PAID WITH THE
LAW FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES AND TO
BE PAID.
THAT ABILITY TO SEE IN PROVIDE
THAT ACCESS WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY CURTAIL SO WE WANT
TO THANK AGAIN THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR MAKING
IT POSSIBLE AND WE HOPE THAT --
WILL HAVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
MEAGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
A STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OR IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
PRINT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER THAT
WORK AND THE AUTHOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MEDICARE KERN JUST WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT I AM SO GLAD THAT --
YOU AND THEM SOME REMEMBER
GARCIA ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
ABSOLUTELY ANY -- THE MORE THE
MERRIER.
THANK YOU OTHER.
SEEING NONE -- THAT LIKE I SAID
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- MISTER MASSIVE
JOINT CLOSE -- ABSOLUTELY AND
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION WE ARE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND ANY
ADDITIONAL -- CO AUTHORS AND
LIKE THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU --
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS BURKE
A SECOND BY MISTER SANTIAGO
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEN'S.
AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS
EXCUSE ME A MINUTE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WHAT I
MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE.
BURKE AYE WICKS FLORA LIMóN
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN ROSS FROM US I
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE AND WALDRON.
YOU HAVE -- FIVE WILL LEAVE THE
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR INDULGING ASIDE COLLEGE EYES
FOR THEM NO WORRIES MISTER
CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE -- TODAY'S
SCHEDULE -- COLLEAGUES AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WOULD HELP
ADDRESS OUR STATE'S OPIOID IN
ADDITION CRISIS BY ESTABLISHING
A THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM TO
OFFER INMATES IMPROVED
MEDICATION ASSISTANCE TREATMENT.
FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS IN
MY CITY AND COUNTY.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THE KNOWS
FULL WELL THE SEVERITY OF THE
OPIOID AND ADDICTION CRISIS IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALONE
ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WERE HOSPITALIZED.
DUE TO AN OPIOID OVERDOSE IN
OVER TWO THOUSAND DIED.
THOSE WHO HAVE A HISTORY OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY OPERATE OVER
REPRESENTED IN OUR STATE'S
PRISONS AND JAILS.
A RECENT RAND STUDY FOUND THAT
58% OF CALIFORNIA INMATES REPORT
A PROBLEM WITH DRUG USE OR
DEPENDENTS.
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS
COMBINES COUNSELING AND
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY WITH THE USE
OF FDA APPROVED MEDICATIONS AND
A WHOLE PERSON AND A WHOLE
PATIENT APPROACH.
NEWER STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
MATT IS A MORE EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION TO TREAT OPIOID USE
AN ALCOHOL ABUSE DISORDER THAN
EITHER BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS
OR MEDICATIONS ALONE.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO THIS
TREATMENT COULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL SAVINGS.
A RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT
PROVIDING MATT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS.
WHO RECEIVES TREATMENT FOR
OPIATE USE COULD RESULT IN A
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
SAVINGS RELATED TO REDUCE COSTS?
WITH REGARDS TO OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND OUR
HIV AIDS TREATMENT.
ALTHOUGH TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IS EXPANDING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE COUNTY JAILS DO NOT
RECEIVE ANY STATE OR FEDERAL
FUNDS TO PROVIDE MAP FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN CUSTODY.
EXPOSURE TO THESE PROGRAMS
DURING INCARCERATION CAN REDUCE
DEATHS AND DRUG RELATED
POISONINGS. FOR THE MORE STUDIES
HAVE INDICATED THAT MAC REDUCE
RE ENTRY INTO THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WITH THAT OF A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES -- AND I'M VERY
PLEASED TO WELCOME ON THE MAYOR
OF THE CITY COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
MARYLAND IN PRE.
WELCOME MADAM MAYOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- CHAIR WOULD AND THANK
YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL --
AND IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE I'M
LINDEN BREED MAYOR OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
WITH A HISTORY OF SUBSTANCE USE
AND ARE SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
REPRESENTED IN OUR JAILS AND
PRISONS IN SAN FRANCISCO AN
ESTIMATED 80%.
OF THE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS BOOKED IN OUR COUNTY
JAIL.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN HAD A HISTORY
OF SUBSTANCE USE WHEN WE
INCARCERATE PEOPLE WITHOUT
PROVIDING THE PROPER SERVICES
AND TREATMENT IT OFTEN LEADS TO
SERIOUS HEALTH COMPLICATIONS.
INCLUDING UNTREATED WITHDRAWAL
DISRUPTED TREATMENT AND INCREASE
RISK OF OVERDOSE.
THESE HARMS ARE PREVENTABLE AND
OUR PRIMARY DUE TO THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO TREATMENT WHILE THEY
IN CAR WHY THEY'RE IN JAIL. TO
HELP THOSE SUFFERING FROM
ADDICTION WE HAVE TO MEET THEM
WHERE THEY ARE WITH PROVEN AND
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT OPTIONS.
IF WE CAN GET PEOPLE HELP WHILE
THERE INCARCERATED WE CAN SET
THEM UP FOR LATER SUCCESS AND
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY STRUGGLING WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
I'VE SEEN TOO MANY PEOPLE I GREW
UP WITH TOO MANY PEOPLE I WORK
WITH IN THE COMMUNITY WHO WERE
ADDICTED TO DRUGS.
WENT TO JAIL AND WHEN THEY CAME
OUT THEY WERE STILL STRUGGLING
WITH ADDICTION.
I'VE SEEN TOO MANY PEOPLE WHOSE
ADDICTION WHILE INCARCERATED
ONLY GOT WORSE PEOPLE LIKE MY
BROTHER WHO'S BEEN IN JAIL FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND WHO IS STILL TO
THIS VERY DAY STRUGGLING WITH AN
ADDICTION.
HE HAS TRIED TO SEEK TREATMENT
BUT LIKE SO MANY OTHER HE SO
MANY OTHERS HE CONTINUES TO
STRUGGLE.
THE TRUTH IS IT'S EASY TO GET
DRUGS IN JAIL AND WE NEED TO
ALSO HAVE AN HONEST CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT.
BUT SADLY IT'S NOT EASY TO GET
TREATMENT WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT
AND WITH THIS BILL WE CAN CHANGE
THAT.
ALTHOUGH TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE
USE IS EXPANDING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE COUNTY JAILS DO NOT
HAVE ANY STATE OR FEDERALLY
FUNDED SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
TREATMENT TO INDIVIDUALS IN
CUSTODY BECAUSE INMATES DON'T
QUALIFY FOR MEDICARE.
REIMBURSEMENT THE FACT THAT
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT IS
COVERED UNDER MEDICARE ONCE AN
INDIVIDUAL IS RELEASED FROM JAIL
BUT NOT COVERED WALL THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS ACTUALLY IN JAIL
MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN TO REHABILITATE PEOPLE.
AND FOR MANY PEOPLE SUBSTANCE
USE TREATMENT WHILE INCARCERATED
IS A CRITICAL POINT OF
REHABILITATION.
SAN FRANCISCO HAS STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE AND PROVIDES RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT TREATMENT FOR INMATES
IN OUR COUNTY JAIL BUT THIS
SUPPORT IS IN SUSTAINABLE AND WE
JUST CAN'T DO IT ALONE.
THIS CARE INCLUDES COMPREHENSIVE
AND INTEGRATED SYSTEMS A MEDICAL
PSYCHIATRIC AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS TREATMENTS WITH THE
GOAL OF REDUCING THEIR RISK OF
OVERDOSE.
THIS DECREASES COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS AND
HOSPITALIZATION STAYS AND HELPS
PEOPLE WITH THEIR SUBSTANCE USE
ADDICTIONS.
BUT THEY'RE BETTER TREATMENT
OPTIONS AVAILABLE AND THERE IS A
WIDER POPULATION THAT NEEDS OUR
HELP AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE UNDER
OUR CARE WE SHOULD PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE HELP THAT THEY NEED.
THIS THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT
TO BE RELEASED OUT OF OUR CARE
TO SEEK HELP.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE THE
HEALTH CONDITIONS OF INMATES
REDUCE THE FINANCIAL BURDENS ON
OUR HEALTH CARE AND JUSTICE
SYSTEMS AND REALLY SAVE LIVES SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU ALL
TODAY AND I HOPE WE CAN COUNT ON
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS.
VERY IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL
REALLY CHANGE HOW WE SUPPORT
THOSE STRUGGLING WITH SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM [inaudible]
MUCH.
BUT TO NOT HIGH -- MY NAME IS
ACTUALLY SO PROUD.
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF JAIL HEALTH
SERVICES WHICH IS A SECTION OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO HEALTH NETWORK --
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TIMES I'M CERTIFIED IN
ADDICTION MEDICINE AS WELL AS
INTERNAL MEDICINE AND I OVERSEE
THE MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
ALSO KNOWN AS ME T. IN THE JAIL.
I'D LIKE TO THANK SOME WOMEN
CHIU FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY -- THE SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY JAIL WOULD BENEFIT
GREATLY FROM AB ONE FIVE FIVE
SEVEN APPROXIMATELY 40% OF
PEOPLE INCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA.
ARE HOUSED IN COUNTY JAILS A
SIGNIFICANT PROPORTION OF WHOM
SUFFER FROM SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
JAILS ARE RUN BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES ON THERE ARE EMBEDDED
IN THE COMMUNITY AND AS SUCH
THERE'S A CRITICAL OPPORTUNITY
TO BEGIN TREATMENT AND RECOVERY
FOR PEOPLE OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER ENTERING JAIL
AND TO CONTINUE THAT TREATMENT.
WHEN THEY RETURN TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES?
AND SAN FRANCISCO WE'VE INVESTED
IN THE FUNDAMENTAL ASPECTS OF
TREATMENT FOR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
THIS INCLUDES INDIVIDUAL AND
GROUP THERAPY COUNSELING
EDUCATION TOOLS FOR RECOVERY.
WE ALSO USE MEDICATION THAT'S
BEEN SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE TO
TREAT THESE DISORDERS.
CURRENTLY WHEN SOMEONE COMES
INTO OUR DELAND SAN FRANCISCO
AND GOES INTO OPIATE.
OPIOID WITHDRAWAL WE TREAT THEM
WITH THE MEDICATION THAT IS
WIDELY AVAILABLE BUT SELDOM USED
IN THIS CONTEXT.
THIS MEDICATION IS DEEPER AND
DEEPER MORPHINE FOR NURSING IS A
MEDICATION THAT DECREASES THE
EXTREME PHYSICAL SUFFERING OF
OPIOID WITHDRAWAL AND ALLOWS YOU
MAIN DETOXIFICATION.
PATIENTS ARE CLOSELY MONITORED
BY OUR PHYSICIANS DURING THIS
PROCESS.
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
DURING THE INCARCERATED CARRIER
PROTECTS PATIENTS FROM
OVERDOSING BOTH IN THE JAIL AND
UPON RELEASE.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ABSTINENT FROM
OPIOIDS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
OVERDOSE WHEN THEY RETURN TO
THEIR PRE INCARCERATION LEVEL OF
USE BECAUSE THEY'VE LOST THEIR
TOLERANCE.
WE THEREFORE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THIS MEDICATION FOR THE
DURATION OF THEIR INCARCERATION.
IT PREVENTS CRAVING AND RELAPSE
WITH THE SUPPORT OF FUNDING
SOURCE OFFERED THROUGH AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WE COULD DO
THIS.
WE BELIEVE THAT PROVIDING
TREATMENT TO PATIENTS REQUIRES A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVELS.
BY RECEIVING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE TO
PURCHASE AND MAY TIAS PROPOSED
HERE WILL TREAT MORE PATIENTS
WHO WE KNOW WILL BENEFIT FROM
THAT TREATMENT AND OUR
COLLEAGUES IN LOS ANGELES ARE
ALSO INTERESTED IN OUR
EXPERIENCE.
THEY OPERATE THE BIGGEST JAIL IN
IN THE NATION -- AND THEY'RE
EAGER TO TO TACKLE THIS AS WELL.
THE TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS IS DIFFICULT BUT WE
HAVE AFFECTED TOOLS TO IMPACT
THIS VEXING ISSUE PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE OVER REPRESENTED IN
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
UNDER REPRESENTED IN ACCESS TO
NEW AN EXPENSIVE MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT.
WITH THIS BILL WE HAVE A CHANCE
TO ADDRESS THAT INEQUITY THESE
MEDICATIONS CHANGE LIVES AND
SAVE LIVES SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FURTHER
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TOM RENT FREE WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. TO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- I YEAH I JUST LIKE
TO THINK MAYOR BREED FOR COMING
TODAY AND TO TESTIFY -- YOU HAVE
BEEN A LEADER IN YOUR COMMUNITY
TRYING TO TACKLE THIS AND IF WE
CAN BE OF SOME HELP TO GET THIS
MOVING ALONG WITH THE PILOT.
PROVIDED THERE'S GOOD REPORTING
THAT WE CAN HELP PASS THIS ON TO
OTHERS -- I THINK THAT THIS IS A
GOOD BILL AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING AFFORD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
TO JUST LIKE TO SAY THE SAME IT
GOES COMMONSENSE CHRISTIAN VERY
MUCH YOU BEING HERE PROCEED THIS
THE BILL AND AND THIS SPIRIT
WHICH IS PRESENTED -- MR CHU THE
THE OF BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE -- I SHOULD MENTION
UP AT THE FRONT -- HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OF VERY MUCH APPRECIATED AND
SOME OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GO
TO WHAT -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY JUST MENTION AROUND
HOW WE REPORT IN THE FUTURE SIR
APPRECIATE THAT -- QUITE SIMPLY
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL HELP US
pNEEDS OF SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS.
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IN HELPING TO SUSTAIN THE
RECOVERY IN WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
MUCH OF WE NEED TO WE LOVE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION -- MOTION BY
MS BURKE A SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
SHE DID A GOOD JOB OF THAT.
A SUBSTITUTE THAT FOR EVERY
EVERY BILL OKAY -- SO THE MOTION
IS -- DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MATTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHEN I WHEN
I MAYES.
THANK YOU VERY.
I BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE.
BURKE I AM WICKS FLORA LIMóN.
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible] FOUR THE WAY
FOR US WE GOT A FEW PEOPLE
MISSING SO I'LL WORK ON THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT OUTLOOK FOR
THE FIGHT YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
JERRY MUCH THOUGH.
NOW WE'RE DOWN [inaudible]
TO THREE MISTER CALDERON.
QUICKLY BEFORE WE OPERATE THE
REST OF THE CAN THE PANEL
DISAPPEARS JUST KIDDING.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO USE A
FUNCTIONAL ASSESSMENT TOOL TO
TRACK MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE RECEIVING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. FOR MEDI CAL
AFTER CHOOSING ASSESSMENT TOOL
CALLED THE CHILD AND ADOLESCENT.
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS REFER TO AS
CANS DSS BEGAN CREATING ONLINE
UP TODAY CLOUD BASED DATA
PLATFORM FOR PARTICIPATING
PROVIDERS TO INPUT DATA IN REAL
TIME.
IN CONTRAST THE DH CS HAS NOT
YET TAKEN THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM WITH PROPOSED
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AB THREE
EIGHTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO DEVELOP UPDATE
OR INTEGRATE WITH AN EXISTING
PLATFORM TO CLOSE TO COLLECT
CANS ASSESSMENTS. TO PROVIDE
REAL TIME DATA ABOUT YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES NEED TO EMPLOY
TECHNOLOGY AND SUPPORT -- TO TO
SUPPORT VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND HELP THEM REACH THEIR FULL
BUT MEANT MENTAL HEALTH
POTENTIAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE IN WITH ME AND SET
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS.
KRISTEN EMERGED THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA LINES
FOR CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
THANK YOU THESE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WOULD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
KRISTIN -- MERTZ EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES REPRESENTING A HUNDRED
AND FORTY NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
WORKING WITH CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
SYSTEMS WE APPRECIATE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAULDRONS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL.
AB THREE EIGHTY FIVE WILL MOVE
US TOWARDS A SOLUTION TO A LONG
STANDING PROBLEM THE CHALLENGE
OF KNOWING WITH CERTAINTY.
THAT THE ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS WE ARE SPENDING OUR
CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IS ACTUALLY
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF CHILDREN.
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH.
AN INTEGRATED DATABASE UTILIZING
THE TOOLS CHOSEN BY DH CS AND DS
US TO MEASURE THE LEVEL OF
FUNCTIONING IN IMPORTANT AREAS
OF THE USE LIVE.
WILL CHIEF THREE PRIMARY GOALS
IMPROVED COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
SYSTEMS.
BY HAVING A TOOL WITH ONE DATA
SYSTEM.
WITHIN ONE DATA SYSTEM BOTH
SERVICE SYSTEMS SHALL WELFARE
AND MENTAL HEALTH WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SAME INFORMATION
AT THE SAME TIME.
SECONDLY TIMELY ACCESS TO THE
RIGHT SERVICE IN THE RIGHT
LOCATION.
THIS WILL ALLOW PROVIDERS TO BE
ABLE TO DETERMINE IF AN
ASSESSMENT HAS BEEN DONE.
ON A YOUTH AND FAMILY THEY ARE
NOW SERVING NO MATTER WHERE THE
ASSESSMENT OCCURRED IN THE STATE
FOR WHICH SERVICE SYSTEM IT.
WAS COMPLETED IN.
AND THIRDLY ADMINISTRATORS AND
LEGISLATORS WILL BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
EFFICIENCY OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
AT THE PROGRAM COUNTY AND STATE
WIDE LEVEL IN REAL TIME.
NOT EIGHTEEN MONTHS LATER.
THIS INTEGRATED SYSTEM WILL SAVE
MONEY IN SEVERAL WAYS IT WILL
DECREASE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
BURDEN TIMES STAFF RESOURCES.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT WILL
REDUCE THE BURDEN ON FAMILIES
HAVING TO GO THROUGH MULTIPLE
ASSESSMENTS.
IT WILL ALSO IN IT ENABLE
SERVICE PROVIDERS COUNTY
AGENCIES STATE DEPARTMENTS IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO MONITOR
CURRENT PROGRESS ON YOUTH AT THE
INDIVIDUAL SYSTEM AND STATEWIDE
LEVELS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
AB THREE EIGHTY FIVE IS INTENDED
TO ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
INTEGRATED ASSESSMENT DATA AND
IS IN NO WAY RELATED TO THIS.
SKEWS ME TO THE DECISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE BY DH CS AND DS
US ABOUT THE ASSESSMENT TOOLS
THAT ARE MANDATED IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE
DUPLICATION COSTS AND IMPROVE
TIMELY ACCESS TO CLIENT DATA.
THE WILL ULTIMATELY ENSURE
BETTER CARE FOR THE CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES RESEARCH WE
SERVE AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA LIKE
ALFA WORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BOX ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL SERVE YOU KNOW
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MARKETS BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL THE
CALIFORNIA BENNETT THE HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT BECUZ
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRING THE BILL FORWARD -- AT
LAGS INTO A TIME LAG.
AND DATA DON'T GO WELL TOGETHER
AND AND SO THAT THE MORE WE CAN
STREAMLINE THINGS. TO GET THE
INFORMATION FASTER THE BETTER
THE OUTCOMES ARE GONNA BE FOR
EVERYONE SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THE GO FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR THE BILL DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE
HAD A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY.
OF THIS -- BURKE YET THAT -- THE
MOTION AS IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS A MATTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT.
HI WHEN I MAYES I GET HURT.
OKAY SORRY I BIGELOW BONTA BURKE.
BURKE AYE.
WICKS.
LARA LEVEL MCCARTY NAZARIAN FROM
A RAMOS RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
WALDRON.
YOU HAVE THREE VOTES WE HAVE A
LOT OF MISSING MEMBERS -- WILL
BE THE BILL ON CALL STUFF MISS
JAY GOT ALONG AGENDA TODAY BE
GREAT IF THEY COULD JUST BE HERE
GET A GUN WHEN IT.
YEAH YEAH LIKE IT'S A REMEMBER
THAT THING.
THE LONG AND WINDING ROAD.
GIVE ANOTHER BILL I DO.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN THIRTY ACTUALLY I WENT TO
SCHOOL [inaudible]
DESPITE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PROUD.
TO SHARE PRESENTATION ON A. B.
TEN THIRTY WITHOUT MY JOIN
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
KIND OF PETRIE-NORRIS AB TEN
THIRTY WILL EMPOWER PATIENTS BY
GIVING THEM MUCH NEEDED
INFORMATION.
GIVEN THE MORE INVASIVE NATURE
OF PUBLIC EXAMINATIONS AND
RECENT HORRIFIC TALES OF ABUSE
DURING THESE EXAMS.
IT HAS BECOME APPARENT THAT
PATIENTS WOULD BENEFIT FROM
ADVANCE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
TO EXPECT DURING A PELVIC EXAM.
AB TEN THIRTY REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD AND THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
TO DEVELOP AN INFORMATIONAL
PAMPHLETS. FOR PATIENTS
UNDERGOING A GYNECOLOGICAL
PELVIC EXAMINATION WITH BASIC
INFORMATION REGARDING HOW THE
PROCEDURE SHOULD BE PROPERLY
PERFORMED.
PRIVACY AND SANITARY
EXPECTATIONS AND BOARD CONTACT
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO REPORT
ANY INSTANCES OF MISCONDUCT.
AB TEN THIRTY SIMPLY REQUIRES
THAT THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
PROVIDED TO PATIENTS PRIOR TO
THEIR FIRST PUBLIC EXAM.
AB TEN THIRTY WILL ENSURE THAT
FIRST TIME GYNECOLOGICAL
PATIENTS RECEIVE THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED.
IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY AND
HOPEFULLY PREVENT INSTANCES OF
SEVERE MISCONDUCT I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE IN THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
CHRISSY LEACH WAS A CONSTITUENT
OF MINE.
AND WHO IS THE SOURCE OF THIS
BILL SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
CHRISTY FOR COMING UP.
AND INVITE YOU TO PLEASE SHARE.
YOUR STORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF AB.
TEN THIRTY MY NAME IS CHRISTY
LEACH AND I AM ONE OF THE NEARLY
SIX HUNDRED SURVIVORS OF THE
SEXUAL ASSAULTS THAT OCCURRED IN
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER AT USC --
AT THE HANDS OF GEORGE TYNDALL --
I'M ONE OF BETWEEN TEN THOUSAND
AND ESTIMATED TEN THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT
HE SAW DURING HIS TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR TENURE AT USC AS THE ONLY
MALE AS THE ONLY KIND OF
COLLEGES IN THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER -- MY STORY IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN MOST OF THE
STUDENTS THAT WENT INTO THE
HEALTH CENTER FOR CARE -- I WENT
IN BECAUSE I HAD -- SYMPTOMS OF
A SINUS INFECTION.
AND I CONSIDERED MYSELF LUCKY
WHEN -- I WALKED INTO THE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER AND THE
DOCTOR APPROACH ME AND LET ME
INTO HIS OFFICE -- I THOUGHT
WELL HELL.
I'M NOT GONNA HAVE TO WAIT VERY
LONG -- WHEN I WENT INTO HIS
OFFICE HE SAT ME ON HIS DESK AND
ASK ME MY SYMPTOMS?
AND I GAVE MY SYMPTOMS AND HE
DIAGNOSED ME WITH SINUS
INFECTION -- GAVE ME ANTIBIOTICS
AND THEN HAD TOLD ME THAT HE WAS
NOT ONLY -- OF A GENERAL
PRACTITIONER BUT AN OBGYN AND
HAD I HAD MY YEARLY EXAM YET.
AND I HAD TOLD HIM THAT I HAD
NEVER HAD A GYNECOLOGICAL EXAM
AND THAT I DIDN'T THINK THAT IT
WAS NECESSARY -- BUT HAD AS HIS
AT HIS INSISTENCE AS A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL I AGREE TO IT --
AND THE EXAM TABLE WAS ACTUALLY
IN HIS OFFICE -- I DRESSED
UNDRESSED FROM THE WAIST DOWN --
I WAS NOT GIVEN -- A CLOTH TO
COVER MYSELF WITH.
AND HE PROCEEDED TO TELL ME THAT
HE WOULD NEED -- TO DO A PELVIC
EXAM TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WERE NO ABNORMALITIES -- SO HE
DIGITAL DIGITALLY PENETRATED ME
WITH HIS HAND WITH HIS UNCLE
HAVE TOWN -- AND HE MADE.
HE HE JUST.
DID A VERY VERY THOROUGH
EXAMINATION MOVING HIS HAND IN
AND OUT AND AROUND -- FOR
SEVERAL MINUTES HE WAS VERY
PAINFUL -- I HAD NO IDEA THAT IT
WAS A SEXUAL ASSAULTS -- WHEN
YOU'RE IN THOSE TYPES OF --
EXAMINATIONS I THINK YOU'RE MORE
INSIDE OF YOUR HEAD.
JUST TRYING TO GET THROUGH IT --
SO I DIDN'T REALIZE.
THAT IT WAS WRONG -- WHILE HE
WAS EXAMINING ME HE ALSO TOLD ME
THAT -- I WAS SO BEAUTIFUL THAT
I COULD BE A MODEL.
AND AND THAT HE WAS SURE THAT MY
MOTHER WAS BEAUTIFUL AS WELL AND
THAT SHE COULD BE A MODEL AS
WELL.
HE ALSO COMMENTED THAT -- MY
THAT I WAS I MUST BE A RUNNER
BECAUSE I WAS TIGHT -- AND THEN
AS HE CONCLUDED THE EXAM.
HE ASKED IF HE COULD TAKE
PICTURES -- BECAUSE HE WANTED TO
USE THE PHOTOS -- FOR RESEARCH
THAT HE WAS WORKING ON ONE THING
THAT -- WE ARE PAINFULLY
LEARNING.
THROUGH THIS -- CASE IS THAT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO HAVE A
CHAPERONE IN THE ROOM.
IN MANY CASES OF THE OTHER.
SURVIVORS -- THERE WERE
CHAPERONES IN THE ROOM -- AND
WE'RE LEARNING THAT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO TRUSTS --
INSTITUTIONAL EXACT --
ADMINISTRATION TO DO THE RIGHT
THING -- MANY CHAPERONES I WENT
TO THE UNIVERSITY TO REPORT HIM --
OVER THE COURSE OF THE TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS AND NOTHING WAS DONE.
OUR TO DISCIPLINE HIM -- I THINK
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE TO KNOW --
THAT I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE GIVEN.
A TRADE CLOTH TO COVER MYSELF I
THINK IT'S JUST BASIC HUMAN
DECENCY -- TO RESPECT SOMEONE'S
PRIVACY -- I THINK IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN NICE TO KNOW THAT A DOCTOR
SHOULD HAVE BEEN WEARING A GLOVE --
BEFORE HE PENETRATED ME -- AND I
THINK THAT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
NICE TO KNOW THAT THE PELVIC
EXAM WAS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE SO
INVASIVE -- ESPECIALLY THE FIRST
TIME -- ONE WAS HAVING AN EXAM --
SO I AM I ASK THAT YOU WOULD
PLEASE.
HELP US EQUIPMENT WOMEN TO
BECOME -- EQUIPPED TO PROTECT AN
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES IN THESE
SITUATIONS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
MAJORITY LEADER FOR ALTERING
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
NEXT CALL OKAY.
RAIN SPENDS ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN STE
DISTRICT NINE A FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR.
NO NEED TO DO SINCE BILL -- TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES WHICH BY THE
WAY WE DO NOT CONDONE THE
ACTIONS OF THAT DOCTOR A DOCTOR
PERFORMS SUCH ACTIONS ON A
PATIENT -- BUT LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR REACHING OUT TO US --
IN THE PROCESS AND WANTING TO
COME TO SOME TYPE OF CONSENSUS
TO MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT SOMETHING HAPPENED HER
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THE
INTENT TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN ARE
INFORMED AND EMPOWERED. TO KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT WE GO INTO A
GYNECOLOGICAL.
EXAM THE THE CONCERN WE HAVE
INDISCRIMINATE HAVE US WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE INFO THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED.
AND THE MODE OF DELIVERY TO THE
PATIENT.
AND I DO THINK WE HAVE AN UP TO
YOU TO GET THERE WE'LL CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
WHICH I LOOK FORWARD TO UNTIL
THEN UNFORTUNATELY A CALL TO
SHOULD NINE MUST REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
MORRELL GARBLED THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND I WOULD
JUST NEAR THE COMMENTS MADE BY
THE MY COLLEAGUE HERE AND ALSO
SAY THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SIR ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S A GREAT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I HAVE A CONSTANT.
DOES IT REALLY MATTER HOW YOUNG
WOMAN GETS INFORMATION.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT WAS JUST
SAID.
THAT.
I DON'T HAVE THE PAMPHLET CAMPUS
ONLINE I DON'T CARE HOW IT IS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALL
PROTECTED.
WE'VE ALL HAD DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS OUR FIRST PAP SMEARS
ARE ALWAYS A SCARY THING.
AND TO HAVE YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT -- I'M SO SORRY.
I'M SO SORRY -- BUT IT MY HOPE
MY POINT IS WHATEVER WE GET THE
HOWEVER WE GET THE INFORMATION
OUT.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
SB SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
OBVIOUSLY -- DESPITE THANK YOU
FOR BRING THE BILL FORWARD AND
THANK YOU TO YOUR WITNESS -- FOR
SHARING THAT WITH US I KNOW
THAT'S DIFFICULT -- TO SAY THE
LEAST -- AND SUPPORT OF IT WHAT
YOU WANT TO DO HERE -- AND I
HOPE THAT AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
THAT YOU COME TO SOME
ARRANGEMENT -- I THINK -- I
THINK IT'S INFORMED CONSENT I
THINK IT'S A PROCEDURE WE DO --
IN HEALTH CARE REVIEW I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT IT IS YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DOING -- AND THE PROCEDURE SO
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THE RISKS
AND THE BENEFITS -- THAT'S THE
WAY IT SHOULD BE DONE AND SO I
SINCERELY HOPE YOU.
WILL BE WATCHING CLOSELY AND AND
WANT TO SEE HOW THIS IS RESOLVED
BUT PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
TO THEM.
BEFORE IT HAPPENS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH MR FS AND THE WOMAN
PETRIE-NORRIS WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE FIRST.
I THINK WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS EARLIER TODAY I SAID
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
SHOULDN'T BE NEEDED.
RIGHT.
BUT I THINK THAT WE ALL KNOW THE
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
EVENTS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
COVERED OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
THAT UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS
NEEDED AND SO I THINK THE AUTHOR.
AND I DO I THINK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR BRINGING FORTH THE SPELL
IDEA.
AND FOR COMING HERE TO SHARE
YOUR STORY WITH ALL OF US THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND
THIS IS ABOUT INFORMATION.
JUST MAKING SURE THAT YOUNG
WOMEN ARE PREPARED I'VE TWO
DAUGHTERS.
YOU KNOW WHEN THEY GO ON FOR THE
FIRST EXAMINATION I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE PREPARED.
AND THEN NEVER PUT IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY WERE GIVEN
INFORMATION.
SO THAT THEY ARE NOT
INADVERTENTLY TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T GIVEN A
PIECE OF PAPER THEY WERE
NOTIFIED IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
NORMAL WHAT IS NOT.
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE -- TO
WORK THINGS OUT AS BEST WE
POSSIBLY CAN -- BUT THIS ISSUE
IS OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP WORKING HARD ON IT --
AND I JUST REALLY WANT TO THANK
MY CONSTITUENT CHRISTY FOR YOUR
BRAVERY TO COME AND SHARE YOUR
STORY BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND
EVERYBODY WATCHING AND THAT YOUR
STRENGTH TO COME AND BE HERE
TODAY.
AS IN JUST HELPING US CREATE
BETTER POLICY TO PROTECT MORE
WOMEN BUT IT'S GIVING STRENGTH --
TO THOSE THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
SITUATION TODAY THAT YOU
EXPERIENCED AND THAT WE'RE GONNA
DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
WE WE DON'T HAVE THAT CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CAN DO OUR BEST.
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
EVER AGAIN SO WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THINK
ABOUT FOR THE TIME RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CALDERON WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
BY THIS.
FIGURE CURRY A SECOND BY MISS
BURKE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW.
FONT BONTA.
BURKE.
I WICKS FLORA LOW MOAN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RAMOS.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON
[inaudible] THREE WE HAVE THREE
VOTE SOME WE'VE.
WILL FIND MEMBERS VISUALLY TO
COME BACK THANK YOU REVEALED AT
ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
SUCCESS.
I GUESS THE TRAINERS. TO GO TO
FARMS PETRIE-NORRIS YOUR NEXT.
AB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX MEMBERS I AM
HERE TODAY TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY FIVE TO SIX THE
PURPOSE OF THIS SPELL IS TO
ENSURE THAT VULNERABLE INFANTS
CHILDREN AND PREGNANT WOMEN.
RECEIVE THE HEALTH CARE THAT
THEY NEED AND ARE ENTITLED TO
THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH AN
EXPEDITED PATHWAY FOR MEDI CAL
ENROLLMENT FROM THE SPECIAL
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION PROGRAM.
FOR WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
KNOWN AS WACK.
WHICH IS A FEDERALLY FUNDED
HEALTH AND NUTRITION PROGRAM TO
IMPROVE BIRTH AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR LOW INCOME PREGNANT
WOMEN CHILDREN AND INFANTS ON
AVERAGE ONE POINT ONE MILLION
CHILDREN AND INFANTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
ARE COVERED EACH MONTH BY WHACK
THERE ARE SIMILAR ELIGIBILITY
CONDITIONS BETWEEN MEDI CAL AND
WAKE.
BUT DESPITE THIS MORE THAN
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN
WHO ARE ENROLLED IN WAY.
AND ARE ELIGIBLE. FOR MEDI CAL
ARE STILL NOT ENROLLED IN
MEDICAID. TO ENSURE THAT THESE
VULNERABLE INFANTS CHILDREN
PREGNANT WOMEN RECEIVE THE
HEALTH CARE THAT THEY NEED WE
NEED TO STREAMLINE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES.
CURRENTLY THE WICK ELIGIBILITY
SYSTEM ALREADY TAX PARTICIPANTS
MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT BY LINKING
TO MEDIC HEALTH DATABASE.
BUT WHEN FAMILIES AREN'T
ENROLLED WE CAN ONLY GIVE THEM A
REFERRAL.
AB FIVE TO SIX WILL ESTABLISH
EXPRESS LANE ELIGIBILITY FOR
MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT.
WITH WITH WITH APPLICANT DOES
NOT SHOW MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO GIVE
CONSENT TO INITIATE EXPRESS LANE
ELIGIBILITY ENROLLMENT.
USING THE WACK ELIGIBILITY
FINDINGS.
WE THINK THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
GAPS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
AND AM PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TO
SUPPORTERS HERE TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND PLEASE.
GO AHEAD. NINE YEAR ON THAT CAN
YEAR NOW.
GOT YOUR GOOD I'M GOOD I DON'T
THINK -- KRISTIN GOLDEN TESTED
WITH THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSORS WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH.
COVERAGE COALITION -- WHICH
INCLUDES THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP -- CHILDREN NOW A
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA C. C. H. I. UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND ALSO A
MARCH OF DIMES -- AND THEN ON MY
COLLEAGUE WAS BECAUSE WELL -- I
WANT TO THANK -- ARE SOME WOMEN
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL IT IS AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO FULFILL
OUR PROMISE FOR COVERING ALL
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB SO FAR AND HEALTH FOR
ALL KIDS.
AND AND NOW THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE IS IN ROLLING SO
REALLY THE WORK OF COVERAGE FOR
ALL CHILDREN INVOLVES MAXIMIZING
ENROLLMENT.
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL -- IS -- A
SMART STRATEGY BY GOING TO WHERE
LARGE NUMBERS OF CHILDREN LIVE
AND EXIST IF THEY SHOW UP AT
PROGRAMS LIKE WE ASK A NUTRITION
PROGRAM.
AND SO THIS OFFERS US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENROLL THEM FROM
WHERE THEY ARE AND THE BENEFIT
AS YOU HEARD IS THAT THEY
ALREADY PROVIDED INFORMATION --
THAT COULD BE USED TO JUST
QUICKLY AND ROLL THEM INTO MEDI
CAL AND AS YOU ALSO HEARD -- THE
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT WE KNOW
OF THESE FOLKS THAT WE KNOWN
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN WE
KNOW THEIR NAMES AND WE KNOW
THEIR NUMBERS AND WE'RE NOT.
IN ROLLING THEM BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT WE HAVE A
STRATEGIES THROUGH THE FEDERAL --
LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR EXPRESSING
MOMENT TO USE WICK FINDINGS SO
THIS REALLY IS A PERFECT
ALIGNMENT WITH SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS.
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PUT
FORWARD IN HIS -- INITIATIVE TO
TRY AND REACH CHILDREN AND AT
THE EARLY STAGES IN LIFE AND
CONNECT THEM TO THE SERVICES
THEY NEED JUST NOT JUST
NUTRITION BUT ALSO HEALTH CARE
WHEN THEY MOST NEED IT AS THEIR
STARTING OFF THEIR LIVES -- AND
WE ARE -- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I'M SORRY TIAS WITH THE I'M
SORRY TIAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AND HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE EIGHTY THREE LOCAL LOOK
AGENCIES SERVING ABOUT A MILLION
PARTICIPANTS MONTHLY.
AND WE'RE SUPPORTING THE BUDGET
ASK FOR ESTABLISHMENT OF EXPRESS
LANE ELIGIBILITY CAPACITY FOR
MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT FROM WITH --
ENSURING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
CONTRIBUTES TO IMPROVED HEALTH
COMES BOTH SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM IN A VARIETY OF RESPECT.
INCLUDING PRETERM AND LOW
BIRTHWEIGHT CHILD DEVELOPMENT
CHRONIC DISEASE MANAGEMENT
ESPECIALLY FOR DIABETES AND
OBESITY -- TRAUMA AND ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND OTHER
OUTCOMES -- IMPROVING THE EASE
OF ACCESS FOR ENROLLMENT.
IN SAFETY NET PROGRAM SUPPORTS
YOUNG FAMILIES IN THEIR EARLY
YEARS WHEN A BIT OF EXTRA HELP
CAN MAKE LASTING IMPACTS ON
FAMILY WELL BEING.
STREAMLINING APPLICATION AND
ENROLLMENT INCLUDING USE OF
TECHNOLOGY OUR EXPECTATIONS FOR
YOUNG MOMS TO DO MOST OF THEIR
BUSINESS ONLINE ESPECIALLY IN
WITH THEIR MOBILE DEVICES.
AND WITH A NEW WICK AND MY ****
SYSTEM ROLLING OUT IN THE NEXT
YEAR PLANNING FOR THE CAPACITY
TO LINK PROGRAMS INCLUDING MEDIC
HOW IS A NATURAL NEXT STEP.
AND LEVERAGING IN MAXIMIZING
YOUR INVESTMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS A
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON RONALD COLMAN
HERE ON BEHALF OF HEALTH TEXAS
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIC HARRIS ON
BEHALF OF MARCH TONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OUR DISCUSS THE WHOLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PENALTY KILL THEIR
WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
AND SUPPORTS.
ON A HAS A BAD WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GALEANO CHILDREN OUT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JANICE CAN ALLEN CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THIRTY OF
ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
HI KELLY MAC MILLAN TO CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
GEN MEMBERS CUT THE MUSTARD FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
GEN FLORES WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH. TWENTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMING [inaudible]
THE THIS IS NOT UNFAMILIAR TO
THIS COMMITTEE ACT.
IT'S REALLY NOT AS FAMILIAR TO
ME EITHER WE ACTUALLY HEARD THIS
IN OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
YESTERDAY SO -- THE BILL OES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
WE HAVE A MOTION -- BY -- MISS
BURKE A SECOND BY MISTAKE HERE
CURRY WHICH I THE CLOSENESS
BETWEEN US ALL TO SAY THANK.
YOU ENSURING THAT VULNERABLE
INFANTS WOMEN PREGNANT WOMEN
CHILDREN RECEIVE HEALTH CARE IS
IS CLEARLY THE RIGHT THING TO DO
AND I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT.
I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE.
AS THIS AS THIS MOVES FORWARD
ALSO THE SMART THING TO DO
BECAUSE YEAH IT'S A SAYS MONEY
IN THE LONG TERM AND IMPROVES
LONG TERM OUTCOMES SO.
I'M.
I APPRECIATE YOUR RECOMMENDATION
AND AND YOUR SUPPORT AND THAT
LOOK.
FOR TO KNOW YOUR SUPPORT AS WE
MOVE THIS MOVE THIS THING
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU BRING THE
BILL FORWARD.
THE BILL OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE BURKE HI.
WICKS FLORA LIMóN MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THIS AREA RAMOS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON.
BEFORE WE WILL LEAVE THE WE WILL
BE THE BILL ON CALL AND I'M SURE
WE'LL HAVE MORE MEMBERS HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT [inaudible]
MR LOW [inaudible]
WELCOME MISTER.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
IT THIS IS A ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY THAT'S WHICH IT IS
CORRECTED ALREADY ENJOYS A
MOTION AND A SECOND WONDERFUL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS WITH
RESPECT TO PROTECTING.
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND WITH
RESPECT TO ASK FOR A VOTE TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
WHICH FOR TWENTY YEARS HAS LED
THE EAGLE THE STATE'S FIGHT FOR
FULL LGBT Q. EQUALITY.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR ENHANCED DATA
COLLECTION RELATING TO THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
DATA IS AN IMPORTANT MEANS OF
UNDERSTANDING COMMUNITY HEALTH
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WHETHER
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS OUR REGION
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
ACCURATE AND COMPREHENSIVE
MORTALITY DATA CAN INFORM POLICY
TO REVIEW REDUCE PREVENTABLE
DEATHS AND IMPROVE QUALITY OF
LIFE LACK OF DATA HAMPERS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TARGETED PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERVENTIONS AND
PREVENTION STRATEGIES.
AND CURRENTLY WE LACK DATA
CONCERNING THE VIOLENT DEATHS OF
LGBTQ PEOPLE.
STUDIES HAVE CONSISTENTLY FOUND
HIGHER RATES OF SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS SUICIDE PLANNING AND
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS AND LGBTQ
PEOPLE COMPARED TO THE GENERAL
POPULATION.
HOWEVER IT'S DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE AT THE RATE AT WHICH
LGBT Q. PEOPLE DIE AS A RESULT
OF SUICIDE AND VIOLENCE AND THIS
BILL SEEKS TO IMPROVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY TO THAILAND
VIOLENT DEATHS OCCUR.
WHO IS MOST AFFECTED AND HOW
THESE DEATHS CAN BE PREVENTED SO
WE SUPPORT THE PRINCIPLES
UNDERLYING EIGHTY SIX FIFTY AND
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW FOR
HIS ATTENTION O THIS ISSUE?
AND AS THE BILL DEVELOPS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM TO
ENSURE THAT THEY NEED TO COLLECT
DATA IS BALANCED WITH RESPECT
FOR DECEDENTS AND THEIR
SURVIVORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
AND A LITTLE IS CALIFORNIA TECH
HELP THAT WORK IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. TWENTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
AS A NOTARY BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER WHAT WHICH I
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MOTION BY
MISS BURKE THE SECOND BY MISTAKE
YEAR CURRY DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
A MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE DO
PASSED TO CORPORATIONS EXCUSE ME.
TO PUBLISH HIS ME.
A BOXER TO PASS A PUBLIC SAFETY
EXCUSE ME -- MATT SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES?
AND YOUR CARD AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE.
BURKE AYE WICKS [inaudible]
FLORA LIMóN.
LEVINE I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MISS AREA RAMOS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO.
WALDRON [inaudible]
I YEAH FIGHT YET EXCUSE ME HAVE
FIVE VOTES THAT WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL AND AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL I'M SORRY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL. EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FOR NON FROM IT
KALASHNIKOV TREATMENTS FOR PAIN
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ACCEPTING
THEM AS PRESENTS.
A BILL TO CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
OTHER ALTERNATIVES WITH RESPECT --
TO PAIN TREATMENT AND A GREAT
WAY. TO FIGHT THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC WITH ME I HAVE IT IS
NOT ONCE IS IN SUPPORT FOR THANK
YOU PLEASE.
OKAY.
MOTION AND A SECOND.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING -- THIS TO BE HEARD
TODAY AND CERTAINLY THANK YOU.
TO A SIMILAR FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS BILL UPTICK I'M A
PRACTICING CHIROPRACTOR HAVE
BEEN FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS I
WORK IN A HIGHLY INTEGRATED
CLINIC.
IN SAN JOSE ON SITE AT CISCO
WITH MEDICAL DOCTORS PHYSICAL
THERAPIST ACUPUNCTURISTS
CHIROPRACTORS -- PAPER HEALTH
COUNSELORS -- A PHARMACY PRETTY
MUCH EVERYTHING YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT A A COMPANY WOULD WANT TO
PUT AN ONSITE CLINIC TO KEEP
THEIR EMPLOYEES HEALTHY AND
HAPPY -- REGARDING THE AB.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO HAVE A
FIXABLE.
PROBLEM THAT IS STILL KILLING
HUNDREDS MORE LIKE THE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE EACH YEAR.
THE LAST OFFICIAL DATA WE HAVE
IS FROM.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A PUTS
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS AT ALMOST
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT YEAR.
AND IT IS NOT JUST THOSE TESTS
BUT THE THOUSANDS OF LIVES AND
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN RUINED.
IT IS ALL OF THE CHILDREN THEY
HAVE LOST A PARENT AS WILL THE
PAIN DISABILITY AND FINANCIAL
RUIN.
COST TO THOSE WHO AVOIDED DEATH
BUT NOT THE ADDICTION WITH AB
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT WE ARE ASKING
YOU TO WORK TO HELP STOP FEELING
THE FINAL OF PEOPLE BEING GIVEN
PRESCRIPTIONS.
THERE THE FOUNDATION OF THIS
PROBLEM. TO QUOTE DOCTOR EVAN
WOULD.
MD PHD WHO IS A PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
BRITISH COLUMBIA STUDYING
ADDICTION MEDICINE AND DRUG
POLICY.
HE STAYED IN THE NEW IN THE MESS
JOURNAL OF MEDICINE THAT THE
ORIGINS OF THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC
CAN BE TRACED TO OVER
PRESCRIPTION OF NARCOTIC
ANALGESICS AND AQUATIC
ANALGESICS ARE OPIOIDS.
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT WILL FACILITATE A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO UNDO THIS
PROBLEM THROUGH A MECHANISM THAT
IS ALREADY IN PLACE AND OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
FULL INFORMED CONSENT.
IT IS ACTUALLY STRIKING THAT HAS
NOT ALREADY IN PLACE FOR OPIOIDS.
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT WILL
REQUIRE TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THE
TRUE RISKS OF OPIOIDS TO THE
PATIENT.
THROUGH A DISCUSSION AND A
SIGNED CONSENT SO THAT PATIENTS
CAN MAKE.
AN INFORMED DECISION. EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT WILL ALSO PUT IN
PLACE.
A REQUIREMENT TO PRESCRIBERS
INFORM PATIENTS THAT EVIDENCE
BASED ALTERNATIVES TO OPIOIDS
EXIST.
INCLUDING NON PHARMACOLOGICAL
PROVIDERS.
WHAT THE RESEARCHERS TOLD US OF
THE PAST FEW YEARS IS THAT FOR
PAIN YOUR TO GENERALLY ARE NOT
RECOMMENDED AND THE NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL PROVIDERS
MENTIONED IN THIS BILL MOST
DEFINITELY ARE?
THERE IS NO MANDATE TO FORCE THE
PRESCRIBER TO PICK ANY SPECIFIC
PROVIDER OR TO MAKE A DIRECT
REFERRAL.
ONLY TO ALERT THE PATIENT ABOUT
SEVERAL EVIDENCE BASED CLASSES
OF PROVIDERS THAT MIGHT BE ABLE
TO HELP THEM.
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT LAST THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER ADDING
THE LIST OF NON PHARMACOLOGICAL
PROVIDERS TO THE ESSENTIAL
BENEFITS PACKAGE.
WHEN IT IS NEXT EVALUATED?
THIS IS NEEDED AS IT TURNS OUT
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT EXPECT THE
PATIENT TO USE EVIDENCE BASED
PROVIDERS.
UNLESS THEY ARE AVAILABLE AND
AFFORDABLE.
IN SUMMARY WERE ASKING YOU TO
REQUIRE AND DOCUMENT THAT
PATIENTS UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PRESCRIBER UNDERSTANDS WHEN
THEY'RE BEING GIVEN AN OPIOID
[inaudible]
IN CLOSING.
YOU KNOW I GET HOME FROM WORK MY
WIFE SOMETIMES WILL ASK ME.
IN A SEMI SERIOUS WAY AS I AM A
CHIROPRACTOR IF I SAVED THE LIFE
TODAY.
IF THIS BILL PASSES AND GETS
IMPLEMENTED WE CAN ALL SAY WE
SAVED MANY LIVES TODAY.
AND YOU CAN SAY THAT WHEN YOU
GIVE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
CARE MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS DR
DANI GAMBINO I'M A DOCTOR
CHIROPRACTIC IN THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT.
OF THE CALIFORNIA CORRECT
ASSOCIATION A SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL.
SEEING FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS --
IT'S CLEAR THAT.
CHANGES NEEDED AWAITED MET PAY
MANAGEMENT IS HANDLED AND CARPET
CARE ANOTHER NON PHARMACOLOGICAL --
TREATMENTS ARE PROVEN AS SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE MEANS TO DEALING
WITH PAIN MANAGEMENT.
COCKERELL STRONGLY BELIEVE THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE. TO FIND PAYMENT
OPTIONS THAT WILL BEND THE CURVE.
FOR OPIOID ADDICTION.
THANK YOU FOR OPPORTUNITIES BE
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
TOM RENT FREE WITH ACCOUNT TO BE
ABLE HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HI CRYSTAL WARD WITH CAL TYRONE
I TEACH PUBLIC HEALTH THAT LIFE
CHIROPRACTIC COLLEGE WEST NAY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MAKING ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT ARE FO ALL TO A NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL TREATMENT SHOULD
BE GIVEN IF APPROPRIATE CMA
REMAINS OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO
AB.
EIGHT EIGHTY DUE TO CONCERNS OF
THE REMAINING PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL.
AB EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT REQUIRES A
PHYSICIAN DISCUSS NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL TREATMENT
OPTIONS WITH EVERY PATIENT
RECEIVING A PRESCRIPTION FOR AN
OPIOID.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY BROAD
PROVISION AND DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE FACT THAT THESE NON
NON PHARMACOLOGICAL TREATMENTS
ARE NOT APPROPRIATE FOR EVERY
TYPE OF PAIN A PATIENT AS
SUFFERING FROM. FOR INSTANCE A
VISIT TO THE CHIROPRACTOR WOULD
NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR PATIENTS
WHO JUST HAVE THEIR WISDOM TEETH
REMOVED.
THE DISCUSSION OF THESE
TREATMENT OPTIONS SHOULD ALSO BE
HAD WITH THE PATIENTS IF THE
OPTIONS ARE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PATIENT.
SIMILAR TO THE OFFER OF OUR FOR
ALL.
ADDITIONALLY THE REQUIREMENT TO
OBTAIN SIGNED INFORMED CONSENT
ATTEMPTS TO STATUTORILY DICTATE
INFORMED CONSENT.
REQUIRING A SIGNATURE THAT THE
PATIENT HAS RECEIVED
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WARNINGS
INCLUDED IN THE STATUTE.
THIS ONE SIZE FITS ALL
DISCUSSION ON OPIOIDS WILL NOW
BE MANDATED AND EVERY ELEMENT OF
THE DISCUSSION WILL BE REQUIRED
TO BE RECITED DIMINISHING THE
VALUE OF THE DISCUSSION
COMPLETELY.
FINALLY THE BILL SIMPLY STATES
INTENT THAT THESE NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL TREATMENT
OPTIONS BE CONSIDERED WHEN THE
STATE REVISITS IT'S ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFITS.
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES HINDERS DIRECTLY ON THE
LACK OF COVERAGE FOR MOST OF THE
SERVICES BY HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS.
INSTEAD OF MANDATING THAT A
PHYSICIAN PROVIDE A REFERRAL TO
AN AND IDENTIFIED IT LIKELY
UNCOVERED PROVIDER.
WE THINK OF THE BEST PATHWAY
WOULD BE TO SEE COVERAGE FOR
THESE NON OPIOID PAIN MANAGEMENT
OPTIONS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE BUT VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
AND LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ON THE POLICY. THREE
MUCH OTHER OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I'D LIKE TO MISTER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE
OPPOSITION BUT SURE SURE YES --
AGAIN -- THE PHRASES -- TO OFFER
OR FOR ALL AND DOES NOT REQUIRE --
A PATIENT TO TRY ANY OF THESE
TREATMENTS BUT INSTEAD TO BE
OFFERED ONE AND DOES NOT REQUIRE
THAT THE DOCTOR PROVIDE A
PATIENT -- SPECIFICALLY WITH
THESE TREATMENTS BUT MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED TO THEM AS ALTERNATIVES.
AND THE REFER A WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO THE KID I MEAN I
THINK THE QUESTION WAS SOMEONE
WHO HAD HER WISDOM TEETH OUT MR
WOULDN'T BE REFERRED TO A
CHIROPRACTOR.
YES YES -- YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT --
THIS IS NOT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND OTHER BUT THIS -- I
THINK THE IN PRACTICE.
OR EVERY REFER I WOULD SUGGEST
IN MALPRACTICE -- THIS IS NOT
THE INTENT AND IT CAN IT'S JUST
AN EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE NON PRESCRIPTION OF THE
OPIOIDS.
AND TREATMENT OF PAIN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEE SEE -- NINE THAT YOU THAT
YOU.
DO HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS BURKE A
SECOND BY.
I CARE CURRY WHICH I TO CLOSE
I'LL TAKE THAT AS A CLOSE OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY THE OTHER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE ROLE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO A PROPS.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY PACKER CURRY I
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA BURKE.
HI.
WICKS.
FLORA.
LIMóN.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON.
WATER
NINE GIVE SIX OUR NUMBERS ARE
GROWING WILL SO LEAVE THE BILL
ON CALL FOR HOPEFULLY A COUPLE
MORE VOTES AT SOME POINT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR Là.
YOU HAVE THREE BILLS TO OKAY ALL
RIGHT.
THROUGH THE ALREADY ONCE
[inaudible]
MR GRAYSON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME FOR THIS.
AND I'M GONNA ASK -- THIS BURKE
WOULD YOU MIND TAKING OVER FOR A
COUPLE MINUTES FOR ME THANK YOU
.
MR GRAYSON IF YOU'D LIKE TO OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL.
ELEVEN SIXTEEN EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL A SERVICE PERSONNEL
WORKING UNPREDICTABLE HIGH
STRESS ENVIRONMENTS THEY CAN
TAKE AN OVERWHELMING MENTAL
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL TOLL THAT
DOES NOT SUBSIDE WHEN THE
INDIVIDUAL SHIFT IS DONE.
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL EMOTIONAL
STRESS THE FIRST RESPONDERS
EXPERIENCE CAN MANIFEST IN
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS SUBSTANCE
A SURVEY CO AUTHORED BY
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND NBC BAY AREA
FOUND THAT NEARLY ONE IN SIX
FIREFIGHTERS HAS CONSIDERED
SUICIDE NATIONAL SURVEYS HAVE
PUT THAT NUMBER AS HIGH AS ONE
IN.
THREE WELL SUPPORT SERVICES MAY
BE AVAILABLE IN SOME CASES FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE OFTEN RELUCTANT
TO UTILIZE THEM FOR REASONS
INCLUDING FEAR OF ADVERSE JOB
IMPACTS THE STIGMA SURROUNDING
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AND THE PERCEPTION AMONG
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL THAT THEY
MUST SHOW NO SIGNS OF WEAKNESS.
AB ELEVEN SIXTEEN WILL INCREASE
THE AVAILABILITY AND USE OF PEER
SUPPORT AND CRISIS REFERRAL
SERVICES BY ALLOWING FOR
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN TRAINED PEER SUPPORT
PERSONNEL.
AND THEIR FELLOW FIREFIGHTERS
PROVIDING PEER SUPPORT TRAINING
TO EMERGENCY SERVICE PERSONNEL
MANY OF WHOM ARE ALREADY
PROVIDING INFORMAL SOME OF
SOCIAL SUPPORT WILL INCREASE
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS AND ENHANCE
OUR ABILITY TO IDENTIFY.
A POTENTIAL HIGH RISK SITUATION
BEFORE A CRISIS EVENT OCCURS.
WITH -- WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
WITNESSED THAT ALLOWED TO SELF
INTRODUCE.
THANK.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS REX
PRITCHARD AND I'M -- ENGINEER
WITH THE LONG BEACH FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND I'M PRESIDENT OF
LONG BEACH FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION.
I ALSO SERVE ON THE BEHAVIORAL
TASK FORCE SPONSORED BY
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL FIRED
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS CAL CHEESE --
YES AND THE CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTER JOINT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM.
I AND I ALSO SERVE ON THE FIRE
SCOPE TASK FORCE FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
I AM HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
ELEVEN SIXTEEN IN THE COURSE OF
DOING OUR JOB FIRST RESPONDERS
ARE OFTEN ASKED TO FACE THE
TRIALS THAT FEW OF US CAN EVER
IMAGINE.
WHETHER IT'S A CATASTROPHIC
FATAL FIRE SHOOTING AUTO
ACCIDENTS PLANE CRASHES OR
TERRORIST ATTACKS ARE
FIREFIGHTERS CONFRONT THE
HORRORS OF LIFE AND BEAR WITNESS
IS THE PAIN OF DEATH.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
ALL TOO OFTEN FIREFIGHTERS TRIED.
TO BURY THE WRENCHING EMOTIONAL
IMPACT OF THESE TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES.
THEY TRIED TO LET GO OF THESE
EVENTS BUT SOMETIMES THE EVENTS
WON'T WILL GO OF US.
NATIONAL STUDIES INDICATE THAT
ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
FIREFIGHTERS SUFFERS
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
ROUGHLY THE SAME RATE THAT IS
SEEN IN THE MILITARY.
FIREFIGHTERS ARE FOUR TIMES AS
LIKELY TO TAKE THEIR OWN LIVES
AS THEY ARE TO LOSE THEIR LIVES
IN A FIRE OR OTHER TRAUMATIC
EVENT.
OFTEN THESE VICTIMS HAVE
SUFFERED IN SILENCE CONCERNED
THAT OPENING UP ABOUT ACUTE
STRESS MIGHT PUT THEIR JOB AT
RISK.
OR BRAND NAME IS UNFIT FOR DUTY.
WE KNOW THAT PEER SUPPORT.
FIREFIGHTERS TALKING
CONFIDENTIALLY WITH OTHER
FIREFIGHTERS IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY
TO HELP WITH THE HEALING PROCESS.
AB ELEVEN SIXTEEN IS DESIGNED TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FIREFIGHTERS
TO SEEK AND RECEIVE THIS CRUCIAL
ASSISTANCE.
IT CALLS UPON CALLOW YES TO
DEVELOP A FIRE SPECIFIC PEER
SUPPORT TRAINING COURSE.
THAT PEER SUPPORT MEMBERS MUST
TAKE.
THE COURSE TO BE DEVELOPED BY
THE CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTER JOIN
APPRENTICE COMMITTEE WILL COVER
THE RANGE OF TOPICS ON PEER
SUPPORT AND STRESS MANAGEMENT
DRAWING ON EXPERTS IN THE AREA.
MORE IMPORTANTLY AB ELEVEN
SIXTEEN INJURES THE
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN SAPIR
SUPPORT MEMBERS AND FIREFIGHTERS
WILL BE CONFIDENTIAL.
UNDER BUT THE BILL THESE
COMMUNICATIONS CAN NOT BE USED
AGAINST A FIREFIGHTER OR THE
QUALIFIED PEER SUPPORT PERSONNEL
IN A CIVIL OR ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEEDING.
THE BILL CONTAINS EXEMPTIONS IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE IS AN
IMMEDIATE THREAT TO LIFE AND
LIMB OR IF THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE
RISK OF A CRIME BEING COMMITTED.
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE ON BEHALF OF THIRTY
THOUSAND FRONTLINE FIREFIGHTERS
WE BELIEVE THAT PROVIDES AN
OPENING FOR MEMBERS TO SEEK THE
HELP THEY NEED.
WITHOUT WORRYING THAT IT COULD
COST THEM THE JOB THAT THEY LOVE.
AND I'M GONNA GO A LITTLE BIT
OFF SCRIPT RIGHT NOW AND TALK
BLUNTLY ABOUT -- INCIDENT.
NO LOSS OF ONE OF OUR BROTHERS
CAPTAIN DAVE ROSA WHO WAS
MURDERED IN LONG BEACH JUNE
TWENTY FIFTH -- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN VERY DRAMATIC EVENT
FIREFIGHTERS AREN'T MEANT.
ART EVER EXPECT TO GET SHOT AND
KILLED.
WHILE RESPONDING TO A OF FIRE IN
FIGHTING A FIRE -- IT WAS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. FOR
FIREFIGHTERS TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
AND TALKING CONFIDENTIALITY WITH
ONE ANOTHER -- TO HELP US GET
THROUGH THAT EVENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT.
ADRIN SELLS ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SIR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PROTECT HERE -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A SOME MEMBER
GRAYSON FOR BRING THIS FORWARD
AND I SPEAK FROM MY HEART.
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS WE'VE SEEN
SO MUCH DEVASTATION OF ALL THE
FIRES A WE'VE HAD IN OUR
DISTRICT.
AND THE I WOULD WANT TO BE IN
THE BOOTS OF THOSE YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN THAT HAVE TO SEE THESE
FIRES ALL SUMMER LONG DAY AFTER
DAY AND NOT HAVE.
SOMEBODY TO TALK.
TO THERE'S NO DOUBT THEIR PTSD
BECAUSE I FELT LIKE I HAD A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME I WAS THERE.
THAT I WITNESSED WAS GOING ON
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO BILL
TO DO IT.
I WISH THAT WE JUST WERE ABLE TO
MOVE -- MENTAL HEALTH AND
TRAINING -- CLASSES -- RIGHT TO
THE FIREFIGHTERS ALL THE TIME
AND I I'M SORRY IT'S TAKEN SO
LONG I'M SORRY WE HAVE TO DO A
BILL FOR THIS -- I WAS IN ROUTE
I WAS MARRIED FOR YEARS TO FARM.
IT'S HARD.
WHEN THEY NEVER GET OVER IT?
AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE IS
TODAY.
BUT I THINK THAT IF WE WOULD
HAVE HAD.
SOME KIND OF COUNSELING IN
SOMEBODY TO HOLD HIS HAND
THROUGH A LOT OF THIS AND I
THINK YOU'VE BEEN A DIFFERENT
PLACE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THIS LIMóN THANK YOU I WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS IN THE
SENTIMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
IN FOR SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A
AM A FIRE STRICKEN.
DISTRICT AND ALSO AND DISTRICT
WITH THE DEBRIS FLOW -- WHERE
OUR COMMUNITY HAS NEVER SEEN
THAT LEVEL OF DEVASTATION -- AND
TO ONLY SEE IT FROM.
A VERY LIMITED PERSPECTIVE AS
OPPOSED TO BEING ON THE SCENE
AND LIVING.
THROUGH WHAT REALLY FIRST I MEAN
DECADS AND DECADES OUR DISTRICT
HAD NOT SEEN ANYTHING LIKE WHAT
WE SAW -- LEAVES AN IMPACT ON
EVERY SINGLE PERSON SO I THINK
THAT THIS IS REALLY.
NEEDED -- AND HEY YOU WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND AND APPROPRIATE TIME
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE MISS WALDRON.
I'M JUST A PIGGY BACK OFF ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUE SAID THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND YOU
KNOW THE WHERE IN THIS THAT IT
ALSO BRINGS WITH IT.
AS WELL -- YOU KNOW LIKE ALSO
COME FROM AN AREA IN SAN DIEGO
WHERE YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD OUR
SHARE OF DEVASTATING FIRES AND
YOU KNOW WE HOLD OUR BREATH FOR
WHEN THE NEXT ONE COMES -- YOU
KNOW WE JUST DID A MEMORIAL FOR
THE CORY IVERSON THE CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS WHO LOST HIS LIFE
IN THE THOMAS FIRE.
AND HIS WIFE ASHLEY HAS STARTED
UP A FOUNDATION.
DEALING WITH MENTAL HEALTH FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS SO IT'S A BIG
ISSUE AND I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE I SUPPOSE IT THANK
YOU -- I THINK YOU FOR YOUR CAME
FROM SOME OF US WHO FOR
EXPERIENCED -- PRETTY
CATASTROPHIC FIRES IN OUR IN OUR
DISTRICTS AND I KNOW OTHER
MEMBERS FEEL THE SAME WAY.
I I THINK WE LOOK AT PROBABLY
LOOK AT OUR FIREFIGHTERS IS
THESE AMAZINGLY STRONG PEOPLE
WHICH THEY ABSOLUTELY ARE BUT
THEY LIKE THE REST OF US -- SEE
THINGS AND OFTEN KEEP THOSE
THINGS THEMSELVES AND I THINK
IT'S IT I THANK APPLY YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
ALL OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS SEE
THINGS.
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SHARE WITH OTHER PEOPLE THEY
NEED SUPPORT AT CRITICAL TIMES
AND OTHERWISE WHO KNOWS YOU KNOW
WE WE KNOW GOOD THAT THINGS
DON'T OCCUR BAD THINGS CAN
HAPPEN WITH SOMEONE SEE THAT
HAPPEN.
WE LOOK AT THEM A STRONG
STRAPPING -- BRAVE PEOPLE WHICH
THEY ARE BUT BUT THEY HAVE --
FEELINGS AS WELL AND AND WE NEED
TO WE NEED TO SUPPORT THEM SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH BRING IT
FORWARD.
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MISS WALDRON.
WE DON'T HAVE A SECOND.
WE WE DO NOW.
I HAVE.
PROMISED BURKE -- AND THE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
WHICH LIKE THE CLOSENESS MR
GRAYSON THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS
MISTER CHAIR AND ALSO TO MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND EXPERIENCES.
AND I WOULD WELCOME CO AUTHOR SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU -- THEM SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WHEN
I MAYES.
AGAR CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE.
BURKE ON WICKS FLORA.
COLOGNE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
THIS AREA.
ROSS ROSS I RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. SEVEN YOU'RE
GETTING CLOSER TO THAT ANYONE
HAS FOR PASSAGE OF THE BILL
TODAY.
SO AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT THIS
WILL PASS I WOULD LIKE TO BE
CONSIDERED AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU.
TAKE ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
RAMOS AND ALSO AS A CO AUTHOR.
YOU GOT IT [inaudible]
SISTER.
OKAY WELL YOU HAVE MISS BURKE
MISSING YOUR CURRY MISS WALDRON
MUSLIM MOMENTS FROM I THINK.
YEAH.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THINKING PROJECT.
BUT YOU KNOW THE BILL PLEASE.
AND AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN REGARDING PEER
SUPPORT PROGRAMS FOR PEACE
OFFICERS.
IN A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STUDY ROUGHLY
THREE FOURTHS OF PEACE OFFICERS
SURVEYED REPORTED HAVING
EXPERIENCED A TRAUMATIC EVENT
BUT LESS THAN HALF OF THEM
REPORTED IT TO THEIR AGENCY.
THE BILL.
AND WITH THAT PIECE OFFICES ARE
OFTEN RELUCTANT RELUCTANT TO
UTILIZE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR REASONS INCLUDING FEAR OF
ADVERSE JOB IMPACTS.
STIGMA AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND THE PERCEPTION AMONG
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY MUST
SHOWS NO SIGNS OF WEAKNESS.
SO I DO HAVE WITNESSES WITH ME
TODAY THAT I ALLOWED TO SELF
INTRODUCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSHING LEVINE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE
CALIFORNIA LODGE -- I'LL BEGIN
BY SAYING -- IN THE ALL AND IN
THE OFF SEASON FEW ISSUES ROSE
THE TOP QUITE LIKE PTSD FOR OUR
RANK AND FILE OFFICERS IT WAS IT
HAS BECOME -- AN ABSOLUTE
EPIDEMIC -- WHEN OUR OFFICERS
WITNESS JUST ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIC
AND UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDIES -- CAR
ACCIDENTS WITH FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN KILLED
SHOOTINGS -- IN SACRAMENTO ALONE
IN TALKING -- TO MY VERY MY
PRESIDENT AND IN VARIOUS RANK
AND FILE OFFICERS ABOUT.
THINGS THEY'VE SEEN ANECDOTES --
WERE OFFICERS WILL BE INVOLVED
IN -- SHE ANY KIND OF VIOLENT
ACT SHOOTING CAR ACCIDENT AND
THE OFFICERS -- WILL REVISIT THE
SCENE AFTER THE FACT AND JUST
START SPEAKING GIBBERISH -- THEY
JUST COMPLETELY ZONE OUT --
OFFICERS WILL COME BACK TO THE
STATION AND TAKE OFF THEIR GUN
BELT AND HAVE THEIR UNIFORM ON
AND THEN PUT SNEAKERS ON AND
JUST START WALKING AROUND -- IN
LONG BEACH -- JUST WITHIN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS WE'VE HAD TWO
OFFICERS COMMIT SUICIDE -- BOTH
HAD FAMILIES AND YOUNG CHILDREN --
ONE WAS RECENTLY RETIRED AND ONE
WAS ACTIVE -- THERE'S JUST NO
MECHANISM IN PLACE FOR THESE
OFFICERS TO SEEK HELP -- THERE
WAS NO ONE EARLY INTERVENTION --
WE SEEN TWO OR THREE OTHER CASES
BE TST IN LONG BEACH TURN IN A
FULL BLOWN MEDICAL CRISES --
OFTEN THE SITUATIONS IF THEY'RE
NOT ADDRESS BY PROFESSIONAL HELP
CAN TURN IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
OR SWORE SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR
WORSE AS WE'VE SEEN.
OUR OFFICE OR SIMPLY NEED AN
OPTION TO COME FORWARD WITHOUT
THE THREAT OF TERMINATION TO
SEEK HELP AB ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
WILL HELP ESTABLISH A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP AT INTERVENTIONS
THESE OFFICERS SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO SUFFER.
IN SILENCE WE RESPECTFULLY
ESCRIBO THANK YOU.
SIR.
MONEY IS A JOB GROWN.
SORRY MY NAME IS JOHN BROWN AND
I'M A PARTNER IN THE LAW FIRM OF
ADAMS FROM THE BROWN ARE FIRM
SPECIALIZES IN THE
REPRESENTATION.
OF PUBLIC SAFETY FIREFIGHTERS
AND POLICE OFFICERS.
AND I'VE BEEN SPECIALIZING IN
WORKERS COMPENSATION FOR THE
LAST TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AND I
CAN TELL YOU IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS I HAVE NOT HAD.
AS MANY SUICIDE CASES IN THE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS I WAS
PRACTICING.
SO RIGHT NOW I'VE HAD TO DEAL
WITH TEN CASES ALL RELATING.
TO POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS THE
COMMON THREAD I HAVE FOUND WHEN
I HAD THE INTERVIEW THESE SAD
CASES.
IS THAT MOST OF THEM DIDN'T SEEK
TREATMENT AT ALL.
IN FACT THEY RESISTED IT OUT OF
FEAR AND THE MINDSET WAS THAT
THEY OBTAIN TREATMENT.
THEY WERE EITHER ELIMINATING A
STIGMA OF WEAKNESS OR WORSE THEY
WERE IN FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOBS.
WE HAVE COUNTLESS EXAMPLES OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD.
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS THAT
ONE DAY OF CARE AND THEY GO BACK
TO WORK YEARS LATER WE FIND
PERSONAL PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
TO PEEL BACK. TO THAT VERY ISSUE.
IN THE END THE MANTRA THAT I'VE
BEEN PUSHING FOR IS CARE BECAUSE
THE SOONER WE GET MEDICAL CARE
TO THESE OFFICERS.
THE SOONER THEY MAY NOT AND IN
THESE OTHER CASES WHERE THEY'VE
TRAGICALLY LOST THEIR LIVES.
AND WE HAD A CASE IN ONTARIO
WERE.
THE POLICE OFFICER WAS IN A
STRESSFUL.
HOMICIDE CASE INVOLVING CHILDREN
THAT WERE KILLED.
AND AFTER -- TWO YEARS.
OF LITTLE LITIGATION THAT AT THE
JURY ENDED IN A HUNG JURY.
AND HE WAS SO DISTRAUGHT BY
DEALING WITH THE VICTIM FOR TWO
YEARS.
I COULDN'T HANDLE IT ANYMORE THE
END OF HIS LIFE IN HIS GARAGE HE
NEVER SOUGHT TREATMENT.
THE PAIN OF IT YOU JUST DID IS
WIFE IT'S ONE WHERE WE JUST
DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO A DOCTOR.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE ACCESS
ENSURING CONFIDENTIALITY WE'RE
TRYING.
TO LOWER THE STIGMA THAT YOU CAN
GO FIND A PLACE THAT'S SAFE TO
GET CARE SO THAT THESE TRAGIC
RESULTS DON'T HAPPEN EVER AGAIN.
SO I REALLY HOPE.
AND PRAY THAT YOUR WISDOM WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY MORE OF THESE
INSTANCES THAT I HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SEVEN
WALKER CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THIS EFFORT REQUIRES A MORE
HOLISTIC EFFORT TO CARE FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN THE WALK THE LINE
WHETHER IT BE INTERNAL OR
EXTERNAL TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE BEST PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
FOR THE FOR THE CITIZENS BECAUSE
THIS IS PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE JEOPARDIZING
THE INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE IN THE ABSENCE OF THIS
CARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NEED ONLY BE
JOHN WITH MAKE YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION BENEFIT
TRUST FUND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VICTOR CHRISTY CALIFORNIA
HELPLESS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ADRIN SELL SOME OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE PRADA SUPPORT THIS
BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO -- ONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I THINK A LOT OF THE COMMENTS WE
COULD TAKE FROM OUR PREVIOUS
YOUR PREVIOUS BILL AND AND WITH
THE RIGHT THERE AND I WOULD HAVE
TO SAY I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING.
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AT IT IS I
I KNOW IT'S AN ISSUE I KNOW IT'S
A CRITICAL ISSUE -- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTAKE YEAR CURRY A
SECOND BY MISS WALDRON -- MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE I'M SORRY
I'M SORRY.
FIND WE'D LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
GRAYSON I'LL ALLOW THAT TO BE MY
CLOTHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY APOLOGIES.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION IT IS TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY -- THAT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY WELL I FIGURE THREE
AYE BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE BURKE I WICKS FLORA
LIMóN.
THE ONE EYED LE CARTY.
IS AREA FROM MOST PROMISE I
RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO WALDRON.
SORRY SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON AYE. SEVEN WERE STILL
WAITING FOR THAT ELUSIVE LAST
VOTE -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
GRAYSON MR HOLDEN
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL -- NINE FOURTEEN
THIS BILL -- IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILLS AND ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF
OF FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
I WOULD LIKE TO LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK WITH
OUR STAFF -- IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
HARD WORK BUT WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE GOOD WORK YOU'VE DONE TO
HELP MAKE THE BILL BETTER.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK OUR
STAKEHOLDERS OVER COMING TO THE
TABLE AND WORKING WITH THE STAFF
ON THIS BILL -- WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM -- WORK
TOGETHER IS THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE MOVES FORWARD.
AB NINE FOURTEEN WILL SUSPEND
MEDI CAL BENEFITS AND TO READ
THE TERM AN ELIGIBILITY THROUGH
A SIMPLIFIED.
YEARLY PROCESS FOR PEOPLE THAT
BECOME INMATES OF A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A PERSON'S
MEDI CAL BENEFITS ARE TERMINATED
AFTER ONE YEAR OF BEING AN
INMATE OF A PUBLIC INSTITUTION.
CURRENTLY THE CDC ARE RUNS
PROGRAMS TO ASSIST INCARCERATED
FOLKS. TO REAPPLY FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFITS FOURTEEN A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS BEFORE THEIR RELEASE.
ALTHOUGH THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL AND ROLLING
PEOPLE.
AND TO MEDI CAL IT CAN STILL
TAKE WEEKS AFTER RELEASE BEFORE
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO CARE.
AND MEDICATIONS.
THE PERIOD IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
RELEASE IS CRITICAL FOR PEOPLE
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS CAN A
CHEMICAL DEPENDENCIES OR MENTAL
ILLNESS.
THE TWO WEEKS FOLLOWING RELEASE
OF FORMALLY INCARCERATED PERSON
IS TWELVE POINT SEVEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE FROM A PREVENTABLE.
COSTS.
SUICIDE HEART DISEASE AN
OVERDOSE OR THE THREE MOST CITED
CAUSES OF DEATH DURING THIS
CRITICAL PERIOD.
WELL THERE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS CHEMICAL
DEPENDENCIES OR MENTAL ILLNESS.
HOW RELIABLE ACCESS TO CARE
WHICH IMPROVES THEIR HEALTH AND
ILLNESS MANAGEMENT?
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS ESSENTIAL
TO DECREASING RATES OF
RECIDIVISM.
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY AND
THESE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AB NINE FOURTEEN WILL ENSURE
THAT FOLKS HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
BENEFITS IMMEDIATELY UPON
RELEASE.
THUS IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR GOING TO GO POPULATIONS
IMPROVING RECIDIVISM RATES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
VERY MUCH IF WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORT.
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KILEY DELGADO ONLY HAVE THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THURMOND DATING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUTS NETWORK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOTABLY BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU -- HAVING ALL OF THE
BUSINESS THAT HIRES FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY.
I UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT CONTINUITY OR HAVING FOR
FOLKS THAT HAVE YOU KNOW SOME
STABILITY.
IN A WHILE INCARCERATED SO THAT
YOU KNOW IT HELPS THEM
TRANSITION EVEN AFTER SO.
I THINK WHAT THIS ESPECIALLY IS
IMPORTANT.
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH ASPECTS
AND ALL THE ISSUES WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THIS ORDER
ANOTHER THANKS -- IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILLS THANK YOU FOR
BRING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE -- WE HAVE
A MOTION TO SEE.
DID DID DID WE OWE YOU DID I'M
SORRY I'VE I'VE I'VE.
DID YOU THAT'S OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION.
NO YES.
THE SECOND OKAY MOTION BY MS
AMERICA SECOND BY MISTAKE YEAR
CURRY -- JOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING TO GO FORWARD I THINK
IT HIGHLIGHTS OF AN ISSUE THAT --
MANY WAS BORN QUITE AWARE OF
QUITE FRANKLY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT.
AND WHICH OF WHICH I TO CLOSE.
NO OKAY WILL TAKE OVER.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MATTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD HI MAYES AGUIAR-CURRY.
I GET CREE AYE BIGELOW BONTA
BURKE.
BURKE AYE WICKS FLORA.
LIMóN.
THE LOAN I MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SEVERAL AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON.
WE HAVE SEVEN VOTES BELIEVE THE
BILL ON COLUMN WE STILL NEED ONE
MORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE MISTER GIBSON IS BACK.
WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS IF
IT.
IF I MAY ASK IF I COULD TAKE
ELEVEN OH FIVE FIRSTLY SIR.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
SO YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION MISTER
GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I BOTH.
OF THEM.
WOULD WOULD YOU ACCEPT OUR
AMENDMENTS I WILL ACCEPT YOUR
AMENDMENTS TO ELEVEN OH FIVE
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
OTHERS A SUPPORT.
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A WITNESSES WHO SELF
INTRODUCED TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF ELEVEN OH FIVE HOW'S IT GOING
MY NAME IS LANCE JONES -- I'M A
PERSON LIVING WITH SICKLE CELL
ANEMIA HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M SURE WE ALL ARE AWARE OF
THE CONCERNS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR PATIENTS
LIVING WITH SICKLE CELL --
SPECIFICALLY.
THE CONCERNS FOR THE ADULTS.
HERE CALIFORNIA THIRTY TO FORTY
YEARS OF AGE.
I'M THIRTY YEARS OLD NOW.
I HAVE.
I AM A NEWLY.
PSYCHOLOGY GRAD STUDENT.
I'M ALSO -- THE LEAD MENTOR FOR
THE SICKLE CELL FOUNDATION
TRANSITION TEAM PROGRAM -- AM
ALSO WORLDWIDE MUSIC ARTISTS.
AND I HAVE GOALS AND ASPIRATIONS
AND DREAMS JUST AS ANYBODY ELSE
HERE.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
I'VE BEEN HOSPITALIZED.
OVER A HUNDRED TIMES WELL MORE
THAN A HUNDRED TIMES IN MY LIFE
WITH MORE THAN SEVEN SURGERIES
[inaudible]
AND THIS PAST JANUARY.
I WAS HOSPITALIZED WITH LEVELS
OF ORGAN FAILURE [inaudible]
AND SEE I AM SET.
A MERRY UP YOU LITTLE FULL
ENGLISH TEACHER NEXT YEAR.
M. UP MARK FEAR AND CONCERN IS
THAT I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO MEET
HER AT THAT ALTAR.
BEYOND THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I AM EXHAUSTED.
OF LOSING.
MY FRIENDS THAT I'VE GROWN. TO
CALL FAMILY FROM SICKLE CELL.
MORE THAN THAT.
I AM EXHAUSTED OF THE DAILY
BATTLE.
OF THE CYCLE OF WAITING FOR
SICKLE CELL TO BURY ME.
I URGE YOU GUYS TO LISTEN TO
THIS BILL.
WE ARE IN.
A REAL NEED FOR COMPREHENSIVE
CARE HERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE
[inaudible]
SO.
THIS BILL MAY SAVE MY LIFE.
IT MAY SAVE A CHILD'S LIFE.
IN A MAY GIVE OTHER ADULTS THE
CHANCE TO LIVE FREE LEE.
AND GROW.
HAVE THEIR OWN GOALS.
THANK YOU.
I'LL BE REALLY BRIEF I'M DIANE
NEW CHIN I I AM A PHYSICIAN.
WHOTAKES CARE OF CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WITH SICKLE CELL DISEASE
IN CALIFORNIA?
AND I HAVE SOME REALLY SIMPLE
NUMBERS FOR YOU TO HEAR IN THE
UNITED STATES LIFE EXPECTANCY
FOR SICKLE CELL.
IS SIXTY ONE YEARS.
IN THE U. K. IT'S SEVENTY YEARS.
IN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IT'S NOW DOWN TO FORTY THREE
YEARS.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE SHORTEST LIFE
EXPECTANCIES FOR SICKLE CELL
PATIENTS FOR INDIVIDUALS LIKE
THIS WONDERFUL MAN SITTING NEXT
TO ME.
WHO'S DONE SO MUCH FOR THE
SICKLE CELL COMMUNITY AND FOR
THE ORGANIZATION.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT HE
REPRESENTS MANY OF OUR PATIENTS
AND AND MANY LIVES IN CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU IF I CAME TO YOU AND I
SAID THERE'S A DRUG THAT WOULD
DOUBLE LIFE EXPECTANCY FOR
CANCER.
OR HEART DISEASE.
YOUR REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH IT
COST WE WOULD BE ALL OVER THAT.
AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
U. K. IN OTHER STATES IN THE
UNITED STATES IS THAT THEY HAVE
A HEALTH CARE NETWORK FOR ADULTS
WITH SICKLE CELL.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO. FOR THIS THIS ONE BILL
WHICH WE SO RESPECT OUR OUR
LEGISLATORS FOR BRINGING TO THE
TABLE.
IT WILL CHANGE LIVES IT COULD
DOUBLE LIFE EXPECTANCY AND IT
WILL PROVIDE A NETWORK OF TEAM
BASED CARE. FOR PATIENTS WHICH
WILL PRESENT PREVENT.
THE COMPLICATIONS THAT LANCE IS
TALKING ABOUT AND EXTEND LIFE SO
THANK YOU I'M PROUD OF
CALIFORNIA THE PIZZA PROGRAM
DOES A GREAT JOB.
BECAUSE THEY ARE TEAM BASED CARE
IT'S A STARTLED HAVE NOTHING SO
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JERRY BROWN PRESIDENT SICKLE
CELL DISEASE FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
JUDITH BAKER CENTER FOR
INHERITED BLOOD DISORDERS
SUPPORT.
CAROLYN REILLY OF CAYENNE
WELLNESS INTO SICKLE CELL
DISEASE -- EDUCATION ADVOCACY
I'M ALSO AN ADULT PERSON WITH
SICKLE CELL DISEASE WE SUPPORT
WITH AMENDMENTS.
I CAN SHARE IT NOW OR LATER.
I'M SORRY AT THE HEAD OF TO THE
SERGEANTS THANK YOU I HAVE
ACTUALLY PRESENTED THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE ASSEMBLY
PERSON -- AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR
AND THERE'S JUST A FOR ONE IS
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SPECIALTY CARE CENTERS ARE --
ATTACHED TO TRAINING US --
TRAINING -- HOSPITALS THE OTHER
ONE IS JUST TO LOOK AT
SUSTAINABILITY.
FAIR TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS --
AN OVERSIGHT AND ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND THEN THE LAST ONE
I SEE THAT IT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN
DONE REGARDING THE TERRITORIES
TO INCLUDE ALAMEDA COUNTY --
FRESNO LA SAN DIEGO SAN
BERNADINO THANK YOU.
IF YOU CAN GIVE US THIS ARE
SERGEANTS.
MAKE SURE THE AUTHOR GETS THE
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BY
CALVET WORK IN SUPPORT -- CHRIS
CHRISTIE YOU'RE RIGHT SICKLE
CELL PATIENT SUPPORT.
MICHELLE STICKER PARENT OF THE
SICKLE CELL PATIENTS SUPPORT.
KELLY MAC MILLAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN SPECIALLY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THE SET SHORT ON BEHALF OF LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY HEALTH AND
SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT --
BATCH AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT [inaudible]
MUCH. THREE ONE IN OPPOSITION.
TO KNOWN A BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION BY --
MISTER SANTIAGO A SECOND BY
MISSILE MON -- YOU DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH I TO CLOSE.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY IF YOU EVER.
HAD A CONNECTION TO A FAMILY
MEMBER OR FRIEND WHO LIVES WITH
A SICKLE CELL AND WITNESSED THEM
GO THROUGH A CRISIS.
AND IT'S AGONIZING.
AND IT'S VERY VERY PAINFUL AND
SOME DOCTORS OR HOSPITALS --
MISUNDERSTOOD THE DIAGNOSES THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH
THINKING THEY ONLY WANT TO GO
JUST FOR DRUGS AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT WE HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH -- WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS OF ONE WE ALSO ASKING FOR
RESOURCES AND OUR BUDGET RIGHT
NOW TO ADDRESS -- THIS NEED AND
I CERTAINLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR LIBEL FROM THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS WAS A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND AND EDUCATING
US AS WELL -- AND AND TO YOUR
WITNESS FOR YOUR STORY AND
EDUCATING US AS WELL -- AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION -- LIKE I SAID WE
ENJOY THE TO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
MADAM SECRETARY THE BIG DAY
ACTUALLY UP MET MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
ON THEM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
AYE MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY WELL
I AGREE I BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE.
BURKE I WICKS.
LARA.
Là M<c.cyan>.</c>
LIVE ON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I'M DOES AREA.
RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE THANK YOU.
YOUR BILL HAS NINE VOTES AS THE
FIRST ONE TO HAVE MANY TODAY.
THAT'S A REALLY NICE MOMENT
ACTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY PLEASURE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE THEN YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILLS.
YES SIR. FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR
THERE WAS A CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START UP BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ITEM HE
REGARDING THE LICENSE STRUCTURE
OF SOBERING CENTERS WITH THE
REQUEST THAT -- WE ARE GIVEN
MORE TIME SO THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR.
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
REVIEWING THIS MEASURE AND THANK
YOU FOR HELPING US TO IMPROVE
THIS BILL THAT WE ARE ABOUT TO
HEAR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR WHICH IS A
CONTINUATION OF MY PREVIOUS
EFFORTS TO ENSURE OUR COMMUNITY
PARA MEDICINE.
AND ALTERNATIVE DESTINATION
PILOT PROGRAM ARE ABLETO BE
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A HEALTHCARE
CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS CRISIS IS EVIDENT WHEN
PEOPLE CALL.
911- AND FIREFIGHTERS AND
PARAMEDICS RESPOND TO THE HEALTH
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE EMERGENCY.
ONLY TO HAVE.
SENT TO PATIENTS TO OVERCROWDING
E. R. WHERE THEY HAVE NOT
RECEIVED ANY PROPER CARE.
MANY NINE ONE ONE USERS ARE ABLE
TO RECEIVED TIMELY CARE BECAUSE
OUR PARAMEDICS ARE ABLE TO
TRANSPORT PATIENTS TO OUR
ALTERNATIVE DESTINATION SUCH AS
A MENTAL HEALTH OR A SOBERING
CENTER.
COMMUNITY PARA MEDICINES ALLOW
SPECIFICALLY TRAINED PARAMEDICS
TO PERFORM OUTSIDE OF THE
TRADITIONAL ROLE AND ENHANCE
ACCESS TO CARE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR
GIVES LOCAL AGENCIES THE
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP THESE
PROGRAMS AND REQUIRED THE
STATE'S AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP A
MINIMUM OF MEDICAL STANDARD.
IT IS A THOUGHTFUL BALANCED
APPROACH THAT GIVES LOCAL
AGENCIES FLEXIBILITY WHICH
SCREENING WHILE ENSURING THE
HIGH STANDARD OF CARE IS MET AT
EVERY PROGRAM.
THIS BILL.
IS THE RIGHT IS RIGHT FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY PROVIDING -- AND
SUPPORTED BY OF OUR PARAMEDICS
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO --
BY OUR HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
I WANT TO PAUSE FOR A MOMENT WE
TRUST OUR PARAMEDICS NOT HEALTH --
PROFESSIONALS NGUYEN OUR LOVE
ONES [inaudible]
SUFFERS STROKE.
WITH A COUNTER HEART ATTACK
GUNSHOT WOUND.
OR EVEN COME IN CONTACT WITH A
CAR ACCIDENT WE TRUST THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE THE RIGHT
CARE.
HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES ARE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
POSITIONS WHO WAS THE BE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN
FORTY FOUR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M CHRISTY
WELL ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE AND I AM SO PLEASED
ENTITIES PATRICK QUARTER FROM
ALAMEDA CITY FIREFIGHTERS A
PRESIDENT WHO WILL MAKE SOME
REMARKS.
THERE YOU CAN HEAR ME -- ONCE
AGAIN MY NAME IS PATRICK ORDER
THEM FROM THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
WE'RE WE HAVE RUN A COMMUNITY
PARAMEDIC PROGRAM FOR THE BETTER
PART OF FOUR YEARS NOW -- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND SINCE MY
THIRD GRADE TEACHER CALLED ME
LOQUACIOUS ON MY REPORT CARD.
I WILL SIMPLY SAY THAT -- THE
COMMITTEE PARAMEDIC PROGRAM IN
THE ONES THAT WE'VE RUN AND ALSO
THE ONES HAVE BEEN RUN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THERE ARE PROACTIVE WAY OF
DEALING WITH A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE SEE OUT ON THE STREETS
EVERY DAY -- THE PEOPLE THAT WE
HELP ARE OFTEN THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR SOCIETY --
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE A NETWORK
OF RESOURCES IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
HAD -- FAMILY MEMBERS FRIENDS
WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM FOR ANY KIND OF TREATMENT
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THE SYSTEM
IS NOT SET UP -- TO TO TO GET
PEOPLE A 100% WHEN THEY'RE
RELEASED -- OFTEN TIMES IT'S
JUST TO GET THEM HEALTHY ENOUGH
TO GET OUT THE DOOR AND CONTINUE
TREATMENT AND AT HOME -- WHERE
ARE PROGRAM COMES IN -- IS TO
BASICALLY FILL GAPS THAT EXIST
IN THE SYSTEM AS A AS A
CURRENTLY -- AS A CURRENTLY
FACES US -- WE DO NOT REPLICATE
SERVICES WERE NOT TRYING TO BE
NURSES -- WE'RE SIMPLY USING OUR
TRUSTED POSITIONS -- TO
EFFECTIVELY TREAT PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD
OFTENTIMES GO UNTREATED
OTHERWISE -- SOMETIMES IT'S A
SIMPLE IS IS JUST MAKING A PHONE
CALL IN MAKING SURE THAT
SOMEONE'S GOT A MEDICATION ON
HAND OR IF THEY NEED TO GET IT
THAT WE CAN GO PICK IT UP FORM --
OTHER TIMES IT'S A SIMPLE AS AS
CALLING THE HOME HEALTH AGENCIES
OF PEOPLE WERE SITE THAT PEOPLE
ARE DESIGNED TO THEM ON THEIR
WAY TO THE HOSPITAL.
AND FINDING OUT WHEN THEY'RE
GONNA START THE SERVICES BECAUSE
SOMETIMES SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS
A FOR NOT BEING SIGNED PROPERLY
STOP THE ENTIRE PROCESS OF SOME
WAS DISCHARGED HOME.
AND THEY DON'T GET ANY FOLLOW UP
CARE BECAUSE SOMEONE DIDN'T FILL
OUT A FORM PROPERLY IT WAS
RECEIVED PROPERLY -- SO AGAIN IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING ME HERE
TODAY THE PROGRAM DOES WORK THE
DATA SHOWS IT -- UCSF IS HAPPY
TO PROVIDE IT -- ON BEHALF OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE RUN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER MEMBERS TO MEN REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND WE ARE A CO
SPONSOR OF AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR IS MISTER
GIBSON HIGHLIGHTED WE DO HAVE A
CRISIS IN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
AS YOU ALL UNDERSTAND.
HE AND THIS BILL PROVIDES A NICE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TAKE
PATIENTS WHO MAY NOT NEED TO BE
IN THE MERCY DEPARTMENT AND GET
THEM TO THE CARE THEY NEED AT
THAT TIME.
THE ALTERNATE DESTINATION
PROGRAMS WHETHER GOES TO A
SOARING CENTER OR TO A MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITY THESE ARE
PATIENTS THAT ARE FALLING
SPECIFIC PROTOCOLS ARE DON'T
THAT ARE -- ORGANIZED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE WITH THESE WE
THINK PROVIDE THE PROPER
PROTECTIONS AND ALSO THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS WITH THE THE POST
DISCHARGE CARE.
WHERE THESE ARE PATIENTS THAT IF
LEFT UNATTENDED MAY END UP BACK
IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT WITH
THE HELP OF THE PARAMEDICS WE
BELIEVE THEY'LL GET THE CARE?
THAT WILL -- KEEP THEM FROM
COMING BACK TO US WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK WINDOWS
WITH US YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA WERE
NEUTRAL AND APPRECIATE THE
SPONSORS WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLELY
SHAMAN BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE WE WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HIS CAN HE TEN YOU'D
WORK ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA'S
LIKE HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TAYLOR
JACKSON WITH CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING A
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNION NURSES --
WE OPPOSE AB -- FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR WHICH IMPLEMENTS PROGRAMS
WHICH THREATENED PATIENT SAFETY.
PARAMEDICS RESPONDED NINE ONE
ONE CALLS ASSASSIN TRIAGE
PATIENTS AND TRANSPORT THEM TO
AN EMERGENCY ROOM AS QUICKLY AND
SAFELY AS POSSIBLE PARAMEDICS
ARE NOT INDEPENDENT
PRACTITIONERS THEY RELY UPON
DIRECTION FROM POSITIONS ARE
REGISTERED NURSES.
FUNCTIONING UNDER SPECIFIC
PROTOCOLS IN THE PRE HOSPITAL
SETTING THEIR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING REFLECT THOSE
LIMITATIONS.
SCENE IS PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE POST DISCHARGE
COMPONENT OF THE COMMUNITY PARA
MEDICINE PROGRAM.
THERE CONTINUES TO BE AN
INCREASE IN THE RATE OF RE
HOSPITALIZATION FOR THE BUTTE
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY POST
DISCHARGE PILOT PROJECTS WHICH
USE PARAMEDICS INSTEAD OF
REGISTERED NURSES TO PROVIDE
HOSPITAL FOLLOW UP CARE.
THIS MEANS PARAMEDICS WOULD BE
SENT TO PATIENTS HOMES AFTER
THEIR DISCHARGE FROM HOSPITAL TO
FOLLOW UP ON PAIN MANAGEMENT
DRUG ORDERS LONG TERM WOUND CARE
AND A VARIETY OF OTHER POST
HOSPITAL ISSUES THEY'RE NOT
TRAINED.
FOR IN THESE PILOTS
INTERVENTIONS BY PARAMEDICS
INSTEAD OF NURSES INCREASED THE
RATE OF HOSPITAL READMISSIONS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE GOAL
OF THESE PROJECTS IS TO DECREASE
HOSPITAL READMISSIONS.
IN FACT YOU COUNTY HAD NEARLY
ONE THIRD RETURN TO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT WITH
VARIOUS PROBLEMS LATE LAST YEAR
BUTTE ACTUALLY JUST CONTINUE THE
PROJECT DUE TO BUDGETARY ISSUES.
AND THE PARAMEDICS INABILITY TO
PERFORM THEIR EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND COMMUNITY PARAMEDIC DUTIES.
EVEN THOUGH THE NUMBERS CONTINUE
TO GET WORSE FOR THESE PILOT
PROJECTS AB FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR
INCLUDES THE POST DISCHARGE
PRORAMS.
THERE ARE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
LICENSED OUR ENDS IN CALIFORNIA
A HUNDRED THOUSAND LPNS AND MORE
THAN SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH LICENSE
PROFESSIONALS WHO CAN PROVIDE
DIRECT ACUTE CARE TO PATIENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA LESS THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND EMTS AND PARAMEDICS ARE
EMPLOYED AND THEY'RE ONLY THIRTY
THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS WERE DULY
CERTIFIED AS EMTS AND PARAMEDICS.
THIS BILL IS BASED ON THE FLAWED
PREMISE THAT PRIVATE AMBULANCE
COMPANIES AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS
CAN PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY HEALTH
SERVICES IN ADDITION TO AND
DURING.
THEIR TRADITIONAL EMERGENCY
SERVICES ROLE WHY SHOULD DULY
CERTIFIED FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDICS
BE DIVERTED FROM THEIR PRIMARY
TASK OF PROTECTING CALIFORNIA
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTERS
LIKE THE CURRENT AND RECENT FIRE
SEASONS AND SUBSEQUENT MUD
SLIDES.
NURSES STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR BECAUSE IT IN
THE INTEREST PAID CHEN SAFETY
AND WE ASK YOU ABOUT NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRING UP ROUTES
KI<c.cyan> YEP THE CALIFORNIA</c>
ASSOCIATION HEALTH SERVICES AT
HOME LIKE TO LAND MY COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE HERE WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE POSTERS CHARGE
FOLLOW UP.
AND THE HOSPICE CARE.
REGARDING HOSPICE THERE IN A
SPECIFIC END OF LIFE PLAN OF
CARE.
ON THAT THE M. T. WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO NECESSARILY MEET THOSE
NEEDS AND OFTENTIMES WOULD CAUSE
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS FOR THE
HOSPICE AGENCY IF THEY WERE TO
GET INVOLVED -- FOR THE PUSHES
CHARGE FOLLOW UP -- WE HAVE
TRAINED -- NURSES THAT ARE
SPECIALLY TRAINED TO WORK WITH
THE CLIENT IN A HOME FOR EXAMPLE
IF A CLIENT IS RELEASED FROM
HOSPITAL WAS TOLD TO BE BED DOWN
FOR EXAMPLE.
AND THEY'RE IN THEIR HOME AND
THEY'RE FIGHTING I DON'T WANT TO
BE THAT DOWN I WANT TO GET UP WE
HAVE NURSES THAT ARE TRAINED TO
DEAL WITH THOSE SPECIFIC
SITUATIONS.
OTHER TIMES IF -- THE GOING TO
EMERGENCY ROOM OF THE MERGERS
EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTOR PRESCRIBES
ONE TYPE OF MEDICINE.
THEIR PRIMARY PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBED ANOTHER TYPE OF
MEDICINE THOSE TWO MEDICINES
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY MIXED
TOGETHER WELL.
A HOME HEALTH NURSE NURSE IS --
WORKING WITH THE DOCTOR TO SAY
HEY WE NEED TO MAKE SOME KIND OF
CHANGES HERE OR ELSE THIS
PERSON'S GOING RIGHT BACK INTO
THE HOSPITAL.
ANY ANTI MAY NOT BE ABLE -- TO
DECISION WAIT THAT SITUATION SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR NO
THANK YOU.
OTHER SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
IT IS AT ALL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND IF I
COULD JUST BE BRIEF -- THAT WE
HAVE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE AND CONTINUING TO
MARK UP AMENDMENTS -- THAT THEY
CAN REVIEW HOWEVER I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
THE LOCAL EMS AT ORTIZ ALREADY
HAD AGENCIES ARE YOU HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO ALTERNATE
DESTINATION IN FACT.
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES A
TORY AT THE STATE LEVEL JUST
RECENTLY RELEASED REGULATIONS
LAST FRIDAY THAT WE BELIEVE
CLARIFIES THAT THERE'S OTHER
AREAS OF OUR AMENDMENTS BUT TO
BE BRIEF I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE ON OPTION --
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FAIR MCDADE TING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WE ARE ALSO IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S.
WILLINGNESS TO TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUE -- WE DO BELIEVE COUNTIES
HAVE THIS AUTHORITY BUT WE WANT
TO ENSURE PATIENT SAFETY -- AS
SOME OF THE OTHER OPPOSITION
MENTION AND COUNTY AUTHORITY TO
KEEP A HOLISTIC SYSTEM
OPERATIONAL AND WE HAVE CONCERNS
AT THIS BILL WOULD FRAGMENT THE
SYSTEM THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M UP HERE THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN --
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS THE MINUTE
POSITION I'M WILL BE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR.
BETSY ARMS ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND COMMITTED TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- ANYONE
ELSE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
A MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TENACITY -- I
HAVEN'T SUPPORTED THIS BILL IN
THE PAST -- I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW.
THIS MOVES FORWARD SINCE IT
SEEMS. TO BE -- OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO YOU -- SO I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS -- IF IF
COUNTIES.
IF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF DOING THIS ALREADY
IS THERE SEVERAL PILOT PROJECTS.
WHY DOES IT?
NEED LEGISLATION. TO AUTHORIZE.
THANK YOU STE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
THESE COUNTIES NOW ARE OPERATING
UNDER WHAT'S IN AN OFSTED PILOT
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE PILOT
PROGRAM.
OF THE WHOLE FUNCTION OF ALL
SHIFTED PILOT PROGRAMS IS TO
TEST AN INNOVATIVE MODEL OF
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY TO SEE IF
IT'S EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
THOSE ARE TIME LIMITED PILOTS.
AND SO THEY HAVE UNDERGONE
MULTIPLE EXTENSIONS AND I THINK
THE OFFER DIRECTOR BECAUSE
BEGRUDGINGLY EXTENDED IT ONE
MORE YEAR.
AFTER THE VETO MISTER GIBSON'S
BILL AND SO WE ARE CONTINUALLY.
A BY HIS SIDE TO NATION'S THE
FIGHTING TO GET THESE PROGRAMS
AUTHORIZED STATEWIDE ABSENT THAT
AUTHORIZATION THOSE PILOTS WILL
HAVE TO SHUT DOWN BUT DOT BUT
SECOND CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR.
OF BUT THAT DOESN'T NEED.
IT DOESN'T AVOID DIDN'T NEED
[inaudible]
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION -- THAT
WAS A REGULATORY BODY THAT PLACE.
WHY CAN'T YOU JUST CONTINUE THIS?
I THINK I DON'T KNOW WHERE ELSE
TO GO ON THAT ASKED AND ANSWERED
THIS IS A A PARAMEDIC WHO IS
OPERATING.
IN A DIFFERENT ROLE AS DESCRIBED
BY THE AUTHOR AND SO THEREFORE.
ABSENT THE PROTECTIONS OF THESE
PILOTS GOVERNED BY OFSHE HEAD OF
WITH MUCH OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING AND DATA AND
REPORTING WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE
THE UCSF STUDIES.
SUGGESTING HOW EFFECTIVE THESE
PROGRAMS ARE BECAUSE THERE HAVE
BEEN ZERO NEGATIVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES IN ANY OF THE PILOTS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE FOUR
YEARS.
THAT THEY ARE THEN GOING TO RELY
ON THAT DATA IN AND PRESENT THIS
TO YOU THE DECISION MAKERS TO
WHETHER YOU'RE GOING TO PASS A
LAW TO AUTHORIZE THESE PROGRAMS
PERMANENTLY STATEWIDE OR TO LET
THEM SUNSET.
AND MOVE ON TO ANOTHER IDEA.
SO IS THIS IS THIS.
WELL -- WHAT WOULD TEND TO BE
THE NEXT STEP AFTER THIS IF THIS
WERE TO PASS AND IF THIS COME
BECOMES LAW?
THEN WHAT HAPPENS.
EXCELLENT QUESTION AND AND MAYBE
IT ALSO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE IN
OPPOSITION THAT IS.
MISTER GIVENS BILL IS OPTIONAL.
SO TO THE POINT ABOUT.
POTENTIALLY CREATING A
FRAGMENTED SYSTEM NOT SO.
COUNTIES ARE EXCLUSIVELY IN
CONTROL OF WHETHER OR NOT THEY
PURSUE A COMMUNITY PARAMEDICS
SPECIALTY OR ALTER DESTINATION
SPECIALTY AND WHICH ONE HOW MANY
AND IT IS THEIR JOB TO THEN
COLLABORATE WITH ALL OF THE
SYSTEM STAKEHOLDERS. TO DEVELOP
THE PROGRAM THAT FITS RIGHT FOR
THAT COUNTY IN THAT COMMUNITY --
I I'VE.
I'VE BEEN RELUCTANT TO SUPPORT
THIS IN THE PAST -- I STILL HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS.
ON SEVERAL LEVELS.
AB.
ONE I REALLY DON'T KNOW IF.
SOMEONE IN A PARAMEDIC POSITION --
AND I'M NOT DISCOUNTING THEIR
CAPABILITY.
THE SAVE LIVES BUT IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS WHERE YOU
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT TRAINING IS GOING TO BE
ENOUGH TO ALWAYS.
ADDRESS SOME ISSUES.
ABOUT SOME OF THE STUDIES THAT
HAVE COME OUT HAVEN'T
NECESSARILY SHOWN.
ADVERSE OUTCOMES.
BUT THAT'S ALSO VAN I THINK ON
STUDIES BASED ON ONLY ABOUT TWO
YEARS.
SO I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
CASE LOAD HAS BEEN.
I HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN A LOT OF
NUMBERS ON THIS SO IT'S PART OF
MY THAT'S ON ME -- BUT THERE'S
THAT INHERENT ISSUE THAT KIND OF
BOTHERS ME BECAUSE YOU DON'T
WANT TO MISCALCULATE SOMETHING.
SECOND.
IT IT'S CREATING ISSUES AMONGST.
THE LABOR FAMILY THAT I DIDN'T
REALLY EXPECT [inaudible]
OF WOULD BE COMING OUT.
SO I WOULD VERY MUCH ENCOURAGE
YOU -- TO CONTINUE WORKING.
WITH ALL SIDES TO FIGURE OUT HOW
YOU CAN -- ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ONGOING ISSUES BECAUSE I FEEL
LIKE.
THERE ARE OUTSIDE PRESSURES.
SAYING THAT THE COSTS ARE TOO
MUCH.
BUT THEN THE ARGUMENT.
COMES DOWN TO IN BETWEEN FOLKS
THAT ARE.
OUR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS OR OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS.
INSTEAD OF THEM BOTH BEING ABLE
TO DO WHAT THEY DO.
AS FIGURING OUT WHERE ELSE WE
CAN CUT SOME OF THE COSTS.
SO.
I DON'T LIKE TO SEE CONSTANTLY.
CHALLENGES COMING FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO ARE ULTIMATELY TRYING TO
PROVIDE SERVICE -- TO OUR
RESIDENTS SORT TO US WHEN WE'RE
IN TIME OF NEED SO -- I'M HAPPY.
SO THAT SONG IS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO SUPPORT AT THIS TODAY.
BUT I'M.
STILL A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE AND
I ASK YOU THAT TO WORK WITH --
WITH ALL SIDES TURN I APPRECIATE --
ONE YOUR QUESTION -- BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST -- SIMPLY
SAY THIS THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ALL SIDES AND THE
OP WITH THE OPPOSITION -- IN
ORDER TO STRENGTHEN AND TO ALSO
TRY TO STRIKE A BALANCE -- IN
THIS PARTICULAR BILL WE TRIED
THIS BEFORE THE GOVERNOR'S BACK
A MESSAGE -- WE WORKING AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS -- ON TO THAT
PARTICULAR IN BUT ALSO WANT TO
MAKE A POINT -- JUSTIN DOLLARS
ON SOMETHING YOU INDICATED WE
TRUST OUR PARAMEDICS ENOUGH
FIREFIGHTERS WE CALL.
911- THEY RESPOND IN A MOMENT'S
NOTICE THEY THEIR RENDERING AND
MAKING ASSESSMENTS WE TRUST THEM
TO DO THAT WE TRUST THEM WHETHER
SOMEONE.
IS A GUNSHOT VICTIM WE TRUST
THEM WHICH WAS THE NEXT PROBLEM
MOTHERS OR FATHERS ARE HAVING A
HEART ATTACK OR STROKE WE TRUST
THEM.
CAN WE TRUST THEM IF SOMEONE IS
IS.
INTOXICATED EITHER BY ALCOHOL OR
DRUGS TO TAKE THEM TO A SOBERING
CENTER CAN WE TRUST THEM ALSO
SOMEONE IS HAVING A MENTAL
BREAKDOWN OR SUICIDAL TENDENCIES
THAT SO THEY WON'T HAVE TO SIT
INTO EMERGENCY ROOM.
BUT THEY'LL BE TRANSPORTED TO A
BEHAVIOR HEALTH FACILITY SO THEY
GET THE SPECIALIZED ATTENTION
THAT THEY NEED CAN WE TRUST THEM
ENOUGH TO DO THAT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE HERE
TODAY WITH FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR WE
TRUST OUR PARAMEDICS WE TRUST
OUR HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS TO
RESPOND IN A MOMENT'S NOTICE.
EVEN IT MEANS SECONDS A LIFE AND
DEATH.
SO THIS BILL DEMONSTRATES THAT
THAT SAME KIND OF TRUSTS.
AND WE'RE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IN THAT REGARD [inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
YES ALSO WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FOR
OVERSEE THAT I'M.
I'M REALLY TORN ABOUT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR.
ON THE ISSUES REGARDING THE
ALTERNATE DESTINATIONS -- BUT I
THINK LOOKING BACK IN.
MY CAR OF OVER THIRTY YEARS
WORKING THE EMS INDUSTRY.
I'VE ALWAYS TAUGHT WE DON'T
DIAGNOSE RIGHT SO SOMETIME I
HAVE A HEART ISSUE ONE WERE.
ASKING OUR PARAMEDICS TO MAKE
THAT DECISION WHERE WE TAKE
SOMEBODY TO EMERGENCY ROOM OR TO
A NON EMERGENT CENTER -- BECAUSE
THEY COULD BE SOMEBODY SUFFERING
FROM A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS OR
COULD BE INTOXICATED.
AND SOMETIMES I JUST FEEL TORN
THAT.
WE'RE NOT DOCTORS AS PARAMEDICS
RIGHT WERE WERE NOT THERE TO
DIAGNOSE THAT THIS PERSON HAS
THIS CONDITION IS THAT CONDITION
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT'S BEST
FOR THE PATIENT.
I GET IT WE'RE TRYING TO
ALLEVIATE THE CONGESTION IN
HOSPITALS BECAUSE MANY THESE
PATIENT DON'T NEED TO BE THAT WE
WE GET IT IF THEY WOULD JUST
FALL WITH THEIR DOCTORS AND DO
THE MINOR THINGS THAT WOULDN'T
BE A LOT IN THE E. ARE SITTING
BUT THAT'S KIND OF SOMETHING.
WE'RE GOING -- TO BUT MY BIGGEST
ISSUE I'M HAVING AS THE POST
DISCHARGE WHEN SOMEBODY IS BEING
DISCHARGED FROM HOSPITAL.
SOMEBODY WITH HOSPICE CARE.
THAT -- FOR HAVING THAT THAT
PARAMEDIC AS AS YOU ALLUDED TO
THAT THEY'RE THERE TO SAVE
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN AND I GET THAT.
BUT SOMETIMES I FEEL THAT THAT
COULD BE AN ISSUE WITH.
OUR NURSES RIGHT BECAUSE TO ME.
I'M NOT HERE.
TO PICK SIDES BUT JUST LOOKING
AT THE OVERALL ASPECT OF OF THE
PROFESSION A PARAMEDIC AND NURSE
THE NURSE INNOCENCE IS THE
HIGHER MEDICAL AUTHORITY.
BECAUSE THAT MORE TRAINING MORE
EDUCATION. TO SEE THAT THAT TYPE
OF PATIENT.
GETTING THE TREE WITH THE FOLLOW
UP CARE THAT SOMETIMES HARD FOR
ME. TO TO TO THE GRAPHS THAT THE
PARAMEDIC IS BETTER THAN THE
NURSE BECAUSE THE NURSES USUALLY
WHAT THEY NORMALLY DO THEY
FOLLOW UP -- WITH PATIENTS ONCE
THEY'RE DISCHARGED FROM
HOSPITALS.
SO I'M I'M KIND OF TRANSFER TO
HOW THIS WOULD WORK.
I LIKE A BIT THAT IT WOULD BE
IT'S NOT MANDATORY ITS REGULAR
FOR EVERY COUNTY OR CITY TO DO
IT'S IT'S AN OPTION WHICH WHICH
I LIKE THAT BUT I JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW THE HOW THE AGENCIES.
WORK TOGETHER WITH OUR NURSES
RIGHT IS THAT SOMETHING THAT.
WE ARE EXCLUDING THE NURSES FROM
DOING THEIR JOB THAT WE HAVE IN
A PARAMEDIC DOING THAT OR I KNOW
DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING WITH
NURSES TOGETHER TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE.
CAN SOMEBODY ELABORATE TO ME ON
THAT ASPECT OF THE CARE.
I CAN SPEAK TO MY EXPERIENCE
JUST -- IN THE WITH A POST
DISCHARGE FEEL BECAUSE I WAS ONE
OF THE THINGS WE LOOKED AT SO
AGAIN BACK TO THE POINT THAT I
MADE -- EARLIER WE'RE NOT
REPLICATING SERVICES WERE NOT
ACTING OUTSIDE OF OUR PROTOCOLS
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE BEHOLDEN
TO ALL THE SAME PROTOCOL SO WE
ARE WE'RE WORKING IN AND THEN I
WANT CAPACITY.
PROBABLY ALSO WORTH NOTING TO
THAT IN MY POSITION RIGHT NOW
I'M NOT I'M NOT PART OF
SUPPRESSION THEY TOOK ME OFF OFF
THE SUPPRESSION LINE I'M WORKING
IN THE ADMIN POSITIONS WITH THE
FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK MONDAY
THROUGH THURSDAY -- THE TEN HOUR
DAYS SO -- REALISTICALLY WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE GO AND VISIT
PEOPLE AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
DISCHARGED AGAIN A LOT OF TIMES
THESE ARE FOLKS THAT DON'T HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS TO HELP NOT WITH
THE WITH THE YOU KNOW MEDICATION
PICK UPS OR TO FOLLOW DOCTOR
VISITS THINGS LIKE THAT -- SO
WE'LL BE FOR WHAT WE DO WHAT WE
DO IS WE WE FILL THESE GAPS
AGAIN.
THERE'S THERE'S A GAP THAT THAT
HAPPENS NATURALLY BETWEEN WHEN A
PATIENT IS DISCHARGED HOME TO
WIN HOME HEALTH SERVICES START
WHAT WE ATTEMPT TO DO IN THAT
INTERIM IS BASICALLY MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE SET UP FOR SUCCESS.
SO IF THEY IF THEY HAVE DISTRICT
MEDICATIONS UNFORTUNATELY OUR
HOSPITAL IN ALAMEDA DOES NOT
HAVE A DISCHARGE PHARMACY SO
PEOPLE ARE REQUIRED TO PICK THEM
UP ON THEIR OWN OR HAVE SOMEONE
PICK THEM UP ON THEIR BEHALF --
SO WHAT WE DO IS WE MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE DISCHARGE
MEDICATIONS THAT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE.
ENSURE THAT THERE THAT THEY KNOW
THAT THEY YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN THAT THEY'RE
TAKING IMPROPERLY.
AND THEN BASICALLY MAKING SURE
THEY'RE FOLLOWING UP AND LIKE I
SAID TO OFTENTIMES ON THE ON
MAKING FOLLOW UP CALLS TO THE
HOME HEALTH AGENCIES THAT HAVE
BEEN ASSIGNED TO THESE FOLKS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
FOLLOWING UP THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO COME IN I'M NOT THERE TO DO
THE THINGS THAT THE NURSE THAT'S
ASSIGNED TO THAT PERSON.
IS DOING I'M SIMPLY THERE AGAIN
TO BRIDGE THIS GAP TO HOPEFULLY
ENSURE THAT THIS PERSON DOES NOT
GO BACK TO THE HOSPITAL FOR
SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE EASILY
BEEN AVOIDED.
BY SIMPLY TAKING A MEDICATION OR
MAKING A FOLLOW UP CALL OR IN IN
SOME CASES EVEN JUST FOLLOWING
UP WITH WITH THE HOME HEALTH
AGENCY [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK A LOT MORE CLEAR YEAH
MAKES LEVEL MORE SENSE SO WE'RE
NOT ACTUALLY TAKING.
A UNIT THAT'S PRIMARILY ORDERED
DO NOT ONE CALLS WERE WERE
HAVING SOMEBODY -- AN EXTRA UNIT
OR AN ADDITIONAL SERVICES THAT
ARE DOUBTS ALL THEIR JOB IS TO
DO.
THOSE FOLLOW UPS WITH THOSE
PAGES THAT ARE BEING DISCHARGED --
I I GET THAT I FEEL A BIT MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT -- BUT
ALSO WANTED TO COLLABORATE MORE
ON THE OPPOSITION TALKED ABOUT
SOME PILOT PROGRAMS STUDIES THAT
THE OUTCOMES WEREN'T AS GOOD IS
THERE ANY FEEDBACK THAT TIME WE
CAN TALK ABOUT.
WHAT THEIR TALKED ABOUT I KNOW
WE WE TALK ABOUT THESE PUBLIC
PROGRAM TO SEEM TO BE WORKING
FINE BUT WHAT ABOUT?
THESE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT SEEM
TO HAVE SOME ISSUES WHAT
HAPPENED THERE AND WHAT WERE YOU
LOOKING TO FIX THAT THAT THAT.
THOSE PUBLIC PROGRAMS ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES WHY THAT HAPPENED
IN MAKING SURE THAT.
THE OUTCOMES ARE BETTER THAN
WHAT.
THEY SPOKE.
TO OF THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ --
SO THE BUTTE COUNTY PILOTS.
INITIALLY HAD DATA CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT THE OPPOSITION.
THAT THE READMISSION RATES DID
NOT CHANGE AND SOME TASTE CASES
THAT INCREASED AND THEY ARE
FOCUSED ON COMPLEX.
MEDICAL ISSUES AND SO WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE BUTTE COUNTY
PILOT IS THE THE THE LOCALS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE AGENCY.
REVIEWED THE PROTOCOLS IN
DETERMINED THAT THE PROTOCOLS
WHEN APPROPRIATE THE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN MAKING AN IN PERSON VISIT
VERSUS A PHONE CALL.
THAT IS THE ENTIRE POINT OF
THESE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
PILOT PROJECTS IS.
TO TEST THE THEORY AND MAKE SURE
AND CERTAIN THAT THE PROTOCOLS
THAT ARE BEING OPERATED UNDER
ARE APPROPRIATE FOR THE FOR THE
PATIENTS THAT THEY ARE SERVING
SO IN THAT CASE THE PROTOCOLS
WERE ADJUSTED.
AND I THINK THERE IS MORE DATA
FORTHCOMING ABOUT WHETHER THAT
IS SUCCESSFUL -- BUT IN ALL
CASES THIS BILL MISTER GIBSON'S
BILL VERY APPROPRIATELY SUGGESTS
THAT THERE SHOULD BE
[inaudible]
DOCTORS NURSES AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE
DETERMINING WHAT THOSE PROTOCOLS
ARE FOR THE STATE WIDE PROGRAM
THAT WILL APPLY STATE WIDE SO
THAT WE WILL BE OPERATING UNDER
THE BEST PROTOCOLS TO SERVE
THESE PATIENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR LEVERING WITH
THAT AS WELL LIKE I SAID EARLIER
I'M I'M STILL WARN ABOUT THE
ISSUE.
I KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW TO
BRUSH ADDRESSED THE ISSUE WITH
PATIENT CARE AND AND THAT
EMERGENCY SENDING -- I LIKE THE
FACT THAT IT'S NOT MANDATED BY
EVERY COUNTY TO DO THAT -- I'M
STILL HAVING ISSUES ON HOW I
GUESS WOULD BE UP TO THE
COUNTIES TO COME UP WITH THESE
ALTERNATIVE DESTINATIONS RIGHT.
THE TYPE OF PERSON THEY'LL BE
WORKING THERE.
AND MAKING SURE THAT -- WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE PATIENTS
TREATED AT THE BEST PRICE
POSSIBLE WHERE THERE'S THE ER OR
THAT.
ALTERNATE DESTINATION -- SOME
LEVERAGE A HOPE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
ON THIS I I AM VERY STRUGGLING
TO SUPPORT THIS BUT I HOPE THAT
YOU CONTINUE WORK THEM ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES AND AND I'M GONNA
JUST RESERVE MY RIGHT WHETHER I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IF IT GETS TO THE FLOOR SO ONCE
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE JUST WANNA KICK.
MAKE SURE CONTINUE A DIALOGUE
WITH OPPOSITION BECAUSE I THINK
THEY HAVE SOME VALID POINTS ON
THEIR END AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
DRUDGERY GUESS LET ME SAY I
TRUST YOU.
I TRUST YOUR SKILL I TRUST YOU
IF I WERE TO FALL OUT RIGHT NOW
YOU CAN RENDER AID.
AND MAKE SURE THAT I'M TAKING
CARE OF BECAUSE YOUR EXPERTISE.
I TRUST THE PARAMEDICS AND
FIREFIGHTERS AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO DO LIKEWISE TO
SOMEONE WHO'S UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF NARCOTICS SOMEONE
WHO IS UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF OF
ALCOHOL AND SOMEONE WHO IS
BREAKING DOWN -- SUICIDAL TO GET
THAT INDIVIDUAL -- TO A CENTERS
THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY HANDLE AND
ADDRESS THEIR PARTICULAR NEED
INSTEAD OF BEING AN EMERGENCY
ROOM FOR HOURS.
AND THEY NOT BEING SEEN.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I JUST -- THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THAT'S ONE
THING I I I KNOW I THIS FEELS A
LITTLE LIKE SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD LAST YEAR.
WE RE LIVING THAT AND I BUT I I
WAS I I HAD MY YOUR PERSISTENCE
ON THIS AND I AND I KNOW THAT
YOU WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON THIS AND I
KNOW THAT.
I KNOW THAT -- THERE'S THEIR
PILOT PROJECTS OUT THERE THAT
ARE THAT ARE WORKING AND I
BELIEVE IN THE INTENT OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING I THINK IT'S I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE DOING HIS
THING ON THE RIGHT TRACK -- AND
LIKE I SAID WE INTERVIEWED YOU
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I
APPRECIATE YOUR PROCESS AS A
PERSON.
ON THIS ISSUE -- WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- BY MISTAKE
YEAR CURRY AND THE SECOND BY
MISTER RAMOS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
DID YOU DID YOU.
NO I'M SORRY DID DID.
DID YOU SECOND MISS ROSE.
IT OKAY AS WE SURE WINNER.
OF I THOUGHT WHAT'S.
OKAY I WASN'T SURE OF OKAY.
WELL IT WAS A LOOK OF SHOCK DOWN
THERE AND MAKE SURE WE'RE ON THE
RIGHT PAGE AYE USER KHAMIS'S MY
CLOTHES RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO -- THEN YOU HAVE IT'S I KNOW
YOU HAVE ACCEPTED THE MEN'S WITH
THE EXCEPT OF THE ONE AND I AND
WE WE ACCEPT WE ACCEPT THAT --
AND STILL AND SO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHEN I WENT AYE MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
I BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE.
BURKE I WICKS.
FLORA FLORA AYE LIMóN.
LIMON EYEING MCCARTY
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS ROLES AYE
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. TEN GET TEN VOTE
SPONSORED GIPSON BILLS OUT LEAVE
THE BOAT WITH OVER THERE.
HE WILL PUNCH YOU APPEAR
[inaudible]
MR O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PLEASE.
WHEN YOU REVEREND YES?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM --
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
RESENT AB TWELVE OR TEN NINETY
EIGHT AND NOVEMBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE VOTERS PASSED THE
ADULT.
USE OF MARIJUANA ACT A PORTION
OF THE TAXES GENERATED THROUGH
LEGAL SALES OF CANNABIS WILL YOU
DEPOSIT IS INTO A YOUTH ACCOUNT.
TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
THE ACCOUNT WILL FUND EDUCATION
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
AND TREATMENT OF YOUTH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE.
THIS PHONE IS TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY A DH CS IN COLLABORATION WITH
CD AND CD PH.
YOU WITH ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND
DRUG USE IS A SERIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN.
TAXES GENERATED THROUGH THE
LEGAL SALE OF CANVAS PROVIDE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THIS SUBSTANCE ABUSE BY YOUTH.
EARLY ESTIMATES BY THE LA --
SUGGESTS THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY GOING TO BE MADE AVAILABLE
IT'S NOT THERE YET BUT THERE IS
A LOT OF MONEY THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE.
HOWEVER PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
WAS SILENT ON CERTAIN CRITICAL
FACTORS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF THE
YOUTH ACCOUNT.
IT CREATES A TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO ADVISE THE THREE
AGENCIES ON DATA COLLECTION.
PROGRAM EVALUATION AND REPORTING.
IT ALSO REQUIRES MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES AND REDUCING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND IMPROVING EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
THIS BILL FIRST SPECIFIES THAT
PROGRAMS FUNDED MUST BE EVIDENCE
BASED.
FINALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
EXPENDITURES AND OUT COMES
THROUGH REGULAR REPORTING THIS
IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDS GENERATED
THROUGH THE TAXES.
ON THE LEGAL SALE OF CANNABIS
ARE USED IN AN EFFECTIVE.
MANNER.
JOINING ME TODAY IS THE COLOR OF
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO
JOIN ME MISTER WOULD BUT YOU ARE
CO AUTHOR I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EITHER DO YOU HAVE WITH US
IN SUPPORT NO OKAY.
OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SAY NO -- ONE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN AND BRING IT BACK
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
I'M HERE FOR SUPPORT MY NAME IS
VALERIE WILLIAMS WITH.
I'M SORRY ACTUALLY NO POSITION
AT THIS TIME -- MY NAME IS
VALERIE WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
URBAN PARTNERSHIP BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOME TYPE OF EQUITY
IMPLEMENTED IN THIS BILL -- TO
FOR THOSE MOST AFFECTED BY THE
WAR ON DRUGS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION TO IT WE DO A
PENDING AMENDMENTS.
YES I'M JIM KEADY WITH YOU
FORWARD -- WORKING WITH YOUTH
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE
ON THIS ISSUE -- SUPPORTED FOR
MEN AND WE'VE BEEN IN A DIALOGUE
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN
AND AND DISCUSS THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WHICH ANYONE ELSE BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
I SAY SEE OBVIOUSLY WERE WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS MISTER MISTER
O'DONNELL AND AT SOMETHING IS A
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME IN AND MY
DISTRICT -- I THINK A FRAMEWORK --
I THINK SOME GUIDELINES OR
REALLY CRITICAL AT THIS IS AN
UNUSUAL OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
RESOURCES -- FOR YOUTH EDUCATION
AND PREVENTION AND I THINK WE
WOULD BE REMISS IF WE DIDN'T
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF EVERY SINGLE
PENNY WE CAN -- TO FOR THE
PROJECT THE USE OF OUR GOING
FORWARD.
I KNOW THAT THEY'LL BE THERE'S
ADDITIONAL WORK GOING FORWARD IN
YOUR COMMITTEE -- AND I THINK OF
PRIDE BE THERE WITH YOU WHEN WE
WHEN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT IT NEXT
BUT I THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS IT DOESN'T CHOI DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO YOUR COMMITTEE
EDUCATION -- WE HAVE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND
BY MISTER RAMOS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THAT'S WHEN I WROTE THANKS SIR.
MOTION IS TO PASS EDUCATION
MEADOW SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHEN I WHEN I MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER
CURRY I BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA BURKE.
HI WICKS.
FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
HI NAZARIAN AYE FROM MOST.
THOMAS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON. NINE VOTES OF BILLS OUT
WE LEAVE IT UP THE ROLE OF THE
BROTHER SAT ON THINK SO MUCH
MISTER AND MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER TING.
THANK YOU MISTER HERE TO PRESENT
AB. THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR FIRST
THANK YOU FOR SO JUST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE THE
CONSULTING THE CHAIR.
FOR YOUR AMENDMENTS THE BILL
ESTABLISHES SOME BASIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS FOR GROCERY
DELIVERIES THROUGH ONLINE
PLATFORMS.
WE KNOW THERE'S SOME INITIAL
OPPOSITION WE ARE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THOSE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WE KNOW WE'RE TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY.
AND WITH THAT -- RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DANIEL CURRY INTO MY
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATES COUNCIL.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
AIMS TO PROTECT.
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS BY
EXTENDING EXISTING REGULATIONS
THAT ALREADY APPLY TO FOOD
RETAILERS.
A GROWING NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS
ORDER GROCERIES ONLINE AND HAVE
THEM DELIVERED.
DIRECTLY TO THEIR HOME. TO
PROVIDE THIS LABOR INTENSIVE
SERVICE FOOD RETAILERS.
I FREQUENTLY RELYING ON ONLINE
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS.
FOOD RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS ARE
SUBJECT TO STRICT REGULATIONS
REGARDING THE HANDLING OF FOOD
TO PROTECT CONSUMER EMPLOYEE
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
DELIVERY COMPANIES EXPOSED
CONSUMER GOODS TO THE SOME OF
THE SAME RISKS THAT MAY ARISE
WITH FOOD RETAILER.
YET THEY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO ANY
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
THIS LACK OF REGULATION IS
PARTICULARLY GRAVE AS DELIVERY
PLATFORM DRIVERS.
USE PERSONAL VEHICLES TO PERFORM
THEIR DUTIES.
DELIVERY PLATFORM [inaudible]
OKAY.
CAN I AM AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OKAY SIR.
ANY ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SORRY MR CHAIRMAN TWEENER MY
NAME'S TERESA BURKE **** ON
BEHALF OF LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS -- WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS TO IDENTIFY LOCAL
RETAIL FOOD CODE ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORKING WITH
HIM.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COURT IN
JENSEN WITH TECH NET HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY AS WE DO NOT BELIEVE ALL
MITIGATE ANY POTENTIAL FOOD
SAFETY CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
DELIVERY OF FOOD.
FIRST LET ME SAY THAT FOOD
SAFETY AND CUSTOMER TRUST AND
SAFETY IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR
TECHNICS MEMBER COMPANIES AND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEIR
RETAIL AND GROCERY PARTNERS.
THEY HAVE IMPLEMENTED FOOD AT
RISK BASED FOOD SAFETY MEASURES
APPROPRIATE FOR THE POTENTIAL
FOOD SAFETY RISKS.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO STATE THAT
WE BELIEVE IS CONVERSATIONS ARE
CONTINUING TO DEVELOP REGARDING
WORKER CLASSIFICATION BILLS LIKE
THESE CREATE CONFLICT AND
CONFUSION THAT WILL NOT HELP IN
COMING TO A SOLUTION TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO RE ENGINEER THEIR
PLATFORMS AND EXERT MORE CONTROL
OVER THEIR DRIVERS WHICH COULD
PUT THESE COMPANIES IN CONFLICT
WITH CURRENT CALIFORNIA LABOR
LAWS.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SINGLES OUT
THE CALIFORNIA GROCERY INDUSTRY
IN CRATES POTENTIAL UNNECESSARY
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS THAT
COULD REDUCE THE EARNING
POTENTIAL OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND NEGATIVELY
IMPACT SMALL BUSINESSES.
LET ME JUST QUICKLY EXPLAIN HOW
THESE PLATFORMS WORK THERE ARE
TWO BASIC MODELS FIRST FOR MANY
GROCERY DELIVERY ORDERS A
CUSTOMER SUBMITS AN ORDER THE
GROCERY STORE AND A GROCERY
STORE EMPLOYEE ASSEMBLES THE
ORDER THAN A DRIVER.
WORKING ON THE PLATFORM PICKS UP
THE ORDER AND DELIVERS IT TO THE
CUSTOMER THE DRIVER NEVER
TOUCHES ARE HANDLES THE FOOD.
I CAN'T FOR OTHER ORDERS A
SHOPPER GOES THE GROCERY STORE
PICKS UP THE GROCERIES IN THE
SAME WAY A CUSTOMER DOES AND
THEN DIRECTLY DELIVERS THE
GROCERIES TO THE CUSTOMERS. FOR
THESE ORDERS A SHOPPER ACTS
EXACTLY LIKE A CUSTOMER WOULD
GOING TO GROCERY STORE PICKING
OUT YOUR PRODUCE PICKING OUT
YOUR PRE PACKAGED SERIAL AND
SHIPS AND THEN PAYING FOR YOUR
GROCERIES AND TRANSPORTING THEM
TO THE CUSTOMER'S HOME.
SO FOR THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
DELIVERY DRIVERS TO OBTAINING
FOOD HANDLER CARD.
NOT EVEN GROCERY STORE EMPLOYEES
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE A FOOD
HANDLER CARD ONLY THESE
EMPLOYEES ONLY THOSE EMPLOYEES
THAT PREPARE AND SERVE FOOD.
THE PROCESS OF GETTING A FOOD
HANDLER CARD IS BURDENSOME BOTH
IN TIME AND FINANCIAL RESOURCES
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO MIGHT BE ON
USING THESE PLATFORMS WERE AS
FEW HOURS A WEEK.
THE AVERAGE IS USUALLY ABOUT
THREE TO FIVE HOURS A WEEK -- IT
REQUIRES TAKING A NINETY MINUTE
COURSE AND THEN PASSING A FORTY
QUESTION TEST FOCUS ON HOW FOOD
SHOULD BE PREPARED AND SERVED IN
A RESTAURANT OR AT A KITCHEN AND
DALY OF A GROCERY STORE.
THE INTENT OF THE FOOD HANDLER
CARD WHAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN FOR
WORKERS AT RESTAURANTS AND OTHER
ESTABLISHMENTS WHERE FOOD IS
BEING PREPARED AND SERVED WHICH
IS NOT THE CASE FOR DRIVERS WHO
ARE SIMPLY COLLECTING AND
DELIVERING PACKAGE PRODUCTS TO A
CONSUMER.
AND QUICKLY I KNOW IT'S GETTING
PAID THERE'S JUST A LOT IN THIS
BILL THAT I'D.
LIKE TO COVER BUT I'M JUST
ANOTHER ONE FINAL POINT I'LL
MAKE AB THIRTEEN SIXTY WOULD
ALSO MAKE DELIVERY DRIVERS AND
PLATFORMS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COMPLIANCE WITH VARIOUS
PROVISIONS OF THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE.
INCLUDING FULL FOOD HOLDING
AREAS AND FOOD PACKAGING THOSE
PROVISIONS ARE WRITTEN FOR FOOD
DELIVERY FROM MANUFACTURERS AND
OR DISTRIBUTION TO RETAIL
LOCATIONS SO AS AN EXAMPLE
ASKING THE FOOD HOLDING AREA OF
THE VEHICLES TO BE CONSTRUCTED
OF A SMOOTH THE WASHABLE
IMPERVIOUS MATERIAL CAPABLE OF
WITHSTANDING FREQUENT CLEANING.
ONE DAY OUT OF THE ELIMINATE
THIS INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S MANY OTHER PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT I'M AND I JUST WRAP UP BY
SAYING OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
PROVIDE TO THEIR SHOPPERS
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO SAFELY
PERFORM THEIRWORK.
AND TO PROTECT CONSUMERS WHILE
NOT OVER BURDENING THEM WITH THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION AND TRYING
TO FIT THIS INDUSTRY INTO A BOX
THEY DO NOT FIT IN WILL STIFLE
INNOVATION HARM CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND WE ASK FOR KNOW
ABOUT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEC KAREN SARKISIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WHERE POST.
IDEAL FOUNTAIN I JUST PERSONAL
I'M -- HEPATITIS A SURVIVOR -- I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION -- THE BILL DOES NOT
DO ANYTHING -- TO ALLEVIATE THE
PROBLEM THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SEEING SEEING NONE -- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH YOU ON A
VARIETY OF ISSUES HERE.
IT'S A LITTLE COMPLICATED -- AND
QUITE A QUITE HONESTLY A LITTLE --
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN THAN
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE ISSUES
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
AGAIN I JUST RESPECT US FOR I'VE --
WE BELIEVE THAT WE WANT TO HAVE --
INSURER -- SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS THAT ARE CONSISTENT --
WE KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT FROM THE FIRST TIME THAT
THE FOOD GETS DELIVERED GROCERY
STORE TO THE TIME THE FOOD GETS
INTO SOMEONE'S.
A POSITION THAT THAT IS HANDLED
CONSISTENTLY AND ACROSS THE SAME
FOR SO RESPECTFULLY I STRIVE
VOTE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK CAN BE STILL WITH US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR TING THE
BILL -- WE WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE DO NOT HAVE A MOTION -- WE
DON'T HAVE MOTION YES YOU CAN
SECOND IF YOU WANT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER ROBERTS THE
SECOND BY MISTER IN THIS AREA.
OF THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
TO JUST YEAR -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHATI'VE
WHEN I MAYES SNOW MAYES NO
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW
[inaudible]
SORRY.
BIGELOW NO BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
WICKS FLORA.
FLORA NO AMOUNT.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS ROSS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON. SEVENTY ONE GIVE SEVEN
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MR WENT
.
AB EIGHT TWO TWO WOULD ALLOW
HEALTH FACILITIES AND HOSPITALS
TO AUTHORIZE THE USE OF NEW
BLOOD COLLECTION METHODS AND
DEVICES.
CALIFORNIA.
IS THE ONLY STATES.
THAT REQUIRES FULL BOTTOM IS TO
USE NEEDLES TO DRAW BLOOD
ADVANCEMENTS IN MEDICINE PROVIDE
FOR SAFER AND NEEDLE LESS BLOOD
COLLECTION METHODS CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS DESERVE ACCESS TO A NEW
MEDICAL PRACTICE TO NEWPORT
MEDICAL PRACTICES THAT ARE SAFE
AND MORE UNCOMFORTABLE.
JUST IMAGINE SITTING IN THE
HOSPITAL.
WITH AN IV IN YOUR ARM AND
HAVING TO HAVE BLOOD DRAWN EVERY
FEW HOURS.
THIS SOLVES THAT ISSUE I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENT TO CLARIFY THAT ANY
NEW DEVICES OR METHODS MUST BE
FDA APPROVED HERE WITH ME IN
SUPPORT IS DR.
HE TO DIVIDE THE DEAD GONE OF A
LOT OF VASCULAR AND DOCTOR FRED
BROWN OF GRIFFIN HEALTH.
GET THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS DOCTOR P. TO DEBORAH
AND I'M A CO FOUNDER AND CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER IT BELONG --
VASCULAR WERE SAN FRANCISCO
BASED MEDICAL DEVICE COMPANY.
I'M ALSO THE INVENTOR OF ARE FDA
CLEARED NEIL FREE BLOOD DRAWING
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS CALLED PECO.
PECO IS A SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE
DEVICE THE TEMPORAL CONNECTS TO
HOSPITALIZE PATIENTS IV CATHETER.
TO ENABLE VIRTUALLY PAINLESS AND
RELIABLE BLOOD COLLECTION.
HOSPITALS AROUND THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ADOPTING IV CATHETER BLOOD
COLLECTION WITH PEABO TO IMPROVE
THEIR PATIENTS EXPERIENCE BY
ELIMINATING PAINFUL NEEDLE
STICKS.
REDUCE THE RISK OF ACCIDENTAL
NEEDLE STICK OR NEEDLE STICK OR
SHARPS INJURIES FOR THEIR STAFF
IMPROVE LABORATORY EFFICIENCY BY
REDUCING THE HOSPITAL'S REJECTED
SAMPLE RATE.
AND LASTLY IN HIGHER ACUITY
POPULATIONS ESPECIALLY TO REDUCE
THE NEED TO ACCESS THEIR
PATIENTS HIGHER RISK CENTRAL
LINES ARE PLANTED PORTS THE
INCREASE THE RISK FOR INFECTION.
THERE'S ROBUST EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT THE USE OF PEOPLE WHEN I
BE CAPITA BLOOD COLLECTION
THERE'S FOR PEER REVIEWED
PUBLISHED JOURNAL ARTICLES A
DEMONSTRATED FIRST LABS
COLLECTED WITH PEOPLE ARE
EQUIVALENT TO BEING A PUNCTURE.
SECOND USING PEOPLE DOES NOT
NEGATIVELY AFFECT THE IV
CATHETER LIFE AND THIRD USING
PEOPLE CAN REDUCE POOR QUALITY
SAMPLES WHICH TRANSLATES INTO
LESS REPEAT REPEATED TESTING.
AND IMPROVED HOSPITAL WORKFLOW.
IN ADDITION TO THE CLINICAL
EVIDENCE PEOPLE USES ABOUT THE
CROSS OVER ONE MILLION IN
PATIENT DRAWS CONDUCTED SO FAR
SINCE ORIGINAL FDA CLEARANCE.
THE MAJORITY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED BY TRAIN FOR BOTTOM
THIS AND OTHER STATES.
THERE'S BEEN ZERO I REPEAT ZERO
ADVERSE EVENTS EVER REPORTED
AFTER MILLION DROSS.
AS A REAL WORLD EXAMPLE LIKE TO
SHARE SOME WERE CONDUCTED BY
INTERMOUNTAIN HEALTH TO MEASURE
PEOPLE'S IMPACT ON THEIR CARE.
INTERMOUNTAIN IS THE LARGEST
HOSPITAL SYSTEM IN UTAH WITH
TWENTY THREE HOSPITALS
ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT 50% OF THE
INPATIENT BEDS IN THE STATE.
LIKE MOST LARGE HEALTH SYSTEMS
THEY RELY ON THEIR FULL BOTTOM
IS TO COLLECT THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR IN PATIENT BLOOD SAMPLES.
DAVID UP THE PEOPLE SYSTEM WIDE
ROUGHLY ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO.
THE TRACK HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE DRAWS ON TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS AND TRACK
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL IV CATHETERS.
THIS IS THE LARGEST DATASET
INVESTOR ACCESS EVER BROUGHT
COLLECTED.
THEIR FINDINGS FROM THE DATA
SAID INCLUDE NO CHANGE AN IV
CATHETER REPLACEMENT RATES WHEN
FOR BOTTOMS ARE USING PICO A 40%
REDUCTION IN SAMPLE REJECTION
RATES WHEN USING PICO.
AND THEY ALSO REMOVED A QUARTER
OF A MILLION INPATIENT NEEDLES
FROM THERE IN PATIENT CARE
ENVIRONMENTS.
PATIENT SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT SEND
THIS NEW PROCEDURE STILL HAS
NURSING IN FULL CONTROL OF THE
PATIENT'S ID CARE.
IF INFUSION IS RUNNING THROUGH
AN IV CATHETER WHEN A BLOOD
DRAWS REQUIRED THE PATIENT'S
NURSE DECIDES IT BRIEFLY PAUSING
THE INFUSION IS APPROPRIATE.
AND IF SO THE NURSE WOULD FLUSH
THE IV LINE BEFORE THE BOTTOM
ASST DRAWS THE PATIENT'S BLOOD
HUSING PEOPLE.
THIS COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
BOTTOM IS A NURSING IS NOT NEW
AND IT'S ALREADY HAPPENED TODAY
WHICH ADDITIONAL BLOOD DRAWS. TO
BE CLEAR OF THE BOTTOMS WILL
NEVER START STOP PAUSE ANY
RUNNING INFUSION NOR WILL THEY
BE INSERTING OR REMOVING ANY IV
CATHETERS PERIOD.
LASTLY.
ALL THE BOTTOM IS THE NURSES
COMPLETE IN PERSON TRAINING AND
DEMONSTRATE COMPETENCY TO
PERFORM THE PROCEDURE SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
SO IN CALIFORNIA TODAY THE
MAJORITY BLOOD DRAWS ARE
CONDUCTED TODAY BY FOUR BOTTOM
MISSED AND THIS BILL WILL ENABLE
THEM TO UTILIZE SAFER AND MORE
HUMANE NEW TECHNOLOGY. TO DRAW
BLOOD FOR HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS
I VERGE I URGE YOU TO VOTE HI
[inaudible]
SIR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
FRED BROWN I'M CURRENTLY THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER VICE
PRESIDENT MEDICAL AFFAIRS IN
PRACTICING CLINICIAN AT GRIFFIN
HEALTH INTERVIEW CONNECTICUT.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND SHARE MY HOSPITAL'S
EXPERIENCE WITH IMPLEMENTING PO.
I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT WE ARE
THE LONGEST RUNNING PEOPLE
HOSPITAL IN THE COUNTRY.
OUR HOSPITAL IS A LEADER IN THE
PATIENT CENTERED CARE MOVEMENT
AND WE ARE THE HOME OF PLANE
TREE.
A NOT FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PERSONALIZING
HUMANA HUMANA ISING.
AND DEMYSTIFYING HEALTHCARE.
WHEN WE LEARNED OF PEOPLE DEVICE
WHICH WAS EVEN BEFORE RECEIVED
FDA CLEARANCE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WE SAW AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR HOSPITAL TO
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE HOW OUR
PATIENTS EXPERIENCE CLUB?
BUT COLLECTIONS.
WHAT DRAWING FOR LABORATORY
TESTING USING TRADITIONAL VENA
PUNCTURE?
IS OFTEN PERFORMED ON
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS MULTIPLE
TIMES A DAY.
IT IS A VERY BIG TO SOUTHWIRE.
WE HAVE YET TO FIND ANYONE WHO
IS PRO NEEDLE AN ORGANIZATION.
WE IMPLEMENTED PEOPLE WHEN OUR
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT WHICH WAS
LED BY OUR ICE YOU NURSES.
THEY BECAME PEOPLE EXPERTS
QUICKLY AND PATIENT SATISFACTION
WAS IMMEDIATE AND OBVIOUS.
SOON AFTER WE DECIDED TO CONVERT
OUR ENTIRE HOSPITAL PEOPLE DRIES
DROSS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT SINCE BLOOD
DRYING IS PERFORMED BY
PHLEBOTOMY TRAINED SPECIALISTS
IN THE MAJORITY OF OUR HOSPITAL.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE TRAINED TO
USE PPO DEVICE OTHERWISE THE
TASK OF BLOOD DRYING WILL BE
ADDED TO THE WORK LOAD OF OUR
NURSES.
THE FEEDBACK FROM OUR NURSE
COLLEAGUES.
WHO ARE USING THE P. VOTE DEVICE
BELIEVE FOR BOTTOM MISSED COULD
SAFELY PERFORMER PEOPLE DRAW
WHICH THEY PERCEIVED TO BE LESS
TECHNICALLY DEMANDING THAT HAVE
BEEN A PUNCTURE?
OUR MEDICAL SURGICAL NURSES ALSO
INDICATED THAT WITH AN
ASSIGNMENT OF FOUR TO SIX
PATIENTS TAKING ON RESPONSIBLY
FOR BLOOD DRAWING WAS TOO
BURDENSOME.
AND PREFERRED THE PHLEBOTOMY
SPECIALS CONTINUE COLLECTING
BLOOD SAMPLES.
THE NURSES EXPRESSED A DESIRE TO
PRACTICE AT THE TOP OF THEIR
LICENSE IN FOCUS ON PATIENT
ASSESSMENT.
MEDICATION ADMINISTRATION AND
DIRECT PATIENT CARE NOT I'M
BLOOD COLLECTION.
WE LAUNCHED PEOPLE ACROSS OUR
ENTIRE HOSPITAL LATE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN PERFORMED
OVER FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE DRAWS
WE HAVE NOT HAD ONE ADVERSE
EVENT.
SIMILAR TO ALL OF THE OTHER
HOSPITALS AROUND THE COUNTRY
THAT HAVE ADOPTED PVO.
GRIFFIN HAS A STRICT POLICY THAT
THE BOTTOM ASSN TECHNICIANS
PERFORMING PEOPLE BLOOD DRAWS
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO STOP OR
RESTART ANY IV INFUSIONS.
THAT WILL ALWAYS BE THE NURSES
RESPONSIBILITY.
MOST BY COLLECTIONS IN
CONNECTICUT AND CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS AS WELL AS HOSPITALS
AROUND THE COUNTRY IS PERFORMED
BY FULL BONDESON TECHNICIANS.
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL SHOULD BE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE THEIR BLOOD
COLLECTION PERSONNEL WHO UNLIKE
IN MOST OTHER STATES ARE LICENSE.
AND THEREFORE HAVE A HIGH
STANDARD OF PRACTICE TO
IMPLEMENT A STAT SAFER AND MORE
PATIENT CENTERED APPROACH IN
PATIENT BLOOD DRYING.
THEREFORE I URGE YOU TO VOTE HI
ON AB.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION
.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND CURTIS L<c.cyan>G JUNIOR WITH</c>
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND REGISTERED
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA.
SEE IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD EXPAND
THE SCOPE.
OF LABORATORY PER BOTTOM MISS
AND PERMIT THEM TO ACCESS
INDWELLING.
INTRAVENOUS CATHETERS.
IN HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS FOR THE%
PURPOSE OF WOULD JOIN BLOOD.
FROM PATIENTS RECEIVING FUSION
THERAPY.
CNA PROPOSES THIS LEGISLATION
FOR THREE PRIMARY REASONS.
FIRST THE INSERTION OF
INTRAVENOUS CATHETERS THE POST
INSERTION CARE OF THE INTERVENES --
INSERTION CATHETERS AND THE SITE.
IN THE MANAGEMENT OF INTRAVENOUS
INFUSIONS IS THE PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF THE DIRECT CARE REGISTERED
NURSE IN COULD NOT BE DELEGATED.
TO AN UNLICENSED PERSONNEL.
THE INSERTION OF INTRAVENOUS
CATHETER INTO A PATIENT CREATES
A PATHWAY DIRECTLY INTO -- THE
VENOUS VENOUS BLOOD STREAM.
IT REQUIRES EXTREME TECHNIQUE
BOTH FOR THE INSERTION AND FOR
THE POST INSERTION MANAGEMENT OF
THE CATHETER.
AND THE CATHETER INSERTION SITE
IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF INFECTION.
OR THE INTRODUCTION OF BACTERIA
DIRECTLY INTO THE BLOODSTREAM.
SECONDLY A CAREFUL READING OF
THE CURRENT STATUTORY LANGUAGE
REGARDING TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE CERTIFIED.
PHLEBOTOMY TECHNICIAN.
DEMONSTRATES THAT NOTHING IN THE
LANGUAGE.
THE C. P. TEASE BUT THE CARE AND
MANAGEMENT OF PERIPHERALLY
INSERTED IVY'S.
CB TEAS ARE TRAINED TO USE
NEEDLES TO PUNCTURE THE SKIN AND
TO WITHDRAW BLOOD FOR LABORATORY
ANALYSIS.
CPT TRAIN DOES NOT INCLUDE
STOPPING IV INFUSIONS FLUSHING
CATHETERS ORIENT STARTING THE IV
INCLUSION INFUSION AFTER BLOOD
HAS BEEN DRAWN.
LASTLY THIS BILL POSES A THREAT
TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS TO ITS
EFFORT TO THE SKILL.
A CENTRAL FUNCTION A
PROFESSIONAL NURSING PRACTICE.
ACCORDINGLY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE. FOR AB.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP RIGHT HERE ON THE
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
AND THE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS
OF CALIFORNIA -- I WOULD JUST
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE CURTIS -- WE
SHARE SIMILAR CONCERNS I THINK
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT -- FULL
BODY MISTER I'M LICENSE PERSON
NOW AND THIS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING TO WHICH IT WHICH IS
WITHIN THE PURVIEW AND SCOPE OF
A NURSE AND IF SOMETHING WERE TO
GO LOOK WRONG IF THERE WAS AN
INFECTION.
IF THE MAIN LINE WAS KNOCKED OUT
ON BY THE FULL BOTTOM IS
PERFORMING THE BLOOD DRIVE.
THAT WOULD -- BE BE REFLECTED ON
THE LIGHT AT THE NURSES LICENSE
AND THAT WE WE FIND THAT HIGHLY
PROBLEMATIC THANK YOU.
OTHERS UP TO SHOULD JUST IN NAME
AND POSITION ORGANIZATION.
SURE SURE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IF I COULD JUST ADD
ONE POINT FOR PEOPLE WITH HIV
AND AIDS OR IN THE HOSPITAL --
THEY ARE IN A PARTICULARLY ACUTE
STAGE OF THEIR CONDITION I'M
HAVING A CHANGE ON THE DELIVERY
OF THEIR CARE SUCH AS THIS BILL
ENVISIONS COULD ACTUALLY BE
TROUBLING FOR THAT POPULATION
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SERRA FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK WINDOWS
WITH THIS YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA
WE'RE AT A NEUTRAL POSITION
RIGHT NOW -- OUR ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS BOTH FULL BOTTOM IS
ANDERSON SO WE HEAR YOU KNOW THE
ARGUMENTS ON BOTH SIDES BUT ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THAT
SPONSORED TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JAZZY GIRL WITH THE OF CW
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LIZ ALLAN ALMOND
DISABLED PATIENT IS AT A CENTRAL
LNE -- NEUTRAL POSITION JUST
WANT YOU KNOW IT'S A REAL PAIN
TO HAVE A NEEDLE AND THE CENTRAL
LINE AT THE SAME TIME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU ALRIGHT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING TO GO FORWARD -- ON
BEHALF.
PATIENCE I I BELIEVE I HEARD
FROM THE FOR THE SPONSOR THE
SPONSORS YOUR YOUR YOUR FOLKS ON
THE SIDE YOU HAD A MILLION BLOOD
DRAWS WITH NO ADVERSE REACTIONS.
WHAT WILL CROSS THE NECKLACE ARE?
WE SHOULD CROSS THAT IN THE NEXT
MONTH OR TWO YEAH COUPLE HUNDRED
IT'S PROBABLY AROUND EIGHT OR
NINE OR THOUSAND SO FAR BUT HALF
OF THOSE WERE DONE BY THE
BOTTOMS.
NO COMPLAINTS FROM THE PATIENTS
WHO HAVE THE BLOOD DRAWN THIS
WENT.
YEAH THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT PRO
NEEDLE NOW.
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW AS A AS A
AS A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER -- I
RECOGNIZE THAT THINGS CHANGE AND
TECHNOLOGIES EMERGE AND THAT
DOES OBVIOUSLY HAVE AN EFFECT ON
PATIENT CARE -- IN THIS ONE TO
ME FEELS LIKE A VERY POSITIVE
EFFECT ON PATIENT CARE -- AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT I SUPPORT
SUPPORT THE BILL SUPPORT THE
AUTHOR IN THIS -- I'D I THINK
THAT INNOVATION IS A GOOD THING.
AND I THINK OF IT -- INC IT
INCREASES THE QUALITY OF THE
EXPERIENCE FOR THE PATIENT AND
DOESN'T HAVE AN ADVERSE SIDE
EFFECT -- I'M.
GONNA I'M GONNA SUPPORT.
SO I WANT TO GIVE YOU THE OPTION
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PROVIDING CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
AND PATIENTS WITH A SAFER OPTION
TO AVOID BLACK AND BLUE ARMS
FROM MULTIPLE NEEDLE STICKS.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY.
THIS BILL DOES NOT AUTHORIZE A
FULL BOTTOM IS TO INSERT REMOVE
OR MANAGE AN IV.
AND I WILL CLARIFY THAT FURTHER
IF NECESSARY WHEN THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD TO THE END.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE THOUGH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS
OR WHEN THE BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THEM IS TO PASS --
TO BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS --
THIS WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
MR FLORA IN A FLURRY OF VOICES
FROM THE SENATE I COULDN'T TELL
WHO.
SO WE WILL TAKE CREDIT FOR
MISTER ROBERTS IS GOING TO TAKE
CREDIT FOR THE SECOND -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AYE HERE CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW?
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
I WICKS.
FLORA BY FLORA AYE LIMóN.
MCCARTY AYE AYE MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN NOT VOTING RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WATER.
GIVE A BOTH THE BILL WITHOUT
LEAVE THE ROLE LOOKING FOR OTHER
STAFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
MUCH.
AT THIS POINT -- WE HAVE MEMBER
BILLS BUT I WANT TO STOP FOR A
SECOND -- IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE I'M SORRY [inaudible]
WE'RE OKAY -- WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A CONSULTATION WE'RE
TRYING [inaudible]
TO OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT WE PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED BUT
WE CONSULTATION WITH THE VICE
CHAIR -- AND MEMBERS WE ARE
POTENTIALLY GOING TO PUT ON ON
FOUR ADDITIONAL ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- THAT WOULD
BE A BILL -- YOU SEE MY MISTER
THIS ARIENS BILL -- AB -- NINE
NINETY THREE MISTER MCCARTY'S
BILL -- AB ONE THOUSAND AND FOUR
MISSING HERE CURRY'S BILL AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR AND MR
MCCARTY IS -- ANOTHER MISTER
MCCARTY BILL AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
NINE SO IF THERE'S AN OBJECTION
IS TO THAT.
IN IF WE CAN ADD ONE MORE I
UNDERSTAND THAT MISTER BONTA
THIS BILL AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
ALSO.
OKAY SO WE HAVE FIVE ADDITIONAL
POTENTIAL CANDIDATES FOR OF
CONSENT -- HI THIS POINT -- WE
DO HAVE AN EXISTING CONSENT
CALENDAR IF ANY MAYBE ONCE OFFER
A MOTION FOR THAT.
SO MOVE -- THIS.
AB.
NINE NINETY THREE NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE AB ONE ZERO ZERO
FOUR ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FOUR AB -- FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN AND THEN ITEM NUMBER FORTY
THREE A. B..
SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE AND ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FOUR A. B..
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE SO THESE ARE
PENDING THOUGH THOSE FIVE ARE
PENDING IF THERE ARE OBJECTIONS --
WILL -- PLEASE SOME IF THERE'S A
MEMBER OBJECTS OF THIS -- PLEASE
COME FORWARD QUICKLY.
AND THEN -- THEN THAT WILL WILL
CALL THAT US THAT WILL COLOR
SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO WE WILL MOVE OUR WILL TO HAVE
A MOTION ON OUR FIRST CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND THE SECOND OF I'M NOT SURE
WHO TO MAKE THE ORIGINAL MOTION
ON THE IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
NOTICES JOURNALISM AS A DREAM WE
ARE MOVING OKAY FIRST CONSENT
THAT'S FINE ON THE FOR FIRST
CONSENT CALENDAR SO.
THE FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR.
INCLUDES ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
THREE SIXTEEN BY MISTER RAMOS
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB SEVEN
FOURTEEN BYE.
BYE WOULD.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB SEVEN
SIXTY NINE BY MISS SMITH.
AB I REMEMBER TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY MR
MCCARTY.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT A. B..
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO BY MISS
PARQUET HAND.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE A. B.
SIXTEEN OH ONE BY MISTER RAMOS
AND ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY FIVE AB SEVENTEEN THERE
TWENTY THREE WOOD SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER -- MAYES SECOND
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY AMOUNT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONLY FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR HI
WHAT I MAYES HI MAYES AYE ANCHOR
CURRY.
I AGREE I THINK A LITTLE.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE II.
SIX FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA HI NAZARIAN EYEING
PROBLEMS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
SO THAT IS EIGHT THAT THAT FIRST
CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES WE GONNA
WAIT A FEW MINUTES BEFORE WE DO
THE SECOND PART OF THAT --
ACTUALLY WE CAN VOTE ON IT NOW
SO THE SECOND CAN SOUND CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS.
AB SEVEN AND NINE NINETY THREE
THAT IS MISTER NAZARIAN.
AB ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR MISTER
MCCARTY.
WITH AMENDMENTS AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR MISTAKE YEAR CURRY.
WITH AMENDMENTS.
AB -- SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE MR
MCCARTY AND THEN AB SEVENTEEN OH
FIVE MR BONTA SO IS OUR MOTION
WITH AMENDMENTS AS OUR MOTION.
MOTION BY MISTER BURKE SECOND BY
MISTER -- MAYES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
SECOND CONCERT CALENDAR.
WHEN I WHEN I MAYES SIDE MAYES
AYE AYE GOOD CURRY OCCUR CURRY I
BIGELOW?
AYE BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE.
WICKS.
FLORA.
FLORA AYE LOW MOAN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE
ROMMEL'S.
ROSS AYE RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
THAT IS EIGHT SO THAT PASSESSO
PRINT WE ARE NOW MOVING TO ME --
COMMITTEE MEMBER BILLS -- TRY TO
FIND WHERE WE ARE IN THE ORDER
HERE -- EXERCISE TO DO IS NOT
HERE.
SO MISTER NAZARIAN IS -- DO YOU
HAVE.
MISS BURKE I'M SORRY.
LOCAL WAIT.
NO WASN'T [inaudible]
MISS BURKE.
YES ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO AB NINE TWENTY TWO
AND AND THEN MISTER HIS HEARING
WILL BE A TWELVE OR NOT.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT
HEALTH COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING
WITH ME ON THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS WHICH I'VE AGREED TO
TAKE INCLUDING THE ADDITION OF A
FOUR YEAR SUNSET.
I AB NINE TWENTY TWO PROMOTES
MEDICAL RESEARCH IN CALIFORNIA
WINE WHILE ENSURING RESEARCH
PARTICIPANTS ARE FAIRLY TREATED
BY REMOVING THE PROHIBITION ON
COMPENSATION FOR WOMEN
PARTICIPATING IN A DONATION FOR
MEDICAL RESEARCH.
THE BILL.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT WOMEN ARE
TREATED EQUALLY TO ALL OF THE
RESEARCH SUBJECTS ALLOWING THEM
TO ACTIVELY EVALUATE THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN RESEARCH
STUDIES AND TO BE PAID FOR THEIR
TIME TROUBLE INC INCONVENIENCE
WHILE THEY DO PARTICIPATE.
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
EMPOWERING WOMEN TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
OWN HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA
DITIONS STOP WHEN IT COMES TO
PARTICIPATING RESEARCH.
NO ONE TAKES A DONATION LIGHTLY
ASSISTED US AYE PRODUCTION TAKES
TIME AND COMMITMENT TO A
RIGOROUS HOME ON PER PROTOCOL.
AND DISCOMFORT THAT GOES ALONG
WITH IT IT'S A PROCESS THAT I
KNOW FIRST HAND I'VE GONE
THROUGH IVF I WOULDN'T HAVE MY
DAUGHTER ISABELLA WITHOUT IT.
I BENEFIT FROM THE ADVANCE AND
RESEARCH THAT HAVE MADE
FERTILITY TREATMENTS EASIER AND
MORE SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED FOR
FERTILITY TREATMENTS THIRTEEN
YEARS AGO?
THE HORMONE INJECTIONS WERE
DIFFERENT THE PROCESS WAS
DIFFERENT.
TODAY TREATMENT IS MORE TAILORED
WE NOW HAVE OPTIONS FOR
FERTILITY THAT PRINT PRESERVE
WOMEN UNDERGOING CHEMOTHERAPY IT
PRESERVATION OF EMBRYOS AND MORE
EFFECTIVE PRENATAL CARE.
ALL OF THESE ADVANCES IN
TREATMENT ARE DUE TO ADVANCE
RESEARCH.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE LAYERS OF
PROTECTION TO GUARD AGAINST THE
EXPLOITATION OF DONORS WE HAVE
THOROUGH LAWS REGULATIONS AND
CONFORM TO CONSENT PROCEDURES.
WE HAVE HUMAN SUBJECT RESEARCH
PANELS AND INSTITUTIONAL REVIEW
BOARDS ENSURE THAT PARTICIPANTS
ARE SCREENED AND INFORMED ABOUT
THE RISKS AND BENEFITS OF
TREATMENTS.
THESE ARE PROCESSES THAT WE
TRUST TO PROTECT EVERY OTHER
RESEARCH PARTICIPATE.
AND A FULLY EXTENT EIGHT DONORS.
REMOVING THE BAN ON COMPENSATION
ALLOWS EGG DONORS JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER RESEARCH PARTICIPANT TO
MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION ON
PARTICIPATION AND TO BE
APPROPRIATELY COMPENSATED --
WITH ME I I HAVE A WITNESSES
THAT WILL INTRODUCE THEMSELVES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THE GERMAN WOULDN'T AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS MARCEL CEDARS --
BUT THE BOARD CERTIFIED
REPRODUCTIVE ENDOCRINOLOGIST AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
REPRODUCTIVE ENDOCRINOLOGY AND
INFERTILITY AT UCSF MEDICAL
CENTER.
AS I WORKED WITH PATIENTS
UNDERGOING THESE PROCEDURES FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS I CAN SPEAK
WITH SOME AUTHORITY ABOUT THE
PROCEDURES INVOLVED THE
POTENTIAL RISKS.
AND HOW TO MINIMIZE THESE RISKS
ADDITIONALLY THE RESEARCH I DO
ON A DAILY BASIS HAS CLEARED
DIRECT AND POTENTIALLY IMMEDIATE
CLINICAL IMPLICATION TO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR MY
PATIENTS.
AND I KNOW THAT WITHOUT
COMPENSATION WE CANNOT OBTAIN --
SITES TO DO THE RESEARCH THAT
ONE DAY WILL IMPROVE MEDICAL
CARE FOR WOMEN.
OVARIAN STIMULATION AND SITE
RETRIEVAL IS A TIME CONSUMING
AND ARDUOUS PROCESS THE TIME
COMMITMENT FOR ONE ASSISTED
REPRODUCTION CYCLE HAS BEEN
ESTIMATED AT FIFTY SIX HOURS.
AND INCLUDES MEDICAL SCREENING
AND MONITORING INTERVIEWS IN
COUNSELING BLOOD TESTS AND OTHER
MEDICAL PROCEDURES.
THE ETHICS COMMITTEE OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF REPRODUCTIVE
MEDICINE HAS CONSIDERED THE
ISSUE OF COMPENSATION FOR DONORS.
AND HAS COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT COMPENSATION IS WARRANTED
AND ETHICAL.
OUR ANALYSIS OF COMPENSATION
DOES NOT CHANGE DEPENDING ON THE
AND USE OF THE DONATION WHETHER
TO HELP CREATE A FAMILY OR TO BE
USED IN RESEARCH WHICH
ULTIMATELY MAY HELP MILLIONS.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA COMPENSATION
IS PROHIBITED ESSENTIALLY
CLOSING OFF RESEARCH THAT COULD
OTHERWISE BE DONE BY OUR WORLD
RENOWNED SCIENTISTS AND
INSTITUTIONS.
WE ARE ONE OF ONLY THREE STATES
THAT HAS SUCH A BAN.
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL RESEARCH
GUIDELINES FOR RESEARCH
PARTICIPANT SHOULD BE
COMPENSATED FOR THEIR TIME
TROUBLE AND INCONVENIENCE
STEMMING FROM RESEARCH RELATED
PROCEDURES.
ADDITIONALLY EVERY MEDICAL
PROCEDURE COMES AT WITH SOME
LEVEL OF RISK.
OVARIAN STIMULATION RETRIEVAL
ARE STANDARD MEDICAL PROCEDURES
THAT HAVE BEEN UTILIZED FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AND IN THE LAST
YEAR THIS PROCEDURE WAS
PERFORMED OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TIMES GLOBALLY.
NEW OVULATION INDUCTION
STRATEGIES ARE THOUGHT TO ALL
BUT ELIMINATE THE COMPLICATION
OF OVARIAN HYPER STIMULATION
SYNDROME AND STUDIES REGARDING
CANCER RISK HAVE BEEN LARGELY
REASSURING.
AND THERE APPEARS TO BE NO
SIGNIFICANT INCREASED RISK FOR
BREAST OVARIAN OR UTERINE CANCER
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PROCEDURES.
ALL RESEARCH INVOLVING HUMAN
SUBJECTS IS REVIEWED BY AN
INSTITUTIONAL REVIEW BOARD WHOSE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
PROTECT RESEARCH PARTICIPANTS
FROM UNDUE RISK AN INFLUENCE.
IT IS ALSO THE JOB OF THESE
REVIEW BOARDS TO SET
COMPENSATION FOR RESEARCH
SUBJECTS.
THERE IS NO REASON THAT THIS
ESTABLISHED POLICY OF OVERSIGHT
SHOULD BE DIFFERENT -- FOR SITE
DONATION TO SCIENCE.
RATHER THAN OTHER TYPES OF
RESEARCH FURTHERMORE ANY
RESEARCH THAT IT INVOLVES
REPRODUCTIVE TISSUES MUST ALSO
UNDERGO.
EXCUSE ME AN ADDITIONAL REVIEW
BY A SEPARATE COMMITTEE OF
SCIENTISTS ETHICISTS AND
LAYPERSONS.
LASTLY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEED -- FOR SITES
FOR RESEARCH IN ADDITION TO USE
AND STEM CELL RESEARCH THERE IS
A NEED TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
BASIC AG DEVELOPMENT AND
MATURITY.
AND A VERY AN AGING IMPROVING
OUR KNOWLEGE ABOUT THE
OVERSIGHT MAY IMPROVE TREATMENT
FOR INFERTILITY AND ALLOW
PROTECTION OF THE FREE FROM
TOXIC EFFECTS OF CHEMOTHERAPY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS NOT CRYSTAL OFF AND I
AM CO OF OF IT RESEARCH THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF INCREASING ACCESS TO OTHER
SITES -- FOR RESEARCH PURPOSES.
I BELIEVE THERE IS VERY BIG
POTENTIAL TO MAKE ASSISTED
REPRODUCTIVE TECHNOLOGIES MUCH
EASIER MUCH HEALTHIER AND MUCH
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR MANY
MILLIONS OF WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLAIN WHY THANK ADOPTING THIS
LAWS IMPORTANT TO THAT.
THERE ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CASE OF CASES OF IN
VITRO FERTILIZATION OCCURRING
PER YEAR IN THE U. S. COSTING ON
AVERAGE TEN TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR PER PROCEDURE.
AND USUALLY BEING PAID DIRECTLY
BY THE PATIENT.
RIGHT NOW PATIENTS MYSELF IN
JACK'S TEN FIFTEEN HORMONE
INJECTIONS BEFORE THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO THE PROCEDURE.
THESE INJECTIONS CAN BE
UNPLEASANT RESULTING AND USUALLY
AND USUALLY UNCOMFORTABLE
BLOATING AND SWELLING.
BUT THERE'S CLEAR PROMISE TO
DEVELOP A WAY WHERE MOST WOMEN
WOULD NOT REQUIRE THESE HORMONE
INJECTIONS IF WE FURTHER DEVELOP
PROMISING RESEARCH.
THE ORGANIZATION I RUN IS A
RESEARCH ORGANIZATION THAT'S
TRYING TO DEVELOP THE WAY FOR
WOMEN TO NOT NEED HORMONE
INJECTIONS PRIOR TO DOING IVF.
AND RIGHT NOW IT'S FAR TOO HARD
TO DO OUR RESEARCH IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET ACCESS TO
THE NEEDED TO SHE IS. TO TEST
OUR WORK WE NEED TO WORK WITH
EGGS THAT HAVE NEVER BEEN
EXPOSED TO HORMONE INJECTIONS
AND WE CAN'T JUST GET -- SITES
LEFT OVER FROM FERTILITY
TREATMENTS AS THEY'VE BEEN
EXPOSED THE MEDICATIONS WERE
TRYING TO AVOID.
THE ONLY WAY TO OBTAIN THE
NEEDED TISSUES IS TO COMPENSATE
WOMEN FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION
AND DONATIONS CYCLES.
WITHOUT ACCESS TO EX WE CAN'T
DEVELOP THIS RESEARCH AND
PERPETUATES THE INABILITY TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER FOR MILLIONS
OF WOMEN AND COUPLES THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD.
OUR ORGANIZATION IS NOT UNIQUE
IN BEING LIMITED ON PURSING
PROMISING RESEARCH INCREASE CARE.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER ACADEMIC
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE BEING STYMIED FROM DOING
MEANINGFUL RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT COULD
TREMENDOUSLY BENEFIT WHEN AND
EXPAND ACCESS TO POPULATIONS
ACCOUNT CURRENTLY AFFORD THE
EXPENSIVE TREATMENTS.
ARE THOSE WHO DON'T WANT OR
CAN'T USE THE HORMONE INJECTIONS.
IF THEY CAN GET ACCESS TO ADD
THIS THESE RESEARCHERS CAN DO.
THIS IS A SOLVABLE PROBLEM OUR
NEIGHBOR IN OREGON ALLOWS
COMPENSATION FOR A DONATION FOR
RESEARCH PURPOSES AS DOES NEW
YORK.
WE CAN TAK THEM BOTH AS PROOF
THERE IS A WAY TO DO THIS
WITHOUT EVIDENCE OF EXPLOITATION
OR ABUSE.
I WOULD CAUTION TO THAT RESEARCH
CAN LEAVE CALIFORNIA.
GREAT COMPANIES AND RESEARCHERS
STRUGGLING TO DO THIS TYPE OF
WORK IN CALIFORNIA WILL GO
ELSEWHERE.
MY COMPANY FOR EXAMPLE IS DOING
SOME OF OUR WORK IN LOCATIONS
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA AND MAY
EVENTUALLY BE FORCED TO MOVE ALL
TOGETHER.
MASSACHUSETTS WHICH SIMILAR HAS
MADE IT DIFFICULT TO DONATE EGGS
FOR RESEARCH PURPOSES HAS
ALREADY EXPERIENCED THIS.
THE BOSTON AREA IS THE CLASSIC
PLACE FOR LIFE SCIENCE RESEARCH
IN THE US MANY RESEARCHERS AND
COMPANIES HAVE ALREADY MOVED TO
NEW YORK WHERE THE LAWS AROUND
OBTAINING EGGS FOR RESEARCH AS
MUCH FRIENDLIER.
SO I COME HERE TO ASK PLEASE
CONSIDER PASSING THIS LAW.
THE BENEFITS IT COULD BRING TO
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE SO HIGH
AND THE RISK IS LOW.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING AND
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
SUPPORT GOOD EVENING SHANNON
SMITH CROWLEY REPRESENTING THE
SPONSOR THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE WE ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU.
MY COLLEAGUES AT ALL WITH
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
TRANSPORTING CAM K<c.cyan>.</c>
RIGHT SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
CULTURE OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. TWENTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH I THINK SO.
THE THING.
MY NAME IS ELENA DELLE.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE AT BUT
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE AT THE
AGE OF TWENTY TWO I DONATE MY
EGGS ONE TIME IN CALIFORNIA TO
HELP INFERTILE COUPLE.
I WAS PAY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR MY DONATION.
I PRODUCE SEVENTEEN ACHES IN MY
RECIPIENTS HAD TWINS.
THE UNUSED EMBRYOS CREATED FROM
MY EGGS WERE USED FOR SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH.
THE FERTILITY DOCTOR PRESCRIBED
TWENTY NINE DAYS OF DAILY LUPRON
INJECTIONS FALL BY OTHER
FERTILITY MEDICATIONS CONCLUDING
WITH PAINFUL AND INVASIVE
SURGERY FOR WHICH I WAS NOT
PROPERLY SEDATED.
I FELT TALKING IN MY OVARIES AS
WELL AS REPEATED STOPPING BY THE
NEEDLES THAT REMOVED MY EX.
AFTERWARDS I WAS COMPELLED
INCAPACITATED BY AN RELENTING
MIGRAINES FOR SEVERAL WEEKS FOR
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS THEY HAVE
CONTINUED UNABATED.
RENDERING ME DISABLED.
MY FIRST NATURAL PUREE CONSISTED
OF A WEEK OF HEAVY HEMORRHAGIC
BLEEDING AND THESE HAVE
CONTINUED EVER SINCE LEAVING ME
FURTHER INCAPACITATED.
WITHIN A YEAR I HAD SEVERE PAIN
IN MY JOINTS AND BODY.
I DID NOT CONNECT THIS PAIN TO
MY DONATION.
I RESEARCH LUPRON WITH THE F. T.
A AND LEARN THE TWO WERE LIKELY
LINKED.
THE CLINIC DID NOT INFORM ME
ABOUT LUPRON RISKS WHICH INCLUDE
MIGRAINES JOINT PAIN.
BONE LOSS AND AUTOIMMUNE SYSTEMS
AMONG OTHERS.
I REGULARLY SPEAK TO OTHER
FORMER EGG DONORS.
WHO WERE ON THIS DRUG WHO
EXPERIENCED SIMILAR SYMPTOMS IN
ADDITION TO OVERREACH AMPUTATION
ENDOMETRIOSIS?
INFERTILITY HYSTERECTOMY HEART
PROBLEMS AND CANCER.
BEFORE EGG DONATION.
I WAS HEALTHY AND STRONG.
I WAS FIREFIGHTER.
I CAN NO LONGER WORKING MY
PUBLIC SAFETY CAREER.
I'VE LOST MORE THAN ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN POTENTIAL INCOME IN
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS HAVE SPENT
AN ESTIMATED. THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ON MY MEDICAL CARE.
I'VE LOST MY HOME AND I'VE HAD
TO FILE BANKRUPTCY.
AT FORTY TWO I REGULARLY SEE
FOURTEEN DOCTORS INCLUDING EIGHT
DIFFERENT PAIN MANAGEMENT
SPECIALIST.
MY ENDOCRINOLOGIST BELIEVES THAT
MY ONGOING HEALTH PROBLEMS ARE
LINKED TO THE SAME HORMONE
DISRUPTORS THAT RESEARCH
SUBJECTS WOULD YOU.
USE.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH HUNDREDS OF
OTHER DONORS WHOSE LIVES WERE
RUINED DUE TO OUR DONATIONS NO
ONE SHOULD ENTER A LIFE OF
SUFFERING FOR RESEARCH.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON PROCURING
EGGS AS RESEARCH MATERIALS WE
NEED A LONG TERM STUDIES ON
DONOR ILLNESS AND MORTALITY.
THE SCIENCE HAS BEEN AROUND
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
WE HAVE STILL YET TO HAVE ONE
LONG TERM STUDY ON A DONOR
HEALTH.
WOMEN DESERVE INFORMED CONSENT
WITHOUT STUDIES WE DON'T HAVE IT.
I ASK YOU TO OPPOSE AB NINE
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AND THANK OU FOR HEARING ME
TODAY MY NAME IS DOCTOR DIANE
TOBER I'M A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO ROY LAUNCH THE I DON'T
A RESEARCH PROJECT IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IS BASED ON
RESULTS FROM MY PILOT DATA WHICH
I HAVE.
PREPARED A BRIEF FOR YOU THAT
YOU HAVE TO IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY.
I AM PRO CHOICE PRO SCIENCE PRO
INFORMED CONSENT AND LIKE MANY
OF YOU I FULLY EMBRACE THE
WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT HER BODY.
WITH THE OPERATIVE WORD BEING
INFORMED.
TODAY I'M GOING TO DRAW UPON A
COMPLETED SURVEYS WITH A HUNDRED
FORTY ONE AND DONE IS LIKE
COLLECTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN BUT IN TOTAL TO DATE I
HAVE INTERVIEWED OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND DONORS AND COLLECTED
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SURVEYS.
NOTE MOST AND DONORS ARE FINE
BUT THAT THERE'S ENOUGH CAUSE
FOR CONCERN WAS THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER ONES WHO NOT.
THAT MAKE ME FEEL LIKE I NEED TO
STEP FORWARD TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION THAT COULD BE
HELPFUL.
THE MAJORITY OF PARTICIPANTS ARE
IN MY STUDY WERE IN THE EARLY TO
MID TWENTIES AT THE TIME OF THE
FIRST CYCLE A DONATION CYCLE.
OVER HALF REPORTED IN INCOMES BE
LOWER SLIGHTLY ABOVE THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE RECOMMENDS
THE DONORS UNDERGO NORMAN NO
MORE THAN SIX TAUGHT CYCLES.
DUE IN PART TO POTENTIAL UNKNOWN
AND KNOWN COMPLICATIONS YET NINE
OUT OF A HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
DOLLARS IN MY EARLIER STUDY
UNDERWENT BETWEEN EIGHT AND
SEVENTEEN CYCLES.
DUE TO FINANCIAL NEED WITH MANY
PRODUCING BETWEEN THIRTY AND AS
HIGH AS EIGHTY THREE EGGS IN A
SINGLE CYCLE DUE TO AGGRESSIVE
STUDENT HORMONE STEEL
STIMULATION PROTOCOLS AND HIGH
PRODUCING DONORS.
THERE IS NO SYSTEM TRACKING
DONOR CYCLES AND NO OVERSIGHT
WHICH MEANS THERE IS ESSENTIALLY
NO INFORMED CONSENT.
PARTICIPANTS EXPERIENCE
COMPLICATIONS MORE FREQUENTLY
THAN THE 1% CITED IN MUCH OF THE
LITERATURE. THIRTY TWO OUT OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE IN THIS
PARTICULAR SAMPLES EXPERIENCE
SEVERE OVER VERY HYPER
STIMULATION SYNDROME THAT
REQUIRED HOSPITALIZATION.
A TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD OWNER IN
MY STUDY EXPERIENCE CRITICAL --
HSS WITH KIDNEY FAILURE AND
ALMOST DIED.
OTHERS REPORTED SURGICAL MISHAPS
OR VERY INTO PORTION REQUIRING
REMOVAL OF THE OVARY.
SEVERAL HAD ENDOMETRIOSIS --
REPRODUCTIVE CANCERS WITHIN A
YEAR OF DONATION RENDERING THEM
UNABLE TO HAVE THEIR OWN
CHILDREN BUT AGAIN WITHOUT LONG
TERM STUDIES WE DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS CONNECTED TO THE REC
DONATIONS ARE NOT.
ACCORDING TO THE BILL TEXT
RESEARCH PARTICIPANTS WILL A NOT
BE UNDULY INDUCED AND WILL BE
UNDERGO A RIGOROUS INFORMED
CONSENT PROCESS.
THE GIVEN THE LACK OF EXISTING
RESEARCH AND MANY DONORS
FINANCIAL PREPARE EDDIE THIS
CLAIM IS PROBLEMATIC.
AS A RESEARCHER I APPRECIATE THE
GOALS OF SCIENCE BUT GIVEN THE
FINDINGS THAT THE AND THE AND
THE STORIES THAT I HAVE HEARD I
DON'T THINK IT IS PRUDENT TO
PASS AB.
NINE TWENTY TWO WITHOUT BETTER
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE SUCH AS SOME
OF WHICH I HAVE HAD OUTLINED IN
THE BRIEF THAT I PROVIDED.
BUT INCLUDING LIMITS ON THE
NUMBERS OF EGGS PRODUCED PER
CYCLE PROTECT POTENTIALLY
CANCELING ANY CYCLE OVER WHICH
TWENTY EGGS ARE BEING PRODUCED.
EXCLUDING THE OWNERS WITH PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS SO FOR
EXAMPLE DONORS THAT HAVE HAD --
VERY TYPE OF STIMULATION
SYNDROME BEFORE OR CAN'T OR
CANCER IN THEIR FAMILY OR
ENDOMETRIOSIS SHOULD BE EXCLUDED.
AND THEN FINALLY TO INCLUDE A
REGISTRY TO TRACK DONOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND DONOR EXPERIENCES
OVER TIME SO WE CAN HAVE A
BETTER IDEA OF WHAT THE LONG
TERM IMPLICATIONS ARE.
AND TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE FOLLOW
UP CARE.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL UNLESS
AMENDED ENERGY TO CONSIDER THE
AMENDMENTS I PROPOSE BEFORE
PUTTING THIS BILL.
AND THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE AN IN BETWEEN A POSITION.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK -- OUR BOARD IS A
THICK POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IN
CPOPS INCLUSION OF A BILL OF
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
YOU KNOW WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS MR MAKES.
YOU KNOW THIS IS ONE OF THOSE --
THINGS WHEN DO YOU HEAR FROM
EXPERTS -- AND IT'S DIFFICULT --
IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
AND TO BE ABLE TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND.
THE DYNAMICS WHAT I DO KNOW IS
THAT THE AUTHOR -- HAS SPENT A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME
STUDYING -- AND I KNOW THAT SHE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO -- THAT WORK
I'M TO SUPPORT THIS -- TODAY
KNOWING -- THAT THE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS SINCERE AND WOULD
WOULD WOULD WOULD NOT WANT TO DO
ANYTHING.
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD HARM ANY
INDIVIDUAL SO I HOPE THAT -- YOU
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR -- THEN I'LL BE
SUPPORTING US TODAY.
THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
[inaudible]
TO ANYONE ELSE.
HELLO -- I PLACE WAS SAFE IS
APPRECIATE GOT TO BRING THIS
FORWARD AYE I APPRECIATE THE
WITNESSES ON BUT THE OP
OPPOSITION AS WELL -- I KNOW
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS -- AS WE GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND OBVIOUSLY NOBODY
WANTS ANYONE TO BE HARMED IN
THIS IN THIS IN ANYWAY -- SIDE
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO WE WANT
GOOD SOUND SCIENCE WE DON'T WANT
ANYONE HARMED IN AND THROUGH
THIS PROCESS SO.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE THAT THAT
THERE WILL BE CONTINUED
DELIBERATIONS REGARDING THIS BUT
I AM PREPARED TO MOVE THE BILL
FOR TODAY THANK YOU AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION -- WE HAVE A
MOTION -- AM I MISSING HERE
CURRY A SECOND BY MISTER RAMOS
WHICH LIKE CLINICS YEAH MY STAFF
HAS MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT I AM
NOT TO CRY AND ANYMORE TESTIMONY
SO I'M GONNA THE SAME THINGS.
BUT IT IS ONLY WITH THIS
RESEARCH THAT WE WILL REACH
PROGRESS IN THE PROCESS WILL GET
EASIER AND AND IT HAS GOTTEN
BETTER.
AND WITH THAT OF COURSE I WILL
ALWAYS TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT
THE OPPOSITION SAYS AND AND BE
VERY MINDFUL OF IT.
I'M OMEN'S HEALTH IS A NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY THE PRIORITY TO ME
AS IS IS HEALTHY BABIES AND HAVE
BEEN MOTHER HOOD.
SO WITH THAT I RISK I APPRECIATE
MY COLLEAGUES -- SUPPORT IN ALL
OF THESE ISSUES THAT I BRING TO
THEM THAT ARE THE MOST
COMFORTABLE ISSUES TO DISCUSS
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN APPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS FOR WE
HAVE A MOTION -- AS I SAID BY --
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY IN A SECOND BY
MISTER RAMOS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS -- M. SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGAR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE I WICKS.
FLORA. FOR I LEVEL [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE I'M SORRY MCCARTY
[inaudible]
PARTY I NAZARIAN AYE.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
GIVE ELEVEN VOTES YOUR BILLS OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF FOR OTHER
OTHERS TO VOTE.
MR BONTA WHICH WAY TO GO.
BONTA HAS AB.
FORTY FOUR FOURTEEN AND AND YOU
KNOW WE PUT AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
ARKANSAS.
I SAW THAT I LIKE THAT A LOT.
THANK YOU YOU'RE OKAY YEAH I AM
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER VICE CHAIR WITH
EVERYTHING MISTER VICE CHAIR FOR
THE WHATEVER YOU READY THANK
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES.
AB FOUR ONE FOUR SIMPLY RE
ESTABLISHES THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT'S INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY
PAYMENTS THAT CONGRESS ROLL BACK.
THERE BY ENSURING THAT HEALTH
CARE MEANS AFFORDABLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT MORE CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S.
REPEAL OF THE PENALTY PAYMENT IS
PROJECTED TO RESULT IN A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND TO FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT.
HEALTH COVERAGE BY.
TWENTY TWENTY BY SIMPLY
REESTABLISHING THE PENALTY AB
FOUR ONE FOUR COULD ALSO
GENERATE REVENUE FOR WHICH
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS INDICATED
COULD BE USED TO INCREASE
INSURANCE SUBSIDIES FOR
HOUSEHOLDS PURCHASING HEALTH
INSURANCE. TO COVER CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA MUST CONTINUE. TO
FIGHT FOR EQUITABLE AND
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE FOR OUR
RESIDENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS BETH CAPELL WITH
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA AND AUTUMN
OGDEN SMITH WITH THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY CANCER ACTION
NETWORK MOVES THE BILL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AND THEY HAVE A HEALTH
TAXES CALIFORNIA IS THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS VERY WELL THE
POINT OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
WAS TO GET PEOPLE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE AS PART
OF A BALANCED SOLUTION THAT THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT REPRESENTED
THAT BAND TO USE A PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS PROVIDED
AFFORDABILITY HELP.
AND ALSO INCLUDED MANDATES ON
INDIVIDUALS AND EMPLOYERS
COVERED CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
SEEN A DROP OF 24% IN NEW
ENROLLMENT SINCE ALL OF THE
DISRUPTION THAT'S GONE ON AS MR
BONTA SAID THERE'S PROJECTED
INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
UNINSURED WHICH IS THE WRONG
DIRECTION IN OUR JUDGMENT -- YOU
WILL HEAR PERHAPS FROM THE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE A HARDSHIP EXEMPTION I
ASSURE YOU THAT IT YEAH WE WERE
YOU FOR VIçT LANGUAGE AND IT
DOES -- AND WE ARE PLEASED THAT
WE ARE HERE ON THE SAME DAY THAT
A DOCTOR WOULD SPILL TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY EVEN FURTHER WILL
ALSO BE HEARD SO WE THINK THAT
THIS IS A IMPORTANT PACKAGE AND
PLEASED TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESULT AMOUNT IN
SMITH WITH THE CANCER SOCIETY
AND THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS MAINTAIN HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE AND WILL HELP TO
DRIVE DOWN COSTS.
AT WHICH IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
FOR CANCER PATIENTS TO SPEND
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
TO COVER THE COST OF THEIR CARE.
WITHOUT THE PARTICIPATION OF
HEALTHY CALIFORNIANS IN THE
MARKET THE BURDEN OF COSTS FALL
ON THE SHOULDERS OF THE VERY
SICK.
WHO CANNOT GO WITHOUT COVERAGE
EIGHTY FOUR ONE FOUR WILL HELP
TO DRIVE DOWN THE COST -- BY
ENSURING THAT THE BURDEN OF
CROSS SO DIVERSE DIVERSIFIED AND
SHARED BY ALL AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
OTHERS TO SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX OFTEN THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THE SAID SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
AND SUPPORT.
RIGHT SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUT ATTIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DARIA MCGREW CALIFORNIA DENTAL
BECAUSE SUPPORTER BLUESHIELD
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NICK LOUISA'S CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS IN
SUPPORT.
KATHY MUSBURGER HEALTH PLANS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVEN SO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
NOW IS IT ALL WITH CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. SEVENTY WATKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUT NETWORK IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. THREE ONE IN
OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TAYLOR
JACKSON OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED AB
FOLKS.
WERE OPPOSED TO EIGHTY FOUR ONE
FOUR BECAUSE IT IMPLEMENTS A
REGRESSIVE TAX WHICH WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT WORKING AND
MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE OF OUR STATE.
DO NOT GO WITHOUT HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THEY WANT TO
LIVE THEY DO IT BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT AFFORD IT AND THE SYSTEM
IS RIGGED AGAINST THEM AN
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE DOES NOTHING
TO CHANGE THOSE FACTS.
CNA DID NOT OPPOSE THE FEDERAL
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE BECAUSE IT
WAS PART OF A LARGER DEAL THAT
OVERALL HELPED OUR PATIENTS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE FEDERAL
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WAS NECESSARY
IN AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
NEGOTIATIONS TO ENSURE
NATIONWIDE MINIMUM ESSENTIAL
BENEFITS AND TO REMOVE BARRIERS
TO CARE SUCH AS INSURANCE
COMPANIES BARRING FOLKS WITH PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS.
YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE NOT
GETTING ANYTHING IN RETURN FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE THIS TIME
AROUND.
IT HAS BEEN ARGUED THE PROFITS
FROM THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE CAN
BE USED TO ASSIST PEOPLE IN
PURCHASING HEALTH INSURANCE.
BUT INCREASE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
FROM THE STATE WON'T HELP OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES CONTINUE TO
RAISE RATES AND GOBBLE UP ANY
INCREASES THE LEGISLATURE MAY
ALLOCATE. EIGHTY FOUR ONE FOUR
IS A CASH COW FOR THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
THE BILL MAKES NO GUARANTEE THAT
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES WON'T
TURN AROUND AND CONTINUE TO
RAISE RATES OUTRAGEOUSLY.
EVEN THOUGH THIS BILL WOULD
FORCE A WHOLE SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION TO PURCHASE THEIR
PRODUCT.
AB FOREIGN FOR HUSTLE ALSO HAS
NO CLEAR DECLARATION TO PROTECT
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD THE
EXPENSE OF FOR PROFIT PRODUCT
THE HEALTH INSURANCE INDUSTRY
SELLS.
BUT WHO MAY MAKE ABOVE THE
THRESHOLD TO QUALIFY FOR MEDI
CAL.
THE FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
IMPLEMENTED UNDER THE ACA HOW TO
SPECIFIC EXEMPTION FROM THE
PENALTY FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO CANNOT AFFORD COVERAGE -- IT
SPECIFICALLY DEFINED UNDER THE
LAW ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
REQUIRED HEALTHCARE CONTRIBUTION
WOULD EXCEED 8% OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME WELL A PREVENT
SENT IS STILL TOO HIGH FOR MANY
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES.
AT THE VERY LEAST THIS LAW HAD A
CLEAR STANDARD.
THE LOWEST TIER OF HEALTH
INSURANCE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ON
THE COVER CALIFORNIA EXCHANGES
THE BRONZE LEVEL THE BRONZE
LEVEL ON AVERAGE MEANS YOUR
HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN ONLY PAY
60% OF YOUR MEDICAL COSTS AND
YOU'RE STUCK WITH THE OTHER.
FORTY NURSES KNOW IF THEIR
PATIENTS CAN'T PAY FOR INSURANCE
A PENALTY FEE IS NOT GOING TO
PUSH THEM INTO PURCHASING A SUB
PAR PRODUCT THEY COULDN'T AFFORD
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
OUR PATIENTS WILL BE STUCK
PAYING A FEE WILL STILL NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO CARE.
ACCORDING TO THE HEALTH CARE
COST AND UTILIZATION PRODUCT THE
AVERAGE HOSPITAL STAY COSTS JUST
OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
EVEN WITH BRONZE LEVEL COVERAGE
THAT PRICE WOULD BANKRUPT MOST
FAMILIES.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS INCREASE BY
TWELVE POINT 5%.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THEIR
ANTICIPATED TO RISE BY NEARLY 9%.
AB FOUR ONE FOUR PUTS CASH IN
THE POCKETS OF INSURANCE COMPANY
EXECUTIVES WITH NO GUARANTEED
GOOD OUTCOMES FOR OUR PATIENTS
OR YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
NURSES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE A
BEFORE ONE FOUR AND ALSO YOU
VOTE NO.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION READ
OPPOSITION.
OKAY BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD HI DEAL
FOUNTAIN REPRESENTING HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND SUPPORTERS OF
AN ACT UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALSO IN OPPOSITION -- TO
EIGHTY FOUR ONE FOUR WE DID A
POLL.
RECENTLY.
OF OVER TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS -- 67% WERE OPPOSED
TO THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
PENALTIES -- MODE A LOT OF
PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD THE
INSURANCE THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
DROPPING OFF -- IT LET ME JUST
GIVE YOU THIS IN CONTEXT -- COST
OF LIVING BAY AREA IS REALLY
HIGH IT'S TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT -- IS THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ANY COST OF LIVING -- SO
EAT MAY BE A PERCENT OF
HEALTHCARE COSTS BUT NOT OF WHAT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY PAYING FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE IN LIFE -- THE
SECOND THING IS THAT
[inaudible]
IT IT.
THIS IS THE SECOND THING IT IS
THAT TO IT ALSO -- THIS SHOULD
COME UNDER THE THE THE PURVIEW
OF THE COUNCIL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND I STILL
DON'T SEE THAT BEING APPOINTED
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE
OUT QUESTIONS WITH THE COMES BY
THE OPPOSITION MISTER BONTA.
YES THANK YOU THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE WILL.
ENCOURAGING SENT PEOPLE TO GET
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE THAT'S GOOD
WE LIKE IT WILL MORE PEOPLE HAVE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE THE
OPPOSITE WILL OCCUR WITHOUT IT.
AND WITH THE THE PENALTY WE WILL
BE ABLE TO SUBSIDIZE ACOSTA
LOWER PREMIUMS EVERYBODY.
THIS IS NOT A CURE ALL A PANACEA
SILVER BULLET IN AND OF ITSELF
WE NEED YOUR BILL DOCTOR WOULD
WE NEED IN A SERIES OF BILLS OF
ALL WORKING ON BECAUSE WE KNOW
ABOUT THE RISING COST OF
HEALTHCARE WE LOWER IT. TO WORK
HAND IN HAND WITH THOSE EFFORTS
TO HELP CREATE.
A SCENARIO CALIFORNIA WE HOPE WE
ASPIRE TO WHERE EVERYONE IS
COVERED AND IT'S AFFORDABLE --
THE BILL.
DOES EXPRESSED INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE THE SAME
EXEMPTIONS THAT THE ACA HAD.
THE ACA HAS EXEMPTION FOR
HARDSHIP FOR INCOME -- FOR
INABILITY TO PAY AND WE THINK
THOSE ARE PRUDENT -- AND THAT'S
WHY WE MODELED IT AFTER THE
ACA'S -- EXEMPTIONS -- WE ALSO
HAVE SECTION ONE ZERO ZERO SEVEN
OH FOUR WHICH SETS FORTH THAT
THE THAT COVER CALIFORNIA WILL
BE IDENTIFYING POTENTIAL --
EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION SO
READING THOSE ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED -- IT WILL BE
ADDRESSED GOING FORWARD AND AND
ARE DRESSED IN THE CURRENT FORM
OF THE BILL AND WITH THE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSENT TO THIS
DISCUSSION WE KNOW THERE'S A
VEHICLE ALSO IN THE SENATE OUR
GOVERNOR IS IS IS IS FOCUSED ON
THIS AND WORKING TOGETHER AS A
AND ASSEMBLY. TO IDENTIFY
SOLUTION THAT WORKS FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA -- SO WITH THAT I
RESPECT THE FEI VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
VERY MUCH.
ANY ANY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF MISS WALDRON -- THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUES SO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE AT LEAST GET A
QUESTION.
ON THE RECORD -- AS FAR AS AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S SOMEONE IN
THE INSURANCE.
FIELD THE COULD ANSWER MAYBE --
IN ACTING SOMETHING LIKE THIS
WOULD.
HELP WITH THE RISK POOL I WOULD
ASSUME OR CAN YOU RESPOND TO
THAT YEAH WHAT HAPPENS TO
PEOPLE'S PREMIUMS MORE PEOPLE IN
THE POOL.
I AM JUST CURIOUS.
I MEAN I JUST QUICKLY SAY AND%
AND I THINK MY WITNESSES WILL BE
ABLE TO SAY BETTER BUT THE THE
THE BIGGER THE POOL THE PART OF
THE POOL THE MORE DIVERSE THE
POOL THE MORE PARTICIPANTS IN
THE POOL.
THAT THE BETTER AND IT WILL HELP
READERS REDUCE COSTS WHEN YOU
HAVE A LARGER INSURANCE POOL
WITH EVERYONE PARTICIPATING --
IT WILL LEAD TO MORE PEOPLE WITH
CARE AND LOWER COSTS -- LET ME
WITNESSES RESPOND AS WELL.
THROUGH THE CHAIR -- BETH BELL
HEALTH ACCESS COVERED CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATED THE PREMIUMS WENT UP
FOUR AND A HALF PERCENT THIS
YEAR SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE
REPEAL OF THE PENALTY.
IN OTHER STATES WHERE THE
PENALTY HAS BEEN IMPOSED
PREMIUMS ACTUALLY WENT DOWN.
SO IT HAS A BIG IMPACT ON THE IN
THE RISK POOL IS MISTER BONTA
SAID BY ENCOURAGING MORE PEOPLE
TO TAKE COVERAGE WHETHER IT'S
MEDI CAL OR THEIR EMPLOYERS
COVERAGE OR TO BUY IT THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA.
AND SO IT WILL DRIVE DOWN
PREMIUMS AND COMBINED WITH THE
AFFORDABILITY HELP AND DOCTOR
WOULD SPILL WILL REALLY HELP
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
COVERAGE.
OKAY THANK YOU -- BUT THAT IS
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
THEIR MOTION BY MISTAKE YEAR
CURRY A SECOND BY MISS BURKE
JUDGE CLOSENESS BONTA.
ESPECIALLY AFTER I VOTE THANK
YOU -- MESSAGES THE MESSAGE
CONCLUSION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS MATTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHEN I WHEN
I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA.
HI BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I FIX
[inaudible]
FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING LIMON.
LOW ON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I THINK THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S.
RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
SIZE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
WELL THEY'RE NOT VOTING.
YOUR BILLS NINE VOTES IT'S OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
[inaudible]
MR ASSYRIAN.
WE HAVE AB.
TWELVE OH NINE RESTORE MON
YOU'RE ON DECK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- A. B.
TWELVE OH NINE WOULD ALLOW
CONSUMERS TO EXERCISE THEIR LONG
TERM CARE BENEFIT. TO KEEP THEIR
ACCESS TO ANY LOAN AND
WITHDRAWAL FEATURES.
OF THEIR LIFE INSURANCE POLICY
IT WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE OF
ATTAINED AGE LONG TERM CARE
RATES IN CALIFORNIA FOR BOTH
HYBRID AND STANDALONE POLICIES.
AND FINALLY IT WOULD INCREASE
THE MINIMUM DAILY BENEFIT FROM
FIFTY DOLLARS TO ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY -- AND I WILL
CURTAIL MY COMMENTS -- SINCE I'M
JOINED BY MICHAEL MARTINEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER MISTER RICARDO LARA
AS A SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING MIKE MARTINEZ HIM
BEHALF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
CARLOTTA.
AND PROBABLY IN SUPPORT AND
SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE ONE
THING TO MISTER NAZARIAN FOR
OFFERING THIS MEASURE.
I'LL BE BRIEF -- GIVEN THE
LATENESS OF THE HOUR JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT -- JUST THE FIRST
TEN FULL MONTHS THAT THE
COMMISSIONER HAS BEEN IN OFFICE
HE HAS BEEN.
INCREASINGLY WORRIED OF THE
INCREASE IN LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE RATES ON OF THOSE WHO
ARE SEEKING.
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE AS WELL
THOSE CURRENT POLICY HOLDERS AND
SO WE FEEL THIS BILL WILL HELP.
HELP WITH REGARD -- TO THE
INCREASE IN LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE RATES WE'VE BEEN
MEETING WITH CONSUMER AND
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS.
REGARDING A JUSTER REMAINING
CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL COME BACK TO
MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
DOES NOT SEEING ANY WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY THE MEMBER FLORA AND A
SECOND BY RODRIGUEZ -- WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU.
THIS IS A DO PASSED TO INSURANCE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WHAT?
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
BURKE.
I WICKS FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
THE LOAN I MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
IS THERE IN HIGH RAMOS.
RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON HIGH [inaudible] ELEVEN
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL PASSES.
I MISS MY MUM [inaudible] THREE
FOUR THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS.
AB TWELVE FORTY SIX INSURER'S
ALL CONSUMERS HAVE COMPREHENSIVE
BASIC HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS PROTECTING.
PROTECTIONS REGARDLESS OF WHICH
STATE DEPARTMENT REGULATES THEIR
HEALTH COVERAGE.
ACCORDING TO THE RECENT SERB
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL THERE ARE
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS INSURED BY
LARGE EMPLOYER COVERAGE
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE.
WHO MAY NOT HAVE THE SAME
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
BENEFITS AS OTHER CALIFORNIANS
WHOSE COVERAGE IS REGULATED BY
THE MHC?
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
CONSUMERS WITH COVERAGE
REGULATED UNDER THE KNOX KEEN
ACT.
HAVE BEEN GRANTED GUARANTEED
COVERAGE THAT PROVIDES MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE INCLUDING BASIC
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SUCH AS
DOCTOR SERVICES HOSPITAL
SERVICES EMERGENCY CARE LAB
IMOGENE AND HOSPICE CARE.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ACA THE SAME BENEFITS STANDARDS
AND PRESCRIPTION DRUG
PROTECTIONS WERE EXTENDED TO
CALIFORNIANS WITH INDIVIDUAL OR
SMALL EMPLOYER COVERAGE
REGULATED UNDER.
THE INSURANCE CODE AND THE KNOX
KEEN ACT.
AB TWELVE FORTY SIX CLOSES THE
GAP IN STATE LINE ENSURES THAT
THOSE WITH A LARGE EMPLOYER
COVERAGE REGULATED BY CDI.
ENJOY THE SAME HEALTH BENEFITS
AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT
MANY CALIFORNIANS ALREADY HAVE.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE MERRY JUNE
DS ON BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR
HEALTH AXIS CALIFORNIA.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MJ DS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA TO
SPONSORS OF AB TWELVE FORTY SIX
WHICH WOULD LEVEL UP THE PLAYING
FIELD.
AND ENSURE CALIFORNIANS WOULD
STATE REGULATED COVERAGE HAD THE
SAME CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
BENEFITS REGARDLESS OF WHO
REGULATE STIR COVERAGE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CODIFY THESE
MINIMUM BENEFITS STANDARDS IN
THE INSURANCE CODE BECAUSE UNDER
FEDERAL LAW LARGE EMPLOYER
COVERAGE ONLY HAS TO MEET
MINIMUM VALUE COVERAGE THERE SHE
HOLDS.
THAT MEANS MINIMUM VALUE
COVERAGE COULD INCLUDE VISIT
LIMITS FOR EXAMPLE.
THIS COULD MEAN HOSPITALIZATION
IS COVERED BUT IS LIMITED TO
THREE TO FIVE DAYS.
THIS CREATES GAPS IN BENEFITS
AND ALSO CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
FOR CALIFORNIANS WOULD LARGE
EMPLOYER COVERAGE IN THE CDI
VERSES DOES REGULATED BY THE
DIEM H. C..
AS NOTED BY THE CHEAPER BUT NOW
SAYS THERE WILL BE NO
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE OR IMPACT AND
BENEFIT CHANGES.
THAT MEANS THERE WILL BE NO
INCREASE IN YOUR THE STATIONS OR
PREMIUM INCREASES AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR I
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YOU HAVE TO RUN.
THE GETTING LATE I DIDN'T YOU.
MORNING GARBLED CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE -- THE ONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME ON BOARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SEVENTY WALK INS WITH
THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE HERE TO
STAY IN OPPOSITION WE'VE HAD
SOME BRIEF CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SPONSOR.
WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SHE BURKE
SAYS THAT THIS WOULD HAVE NO OR
MINIMAL IMPACT TO OUR MEMBERSHIP
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE WHAT THIS
WOULD DO IS IT WOULD TRIGGER.
A RE FILING ABOUT THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED LARGE GROUP FILINGS INTO
THE DEPARTMENT.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERN AT
JUST ABOUT WORKLOAD AND REFINE
ALL THOSE WE ALSO DO YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WHAT THIS WOULD
DO IS FOR THOSE CD I REGULATED
PRODUCTS.
IT WOULD TIE THEM TO DE MHC
REGULATIONS SO THERE WOULD BE A
QUESTION OF DUE PROCESS WITH
RESPECT TO REGULATORS.
WE ALSO WANT TO JUST.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IF THERE ARE
DEFICIENCIES WITH RESPECT TO
COVERAGE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS MAYBE
OUTSIDE OF THIS PROCESS AND SEE
IF THERE'S SOMETHING IN THE
LARGE GROUP MARKET OUR CONCERNS
WITH RESPECT TO GENERAL COVERAGE.
AS MANY OF YOU HAVE HEARD BEFORE
IN THE LARGE GROUP MARKET MANY
TIMES THOSE PRODUCTS ARE FAR
MORE ROBUST.
AND COVERAGE THAN YOU NORMALLY
SEE IN A SMALL GROUP OR
INDIVIDUAL MARKET SO AT THIS
BILL DOES MOVE FORWARD I THINK
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS CERTAINLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE IF WE'RE ADDING
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE COST
IN FILINGS INTO THE DEPARTMENT.
THERE'S A DIRECT BENEFIT TO
CONSUMERS AND RIGHT NOW WE JUST
REALLY QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY OR
THERE'S ANY DEFICIENCIES WE CAN
ADDRESS OUTSIDE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE REMAIN
OPPOSED.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER ALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS AND I WOULD JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE AND MISS HAWKINS THANK
YOU.
DONE MORE IN HIGGINS
REPRESENTING AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. TO KNOW MORE BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SEE SEE NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS.
BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT TIME LINE WITH REGARDS TO
HOW INSURERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
COMPLY SHOULD AB TWELVE FORTY
SIX BE ACTED.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THE BILL ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A MOTION AND A SECOND AND
WITHOUT THEIR THE MOBILE BUT A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
NO WE'RE WAITING.
FOR OKAY -- I WILL TAKE THAT AS
A MOTION BY MS BURKE A SECOND BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
YOU'RE FREE AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
I WICKS [inaudible]
FLORA.
LARA KNOWN LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
RAMOS ROTH AYE RODRIGUEZ RIGHT I
GUESS I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
OVER NOW. EIGHT THREE GIVE ABLE
TO BILLS THAT WILL LEAVE THE
ROAD OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU.
MISTER MCCARTY ARE YOU READY
[inaudible]
THINKING ABOUT.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE OPIOID
PREVENTION AND REHABILITATION
ACT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER AND I
MAKE IT UNLIKELY DO WELL COMING
UP HERE. TWO PRESENTS A BILL
TOGETHER BUT THAT'S IS THAT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMEDIAN
AMENDMENTS.
SO THIS IS WHAT I WANT TO PAY TO
A SCENARIO IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU BUY A MATTRESS?
A TV -- BATTERIES YOU PAY INTO
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP FUND TO PAY
FOR THE NEGATIVE EXTERNALITIES
BORN OUT OF CERTAIN PRODUCTS
THAT IMPACT OUR ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S THE SAME MENTALITY THAT
THAT WE PRESENT THIS BILL TODAY.
THIS A PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
TO TACKLE THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
AND CRISIS IS IMPACTING ALL OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS ALL OF OUR
CITIES.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT
MANUFACTURES AND WHOLESALERS
THAT SELL OR DISTRIBUTE OPIOIDS.
A REPORT ON THE AMOUNT OF THE
CELL EVERY YEAR TO DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THOSE NUMBERS
WITH SB INTO A FORMULA.
BASED UPON WHICH THEY WOULD PAY
INTO THIS OPIOID PREVENTION
REHABILITATION FUND.
WE KNOW THAT THE PROBLEM IS
SEVERE WE KNOW THAT THREE AND
FOUR RECENT HEROIN USERS GOT
THEIR START.
FROM PRESCRIPTION PAIN.
TELLS.
WE KNOW THAT OVER TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED OPIOID DEATHS OCCURRED
IN CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE LAST YEAR FIRST
FOR NUMBERS ABOUT THIS.
WILL BE OUR ROOMS ARE FILLED
ACROSS OUR STATE FLOODED WITH
OPIOID RELATED PATIENTS.
OVER FOUR THOUSAND LAST YEAR.
324-000-25000 DOLLARS PER PERSON
GOING INTO THE ER PER DAY THE
COSTS ARE TREMENDOUS HONOR
TAXPAYERS ARE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
PLACING.
ADDITIONAL BURNS AND AND IMPACTS
ON TAXPAYERS AND TAXING THE
OVERALL EMERGENCY HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
SO THIS ISSUE BASICALLY ASK A
SIMPLE QUESTION WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
WHO SHOULD PAY TO TACKLE THE
PROBLEMS CERTAINLY OUR TAXPAYERS
ARE PAYING THROUGH THE FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENT CERTAINLY
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS ARE
PAYING?
CERTAINLY ARE COUNTIES ARE
PAYING AS WELL THROUGH THEIR
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS BUT THIS
RAISES THE ISSUE SHOULD THE
INDUSTRY THAT HELPED CREATE THIS
PROBLEM HELP STEP UP.
WITH THE SOLUTION AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE PROVIDING HERE TODAY.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE FEDERAL
FUNDS CURRENTLY IN EXISTENCE TO
HELP TACKLE THIS PROBLEM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THESE FUNDS WILL EXPIRE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY WE NEED A
FINANCIAL PLAN CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND OUR EFFORTS
AS WELL AS FOCUS ON CURRENT
PROBLEMS AN ACCOUNT THAT YOU CAN
HEAR FROM IN JUST A SECOND -- I
DO HAVE SOME SOME ISSUES I WANT
TO ADDRESS YEAH I POTENTIALLY IN
THE QUEUE IN A IN OUR CLOTHES.
ON SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF THE
ISSUES RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
AND SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH
THAT LET ME INTRODUCE SOMEONE OR
GALLAGHER. TO CO.
WELL THANK YOU ALL TO HONOR TO
BE HERE -- TO PRESENT IS JOINTLY
WITH THIS HOWEVER MCCARTY WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOW.
AND I THINK WHAT I WANT TO GET
ACROSS IS -- AND I THINK MANY OF
YOU KNOW THIS IS THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC -- CERTAINLY HAS.
YOUR BEEN NATIONWIDE -- IT'S
CERTAINLY HIT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT IS ESPECIALLY
AFFECTING.
OUR RURAL AREAS OF OF THE STATE --
IN FACT IF YOU WERE TO LOOK AT A
MAP OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND SEE SOME OF THE HOT SPOTS.
THERE AND SOME OF OUR MOST --
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE -- AND
SHASTA COUNTY SISKIYOU COUNTY
BUTTE COUNTY -- THAT I REPRESENT --
AND JUST YOU KNOW TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA OF SOME OF THE STATS THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH -- IF YOU
LOOK AT THE OPIOID [inaudible]
SNAPSHOT.
THE DASHBOARD YOU CAN SEE THAT
WE ARE AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
OPIOID PER CAPITA OPIOID.
ADMISSION TO THE HOSPITAL FOR
OVERDOSES -- FOUR DEATHS RELATED
TO OPIOID OVERDOSE IS OVERDOSES --
IN BUTTE COUNTY ALONE A RECENT
STAT WAS IT THERE WERE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED PRESCRIPTIONS PER ONE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS -- AND THAT
EQUATES TO WE HAVE AN AVERAGE OF
ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY AND THEN THESE.
PRESCRIBED PER RESIDENT ANNUALLY --
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE IS -- SIX
HUNDRED FORTY SO THAT'S YOU KNOW
GIVES YOU A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH -- IN SERVE
OUR RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE.
AND WHAT IN THE WAY THAT I
APPROACH THIS ISSUE.
YOU AS A REPUBLICAN.
IS RIGHT NOW OUR TAXPAYERS ARE
SADDLED WITH THE ENTIRE COST OF
THIS BILL -- IN DEALING WITH THE
DOMESTIC ISSUES THAT HAPPEN IN
DEALING WITH.
THE ADMISSIONS TO HOSPITALS THAT
ARE ALREADY THAT ARE ALREADY
OVERLOADED AS YOU KNOW -- IN
DEALING AND THAT MOST OF THIS IS
TAKING CARE BY PUBLIC DOLLARS --
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS WHO FROM WHO OF
WHO PLAYED A ROLE.
IN CREATING THIS PROBLEM HAVE TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION AS WELL --
AND SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT I
BELIEVE.
AB.
TWENTY FORTY SIX ATTEMPTS TO DO.
WE ARE TRYING TO CREATE A FUND --
THAT THE MANUFACTURERS WOULD PAY
INTO.
THAT WOULD HELP.
ADDRESS THESE THESE HOT SPOTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED TREATMENT -- THAT I
CAN TELL YOU SOME OF THESE REAL
COMMITTEES WERE OVER TAX WE
DON'T HAVE.
WE DON'T HAVE WE SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF AND THE
CAPABILITY. TO TAKE ON THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH ADDICTION AND ALL
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED.
THERE WITH.
AND SO I THINK ALL WE'RE REALLY
ASKING IS THAT EVERYBODY PLAY A
ROLE EVERYBODY PLAY A ROLE.
IN THEIR PROPER ROLE IN TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT WE DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS OPIOID EPIDEMIC --
AND I KNOW THERE HAS BEEN SOME
CONCERN.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS BILL HAS BEEN
LABELED A JOB KILLER.
WELL LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THE
ULTIMATE JOB KILLER IS ADDICTION.
WHAT WE SEEN HIGH RATES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT AND A LOT OF IT IS
DUE TO THE ADDICTION THAT MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE ARE FACING --
AND EVERYTHING THAT THAT COMES
THERE WITH -- SO I WOULD.
I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
TO LOOK AT THIS BILL CLOSELY --
WE WE CERTAINLY ARE WANTING TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION WANTED
TO WORK AND FIND A WAY HERE --
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS NEEDED.
AND TOGETHER WE'RE GOING TO WORK
IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION -- TO
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE -- YEAH A
SOLUTION GOING FORWARD IN A
FUNDING SOURCE GOING FORWARD TO
ADDRESS -- WHAT IS TO BECOME A A
HUGE PROBLEM IN MANY OF OUR
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA WITH -- AND
WE DO HAVE A WITNESS HERE I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
BUTTE COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER WHO
CAN GIVE YOU A LOT MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION -- ANDY MILLER.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR GOOD EVENING --
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS ANNE
MILLER I AM A FAMILY PRACTICE
DOCTOR AND HE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER FOR THE COUNTY BUTTE I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND I'M IMPRESSED WITH YOUR
STAMINA -- AT THIS BILL USES AN
APPROACH -- THAT CONSIDERS THE
GREATER SOCIETAL COST OF A
COMMERCIAL PRODUCT AND THAT'S AN
APPROACH THAT'S BEEN PROVEN
EFFECTIVE IN OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES LIKE IN TOBACCO.
A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
OPIOID CRISIS THAT WE FACE
TOGETHER HAS BEEN THE MARKETING
AND MISS MARKETING.
OF OPIOID MEDICATIONS.
THESE MEDICATIONS HAVE RESULTED
IN GREAT PROFITS FOR THEIR
PRODUCERS.
BUT GREAT PUBLIC COSTS BOTH
FINANCIALLY AND IN LIVES.
HI THIS BILL BEGINS TO PLACE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY WHERE
IT LOGICALLY BELONGS.
THE OPIOID CRISIS HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
RURAL AREAS AS YOU'VE HEARD
ALREADY.
BOTH OUR COUNTRY AND OUR STATE.
IN BIãU COUNTY WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE AMONG THE WORST RATES OF
OPIOID PRESCRIPTIONS PER CAPITA
AND HOSPITALIZATION OVERDOSES.
WE'VE MADE PROGRESS LOCALLY ON
OUR DEATH RATE AND SOME OTHER
IMPORTANT RELATED MEASURES BUT
ALL OF THESE RATES ARE STILL
UNACCEPTABLY HIGH.
WHEN I TOOK THE POSITION OF
HEALTH OFFICER VIEW COUNTY TWO
AND A HALF YEARS AGO -- THE IF
YOU COUNTY RESIDENTS WERE
PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS AT THREE
TIMES THE NATIONAL RATE AS YOU
HAVE ALREADY ALLUDED.
TO HI THIS BILL INTELLIGENTLY
ADDRESSES THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE FUNDS.
ARE BASED ON THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE PROBLEM IN OUR STATE.
THIS BILL IF ENACTED WOULD JOIN
OTHER -- STATE LOCAL EFFORTS TO
DEGREES YOUR USE THIS USE --
DEATHS AND TO BOLSTER SOME MUCH
NEEDED MEDICAL TREATMENT FOR
OPIATE ADDICTION TO DATE NEARLY
ALL THE FUNDING FOR THESE
RELATED EFFORTS HAVE COME FROM
FEDERAL SOURCESAND AS YOU HEARD.
THOSE ARE DUE TO SUNSET SOON.
OUR RESOURCES DEDICATED TO
APPEAR PREVENTION AND TREATMENT
SAVES LIVES AND MONEY WHICH IS
WHY I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF IT I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVEN SO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA OUR APOLOGIES FOR NOT
GETTING OUR LETTER IN ON TIME
FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILLABLE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CONNIE DELGADO BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA'S
LIKE OF MY WORK IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
THIS CHAIRMAN WOULD MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LEE L.
LINDAHL'S WITH THE HEALTH CARE
DISTRIBUTION ALLIANCE --
REPRESENTING THIRTY FOUR PRIMARY
PHARMACEUTICAL WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTORS WERE HERE TODAY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT NEARLY
IDENTICAL TO NEW YORK LAW THAT
WAS FOUND ON CONSTITUTIONAL
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WOULD CREATE AN ARBITRARY
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
SURCHARGE.
ON WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTORS AND
MANUFACTURERS.
IN THE FEDERAL JUDGE'S DECISION
IT WAS MADE CLEAR THAT PLACING A
FINANCIAL ASSESSMENT.
I'M PRESCRIBED MEDICATIONS IS
ILL CONCEIVED AND VIOLATES THE
DORMANT COMMERCE CLAUSE OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION.
AS WELL AS COULD REDUCE THE
AVAILABILITY OF OPIOID
MEDICATIONS FOR THOSE WHO NEEDS
THEM WHICH THE JUDGE NOTED RUNS
COUNTER TO PUBLIC INTEREST.
THE COURT'S DECISION LEFT LITTLE
ROOM TO DEBATE THAT THIS IS A
PART THIS PROPOSAL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND COULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
HM IT'S MEMBERS SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF THE FEDERAL COURT
ALONG WITH PATIENT PROVIDER
ORGANIZATIONS ESTABLISHING A ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
SURCHARGE COULD INCREASE
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
AND THREATEN TO DIMINISH ACCESS
TO VITAL THERAPIES FOR
LEGITIMATE PATIENTS THOSE
PATIENTS SEEKING EPIDURAL DURING
CHILDBIRTH -- SEEKING ANESTHESIA
OR MORPHINE WHEN THEY'RE
OPERATING OR IN SURGERY AND EVEN
FOR THOSE SEEKING TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS -- ALL
OF THOSE PATIENTS UNDER THE CARE
OF LICENSE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
IN MANY INSTANCES THE PROPOSED
ASSESSMENT RESULT IN A RATE
HIGHER THAN THE COST OF THE
MEDICATIONS THEMSELVES --
THREATENING AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCESS WHEN CONSIDERING THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL IT'S
CRITICAL TO RECOGNIZE THE ROLE
WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTOR PLACE.
HM MEMBERS DO NOT RESEARCH
MANUFACTURE MARKET OR PRESCRIBE
MEDICATION NOR DO THEY INFLOWS
PRESCRIBING PATTERNS THE DEMAND
FOR SPECIFIC PRODUCT OR PATIENT
BENEFIT DESIGN.
WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTOR SIMPLY
ENSURE THE SAFEST MOST EFFICIENT
DELIVERY OF MEDICAL PRODUCT TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES INCLUDING
SEVENTY THOUSAND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THE MEDICATIONS BEING
DISTRIBUTED ARE BASED SOLELY ON
ORDERS FROM DE A LICENSED
PROVIDERS PHARMACIES AND
HOSPITALS.
ORIGINATING FROM PRESCRIPTIONS
WRITTEN BY LICENSED PHYSICIANS.
DUE TO THE STRUCTURE OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN THE LEGISLATION A
PREDOMINATELY PENALIZE THE
WHOLESALER.
AFTER THE FIRST AND SEE MAKING A
TRANSACTION INTO THE STATE.
HM IT'S MEMBER SUPPORT POLICIES
THE DECREASE OF YOUR DEMAND AND
DISPENSING WHILE ALSO ENSURING
LEGITIMATE PATIENTS MAINTAIN
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE TREATMENTS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY PLACING --
FINANCIAL ASSESSMENT ON
WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTORS FOR
COMPLETING ORDERS OF TRUSTED
MEDICAL PROS PROFESSIONALS
PLACES THIS INDUSTRY IN A VERY
DIFFICULT POSITION AND FOR THAT
WE ASK YOU TO OPPOSE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU.
PETER CALLOUSED ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ASSOCIATION --
WHILE THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS
LAUDABLE AND WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND GALLAGHER THE
HOSPICE ASSOCIATION MUST AND
HAPPILY OPPOSE THE BILL -- THE
REASON BEING IS THAT HOSPICE IS
A CAPITATED BENEFIT THEY ARE AT
RISK FOR EVERYTHING THAT THEY
SPEND IN CARE FOR THE TERMINALLY
ILL. FOR THOSE PATIENTS WHO ARE
AT THE END OF LIFE MORPHINE.
OPIOIDS ARE A PART OF HOW CARE
IS PROVIDED -- DATED DAY BY DAY
HOUR BY HOUR MORPHINE IS
ADJUSTED TO ENSURE THAT THE
PATIENTS ARE RECEIVING ENOUGH --
TO BE COMFORTED IN THEIR FINAL
DAYS.
WE KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR HAS MADE
A LEGITIMATE ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
AVOID THE COSTSBEING PASSED
DOWN THE FOR THE CHAIN WE DO NOT
SEE HOW THAT WILL BE PRACTICAL
IN THE LONG RUN.
IF MANY AFFECT FEWER
MANUFACTURERS PARTICIPATE MAKING
MORPHINE OR OPIOID PRODUCTS
SECONDLY LOOKING AT NEW YORK AT
THE SITUATION THERE THAT CLAUSE
WAS NOT SUSTAINED WE BELIEVE THE
COSTS WILL BE PASSED DOWN AND
THAT WOULD BE.
IT WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT
HOSPICES ABILITY TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING QUALITY CARE TO THE
TERMINALLY ILL. FOR THESE
REASONS WE MUST REGRETFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MICHELLE
REVERSE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION WE TOO
MUST REGRETFULLY OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE SEE PAGE HIS BEEN I
THINK A GOOD PARTNER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR COLLEAGUES
AND HEALTH CARE TRYING.
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BUT WE
DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS THE
RIGHT APPROACH WE'RE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES WERE
ALREADY BEING SQUEEZED OUT OF
THE MARKET DOING DUE TO LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES BY PPM SET
SET TRY.
THEY'RE ALREADY HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME MAINTAINING STOCK
FOR A NUMBER OF MEDICATIONS AND
WHILE WE DO ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
GOAL TO PREVENT.
THIS COSTS FROM BEING PASSED ON
TO THE PURCHASER WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND PURCHASED SO THERE IS THE
PHARMACIST.
SO THEY WILL BEAR THE BURDEN OF
THIS WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUES WITH -- THE
DISTRIBUTORS AND THE
MANUFACTURERS WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A WAY.
TO ENFORCE THE THE PROVISION OF
THE BILL AGAIN WHICH ATTEMPTS TO
PROHIBIT THE PASSING DOWN OF
THIS TAX ON TO THE END PURCHASER
AND AGAIN THAT BE IN THE
COMMUNITY PHARMACISTS.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THIS
MEDICATION WILL BECOME
UNAFFORDABLE FOR PHARMACISTS TO
BE ABLE TO START.
MAKING IT DIFFICULT AND IN SOME
CASES IMPOSSIBLE FOR PATIENTS TO
BE ABLE TO A CAR THE MEDICATIONS
WE KNOW THERE'S A PROBLEM OUT
THERE BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE STATE
WHO HAVE LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
NEEDS AND WHO NEED THAT PAIN
MEDICATION.
AND IT'S BECOMING INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO AND TO GET
THE MEDICATIONS THAT THEY NEED
SO WITHOUT MY WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO FILE.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MORGAN HAGEN'S REPRESENTING BY A
COMMON OPPOSITION AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION COULD
BE HERE BUT THEY ARE ALSO POST.
FRED NO OR REPRESENTING PHARMA
AND WE ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KAREN SARKISIAN WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WERE OPPOSED.
I ALWAYS AT ALLWITH CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COLLISION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE KNOWN BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MR BONTA.
THANK YOU TO OUR OFFICE FOR
BRINGING FORWARD -- THIS
IMPORTANT BILL I WANT JUST ASK A
QUICK QUESTION ABOUT THE
REFERENCE TO THE NEW YORK.
LITIGATION AND THE STATE OF NEW
YORK'S OPIOID STEWARDSHIP ACT
THAT IT HAD.
YEAH I'M CAN YOU COMMENT A
LITTLE BIT ON ON HOW YOUR BILL
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT THAN THAT
THAT NEW YORK -- FOR WHICH THERE
WAS A ANALYSIS AROUND THE
DORMANT COMMERCE CLAUSE AND ALSO
MADE A COMMENT ON ANY
SEVERABILITY COMPONENT YOU HAVE
YOUR BILL.
WELL TO THINK SO OUR PROPOSAL
WAS BASED LOOSELY ON THAT THE
NEW YORK PROPOSAL.
A LOWER COURT STRUCK DOWN THAT
PIECE THE STATE OF NEW YORK DID
FILE AN APPEAL TWO MONTHS AGO SO
IT'S GOING TO THE PROCESS.
BUT PLANNING FOR THE WORST WE
HAVE INCLUDED IN THE LEGISLATION
A SEVERABILITY CLAUSE SO IF THIS
AT PEACE -- BECOMES INVALID THIS
WOULD WOULD BE KNOCKED OUT BUT
THE REST THE BILL WOULD GO
[inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS.
CONCERNS.
SO I JUST COM COM COMMENTS --
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH YOU
CLOSE THE ON THIS -- MISTER
MCCARTY AND RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE THERE ARE STILL SOME
UNRESOLVED ISSUES HERE --
HOWEVER -- NO ONE CAN QUESTION
YOUR INTENT AS FAR AS TRIED IT
AND AND MISTER GALLAGHER AND AND
AND TRYING TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
HELP STE -- HELP PROTECT PEOPLE
AND BEGIN TO STEM THE CRISIS AS
MUCH AS WE CAN -- YOU DO ENJOY
IT A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND
I I ONCE I SAY I YEAH WE'VE BEEN
FOR WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING ON YOUR
GOOD ISSUE.
THE TWO OF US ALL OF US FOR YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN THIS IS MY FIFTH
YEAR AS AS IT IS WITH YOU WITH
YOU GUYS AND WE'RE OUT WE ALSO
BROUGHT STRUGGLING WITH THIS AND
AND THERE ARE NO MAGIC BULLETS
AND AND AS WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
ON THIS -- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT -- COMES UP IN THE BILL --
AND THIS IS SOMETHING ONLY
CLARIFICATION GOING FOR TO GOT
IT DIDN'T COME WITH THE LANGUAGE
BECAUSE BACKING FOR TWIN
MANUFACTURES OR WHOLESALERS.
AS WE NEED TO CLARIFY IS IT IS
IT BOTH IS IT ONE OR THE OTHER
AND AND SO THERE'S SOME THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT CLEANER WORK TO DO
THERE AS WELL -- AND AND ALSO WE
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW AS IF IF
AS THE BILL IS ENVISIONED IN YOU
ACTUALLY BEGIN TO SEE A DECREASE --
THAT THAT THAT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS NUMBER THAT YOU'RE
TARGETING SHOULD BE DECREASING
AS WELL -- SO THAT THERE AS AS
YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE ARE
NOT PAYING FOR MORE -- IN THE
THE PEOPLE STILL PAYING OR NOT
PAYING MORE -- YOU'RE ACTUALLY
MOVING IN THERE IN THE IN THE
LOWER LOWER COST DIRECTION SO.
SO I EIGHT YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THERE THERE'S CONTINUES TO BE
WORK ON TO DO ON THIS BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE TWO OF YOU -- LIKE
MYSELF OR PASSIONATE ABOUT DOING
WHAT WE CAN TO TO HELP STE TO
HELP PROTECT PEOPLE AND STEM THE
STEM THE PROPER STEM THE TIDE SO
TO SPEAK -- IT IS IN THAT SPIRIT
THAT I A OFFER A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- AND THAT WOULD
GIVE YOU TO AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE
IF YOU'D LIKE.
SURE FOR FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH US FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND AND YOU KNOW
THIS ISSUE ISN'T GOING AWAY BUT
WE DO KNOW WE DO WE DO NEED MORE.
TREATMENT AND SERVICES FOR OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO HAVE WHO
ARE ADDICTED.
WE KNOW THAT ALL EOPLE TAKING
PAIN KILLERS DON'T GO TO HEAR
WHEN WE DO NOT PEOPLE THAT ARE
ON HERE ONE THREE AND FOUR OF
THEM.
CAME FROM PAIN KILLERS IT'S A
REAL PROBLEM IN THE FEDERAL
MONEY IS GOING TO RUN OUT.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO STEP UP
AS WELL HE SAYS SHOULD JUST BE
BORN THE TAXPAYERS ARE SHOULD
THE INDUSTRY.
PARTICIPATE AS MR GALLAGHER SAID
SO THAT'S THE SOLUTION WE HAVE
HERE THAT THE DOLLAR AMOUNT IN
THERE FOR A HUNDRED MILLION.
THAT'S JUST THAT'S A STARTING
PLACE ORDER PLAN IT MAY NOT BE
THE FOR THE FINAL -- NUMBER THAT
WE HAVE DOWN THERE AS WE GO DOWN
SO WE'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED.
YOU DO BRING UP A GREAT POINT
SUCH AS WITH THE TOBACCO TAX
HOPEFULLY THE PARTICIPATION RATE.
WITHOUT WITH TOBACCO PAINKILLERS
WILL GO DOWN.
SO WHERE WHERE WE WILL PUT IN
THE AND THE MEASURE OF CLOSET AT
IS GOES AS IT GOES DOWN THE
NUMBER IN THE FUND WILL GO DOWN --
ACCORDINGLY AS WELL IT WILL IT
WILL FACE DOWN.
AND THEN -- ON THE ON THE ENDS
VERSES THE ORDER IT'S THE THE
INTENT THAT.
THE FIRST PLACE IT TOUCHES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY RIGHT NOW
IT'S AS INDOOR BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY CLARIFY THAT AS WE GO
ON AND AGAIN WE'RE WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO TALK WITH -- OTHER
PARTNERS ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES AND THAT THEIR CONCERNS.
WITH THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- MISTER GARVEY HAVING. TO
COME UP JUST REALLY BRIEFLY --
YEAH I THINK WE HAD A LOT OF THE
POINTS -- IN ON WHY THIS IS A
WORTHY -- OBJECTIVE IN AGAIN WE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
OBVIOUSLY.
TO AND HELP ENSURE THESE COSTS
ARE PASSED ON TO PEOPLE WHO WERE
OBVIOUSLY LEGITIMATELY USING
OPIOIDS FOR FOR PAIN AND FOR
PALETTE OF KERR ALL THOSE THINGS.
BUT YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T IGNORE
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM YOU
KNOW WHICH IS THAT WE HAVE A
HUGE JOB YOU A CRISIS.
AND SOMEONE WHO WASN'T HERE BUT
WHO HAVE HAD SOME ME OF GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIS OUR
SHERIFF IN BUTTE COUNTY -- WHO
IS SEEN YEAH?
THIS RELATED TO ALSO CRIMES --
THAT THERE IS THIS RELATIONSHIP
OBVIOUSLY FROM MOBILE IT'S TO
HEROIN AND ALSO WHAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY TALKED ABOUT TO FEDERAL --
IN WHAT WERE SEEN YOU KNOW SOME
SOME HUGE PROBLEMS THEY'RE AS
THAT IS THAT DRUG IS COMING.
INTO OUR STATE AND WERE HAVING
MIA OVERDOSES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT AND SO.
BUT IT ALL STEMS TO PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW AS AS A SAID THREE AND
FOUR PEOPLE GETTING HOOKED ON
THIS JUST.
STARTED ON PAIN PILLS.
AND I THINK THE OTHER THING IS
THIS THIS IS HAPPENING TO YOUR
NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR.
THIS IS HAPPENING THIS IS
HAPPENING.
TO THE MOTHER RECOVERING.
FROM CHILDBIRTH TO WHO TAKES
THESE PILLS FOR PAIN AND THE
GETS HOOKED ON THEM -- AND YEAH
THIS IS THIS IS HAPPENING TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE -- AND AND MAYBE
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT.
BUT IT'S BUT THEY DO ARE ENDING
UP ADDICTED AND AND HOSPITALS.
AND IS BECOMING A VERY HUGE
BURDEN ON LAW ENFORCEMENT ON OUR
HOSPITALS ARE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WHAT ABOUT ALL THOSE COSTS.
YOU KNOW AND RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
THAT'S BEEN IT'S IT'S BEING
BORNE BY YOU IN INSURANCE
PREMIUMS.
BECAUSE I GUARANTEE YOUR
INSURANCE PREMIUMS ARE GOING UP
BECAUSE OF THESE
HOSPITALIZATIONS -- SO WE'RE ALL
PAIN.
BUT WE'RE JUST SAYING HEY
ANOTHER PERSON.
AT THE TABLE SHOULD BE PAYING
AND CONTRIBUTING TOWARDS US AS
WELL.
AND WE THINK THAT THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS RIGHTFULLY NEED TO
BE PAINTED TO HELPING SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SIR
MOTION [inaudible]
SO.
THE MOTION BY MISTER IS THERE IN
A SECOND BY MISTER BONTA TO
ENJOY THE TO PASS A
RECOMMENDATION -- YOU'VE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS -- SO
THE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
SENATOR CORY NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I WICKS.
FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
I MCCARTY HI MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE ROLES.
FROM US NO.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
CENTER FIVE WALDRON.
WATER NO.
YES SEVEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN -- ACTUALLY THE BILL A
CALL EXCUSE ME I DON'T THINK
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU TO WITNESSES --
MISTER SANTIAGO.
SO IS THERE SUCH A YOU HAVE A
YOU'RE PRESENTING FOR MR GARCIA
AND AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN AND THEN YOUR OWN.
EIGHTY FOUR OH SEVEN WHAT IT.
WOULD BE OKAY WITH THE CHAIR
FIBER -- BEGIN WITH THEM MR
GARCIA'S BILL YES ABSOLUTELY SIR.
AND I'LL KEEP THEM.
YEAH MOTION A SECOND A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN IS A
CLEAN A BILL THAT AB.
TWO SIX TWO I RESPECTFUL -- WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS WILL ALSO BE
BRIEF AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EITHER MR.
I WOULD BE VERY -- HELLO MY NAME
IS LIZ ALLEN I'M THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE C<c.cyan> ALLIANCE</c>
THE COOK ALLIANCE WAS THE
PRIMARY SPONSOR OF AB SIXTY SIX
THE HOMEMADE FOOD OPERATIONS ACT --
AND WAS WORKING ON LEGALIZING
HOME COOKING FOR THREE YEARS WE
REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF COOKS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER'S FARMERS
SMALL BUSINESS SUPPORTERS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS.
LEGALIZING HOME COOKING AS A
BROAD SUPPORT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
IN FACT LAST YEAR SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE SIGNED A PETITION.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE CALL THE
ROAD THERE LIKE IT OFFICIALS IN
OVER A HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS.
SIGNED ON IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIXTY SIX SINCE AB SIXTY SIX ONE
TWO AFFECT IN JANUARY WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH COUNTIES INTERESTED
ON INFO ON IMPLEMENTING THIS --
IN ISSUING HOME COOKING PERMITS
HOWEVER IT'S KIND OF BEEN REALLY
SLOW TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN CONFUSION
AROUND BOTH JURISDICTIONAL
ISSUES.
AND SOME PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIREMENTS.
SO IT THIS BILL SO THIS IS
SIGNIFICANTLY SLOW THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN MANY COUNTIES
EFFECTIVELY BLOCKING THIS THIS
NEW OPPORTUNITY FOR THOUSANDS OF
COOKS EVEN THOUGH THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THIS AB SIXTY
SIX UNANIMOUSLY LAST YEAR.
HE SUPPORTERS CONTINUE TO BE
EXCITED TO EMBRACE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE BELIEVE THAT
AB THREE SEVEN SEVEN ONE BLOCK
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SIXTY SIX
BECAUSE IT CREATES MORE CLARITY.
AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH AND HOW IT
COUNTIES AND OF COURSE THE FOUR
CITIES -- CAN OPT INTO THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
THANKS TO THE TIRELESS
COLLABORATION BETWEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS AND HOME
COOKING ADVOCATES THREE SEVEN
SEVEN ACTUALLY REPRESENTS ALL
INTERESTS.
AND THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH SAFEGUARDS
EXPEDITED OPTION AND LESSEN THE
RISK OF UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
COURSE ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT
ALLOWING HOME COOKS WHICH ARE
MOSTLY WOMEN IMMIGRANTS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR TO USE THEIR
SKILLS. TO GENERATE INCOME.
AND BRIEFLY JUST TO GO OVER WITH
THE BILL CALL CALL -- FLIES --
IT SAYS IT SAYS WHICH
JURISDICTIONS ARE ABLE TO OFTEN
AT TALKS ABOUT HOW STANDARDS FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY SHALL BE
IMPLEMENTED TO PROTECT COOKS AND
CONSUMERS.
CLARIFIES HOW INSPECTIONS ARE
CONDUCTED -- TALK ABOUT
EXPECTATIONS FOR ADVERTISING AND
MAKES IT CLEAR TO CHELATION OF
THE FACT THAT HOME KITCHEN
OPERATORS CAN'T USE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY SERVICE AS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA FROM A TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP PLANS WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THERESA BROKERAGE WITH THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS WE JUST WHEN I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING ON
THE IMPORTANT ISSUE AND THINK
THE SPONSORS FOR SPONSORING THIS
THANK YOU.
CAN'T TO BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATT JORGENSEN FROM THE CLIENTS
IN OAKLAND HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT. TO
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE JUST
RIGHT WAYS -- DAVE JONES ABOUT
CITY SOUTH PASADENA -- THEY
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE UNDERLYING BILL AND WE
THOUGHT THAT THE DIRECTION THE
BILL WAS TO ALLOW JURISDICTIONS
TO OPT OUT.
BY THEIR CHOICE THE WITH THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED IN THE
COUNTY CHIU STOPPED AND AND THE
CITY OF TRACY OPTED OUT. FOR YOU
SEE WOULD AUTOMATICALLY BE IN
THE BILL SO THE WEIGHTS BILLS
CURRENTLY CRAFTED IF YOU HAVE
JURISDICTION THEY DIDN'T THINK
THEY HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL
LIKE SELF PASSED VERY SMALL --
NOT SEE A LOT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ATTENTION FROM LA COUNTY -- THEY
WOULDN'T DON'T FEEL LIKE IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE THING FOR THIS
DECISION TO BE MADE FOR THAT
BECAUSE THE BILL MAKES IT VERY
CLEAR.
THAT IF YOU -- IF THE COUNTY OF
LA OPT IN NO SNOW LOCAL
JURISDICTION IN LA COUNTY CAN
OPT OUT.
SO THOSE ARE BASIC CONCERNS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD QUESTIONS FROM DIVERSE.
WAS NOT A QUESTION JUST A
COMMENT IS A FANTASTIC BILL NO
I'M IN FACT -- IF YOU BELIEVE IN
LIBERTY THIS GETS MORE LIBERTY
IF YOU BELIEVE IN SMALL
BUSINESSES THIS ACTUALLY HELP
SMALL BUSINESS PEOPLE STARTING --
THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL I'D
LOVE TO BE I KNOW YOU'RE NOT THE
AUTHORED MIGUEL BUT I'D LOVE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR -- IT'S
IMPORTANT MID TO RELAYING THAT
COMMENT YEAH.
NICELY DONE TODAY BY THE WAY.
OTHER OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
SEE SEE NONE WILL -- I WAS IT
WILL ASK THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS -- OF THE IT AS THE
BILL AS IF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD BUT THAT WAS NOT
SOMETHING THAT I WAS AWARE OF SO
THAT THAT WAS A CONCERN SO IF I
MISSED IT I APOLOGIZE BUT BUT
THE BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- AND WE WILL
ASK THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO LOOK
LOOK AT THAT ISSUE GOING FORWARD
SO -- LOOKING FOR WE HAVE A
MOTION -- MY MISTER FLORA A
SECOND BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER SANTIAGO
THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
PREPARATIONS ARE SUCH LAST WHEN
I VOTE -- MR TRIPLET CALL THE
ROLL.
WHAT HI WHEN I MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE AGAR CURRY?
NOW HERE CURRY I BIGELOW.
HELLO I BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
BURKE I WICKS.
WICKS HI FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN.
THE ONE I'M VOTING MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
HI.
I RAMOS.
ROSE AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
HI SANTIAGO HI WALDRON
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT HAS THIRTEEN VOTES A
BILLABLE LEVINE WHO LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON MR
SUCH AS WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL AB.
FOUR OH SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
I'LL ATTEMPT TO BE BRIEF AND AND
THEREFORE IT'S JUST SAY THAT I
WANT EXCEPT THE IN -- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- WE OF WITNESSES
WILL ALSO BE BRIEF BUT ADDRESS
THE ISSUE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH I THANK HIM STONE
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION WITH THE CHAIRS AND
DALTON SO MAKE BRIEF REMARKS ON
THAT I WILL TAKE FROM OUR SECOND
WITNESSES TIME.
THAT -- THIS BILL ALLOWS AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY FOR DOCTORS AND
PODIATRISTS IN CALIFORNIA.
HAVE PERMISSION TO USE FLORA
SKIPPY IN SURGERY.
THE CURRENT -- PROCESS BY WHICH
YOU HAVE TO TAKE A STATE
CERTIFIED TEST IS CUMBERSOME FOR
OUT OF STATE DOCTORS BECAUSE
THAT TESTING PROCESS BECAUSE OF
MEAN -- IT'S UP TO SIX MONTHS
WARNING OUT OF STATE POSITION.
AT TO GET THAT CERTIFICATION
PROCESS BECAUSE SOME NEW
REQUIREMENTS IN CALIFORNIA ON
HOSPITALS AND OUTPATIENT SURGERY
CENTERS NOW REQUIRE ANNUAL
TRAINING.
OF PHYSICIANS REGARDING --
FLUOROSCOPY AND PATIENT HEALTH
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW BACK
ANNUAL TRAINING TO SUBSTITUTE
FOR TAKING IN PASSING THAT TEST
AS WELL AS FOR ONGOING MEDICAL
EDUCATION -- I WILL PASS THIS
OVER -- TO DR AND RUSSELL NORD
AND THEN -- JESSE SCOTT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ARE ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS
RUSSELL NORTON -- ORTHOPEDIC
SURGEON PRACTICING IN BONTA
ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M ALSO THE
LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS OUR
STATES ORTHOPEDIC SURGEONS.
SO JUST AS AN INTRODUCTION FOR
OSCAR B. IS ESSENTIALLY AN X.
RAY WITH SOME SPECIAL FEATURES --
SPECIFICALLY IT ALLOWS REAL TIME
IMAGING WITH THERE'S NO DELAY
AFTER ACTUALLY SHOT BEFORE THE
IMAGES SEEN.
SECONDLY IT'S EXTREMO BILE WITH
MULTIPLE DEGREES OF FREEDOM AN
AXE AND MANEUVERABILITY WHICH
MAKES IT VERY USEFUL TO GET
SPECIFIC X. REVIEWS ON A PATIENT
WHO'S A MOBILE SUCH AS ONE ON
THE OPERATING ROOMS DURING
SURGERY.
THIRDLY -- THE FROST MACHINE WE
USED TO DO LIVE ACTUARIES WERE
RATHER JUST GETTING A STATIC
IMAGE -- ON AN X. RAY YOU CAN
ACTUALLY DO A SHORT VIDEO WHICH
CAN BE VERY IMPORTANT IN DOING
CERTAIN SURGICAL PROCEDURES. FOR
THESE REASONS FOR US TO BE HAS
BECOME A CRITICAL AND
UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED TOOL WITH
AN ORTHOPEDIC SURGERY AS WELL AS
OTHER SPECIALTIES WITHIN
MEDICINE.
AND IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS
I ALLUDED TO IN THE OPERATING
ROOM.
IN FACT IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE
WHO'S EVER HAD A SURGERY FOR A
BROKEN BONE WITH SOME METAL AND
PLANTED IT'S ALMOST CERTAIN THE
FEROCITY WOULD HAVE BEEN USED
DURING THAT PROCEDURE -- WE
HANDED OUT SOME X. REVIEWS --
THAT SHOW FIRST A HIP FRACTURE
IN THE ONE I IMAGE WITHOUT ANY
METAL OR WHITE IN IT.
ON OF THOSE WERE DISTRIBUTED.
BUT ANYWAY -- THEY MAKE THE
ENEMY THANK YOU.
AND THE OTHER IMAGE SHOWS -- THE
REPAIRED BONE WITH A ROD AND
SOME SCREWS IN PLACE THE
FLUOROSCOPY IS CRITICAL DURING
THE SURGERY TO DO THIS FIRST TO
MAKE SURE THE BONES ARE ALIGNED
PROPERLY BEFORE THE PLACE IN THE
HARDWARE.
AND SECONDLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THE HARDWARE IS IMPLANTED
PROPERLY -- SO THAT THE BONES
WITH YOUR WHOLE CORRECTLY.
ON THE CORRECT POSITION AND NONE
OF THE HARDWARE WILL BE
PROMINENT IN THIS INSURES THAT
THE PATIENT RECOVERS WELL HAS
GOOD FUNCTION.
AND DOESN'T REQUIRE SECONDARY
SURGERIES.
SO HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
EVERYONE AGREES IT FOR US TO BE
AS NECESSARY AND ONE ALSO AGREES
THAT HAS TO BE USED SAFELY.
WHICH IS WHY PHYSICIANS WHO USE
FOR US TO BE I HAVE EXTENSIVE
TRAINING IN MEDICAL SCHOOL AND
RESIDENCY FOR THIS.
THE PROBLEM IS THE CURRENT
PROCESS FOR FLUOROSCOPIC
CERTIFICATION TESTING IN
CALIFORNIA IS PROBLEMATIC WHEN
ORTHOPEDIC SURGEONS MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA FROM OTHER STATES
OFTEN TO UNDERSERVED AREAS.
WELL THEY RECEIVE THEIR
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL LICENSE THE
FLASK WE CERTIFICATION
PROCESSING OFTEN TAKES LONGER
PRECLUDING THE SURGEON FROM
TAKING THE EMERGENCY ROOM CALL.
THAT THEY'VE BEEN BROUGHT INTO
TAKE BECAUSE TO TREAT THOSE
PATIENTS IN THAT YEAR WITH THE
FRACTURES -- THE NEED TO HAVE
THE FEROCITY CERTIFICATION TO DO
THE SURGERY -- TO TREAT THOSE
INJURIES
NOW OFTENTIMES THESE OR THE
PEAKS WITH HIS HAVE USED FOR US
TO BE IN OTHER STATES FOR MANY
YEARS WITHOUT NEEDING A SPECIAL
CERTIFICATION WHEN THEY COME TO
CALIFORNIA THIS IS NEEDED.
AND A RETREATS A BARRIER THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION IS GONE COMPLAINTS
FROM WITH BIG SURGE OF THE
PROCESS OF TAKING THE TEST ME
CUMBERSOME.
AND TAKE UP TO SIX MONTHS WE'VE
HEARD COMPLAINTS FROM NAPA
FRESNO REDLANDS SANTA BARBARA
CAPITAL SAM CISCO LOS ANGELES.
AS WELL AS OTHER AREAS WE SEE IS
A STATEWIDE PROBLEM THE DELAYS
ACCESS TO CARE.
ALL THE OTHER STATES IN THE
UNION HAVE BEEN ABLE. TO SAFELY
USE LOST WITHOUT THE SORT OF
PROCESS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TO HELP US MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD SO WE CAN
JOIN THAT GROUP THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OTHER SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JESSE SCOTT IN THE
ADMINISTRATOR AT PRESIDIO
SURGERY CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND LAST YEAR JOINT COMMISSION
WHO SURPRISEUS CAME OUT WITH A
NEW REQUIREMENT FOR US TO
DEVELOP AN EDUCATION MODULE FOR
THE PHYSICIANS AND FOR THE STAFF.
ARE THEY POINTED US IN THAT
EDUCATION MODULE TO IMAGE GENTLY
AN IMAGE WISELY WHICH ARE WHAT
THE RADIOLOGY SOCIETIES HAVE PUT
OUT AS FAR AS THE EDUCATION THEY
WANT.
INFORMATION FROM THOSE SITES AND
THEN HAD OUR CONSULTANT
RADIOLOGIST PUT IN INFORMATION
SPECIFIC TO THE MACHINES THAT
THE PHYSICIANS WOULD USE AT OUR
CENTER.
AND THAT'S NOT PART OF OUR
ORIENTATION FOR ANY NEW POSITION
COMING ON AS WELL AS FOR STAFF
OR ANY KIND OF LICENSED
INDEPENDENT PRACTITIONER.
AND IT'S PUT OUT ANNUALLY FOR
REVIEW WE WOULD IT WILL BE IT
WILL BE ANNUAL WE HAVEN'T DONE
IT YET BECAUSE IT'S NEW.
BUT IT WILL GET UPDATED ANNUALLY
AND RE SENT OUT TO THE
PHYSICIANS WHO ATTEST THAT
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH IT AGAIN --
SO IT'S NOT A HARDSHIP FOR THE
FACILITY TO DO [inaudible]
THROUGH MUCH.
OTHERS THE SUPPORT.
SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRETTY AFTER MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WHERE THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
DIANNE CHIP YOU TO SKI I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
TRY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS MIGHT HAVE
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANKS.
MR TURN MEMBERS BOB ACURA BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RADIOLOGICAL
SOCIETY.
WE'RE GOING TO WE WERE OPPOSED
WE OF UNDERSTAND THE THE
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE COMPLEX IS
THE PROCESS WOULD WELCOME -- ANY
REFORM THAT EFFORT THE TEST IS
ADMINISTERED BY AN OUTSIDE
NATIONALIZATION.
WAS THE WEARABLE THE TIME FRAME
ISSUES BUT CERTAINLY THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WOULD SUPPORT --
REVISIONS ON THE TEST ITSELF IS
SOMETHING THE MEASURE THE
COMPETENCY THE POSITION THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF RADIATION SAFETY
AND RADIATION DOSE -- AS THE
ORTHOPEDIC SURGEON TESTIFIED FOR
OSCAR B. AS A REAL TIME IMAGE
STANDING ON THAT PEDAL TOO LONG
EXPOSE THE PATIENT NECESSARILY
TO EXCESS RADIATION.
AS WELL AS POSITION THEMSELVES
SO HAVING THAT KNOWLEDGE WE
THINK IS ESSENTIAL TO
APPROPRIATE -- USE OF THE
EQUIPMENT FOR IN PATIENT
PROTECTION.
THE PHILOSOPHY PERMIT WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
BECAUSE THE PERCEPTION THAT
TRAINING EDUCATION WAS ON EVEN
IN THE STATE SO MODEL SYLLABUS
WAS DEVELOPING A TEST WAS
CREATED.
BUT HAS BEEN MODIFIED THE PASS
RATE IS 83% THE LAST TWO YEARS
SO I WAS OF THE TEST ITSELF IS
NOT AN IMPEDIMENT GETTING TO THE
TEST SEEMS TO BE THE PROBLEM.
SO WOULD WELCOME THAT EFFORT TO
REFORM IT THINK THE PERMIT
PROCESS IS LEGITIMATE REGIONAL
FOR PATIENT PROTECTION.
THE NEW JAYCO REQUIREMENTS ARE
HEADING TOWARDS MORE
DOCUMENTATION NOT LESS SO I
THINK CALIFORNIA MAY HAVE BEEN
OUT IN FRONT OF THIS ISSUE BUT
PROBABLY OTHER STATES GOING TO
CATCH UP.
IN TERMS OF THE REQUIREMENTS ARE
TO BE PLACED OPPOSITION SO
REGRETFULLY REPOSE THE CURRENT
VERSION THANK YOU.
Q. QUESTIONS CONCERN FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR MAKES.
YOU KNOW THESE THINGS ARE --
SPEED OF DIFFICULT THE BOMB.
AND IN I ALWAYS WONDER IT'S
ALWAYS THE QUESTION WHY THE
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY WOULD WOULD
BE OPPOSE IS IT.
IS IT TRULY BECAUSE OF THIS
PERMIT PROCESS OR IS THERE SOME
OTHER ECONOMIC INTEREST ON THAT
IS GUIDING OF THE IT GOT IN THE
OPPOSITION -- SO IT IS OR
SOMEONE A WORKAROUND IS TO GET
YOU TO SUPPORT.
WELL I I DON'T THINK WE WOULD
THERE'S NO ECONOMIC AUTOMATION A
RADIOLOGIST OF THE PRIMARY
PROVIDERS IMAGE SERVICES YOU
KNOW AND PROBABLY DO A FAIR
AMOUNT OF FLUOROSCOPY BUT IN THE
SURGERY SUITE IS THE SURGEON
DOING IT.
AND THE PODIATRY -- SURGICAL
OFFICE IT'S A PODIATRIST WE
ALL WE'RE SAYING IS THAT
PHYSICIAN AND THE PATIENT SHOULD
HAVE.
A PRACTITIONER KNOWLEDGEABLE OF
RADIATION DOSE AND SAFETY IT'S
NOT SOMETHING IT'S INDICATIVE OF
THOSE SPECIALTIES IT IS FOR
RADIOLOGY.
BUT THE TEST AND 83% PASS IS NOT
AN IMPEDIMENT.
AND SEEMS TO BE REASONABLE IN
TERMS OF EDUCATION SO.
IT'S REALLY A MATTER OF GETTING
TO A POINT WHERE THE PHYSICIAN
CAN ACCOMPLISH THE PERMANENT
TIMELY BASIS AND WE WOULD
SUPPORT THAT -- THAT'S MORE THE
BUREAUCRACY AND NOT SOMETHING WE
CONTROL -- IMAGE WISE IT WAS
MENTIONED RADIOLOGIST THE
FOREFRONT OF REDUCING THE DOSE
MAKING THE DOES THE MINIMUM
NECESSARY TO ACCOMPLISH THE
DIAGNOSTIC PURPOSE.
SO WE'RE NOT THERE'S NOTHING
HERE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO RUN
OTHER PHYSICIANS FROM PRACTICING
AT ALL.
THE ANSWERS A QUESTION WOULD
IMAGES TO THE I THINK THE
RADIOLOGIST SO OBVIOUSLY --
SPECIALISTS BY HERE AND HAVE THE
THE KNOWLEDGE IN ANY INSIGHT --
AND AND SO IT'S TO ME IT'S IT'S
IT'S A CONCERN THAT YOU GUYS ARE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS AND I'M JUST
WONDERING.
IF THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE TO BE
ABLE TO GET -- YOU KNOW TO WHERE
YOU GUYS CAN GET TO A SUPPORT
POSITION.
I DON'T KNOW IS THAT THE AUTHOR
OF YOU GUYS HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WE CONTINUE TO KEEP WORKING WITH
THEM TO WELL -- I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
THEY LET LET ME FIRST START OFF
BY SAYING THAT I WOULD BE WITH
ANY STANDARDS TRAINING SAFETY.
A MEASURE THAT AT THAT -- THAT
THEY WOULD PUT ON THE TABLE --
WHEN I AGREED TO TAKE THE BILL I
KIND OF I CAN LOOK AT THIS AND
THOUGHT IT WAS AND -- GOOD
EFFICIENCY BILL SO IF YOU HAVE
TESTING THAT IT THAT THAT IS
STATE MANDATED IN NOW THE
HOSPITALS HAVE TO DO THIS SORT
OF TRAINING.
EVERY YEAR -- WE CAN EASILY WORK
ON CHANGING THE TRAINING AT THE
HOSPITAL IF THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT THAT IS SEEN IS DEFICIENT --
FROM THE RADIOLOGIST PERSPECTIVE
BUT WHY IF THE TRAINING OF THE
HOSPITAL AND THE DOCTOR HAS TO
THE TRAINING AT THE HOSPITAL
THEY WERE GONNA SEND OF THE
STATE -- THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS WHEN WE COULD JUST DO AT
THE HOSPITAL WHEN THEY'RE DOING
THEIR I MEAN I HAVEN'T.
WE ALSO TOOK A BECAUSE I HAD A
LITTLE BIT OF AN INTEREST MOST
OF YOU KNOW THAT I HAD A INJURY
LAST YEAR THEY WENT THROUGH THIS
WHOLE PROCESS.
I KEPT THINKING MYSELF BUT IF I
GET REDUCE ONE MORE BARRIER TO
HAVE A A DOCTOR IS OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL -- WORKING OF THINGS
ARE IMPORTANT AS OPPOSED TO
DRIVING IN TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
CUMBERSOME PROCESS WHY NOT.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE I HOPE THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS AND AND THE
COUNTRY RESOLUTION THE BILL DOES
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
WHICH I CLOSE MISTER SANTIAGO I
RESPECT UNANSWERED AYE VOTE AND
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORK ON
THIS THANK YOU -- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY -- MISTER RAMOS THE
SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT HI WHEN I MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AFTER
CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE.
WICKS.
WICKS ONLINE.
FLORA FOR I LIVE ALONE.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
THE AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS REMOVES AYE
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON -- THE BILL'S.
THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU.
I'M MOVING ON TO MISTER CHAIR
DOCTOR WOULD -- SO WITH AB.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS A FIRST OF FIFTEEN
GOES OUT NUMBERS -- THE MALL I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU -- IN
IN IN IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I'VE SHORTENED WE SHORTEN OUR
SUMMER STATEMENTS HERE SO THE AB
ONE SEVENTY FOUR THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES AND COST SHARING
ASSISTANCE. TO THOSE WITH HEALTH
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES BELOW 4100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
ALSO PROVIDES ASSISTANCE REDUCE
PREMIUMS FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
PROPER OF HOUSEHOLD INCOMES OF
BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND 1%
8100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
AND WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE ACA
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE A
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES TO YES.
FELT COMPELLED TO HAVE
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
LAST YEAR THE ASSEMBLY TOOK THE
STEP OF COMMITTING A BILLION
DOLLARS TO GETTING TO UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE THAT WAS A GOOD SOLID
FIRST STEP WE HOPE TO DO
SOMETHING SIMILAR THIS YEAR --
YOU ALSO IF ENACTED THE AB
EIGHTEEN TEN AFFORDABILITY.
OF WORK GROUP OF IT THE RESULT
OF WHICH IS THAT.
INVESTING IN BETTER
AFFORDABILITY WILL MOVE US
CLOSER TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE AARON
SUPPORT.
GEN FLOOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE ARE
ALSO PROUD TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
AB EIGHTEEN TEN PROCESS.
AND WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE ACROSS
THE INCOME SPECTRUM IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STRUGGLING TO
AFFORD THEIR HEALTH COVERAGE AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL
INCLUDES ALL OF THEM.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SO.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
OF MEMBER CAN SUPPORT.
COLOR SUPPORT OF BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THE SET SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
AND THE PRIVATE CENTRAL ACCESS
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS IN SUPPORT.
DARIA GREW CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ON A HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND IN THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
JENNIFER RALLY WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE WALKING THE MAP WITH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN SUPPORT.
ALEX AUTHOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
OUR DISCUSS THEIR HOME TO
CALIFORNIA PENITENT HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVEN TO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
YOU MUST FOR LOCAL PLANS
CALIFORNIANS PORTS.
GREAT MOVING ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I AM ACTUALLY IN A NEUTRAL BUT I
I WANT TO SO DEAL FOUNTAIN WITH
INACCURATE SO HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS --
IT JUST REALLY QUICKLY -- WHAT
WE WOULD SUPPORT WITH WITH%
AMENDMENTS IF IT INCLUDED THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS FOR A
PERSON'S AREA AS I SAID BEFORE
WITH THE PREVIOUS BILL FOR
FRANCE LIKE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS?
FOR A ONE ON A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT MAKES IT MAKES ANY
PREMIUM REALLY ON AFFORDABLE SO
IF THAT CAN BE ADDRESSED IT WE
WOULD.
GO FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NEVER COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ON FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THERE NO QUESTIONS ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE DO HAVE A A
MOTION BY MISTER FLORA AND THE
SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY --
BUT DOCTOR WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT -- PLEASE CALL OF THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- PLEASE CALL
WORLD WHERE I WOULD FIND MAYES
AYE MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA
[inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I WICKS.
WICKS I FLORA FLORA AYE LOW MOAN.
LIMON I'M A PARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN AYE
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. THIRTEEN OF
THIRTEEN IS THERE THE BILL IS AT
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE ARE GOING TO MOVE.
TO IS THAT IT -- I TO THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN YES YES
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS -- EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN REQUIRES
APARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH A QUALITY ASSESSMENT
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PROVIDED BY
MANAGED MANAGED CARE PLANS
REDUCE HELP REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES.
THE BILL WILL REQUIRE DH CS TO
SET A MINIMUM PERFORMANCE LEVEL
THAT IMPROVES QUALITY IT REDUCES
HEALTH DISPARITIES IT WILL
ESTABLISH A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO REWARD MANAGED CARE
PLANS.
THAT MEET PERFORMANCE TARGETS
THAT EXCEED THE NEW MINIMUM
PERFORMANCE LEVEL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE AYE
VOTE WE HAVE WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS -- MARKETS
GOT THROWN THE CALIFORNIA
BENNETT NICK HEALTH NETWORK --
PLEASE BE A CO SPONSOR OF AB --
FIVE THREE SEVEN I'LL JUST GIVE
A VERY BRIEF -- WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE ACS IS LATEST
COMMITMENT TO INCREASING -- THE
M. P. L. -- IN LIGHT OF THE
RECENT AUDITOR'S REPORT -- WE
BELIEVE MORE IS NEEDED -- SUCH
AS CREATING THE A NEW ME M. P.
L. WITH THE STAKEHOLDER.
INPUT THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
FACTORS THAT WILL DRIVE QUALITY
IMPROVE HEALTH DISPARITIES --
HEALTH PLANS HAVE REAP
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL REWARDS
FOR SERVING CALIFORNIANS IN MEDI
CAL -- YEAH FOR CALIFORNIANS ON
MEDI CAL HEALTH OUTCOMES ARE
STILL DIFFERENT BECAUSE THERE'S
A CODES -- RACE GENDER WHAT
LANGUAGE THEY SPEAK -- EVERYONE
DESERVES QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD A
HEALTHIER LIFE FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB
FIVE THREE SEVEN AND REQUEST
DRIVE UP.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK -- IN SUPPORT OF
THE ROOM PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR -- THE BILL IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T FIX WHAT YOU
DON'T MEASURE AND WE HAVE.
TOWN HALL MEETINGS ALMOST EVERY
YEAR FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS.
AND OF AMONG THE TOP FIVE
CONCERNS IS FIXING THE SYSTEM IN
A PART OF FIXING THE SYSTEM IS
HOLDING AN ACCOUNTABLE.
SO THE ASPECTS OF THE BILL THE
REQUIRE REPORT ASSESS AND THEN
UTILIZE THE DATA AND ALSO
PROVIDES INCENTIVES -- TO END
HEALTH DISPARITIES IS IMPORTANT
TO US AND FOR THOSE REASONS --
WE ARE TRYING TO VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL MOVED TO
ADDITIONAL.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSOR
HIV.
FANTASTIC -- ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOSE TOWARDS WITH HEALTH ACT THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GALEANO CHILDREN ON SUPPORT.
GREAT SEEING IN NEW.
AND FURTHER WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON FORD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL I'M JENNIFER ONLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL OF THIS
EVENING -- MY NUMBERS ARE YOU
KNOW CAP REPRESENTS HEALTH PLANS
THAT YOU KNOW PARTICIPATE IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM WE HAVE FOR
PROFIT NONPROFIT PLANS IN OUR
MEMBERSHIP AND THEY ARE
COMMITTED. TO IMPLEMENTING THE
NEW QUALITY REQUIREMENTS BY THE
DEPARTMENT THIS IS SIMILAR TO A
BILL THAT WE OPPOSE LAST YEAR
AND I THINK ONE OF THE MAJOR
CHANGES BETWEEN.
THE BILL LAST YEAR IN THIS
YEAR'S AND MARCH OF THIS YEAR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES COMPLETELY REVAMPED AND
REVITALIZED THE QUALITY
MONITORING PROGRAM THAT THEY
HAVE FOR MANAGED CARE PLANS.
AND SO WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT
MEAN RIGHT WE TALK ABOUT QUALITY
WANT TO TREAT SURGERY THINGS
THAT YOU MEASURE THAT.
PROVIDERS ARE DOING THEY CAN
KIND OF GIVE YOU -- AN INSIGHT
INTO HOW POPULATION HEALTH THIS
SO YOU LOOKING YOU FIND OUT OUR
KIDS GETTING THERE --
IMMUNIZATIONS ARE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE GETTING YOU KNOW OTHER
PREVENTIVE SCREENINGS THAT WERE
AT THEIR REQUIRED TO GET AND SO
WHAT THAT THE STATE ORDERED THE
PLANTS TO DUE IN MARCH.
WAS TO UTILIZE THE ENTIRE COURSE
AT THAT'S PUBLISHED BY THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICAID AND EMBER.
OF MEDICAID SERVICES WHICH WAS A
HUGE CHANGE -- THAT'S INCLUDED A
LOT MORE MEASURES THAT WERE.
BEING MEASURED BY PLANTS PRIOR
TO THAT CHANGE AND THEY ALSO
RAISE THE MINIMUM PERFORMANCE
LETTER LEVEL FOR PLANTS FROM
25250% SO THAT DOUBLE WHERE THEY
NEEDED TO BE IN THEIR QUALITY
EFFORTS.
AND THEY MADE THESE REQUIREMENTS
RECTAL RECTOR.
RETROACTIVE. TO JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR IN THE END OF MARCH AND SO
MY MEMBERS ARE VERY ENGAGED IN
IN IMPLEMENTING THESE.
INVOLVES CHANGING ON HOW THEY
COLLECT DATA FROM PROVIDERS H.
EDUCATING PROVIDERS THAT THEY
NEED TO SUBMIT THAT INFORMATION.
AND IT'S A HUGE LIVE FOR THEM
AND THEY'RE VERY COMMITTED TO
MAKING THAT WORK AND SO -- TO
REQUIRE THAT A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS BE DEVELOPED TO CREATE A
NEW QALITY PROGRAM IS A PROBLEM
FOR US BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW HOW
THAT WILL LINE WITH THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING TO IMPLEMENT
THE NEW -- PROCESS OUTLINES THAT
I JUST THAT COVERED -- AND WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR HEALTH PLANS
ON HOW THEY NEED TO REPORT THEIR
DATA -- SOME OF THE INFORMATION --
IN THE DEMOGRAPHICS THAT THEY
WANT HEALTH POINT MINT MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS DO NOT HAVE
WE DO NOT GET IT.
FROM THE FILE OF OUR ENROLLEES
THAT JUST THEIR PROCESS TO THE
COUNTIES BECAUSE THAT
INFORMATION IS A FAST.
AND SO TO SET AN EXPECTATION OF
THAT WE WOULD -- PROVIDE CERTAIN
INFORMATION ON OUR ROLE IS THAT
WE JUST DON'T HAVE KIND OF PUT
THIS IN AN AWKWARD POSITION WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE QUALITY OF
THOSE REPORTS ONCE THEY BEGIN
BEING PUBLISHED.
AND SO -- WE DO A LIKE THE
APPROACH TO INCLUDE A FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR PLANTS
THAT EXCEED THEIR QUALITY LEVELS
THAT'S A DIFFERENT APPROACH THAN
WE'VE SEEN BEFORE WE DON'T
OPERATE ON THAT NOW WERE FINED
BY THE DEPARTMENT WHEN WE DON'T
NEED IT.
AND PAY FOR PERFORMANCE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DO DO WITH OUR
PROVIDERS AND SO WE'RE
INTERESTED IN DISCUSSING THAT
BUT FOR THIS AT THIS TIME WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO DISPEL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THERE NO QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECT I'VE I'VE FOR
SHADE WHERE THE HEALTH PLANS ARE
COMING FROM -- I THINK THIS IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT APPROACH --
WITH THE THE IS THE INCENTIVE
FOR A PROGRAM TO REWARD MANAGED
HEALTHCARE PLANS THAT.
THAT MEET NEW PERFORMANCE
TARGETS I THINK IS IS -- IS
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE OF A
CHARACTER THAN A STICK.
AND MY HOPE IS THAT -- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THAT -- WILL BE
ABLE TO WORK THIS OUT WITH
PLANTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD WE DO YOU --
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS UYGHUR
CURRY AND A SECOND BY THE MISS
BURKE THE MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WHAT?
I WOULD AYE MAYES NOTHING MAYES
NOT VOTING.
I GOT CURRY.
CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
NO [inaudible]
BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE ONLINE WICKS.
WICKS ONLINE FLORA.
FLOOR KNOWS THE MOST.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S.
BROWN'S FIVE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
THE NO. TWENTY THREE THE YOUR
BILL IS OUT AND WE WILL.
MOVE ON TO AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY THE NUMBER.
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MANY CAL
MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS ARE
DELIVERED BY BOTH COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS DEPENDING ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION OF
THE PATIENT.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
IMPROVE HOW THE MEDI CAL MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM FUNCTIONS FOR
PEOPLE WHOSE CONDITION CHANGES
SO THEY HAVE TO CHANGE FROM ONE
PLAN TO ANOTHER.
THE BILL WILL PROVIDE MORE DATA
ON HOW WELL THE SYSTEM FUNCTIONS
INCLUDING THE EXTENT TO WHICH
PROVIDERS PARTICIPATING BOTH
SYSTEMS AND THE USE OF
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS.
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT SAYS DESCRIBING
COMMENT SEVEN OF THE COMMITTEE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTIVE GREAT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTEN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE IT IMPROVE CARE
COORDINATION REFERRALS
CONTINUITY OF CARE AND DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS BETWEEN THAT
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS AND
THEN MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS.
I WE HAD SOME INITIAL --
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REGARDING
THEIR CONCERNS.
AND LOOK -- FOR AND WILL
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION THANK
YOU.
MARKETS BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL THE
CALIFORNIA BENNETT NICK HEALTH
NETWORK -- JUST LIKE TO SAY WE
APPRECIATE THE SPONSOR AND
AUTHOR FOR WORKING HONEST WITH
AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL ON THE BILL'S
CLARIFIES THE DATA THAT IS
NEEDED -- TO HOLD PLANS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THESE SERVICES --
ON TO PROVE AT ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CARE WE ARE DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUTS NUMBER CAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT ON THE MOVE ARE WILL
MOVE.
TO BUT LIKE I THINK OF A TWEENER
THING THAT'S WHAT THAT MEANS AT
THE CLEANERS -- CONNIE TALBOT ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
OUR ASSOCIATION IS.
STILL REVIEWING THIS BILL WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR THE
STAFF.
AND THE SPONSOR FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD AND
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ON CARE
COORDINATION AND SERVING THESE
PATIENTS WHO ARE DESPERATELY IN
NEED OF THE SERVICE THANK YOU.
ASK MORE TIME OF THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AS
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
ANY COMMENTS I BELIEVE WE'VE GOT
A MOTION FROM A MISTER BIGELOW
AND A SECOND FROM MISS WALDRON --
DIET DOCTOR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
I DISS SAY LIKE THE SAID.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU KNOW WE HAD HEARINGS ON ON
HOW HOW THE SYSTEMS ARE WORKING --
AND I THINK THERE ARE THERE'S
DEFINITELY ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT
ESPECIALLY AS SOMEONE MOVES FROM
ONE TO ONE PLAN TO ANOTHER AND
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO MAKE THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE UP THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES HI THANKS
I AM HERE CURRY?
I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE BURKE I WICKS.
WICKS I FLORA.
FLORA LIMóN.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
THE AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BONTA.
AYE.
HI.
A FIFTEEN YEAR THE BILL PASSES I
MOVING ON TO I BELIEVE THE LAST
ITEM OF OF THE DAY WHICH IS ITEM
FORTY TWO A. B..
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE PATIENTS THE
COMMITTEE.
JUST LAST MONTH THE BUREAU OF
STATE AUDITS RELEASED A CRITICAL
AUDIT ON HOW WELL THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM FOR THE PROVIDES
PREVENTIVE CARE TO CHILDREN.
THE AUDIT IDENTIFIED MULTIPLE
DEFICIENCIES IN THE DELIVERY OF
PROFESSION -- PREVENTIVE
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND
MEDICARE -- INCLUDING LOW --
LEAVE UTILIZATION RATES IN
ADEQUATE MEDICAL PROVIDER RATES
AND ON REASONABLE TRAVEL TIMES.
THIS BILL WOULD TAKE A NUMBER OF
STEPS TO CONVERT COMPREHENSIVELY
ADDRESSED THE PROBLEMS ADDRESSED
BY STE ADDRESSING STATE.
PAYMENT RATES TO PULL UP THE TO
PLANTS INCREASING THE PENALTY
FOR CARE TO NILES REQUIRING
PLANS TO ATTEMPT TO FIND A
CLOSER PROVIDER WHEN
BENEFICIARIES HAVE TO TRAVEL
OUTSIDE THE GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
THIS COMMITTEE WILL HAVE AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
AUDIT -- ON APRIL THIRTIETH AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
I'D LIKE TO HEAR TO HEAR FROM
OUR BILL SPONSORED SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE ESCRIBIR.
THAT WAS FANTASTIC OF LOOK WILL
GO TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THAT'S CAPELL FOR HEALTHAXIS IN
GALIEN RITUALS ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA'S
LIKE OF MY WORK IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BENEFIT
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
GREAT WILL MOVE TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I TH OWN MY GOODNESS. FOR SURE.
WORKS.
SORRY
GOOD EVENING LAST PROFILE KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF AND JENNIFER
ONLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION -- ON THIS BILL
AND WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CHAIRMAN
STAFF AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING OUT SOME OF OUR
ISSUES -- YOU KNOW IT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE -- ALTERNATIVE
ACCESS REQUIREMENTS SO THAT WE
FILE WITH OUR REGULATOR -- IN
THIS BILL CHANGES THOSE AND SO
WE WANT TO HAVE SOME
CONVERSATION SO -- ESSENTIALLY
YOU KNOW HEALTH PLANS HAVE TIME
AND DISTANCE STANDARDS THAT VARY
BY COUNTY -- AND WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE A PROVIDER FOR WHATEVER
REASON THE PROVIDERS FULL THEY
DON'T WANT TO CONTRACT WITH
MEDICARE HOW -- OR THEY'RE
THEY'RE SEEKING A REIMBURSEMENT
RATE THAT'S TOO HIGH THE PLAN
MIGHT NOT HAVE A PROVIDER --
THAT'S CLOSE ENOUGH THAT MEETS
THOSE TIME AND DISTANCE
STANDARDS AND SO WE FILE
ALTERNATIVE ACCESS THAT APPROVED
BY REGULATORS IN THE WEEKLY THE
CONTRACTED.
PROVIDER IN OUR NETWORK AND SO --
THERE'S JUST SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THAT PROCESS WORKS THE
TIME IT JUST AND STANDARDS ARE
RELATIVELY NEW -- THURSDAY
SUNSET IN A FEW YEARS AND SO
THIS IS JUST TAKING A LOOK AT
THOSE AND WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW IT'S DRAFTED IN THE
BILL WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THOSE.
AND THEN WE'RE ALSO ASKING --
FOR A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FINE JUST BECAUSE THE
REQUIREMENTS OR SOME NEW SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE OF ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
OF THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YEAH I REFER FOR RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WE
JUST LIKE.
TO ESSENTIALLY LIKE TO HAVE A
PLANS TRY HARDER TO FIND SOMEONE
WHO'S CLOSER -- TO THE PEOPLE
HAVE TO TRAVEL SO FAR TO GET THE
SERVICES AND OUT OF MY AND FOR
CLARIFICATION WITH ARE YOU GOING
TO TAKE THE MINUTES YES.
I WILL TAKE ADVANCE FANTASTIC.
APOLOGIZE A FANTASTIC -- DO HAVE
A MOTION -- FROM -- MISS BURKE
AND THE SECOND FROM AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THAT TO APPROPRIATIONS --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE AYE YOUR CURRY.
I GET CURRENT.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING ONTA.
AYE BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE I WICKS.
WICKS I FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS FROM US I
RODRIGUEZ.
SO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING.
REGULATIONS ARE DILIGENT YOUR
BILL THAT TWELVE VOTES PASSES
IT'S ALL YOURS.
OKAY SO I WOULD ASK ALL MEMBERS
PLEASE STAY HERE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO IT
WILL DO THIS AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN.
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF BILLS THAT
ARE ON CALL.
WE WERE HERE FOR ALL OF YEAH.
THERE'S A HARD CORE.
AB FOR THE VERY FIRST BUT THE
FIRST -- BILL IS -- WHAT WE NEED
A MOTION ACTUALLY WHEN THEY?
THE WAY SAY TO REMOVE IT WE
MOVED EVERYTHING THAT WE PUT
EVERYTHING [inaudible]
THE ONES.
I'M SURE THEY'RE ON CALL THERE
OKAY NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER NEEDS
OKAY YOU GOT IT THREE ALL RIGHT.
CLEARLY CLEARLY THERE'S A LACK
OF BLOOD SUGAR GOING ON HERE
[inaudible]
GOT IT [inaudible]
OKAY SIR.
NO NO NO NO NO NO I'M NOT DOING
THAT.
IF YOU TAKE THAT AWAY MISTER
MISTER RESIDENTS REGARDING.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY AREA ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FOR
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
REYES.
PAGE NOT VOTING [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BIGELOW NO.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE WICKS.
WICKS I LIMóN.
I NAZARIAN.
THE SYRIAN AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ELEVEN THREE AS
ELEVEN TO THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE LIFT THE CALL AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
HELLO NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS WICKS I FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMóN.
THE LOAN I WALDRON THE WATER NO.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES IT'S
OUT -- ITEM NUMBER -- THREE IT.
PLEASE LET THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AB SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR MISTER BONTA.
MAYES.
NUMBER MAYES NOT VOTING.
LIMóN.
LU<c.cyan> I SANTIAGO.</c>
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible] SIX ALL OF THE X.
NUMBERED.
I'M SORRY WICKS I WORKS
[inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WATER NO. EIGHTY FOUR THAT IS
EIGHT TO FOR THAT BILL IS OUT --
ITEM NUMBER SIX WAS EVERYONE
HERE.
I'M ITEM NUMBER SIX PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLLING CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA.
I REMEMBER SIX AB [inaudible]
ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONCE I FOURTEEN
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB -- THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
REPRESENTED BY MISTER SANTIAGO --
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE A CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT WAS A GARCIA
BILL [inaudible]
WALDRON.
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB.
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN I HAVE A I'M
GONNA NOT.
WELL THE NUMBER IS.
WALDRON KNOWS. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
TO ONE ITEM ITEM NUMBER NINE
PLEASE -- WHICH IS AB THIRTY
THREE EIGHTY FIVE BY MISTER
CALDERON PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
LIFT THE CALL AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
HI BIGELOW HI BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS WORKS I FLORA.
FLORA AYE LEVEL.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE AND WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
TEENS.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB FOUR OH SEVEN MR SANTIAGO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
BONTA AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WATER NO. FOURTEEN HAS FOURTEEN
ONE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. FOR
FOURTEEN MISTER BONTA PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WICKS HI WICKS I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
HELLO.
THAT'S ELEVEN TO ONE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB FIVE
TWENTY SIX PETRIE-NORRIS.
MAYES ALL RIGHT MAYES AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA
EIN.
WICKS WICKS I FLORA -- FLOOR I
LOW MOAN.
LIMóN AYE NAZARIAN.
HI NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN A. B. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BONTA.
BONTA I LIVE IN A THREE THAT'S
ELEVEN TO THREE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB SIX
FIFTY MISTER LOW.
MAYES HI MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BUT I WICKS.
WICKS I FLORA.
FLORA AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. FIFTEEN THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN A. B. SEVEN SEVENTY
EDUARDO GARCIA AS IT WAS
PRESENTED BY MR MATHIS PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
HELLO I BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS WICKS I FLORA.
FOR I LIVE ALONE.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. FIFTEEN THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB EIGHT TWENTY TWO
IRWIN PLEASE LET THE CALL AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
WICKS.
X. NOT VOTING [inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMON AYE.
THIS -- RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
FORMER NOT VOTING.
THAT IS TO THAT SO THAT IS TEN
ZERO THAT THAT BILL WAS OUT ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN AB EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT MISTER LOW PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES HI MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS WICKS I FLORA.
FOR I IN THIS AREA.
IS THERE AND I RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
YES.
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN AS FIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBERTWENTY ONE A.
B. NINE FOURTEEN MISTER HOLDEN
PLEASE LET THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE SIX WEEKS I FLORA.
FLOOR AYE.
THE CARD.
AYE MCCARTY AYE IS AREA.
NAZARIAN IRAQ BECAUSE RODRIGUEZ
I FIFTEEN THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB NINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE APPS AS BURKE -- PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WICKS WICKS HI Là M<c.cyan>.</c>
LIMON AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON -- WELL
THEY'RE NOT VOTING.
RECEIVED AS FOURTEEN ZERO ITEMS
NUMBER TWENTY THREE EIGHTY NINE
NINETY THREE NECESSARY AND THAT
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB ONE ZERO
ZERO FOUR MCCARTY.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN A. B.
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR AGUILAR
CURRY ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE
SIX TEAMS AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE
MCCARTY.
AND ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE BOB BONTA
WE'RE OUR SECOND CONSENT
CALENDAR.
I HAVE MADAM SECRETARY OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BONTA.
BONTA HI WICKS.
WICKS EILEMA.
LOAN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HIGH RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN THROUGH AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING COULD SECOND
WONDERS WILL MOVE TO THE
ORIGINAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
WHICH WAS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
THREE SIXTEEN BY MISTER RAMOS.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB SEVEN
FOURTEEN WOULD ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB SEVEN SIXTY NINE
SMITH ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
A. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE MCCARTY.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO POWER QUE HAN
ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE SIX A. B.
SIXTEEN OH ONE BY MISTER RAMOS.
AND ITEM NUMBER FORTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE WOULD --
MADAM SECRETARY OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
BONTA HIGH WORKS WICKS EILEMA.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE THE TEACHER SAYS.
FIFTEEN ZERO MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE A. B. TEN
THIRTY BY MISTER CALDERON PLEASE
LIST THE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS WICKS I FLORA.
FLOOR I LIVE ALONE.
LOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
THIS IS EXACTLY CORRECT.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
FIFTEEN THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX A. B. TEN
THIRTY SEVEN MISTER GIPSON
PLEASE LET THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES BY MAYES AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE WORKS WORKS I FLORA.
FLOOR FLOOR I AND LIMóN.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
THE VERY AND I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
AT FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT A. B. TEN NINETY
EIGHT BY MISTER O'DONNELL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
WICKS.
LICKS EILEMA.
LOAN AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
HI.
FIFTY TWO AS FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY NINE AB ELEVEN OH
FIVE MR GIPSON PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE IN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS WICKS I FLORA.
FLORA AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I FIFTEEN HAS FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS IS
AB ELEVEN SIXTEEN BY MR GRAYSON.
MAYES ALL RIGHT MAYES AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE WORKS WICKS I FLORA
FLORA I AM MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I FIFTEEN AS FIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN BY MR GRAYSON
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS WICKS I FLORA
FLORA AYE MCCARTY.
RT I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I FIFTEEN OKAY.
AS FOR OTHER SERVICEFIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO IS
ALREADY.
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER --
THIRTY THREE A. B. TWELVE OR
NINE BY MISTER NAZARIAN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WHERE.
WOULD I WICKS.
WICKS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR A. B. TWELVE FORTY SIX
MISSED Là MON PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES.
IS NOT VOTING.
WICKS WICKS I NAZARIAN.
HI THIS IS THE LOAN.
GETS.
YES -- FORTY SIX YES.
IS THERE IN HIGH SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THREE THAT'S ELEVEN
TO THREE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY MISTER TEAM
WORKS.
IT WAS SEVENTY TWO IT WAS
ACTUALLY EXECUTIVE -- THREE SIX
SIX TO THREE SO EARLIER.
AND SIXTY TWO EARLIER -- ON ON
THE SHOOTINGS BILL YES SO
EARLIER ON MISTER TINGS BILL
BEFORE IT WENT ON CALL.
OF WE WE MADE AN ERROR IN THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THE ACTUAL BUT WAS.
SIX TO THREE SO AT THIS POINT --
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY MISTER TANG WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL AND AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
AYE BONTA AYE BURKE [inaudible]
HOSTED.
WICKS HI WICKS I LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE SANTIAGO.
AB. THIRTEEN SIXTY MISTER TING.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
WATER NO. TEN FOUR THAT'S FOR
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT MISTER
MCCARTY -- PLEASE LET THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WICKS HI WICKS I EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT TO FIVE THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER 398-015-5040 FOUR
MISTER GIBSON PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HELLO.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE WICKS.
WICKS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THE TWO ZERO THIS FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER FORTY AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN MISTER CHIU PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES -- AND MAYES AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA
AYE WORKS WORKS I FLORA.
FLOOR I LIVE ALONE.
THE LOAN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
MODERNIZE. FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
ZERO AND THEN THE FINAL ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER -- FORTY TWO THAT'S
IT SO [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY OKAY -- THAT COVERS IT
THERE'S A ONE ONLY ONE ONE
MEMBER DID NOT VOTE ON ONE BILL
AND WE'RE CONTACTING HER BUT
OTHERWISE SO WE COVER IT OFF
THANK YOU.
SOME OF THE HOLD OUT OF THE FOR
A MOMENT TO HEAR FROM THE FOR
THAT MEMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH
EVERYONE
.
WE ARE -- WITH THAT WE WILL
CLOSE THE THE MEETING THE
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH